Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
I'm bringing you another free Eva's certification
course. And this one happens to be the most
popular in demand. And it is the solutions
architect associate certification. So if you're
looking to pass that exam, this is the course
for you. And we are going to learn a broad
amount of database services, we're going to
learn how to build applications that are highly
available, scalable or durable. And we're
going to learn how to architect solutions
based on the business use case. Now, if you're
looking at this course, and it's 2020, and
you're wondering if you can use it to pass,
you definitely can because the video content
here was shot in late 2019. The only difference
is that the AWS interface has changed a little
bit in terms of aesthetic, but it's more or
less the same. So you can definitely use this
course, if you want a high chance of passing,
I definitely recommend that you do the hands
on labs here in your own AWS account. If you
enjoyed this course, I definitely want to
get your feedback. So definitely share anything
that you've experienced throughout this course
here. And if you pass, I definitely want to
hear that as well. And I also hope you enjoy
this course. And good luck studying.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are going to look at the solution architect
associate and whether it's a good fit for
us to take the certification. So the first
thing I want you to know is that this kind
of role is for finding creative solutions
by leveraging cloud services instead of reinventing
the wheel. It's all about big picture thinking.
So you're going to need broad knowledge across
multiple domains. It's great for those who
get bored really easily. And so you're gonna
have to wear multiple hats. And it's really
less about how are we going to implement this
and more about what are we going to implement,
okay, so you would come up with an architecture
using multiple different cloud services, and
then you would pass it on to your cloud engineers
to actually go implement, it's not uncommon
for a solution architect to be utilized within
the business development team. So it's not
quite unusual to see solution architects being
very charismatic speakers and extroverts,
because they're going to have to talk to other
companies to collaborate with, alright, and
just to really give you a good idea of what
a solution architect does, they're going to
be creating a lot of architectural diagrams.
So here, I just pulled a bunch from the internet,
and you can see kind of the complexity and
how they tie into different services, you're
going to require a lot of constant learning,
because AWS is constantly adding new services
and trying to figure out how they all fit
together is a common thing. And advice that
I get from some senior solution architects
at large companies, is you're always thinking
about pricing, and you're always thinking
about can you secure a whatever that is okay,
but at best is gonna have their own definition
there, which is all about the five pillars,
which comes into the well architected framework.
But you know, we'll learn that as we go along
here. Okay, so let's talk about what value
do we get out of the solution architect associate?
Well, it is the most popular at a certification
out of every single one. It's highly in demand
with startups, because you can help wherever
help is needed startups, from small to medium
size, just need people to fill any possible
role. And because you're gonna have broad
knowledge, you're going to be considered very,
very valuable, it is recognized as the most
important certification at the associate level,
and it's going to really help you stand out
on a resumes, I would not say the associate
is going to help you increase your salary
too much. But you're definitely going to see
a lot more job opportunities to see those
increase in salaries, you're gonna have to
get those pros and specialty certifications.
Okay, so if you're still not sure whether
you should take the solution architect associate,
let me just give you a little bit more information.
So it is the most in demand a certification.
So it has the most utility out of any other
certification because of that broad knowledge.
It's not too easy, but it's not too hard.
So it's not too easy, in the sense that, you
know, the information you're learning is superficial,
it's actually going to be very useful on the
job. But it's also not that hard. So you're
not going to risk failing the exam because
you don't know the nitty gritties of all the
services, okay, it requires the least amount
of technical knowledge. So if you're really
more of a, a academic or or theory based learner,
instead of having that hands on experience,
you're going to excel here taking the solution
architect associate. And again, when in doubt,
just take this certification because it gives
you the most flexible future learning path.
So I always say that if you aren't sure what
specialty you want to take, take the solution
architect associate. So you get to familiarize
yourself with all the different kinds of roles
that you can encounter. So if you're definitely
thinking about doing big data security, machine
learning, I would absolutely think a to do
Take the solution architect associate first.
Of course, you can always do the solution
architect professional, if you want to keep
on going down this specific path. And if you
are new to AWS and cloud computing in general,
that I strongly recommend that you take the
CCP before taking the solution architect associate
because it's a lot easier. And it's going
to give you more foundational knowledge so
that you're going to have a really easy time
with this exam. And it specifically is the
direct upgrade path. So all that stuff you
learn in the CCP is directly applicable to
the Solution Architect associate. So how much
time are we going to have to invest in order
to pass the solution architect
associate. And this is going to depend on
your past experience. And so I've broken down
three particular archetypes to give you an
idea of time investment. So if you are already
a cloud engineer, you're already working with
AWS, you're looking at 20 hours of study,
you could pass this in a week, okay, but that's
if you're using AWS on a day to day basis,
if you are a bootcamp grad, it's going to
take you one to two months. So we're looking
between 80 to 160 hours of study. If you have
never used AWS or heard of it, then you probably
should go take the certified cloud practitioner
first, it's going to make things a lot easier,
which has a lot more foundational information,
you might start this here and be overwhelmed,
because you feel that you're missing information.
So you will probably want to go there first.
If you are a developer, and you've been working
in the industry for quite a few years, but
maybe you've just never used AWS, then you're
looking at one month of study. So that's about
80 hours of study. Okay, and so that will
give you an idea how much time you need to
commit. Okay, so let's just touch on the exam
itself here. So the exam itself is going to
cost $150, for you to take and that's in USD,
you have to take it at a test center that
is partnered with AWS. So you will have to
go through the portal there and book it and
then you'll be going down to that test center
to right at the exam gives you 130 minutes
to complete it. There's a 65 questions on
the exam, the passing score is around 72%.
And once you have the certification, it's
going to be valid for three years. All right.
So hopefully, that gives you a bit of perspective
and whether the solution architect associate
is right for you. Here I have on the right
hand side, the exam guide. And I'm just going
to walk you quickly through it just so you
get a kind of a breakdown of what it is that
AWS recommends that we should learn and how
this this exam is broken up in terms of domains,
and also its scoring. Okay, so here on the
left hand side, we're going to first look
at the content outline. Okay, if we just scroll
down here, you can see it's broken up into
five domains. And we get a bunch a bunch more
additional information. Okay, so we have a
design resilient architectures, design performance
architectures, specify secure applications
and architectures designed cost optimized
architectures, and define operational excellent
architectures. Now I highlighted the word
in there resilient performance, secure cost,
optimizing operational excellence, because
this actually maps to the five pillars of
the well architected framework, which is a
recommended read for study here, okay. So
there is a rhyme and rhythm to this layout
here, which we will talk about when we get
to the white paper section. But let's just
look inside of each of these domains. So for
resilient architecture, you have to choose
reliable and resilient storage. So there we're
talking about elastic block store in s3 and
all the different storage options available
to us design, how to design decoupling mechanisms
using AWS services. So they're talking about
application integration, such as Sq s, and
SNS. Then we have a design how to or determine
how to design a multi tier architecture solution.
Maybe they're hinting there at once as multi
tier. So when you have tiers you, you'd have
your database layer, your web layer, your
load balancing layer, okay, so that's probably
what they mean by tiers. Determine how to
design high available availability or fault
tolerant architectures. So that's going to
be knowing how to use row 53. Load Balancing
auto scaling groups, what happens when an
AZ goes out what happens when a region goes
out? That kind of stuff, okay. The next thing
is design, performance architecture. So choose
performance storage, and databases. So that's
just going to be knowing Dynamo DB versus
RDS versus redshift, okay? That we can apply
caching to improve performance. That's going
to know that dynamodb has a caching layer
that's going to be knowing how to use elastic
cache or maybe using cloud Front to cache
your static content, then we have designed
solutions for elasticity and scalability.
So that sounds pretty much like auto scaling
groups to me, okay. And then we got specify
secure applications in architecture. So determine
how to secure application tiers. So again,
there's three tiers database, web network,
or load balancing. There's obviously other
tiers there. But just knowing when to check
box to turn on security for those services
and how that stuff works. From a general perspective,
okay,
Turman, how do you secure data, so just knowing
data at rest, like data in transit? Okay,
then defining the networking infrastructure
for a single VPC application. This is about
knowing v PCs inside and out, which we definitely
cover heavily. I'm a solution architect associate
and all the associate certifications, because
it's so darn important that we have designed
cost optimize architecture. So determine how
to design cost optimized storage, determine
how to design cost, optimize, compute, we're
talking about storage, they're probably really,
really talking about s3, s3 has a bunch of
storage classes that you can change and they
get cheaper, the further down you go, and
knowing when and how to use that for compute,
maybe they're talking about just knowing when
to use us different kinds of ECU instances,
or maybe using auto scaling groups to reduce
that cost to, to scale out when you don't
have a lot of usage. Then the last one here
is design, operational, excellent architecture.
So design features and solutions that enable
opera enable operational excellence, okay,
and so you can see, and I'm not even exactly
sure what they're saying here. But that's
okay. Because it's worth 6%. Okay, it's definitely
covered in the course, it's just, it's a funny
word in one there, I never could remember
what they're saying there. Okay. But you can
see the most important one here is designing
resilient architecture. Okay, so that's the
highest one there. And the last two is cost
and operational excellence. So you're not
going to be hit with too many cost questions,
but you just generally have to know, you know,
when it makes sense to use x over y. Alright.
So yeah, there's the outline, and we will
move on to the next part here. And that's
the response types. Okay. So this exam, I
believe, has a 65 questions. I don't think
it actually states it in here. But generally,
it's 65. Okay, a lot of times when you take
the exams, they'll actually have additional
questions in there that are not scored, because
they're always testing out new questions.
Questions are going to come in two formats,
multiple choice. So we're going to have the
standard one out of four. And then we're going
to have multiple response, which is going
to be choose two or more out of five or more,
okay, generally, it's always two out of five.
But I guess sometimes you could have three
out of six. All right. And so just be aware
of that. Now, the passing score for this is
going to be 720 points out of 10,000 points.
Okay, so they have this point system, and
so 720 is passing. So the way you can think
about it, it's 72%, which is a C minus two
pass. All right, I put a tilde there, I know
it looks a bit funny there. But the Tilda
means to say like about or around because
that value can fluctuate. So the thing is,
is that it's not exactly 72%, you could go
in and get 72%, and fail, you can go and get
75% and fail, it just depends on how many
people are taking the exam, and they're going
to adjust it based on how you feel or passing
or failing, okay, but it doesn't, it doesn't
fluctuate too far from this point, okay, it's
not gonna be like, you have to get 85%. Alright.
And then just the last thing here is the white
paper. So each of us recommends white papers
for you to read. And they're not very clear
here. So they do architecting for the cloud
as best practices, that's when you should
definitely read. It's not a very difficult
read. So it's on the top of your reading list.
And then there's Eva's well, architected architected
webpage. And so that web page contains a bunch
of white papers. And this is the full list
here. Okay, so we have the well architected
framework, which talks about the five pillars
and then then they actually have a white paper
for each pillar. And then there's these other
ones down below, which are kind of new additions.
So the question is, do you have to read all
of these things? No. In fact, you should just
probably just read the top one here as well
architecture framework, and you could read
half of that and you'd still be good. It is
great to dove dive into these. These ones
here. So um, there are still listed here.
The last ones here are definitely 100% optional.
I do not believe they are on the exam. But
again, they just tell you to go to the entire
page. So it is a bit confusing there. So hopefully,
that gives you a bit of a breakdown so you
are prepared. what's ahead of you for study.
Hey, this is Angie brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at simple storage service,
also known as s3, which is an object based
storage service. It's also serverless storage
in the cloud. And the key thing is you don't
have to worry about falling systems or display
to really understand three, we need to know
what object storage is. And so it is a data
storage architecture that manages data as
objects, as opposed to other storage architectures,
other architectures being file systems, where
you manage data as files within a file hierarchy,
or you have block storage, which manages data
as blocks, when within sectors and tracks,
the huge benefit to object storage is you
don't have to think about the underlying infrastructure,
it just works. And with s3, you have practically
unlimited storage. So you just upload stuff,
you don't worry about disk space. s3 does
come with a really nice console that provides
you that interface to upload and access your
data. And the two most key key components
to s3, our s3 objects and s3 bucket so objects
are is what contains your data. And they're
kind of like files. And an object is composed
of a key value of version ID and metadata.
So the key is just the name of the file or
the object, the value is actually the data
itself made up as a sequence of bytes. The
version ID, if you're using versioning, then
you have to enable that on s3, then each object
you upload would have an ID. And then you
have metadata, which is just additional information
you want to attach to the object. An s3 object
can be zero bytes in size and five terabytes.
Please note that I really highlighted zero
bytes, because that is a common Trick question
on the exam, because a lot of people think
you can't do zero bytes, and you definitely
can. And then you have buckets and buckets,
hold objects, they are kind of like top level
folders or directories. Buckets can also have
folders, which in turn hold objects. So buckets
have a concept called folders. And so you
can have had those objects directly in that
bucket. Or in those folders. When you name
an s3 bucket, it's using a universal namespace.
So the bucket names must be unique. It's like
having a domain name. So you have to really
choose unique names. Okay. So the concept
behind storage classes is that we get to trade
retrieval time accessibility and durability
for cheaper storage. And so when you upload
data to s3, by default, it's using standard.
And it's really, really fast. It has 99 point
99% availability, it has 11 nines of durability,
and it replicates your data across three availability
zones. And as we go down, this list is going
to get cheaper, we're going to skip over until
intelligent tearing, we'll come back to that.
And we're gonna look at standard and frequency
access, also known as IAA. So it's just as
fast as standard. The trade off here is that
it's cheaper if you access files less than
once a month. There isn't an additional retrieval
fee when you access that data. But the cost
overall is 50%. Less than standard. So the
trade off here is you're getting reduced availability,
then you have one zone IAA. And as the name
implies, it only runs your data or only replicate
your data in one AZ so you don't you have
reduced durability. So there is a chance that
your data could get destroyed, a retrieval
fee is applied just like an AI a, your availability
is going to drop down to 99.5%. Okay, then
you have glacier and glaciers for long term
cold storage.
It's for the trade off here, though, is that
the retrieval is going to take minutes to
an hour, but you get extremely, extremely
cheap storage. There also is a retrieval fee
applied here as well. And glacier normally
is like pitched kind of like its own service.
But really, it's an s3 service, then you have
glacier deep archive. And this is just like
glacier except now it's going to take 12 hours
before you can access your data. Again, it's
very, very, very, very cheap at this level.
It's the cheapest tier here. And so this is
really suited for long archival data. Now
we glossed over intelligent, tearing, but
let's talk about it. So what it does is it
uses machine learning to analyze your object
usage and determine the appropriate storage
class. So it's going to decide for you what
storage class you should use so that you save
money, okay, and so that is all of the classes
and we're going to compare them in a big chart
in the next slide. I just have here up the
comparison of storage classes just to make
it a bit easier for you to see what's going
on here. So you can see across the board we
have durability at the 11 nines across all
services. There is reduced durability in one
zone I A but I guess it's trying to say that
maybe it has 11 nines in that one zone. I'm
not sure so that one confuses me a bit. But
you have to think that if you're only running
one zone, there has to be reduced durability.
For availability, it's 99.9% until we hit
one zone IAA. For glacier and glacier deep
archive. It's not applicable because it's
just going to take a really long time to access
those files. So availability is like indefinitely
Hello, we're not going to put a percentage
on that. For azs. It's going to run in three
or more azs. From standard to standard ay
ay ay ay. Actually, across the board. The
only one that is reduced is for one zone IAA,
I always wonder, you know, if you're running
in Canada Central, it would only use the two
because there's only two availability zones
there. So it's always a question I have on
the top of my head. But anyway, it's always
three or more azs, you can see that there
is a capacity charge for standard IAA. and
above, for there is a storage duration charge
for all the tiers with the exception of standard.
And then you have your retrieval fees, which
are only going to come in your eyes and your
glacier, okay. And then you have the latency.
That's how fast you can access files. And
you can see Ms means milliseconds. So for
all these tiers, it's super, super fast. And
you know, it's good to just repeat, but you
know, AWS does give a guarantee of 99.99%
availability, it has a guarantee of 11 nines
durability. Alright, so there you go, that
is the big. Now we're taking a look at s3
security. So when you create a bucket, they're
all private by default. And AWS really obsesses
over not exposing public buckets, they've
changed the interface like three or four times,
and they now send you email reminders telling
you what buckets are exposed because it's
a serious vulnerability for AWS, and people
just seem to keep on leaving these buckets
open. So when you create a new bucket, you
have all public access denied. And if you
want to have public access, you have to go
check off this for either for your ACLs or
your bucket policies. Okay.
Now, in s3, you can turn on logging per request.
So you get all the detailed information of
what objects were accessed or uploaded, deleted
in granular detail. log files are generated,
but they're not putting the same bucket, they're
putting in a different bucket. Okay. Now to
control access to your objects. And your buckets,
you have two options. We have bucket policies
and access control lists. So access control
lists came first, before bucket policies,
they are a legacy feature, but they're not
depreciated. So it's not full pot to use them.
But they're just simpler in action. And sometimes
there are use cases where you might want to
use them over bucket policies. And so it's
just a very simple way of granting access,
you right click in a bucket or an object and
you could choose who so like there's an option
to grant all public access, you can say lists
the objects, right the objects, or just read
and write permissions. And it's as simple
as that now bucket policies are, they're a
bit more complicated, because you have to
write a JSON document policy, but you get
a lot more rich, complex rules. If you're
ever setting up static s3, hosting, you definitely
have to use a bucket policy. And that's what
we're looking at here. This is actually an
example website where we're saying allow read
only access, forget objects to this bucket.
And so this is used in a more complicated
setup. But that is the difference. So bucket
policies are generally used more, they're
more complex and ACLs are just simple. And
there's no foolproof. So we talked about security
and very big feature about that is encryption.
And so when you are uploading files to s3,
it by default uses SSL or TLS. So that means
we're going to have encryption in transit.
When it comes to server side encryption, actually
what is sitting on the actual data at rest.
We have a few options here. So we have SSE
a s, we have SSE kms. And SSE C, if you're
wondering what SSE stands for, it's server
side encryption. And so for the first option,
this is just an algorithm for encryption.
So that means that it's going to be 256 bytes
in length or characters in length when it
uses encryption, which is very long. And s3
is doing all the work here. So it's handling
all the encryption for you. Then you have
kms, which is key management service, and
it uses envelope encryption. So the key is
then encrypted with another key. And with
kms. It's either managed by AWS or managed
by you the keys itself, okay, then you have
customer provided keys, this is where you
provide the key yourself. There's not an interface
for it here, it's a bit more complicated.
But you know, all you need to know is that
the C stands for customer provided, then you
have client side encryption, there's no interface
or anything for that. It's just you encrypting
the files locally and then uploading them
to s3 or looking at s3 data consistency. Sorry,
I don't have any cool graphics for here because
it's not a very exciting topic, but we definitely
need to know what it is. So when you put data
or you write data to s3, which is when you're
writing new objects, The consistency is going
to be different when you are overwriting files
or deleting objects. Okay, so when you send
new data to s3, as a new object, it's going
to be read after write consistency. What that
means is as soon as you upload it, you can
immediately read the data and it's going to
be consistent. Now when it comes to overwriting
and deleting objects, when you overwrite or
delete, it's going to take time for s3 to
replicated to all those other azs. And so
if you were to immediately read the data,
s3 may return to you an old copy. Now, it
only takes like a second or two for it to
update. So there, it might be unlikely in
your use case, but you just have to consider
that that is a possibility. Okay. So we're
taking a look at cross region replication,
which provides higher durability in the case
of a disaster, okay, and so what we do is
we turn it on, and we're going to specify
a destination bucket in another region, and
it's going to automatically replicate those
objects from the region source region to that
destination region. Now, you can also have
it replicate to a bucket in another AWS account.
In order to use this feature, you do have
to have versioning turned on in both the source
and destination buckets.
Now in s3, you can set on a bucket versioning.
And what versioning does is it allows you
to version your objects, all right. And the
idea here is to help you prevent data loss
and just keeping track of versions. So if
you had a file, here, I have a an image called
tarok. Nor the name is the same thing as a
key, right, it's gonna have a version ID.
And so here we have one, which is 111111.
And when we put a new file, like a new object
with the exact same key, it's going to create
a new version of it. And it's going to give
it a new ID, whatever that ID is 121212. And
the idea is now if you access this object,
it's always going to pull the one from the
top. And if you were to delete that object,
now it's going to access the previous one.
So it's a really good way of protecting your
data from and also, if you did need to go
get an older version of it, you can actually
get any version of the file you want, you
just have to specify the version ID. Now when
you do turn on s3, versioning, you cannot
disable it after the fact. So you'll see over
here it says enabled or suspended. So once
it's turned on, you cannot remove versioning
from existing files, all you can do is suspend
versioning. And you'll have all these baseball's
with one version, alright.
So s3 has a feature called Lifecycle Management.
And what it does is it automates the process
of moving objects to different storage classes
or deleting them altogether. So down below
here, I have a use case. So I have an s3 bucket.
And I would create a lifecycle rule here to
say after seven days, I want to move this
data to glacier because I'm unlikely to use
that data for the year. But I have to keep
it around for compliancy reasons. And I want
that cheaper cost. So that's what you do with
lifecycle rule, then you create another lifecycle
rule to say after a year, you can go ahead
and delete that data. Now, Lifecycle Management
does work with a version and it can apply
to both current or previous version. So here
you can see you can specify what you're talking
about when you're looking at a lifecycle rule.
So let's look at transfer acceleration for
s3. And what it does is it provides you with
fast and secure transfer of files over long
distances between your end users and an s3
bucket. So the idea is that you are uploading
files and you want to get them to s3 as soon
as possible. So what you're going to do is
instead of uploading it to s3, you're going
to send it to a distinct URL for a edge location
nearby. an edge location is just a data center
that is as close as you as possible. And once
it's uploaded there, it's going to then accelerate
the uploading to your s3 bucket using the
AWS backbone network, which is a an optimized
network path. Alright. And so that's all there
is to it. So pre signed URLs is something
you're definitely going to be using in practicality
when you're building web application. So the
idea behind it is that you can generate a
URL which provides you temporary access to
an object to either upload or download object
data to that endpoint. So presale URLs are
commonly used to provide access to private
objects. And you can use the CLR SDK to generate
pre signed URLs Actually, that's the only
way you can do it. So here using the COI you
can see I'm specifying the actual object and
I'm saying that it's going to expire after
300. I think that's seconds. And so, anyway,
the point is, is that, you know, it's only
going to be accessible for that period of
time. And what it's going to do is gonna generate
this very long URL. And you can see it actually
has an axis axis key in here, sets the expiry
and has the signature. Okay, so this is going
to authenticate a temporary temporarily to
do what we want to do to that object of dairy,
very common use cases, if you have a web application,
you need to allow users to download files
from a password protected part of your web
app, you'd also expect that those files on
s3 would be private. So what you do is you
generate out a pre signed URL, which will
expire after like something like five seconds,
enough time for that person to download the
file. And that is the concept. So if you're
really paranoid about people deleting your
objects in s3, what you can do is enable MFA
delete. And what that does is it makes you
require an MFA code in order to delete said
object. All right, now in order to enable
MFA, you have to jump through a few hoops.
And there's some limitations around how you
can use it. So what you have to do is you
have to make sure version is turned on your
bucket or you can't use MFA delete. The other
thing is that in order to turn on MFA delete,
you have to use the COI. So here down below,
I'm using the C ally. And you can see the
configuration for versioning. I'm setting
it to MFA delete enabled. Another caveat is
that the only the bucket owner logged in as
the root user can delete objects from the
bucket. Alright, so those are your three caveats.
But this is going to be a really good way
to ensure that files do not get deleted by
act. Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro,
and welcome to the s3 Follow along where we're
going to learn how to use s3. So the first
thing I want you to notice in the top right
corner is that s3 is in a global region. So
most services are going to be region specific.
And you'd have to switch between them to see
the resources of them, but not for s3, you
see all your buckets from every single region
in one view, which is very convenient. That
doesn't mean that buckets don't belong to
a region, it's just that the interface here
is
global.
Okay, so we're going to go ahead and create
our first bucket and the bucket name has to
be unique. So if we choose a name that's already
taken by another database user, we're not
gonna be able to name it that and the name
has to be DNS compliant. So it's just like
when you register for a domain name, you're
not allowed certain characters. So whatever
is valid for a domain name, or URL is what's
going to be valid here. So I'm going to try
to name it exam Pro. And it's going to be
in this region here. And we do have all these
other options. But honestly, everybody always
just goes ahead and creates and configures
after the fact, we're gonna hit Create. And
you're gonna notice that it's gonna say this
bucket name has already been taken, and it
definitely has been because I have it in my
other AWS account here. So I'm just gonna
go ahead and name it something else, I'm gonna
try 000. Okay, I'm gonna hit Create. And there
we go. So we have our own bucket. Alright,
now if we wanted to go ahead and delete this
bucket, I want you to do that right away here,
we're going to go ahead and delete this bucket,
it's gonna pop up here, and it's going to
ask us to put in the name of the bucket. So
I was just copy it in here, like this. And
we're going to delete that bucket. Okay, so
that's how you create a bucket. And that's
how you delete a bucket. But we're gonna need
a bucket for to learn about s3. So we're gonna
have to go ahead and make a new bucket here.
So I'm going to put in exam pro 000. And we
will go ahead and create that. And now we
have our buckets. So great. And we'll go click
into this bucket. And there we go. So let's
start actually uploading our first file. So
I prepared some files here for upload. And
just before I upload them, I'm just gonna
go create a new folder here in this bucket.
Okay. And I have a spelling mistake there.
Great. And so I'm gonna just go upload these
images. Here. They are from Star Trek The
Next Generation. They're the characters in
the show. And so I all I have to do here is
click and drag, and then I can go ahead and
hit upload down here. And they're just going
to go ahead and upload them. Alright. And
we'll just give that a little bit of time
here. And they are all in Great. So now that
I have all my images here in my bucket, I
can click into an individual one here. And
you can see who the owner is, when it was
uploaded, uploaded the storage class, the
size of it. And it also has an object URL,
which we're going to get to in a moment here.
All right. So but if we want to actually just
view it in the console here, we can click
open and we can view it or we can hit download.
Alright, and so that's going to download that
file there. But then we have this object URL
and this was why we're saying that you have
to have unique you Unique a bucket names because
they literally are used as URLs. Okay, so
if I were actually to take this URL and try
to access it, and I actually just had it open
here a second ago, you can see that we're
getting an Access denied because by default,
s3 buckets are private. Okay? So if we wanted
to make this public, so anyone could access
this URL, we want to hit the make public button,
we're going to see that it's disabled. So
if we want to be able to make things public,
we're gonna have to go to our bucket up here
at the top here, go to the properties, or
sorry, I should say permissions. And we're
going to have to allow public access. Okay,
so this is just an additional security feature
that eight of us has implemented, because
people have a really hard time about making
things public on their bucket and getting
a lot of bad stuff exposed. So we're gonna
go over here and hit edit, and we have a bunch
of options. But we're first going to untick
block all public access, and this is gonna
allow us to now make things public. So I hit
save, okay, and I go to type in confirm. Okay.
And so now, if I go back to our bucket here
into the enterprise D and data, I now have
the ability to make this public. So I'm going
to click make public. And so now, this file
is public. And if I were to go back here and
refresh, okay, so there you go. So now I could,
I could take this link and share it with you,
or anybody, and anyone in the world can now
view that file. Okay. Great. So now that we
learned how to upload a file, or files, and
how to make a file public, let's learn about
versioning.
So we uploaded all these different files here.
But let's say we had a newer version of those
files. And we wanted to keep track of that.
And that's where version is going to help
us in s3. So, you know, we saw that I uploaded
these characters from Star Trek The Next Generation.
And there, we actually have a newer images
here of the characters, not all of them, but
some of them. And so when I upload them, I
don't want the old ones to vanish, I want
it to keep track of them. And that's where
virgin is going to come into play. So to turn
on versioning, we're going to go to exam pro
000. And we're going to go to properties here
and we have a box here to turn on versioning,
I just want you to notice that when you turn
on versioning, you cannot turn it off, you
can only suspend it, okay. So what that means
is that objects are still going to have version
history, it's just that you're not gonna be
able to add additional versions, if you turn
it off, we'll go ahead and we're going to
enable versioning here, and versioning is
now turned on. And you're going to notice
now that we have this versions tab, here we
go hide and show and it gives us additional
information here for the version ID. Okay,
so I'm going to go into the enterprise D,
I hit show here, so I can see the versions.
And now you're gonna see, we've got a big
mess here. Maybe we'll turn that off here
for a second. And we're going to go ahead
and upload our new files here, which have
the exact same name, okay, so I'm gonna click
and drag, and we're gonna hit upload, and
Oh, there they go. Okay, so we're gonna upload
those files there. And now let's hit show.
And we can see that some of our files where
we've done some uploading there have have
additional versions. So you're gonna notice
that the first file here actually has no version
ID, it's just No, okay, but the latest version
does, it's just because these were the, the
initial files. And so the initial files are
going to have null there. But you know, from
then on, you're going to have these new version
IDs. Okay, so let's just see if we can see
the new version. So we're looking at data
before. And what we want to see here is what
he looks like now. So I click open, and it's
showing us the latest version of data. All
right. Now, if we wanted to see the previous
version, I think if we drop down here, see
vs latest and prior, so we have some dates
there, we click here, we hit open, and now
we can see the previous version of data. Okay.
Now, one other thing I want to check here
is if we go up to this file here, and we were
to click this link, is this going to be accessible?
No, it's not. Okay. Now, let's go look at
the previous example. Now we had set this
to be public, is this one still public? It
is okay, great. So what you're seeing here
is that when you do upload new files, you're
not going to inherit the original properties,
like for the the public access, so if we want
data to be public, we're going to have to
set the new one to be public. So we're going
to drop down the version here and hit make
public. And now if we go open this file here,
he should be public. So there you go, that
is versioning. Now, if we were to delete this
file out of here, let's go ahead and delete
data out of here. Okay, so I'm going to hit
actions and I'm going to delete data. So I'm
going to hit Delete. Notice it says the version
ID here, okay? So I hit delete, and data is
still here. So if we go into data,
and we hit open, okay, we're Now we get the
old data, right? So we don't have
the previous versions. I'm pretty sure we
don't. So we just hit open here open. Great.
And if I go here and go this one open, okay,
so the specified version does not exist. So
we, it still shows up in the console, but
the the file is no longer there. Okay? Now
let's say we wanted to delete this original
data file, right? Can we do that, let's go
find out, delete, and we're gonna hit delete,
okay, and still shows the data's there, we're
gonna hit the refresh, we're going to go in
there, and we're going to look at this version
and open it. Okay, and so you can still see
it's there. So the thing about versioning
is that it's a great way to help you protect
from the deletion of files. And it also allows
you to, you know, keep versions of stuff and
those properties, you know, again, does not
carry over to the next one. So, now that we've
learned about versioning, I think it'd be
a bit of fun to learn about encryption. Okay.
Actually, just before we move on to encryption,
I just want to double check something here.
So if we were to go to versions here, and
I was saying, like, the initial version here
is normal, what would happen if we uploaded
a file for the first time? That because remember,
these were uploaded, before we turned on?
versioning? Right. And so they were set to
novel what happens when we upload a new file
with versioning turned on? Is it going to
be normal? Or is it going to have its own
version ID? Okay, that's a kind of a burning
question I have in the back of my mind. And
so I added another image here, we now have
Keiko, so we're going to upload kago. And
we're going to see is it going to be no, or
is going to have an ID and so look, it actually
has a version ID. So the only reason these
are no is because they existed prior to versioning.
Okay, so if you see no, that's the reason
why. But if you have versioning turned on,
and then from then on, it's always going to
have a version ID. Actually, just before we
move on to encryption, I just want to double
check something here. So if we were to go
to versions here, and I was saying like, the
initial version here is novel, what would
happen if we uploaded a file for the first
time? That because remember, these were uploaded,
before we turned on? versioning? Right. And
so they were set to novel what happens when
we upload a new file with versioning turned
on? Is it gonna be normal? Or is it gonna
have its own version ID? Okay, that's a kind
of a burning question I have in the back of
my mind. And so I added another image here,
we now have Keiko and so we're gonna upload
Keiko, and we're gonna see is it going to
be no? Or is it going to have an ID and so
look, it actually has a version ID. So the
only reason these are null is because they
existed prior to versioning. Okay, so if you
see no, that's the reason why. But if you
have versioning turned on, and then from then
on, it's always going to have a version of
it. Alright, so let's explore how to turn
on server side encryption, which is very easy
on s3. So we're going to go back to our bucket,
go to our properties, and then click on default
encryption. And by default, you're gonna see
we don't have any encryption turned on. But
we can turn on server side encryption using
a Aes 256, which is uses a 256 algorithm in
length or key in length. I'm always bad on
that description there. But the point is,
it's 256 something in length for encryption,
and then we have AWS kms, we're going to turn
on a Aes 256, because that's the easiest way
to get started here. But look at the warning
up here, it says the property, this property
does not affect existing objects in your bucket.
Okay. And so we're going to turn on our encryption.
So we got our nice purple checkmark. And we're
going to go back to our bucket to see if any
of our files are encrypted, which I don't
think they're going to be based on that message
there. So we're going to go and check out
data. And we can see that there is no server
side encryption. Okay. So in order to turn
it on for existing files, I would imagine
it's gonna be the same process here, we'll
go to properties. We're going to have encryption
here, and we're going to turn on a Aes 256.
So you can see that you can set individual
encryption profiles. And you can also do it
per bucket. And so we're going to go ahead
there and encrypt data there. Alright, so
now if we were to go access this URL, do we
have permissions even though it is set to
public? So remember, data is public, right?
But can we see it when encryption is turned
on? And apparently, we totally totally can.
So encryption doesn't necessarily mean that
the files aren't accessible, right? It just
because we have made this file public, it
just means that when they're at rest on the
servers on AWS, there are going to be encrypted.
Okay. So, you know, that is how easy it is
to turn on encryption. Now when it comes to
accessing files via the csli and kms. There
is a little bit more work involved there.
So you know, for that there's going to be
a bit more of a story there. But, you know,
if we do get to see alive, we'll talk about
that. Okay.
Now, I want to To show you how to access private
files using pre signed URL. But just before
we get to that, I figured this is a good opportunity
to learn how to use the COI for s3. And we'll
work our way to a pre signed URL. So here
I have my terminal open. And I already have
the a vcli installed on my computer here.
So what we're going to do first is just list
all the buckets within our Eva's count. So
we can do ABS s3 Ls LS stands for list. And
then what's going to do is we're going to
see that single bucket that we do actually
have here, if we wanted to see the contents
of it, we can just type AWS s3 Ls, and then
provide the bucket name. And it's gonna show
us its content, which is a single folder.
And then if we wanted to see within that folder,
you kind of get where we're going here, we
can put that on the end there and hit enter.
Okay, and then we're gonna see all our files.
So that's how easy it is to use. ls, you're
going to notice over here, I do have a very
slightly different syntax here, which is the
using the s3 protocol here in the front. This
is sometimes as needed for certain commands,
which are going to find out here with CP in
a moment. But not all commands require it,
okay, like so for instance, in LS, we've admitted
that protocol there, but yeah, moving on to
copying files, which CP stands for, we can
download objects to and from our desktop here.
So let's go ahead and actually go download
a Barkley from our bucket here. So I'm just
going to clear this here, and type A, this
s3, CP, we're gonna use that protocol, we
definitely have to use it for CP or will air
out and we'll do exam Pro, there was a zero
enterprise enterprise D here. And then it's
going to be Barclay, okay. And we're just
going to want to download that, that fellow
there to our desktop. Okay, and then we're
just gonna hit enter there. And it's just
complain, because I typed it in manually.
And I have a spelling mistake, we need an
R there. And it should just download that
file. Great. So if we go check our desktop,
there we go, we've downloaded a file from
our s3 bucket. Now, we want to upload a file.
So down in here, I have an additional file
here called Q, and I want to get that into
my bucket vcli, it's going to be the same
command, we're just going to do it in the
reverse order here. So we're gonna do Avis
s3, CP, and we're first gonna provide the
file locally, we want to upload here, and
that's going to be enterprise d, q dot jpg,
and we're going to want to send that to s3.
So we have to specify the protocol of the
bucket name, the folder here that it's going
to be in enterprise D, make sure it won't
be spelling mistakes this time. And we're
just going to put q dot jpg, okay. And we're
going to send out there to s3 and you can
see it's uploaded, we're going to refresh.
And there it's been added to our s3 bucket.
Great. So now we know how to list things and
upload or download things from s3. And now
we can move on to pre signed URL. So we saw
earlier that was data, we had access to data
here because he was public. So if we were
to click this fellow here, we can access him
right. But let's say we wanted to access a
queue that we just uploaded, right? And so
by default, they are private. Okay, so if
I was to open this, I'm not going to be able
to see it, it's access tonight, which is a
good, good, good and sane default. But let's
say I wanted to give someone temporary access.
And this is where pre signed URLs come. So
pre signed URLs, what it's going to do is
going to generate a URL with the credentials
that we need to be able to temporarily temporarily
access it. Okay. So if I were to copy this
AWS s3 pre signed URL here, and what we'll
just type it out, it's not a big deal here.
And we're going to try to get access to this,
this Q file here. So we're going to want to
do enterprise D.
And we're gonna say q dot j, jpg, and we're
gonna put an expires on there expires, like
by default, I
think it's like an hour or something. But
we want it to expire after 300 seconds. So
people like these aren't these links aren't
staying around there. Again, they're temporary,
right? And I'm just going to hit enter there.
Um, and I've made a mistake, I actually forgot
to write the word pre signed in there. Okay,
what's going to do, it's going to spit back
a URL. So if we were to take this URL, right,
and then supply it up here, now we actually
have access. So that's a way for you to provide
temporary access to private files. This is
definitely a use case that you'd have if let's
say you had paid content behind, like a web
application that you'd have to sign up to
gain access. And this is how you give them
temporary access to whatever file they wanted.
And I just wanted to note, I think this is
the case, where if we were to actually open
this here, so again, if we have this URL that
has the Access ID, etc, up there, but if we
were to open it up via this tab, I think it
doesn't exact same thing. So it has a security
token here. So I guess maybe it's not exactly
the same thing, but I was hoping maybe this
was actually also using a pre signed URL here.
But anyway, the point is, is that if you want
to access temporary files, you're going to
be using pre signed URLs.
So we uploaded all our files here into this
bucket. And when we did, so it automatically
went to the storage class standard by default.
So let's say we want to change the storage
class for our objects, we're not going to
do that at the bucket level, we're going to
do it at the object level here. So we're gonna
go to properties here for Gaiden. And all
we have to do here is choose the class that
we want to standardize. And we're going to
hit save, and now we can start saving money.
So that's all it takes to switch storage classes.
But let's say we want to automate that process.
Because if we were handling a lot of log files,
maybe after 30 days, we don't really need
need them anymore, but we need to hold on
to them for the next seven years. And that's
where lifecycle policies are going to come
in play. So what we're going to do is we're
going to go back to our bucket, we're going
to go to management. Here, we have lifecycle,
and we're going to add a new lifecycle rule.
So we'll say, here, we'll do just for something
simple, say so after 30 days, so 30 day rule.
And we could limit the scope of what files
we want. So if we wanted to say just enterprise
D here, we could do enterprise D, okay, that's
not what I'm going to do. I'm just going to
say, all files within the actual bucket here,
go next. And then we can choose the storage
class. So transition. So here, we have to
decide whether it's the current version of
the previous versions, okay, and so I'm just
gonna say it's gonna be the current version.
All right, always the current version here,
we're going to add a transition, and we're
going to move anything that's in standard
into standard ay ay ay. and it's going to
be after 30 days, I don't think you can go
below that, if I try seven here, see, so the
minimum value here has to be 30. So we're
gonna have to set it to 30. I think we saw
those, those, those minimums in the actual
storage class when we were setting them. So
if you're wondering what those are, they're
probably over there. But we'll just hit next
here. And so then after we're seeing that
it's been transitioned, after 30 days, it's
going to move to move to that. And we can
also set an expiration. So we don't necessarily
need to set this but this is if we wanted
to actually delete the file. So after current
days, we could then say, to completely delete
the files, which is not what we're going to
do, we're just going to hit next. And click
that. And now we have a rule that was going
to automate the moving of our files from one
storage class to another. Alright, so there
you go.
So we're gonna learn how to set up cross region
replication here. And so this is going to
allow us to copy one files to from a bucket
to another bucket. And this could be in another
region and in another AWS account, okay, so
there's a few different possibilities here
as to why we'd want to do that. But let's
just learn how to actually do it. And so we
did, we're going to need to create a replication.
But before we can do that, we're going to
need a destination bucket. So we're going
to go back here to s3, we're going to create
a new bucket, I'm just going to call it exam
pro BBB. And I'm going to set this to Canada
Central, okay, if this name is not available,
you're just going to have to come up with
your own names here. But just make sure you're
saying it to another region for this, this
example here. And so now we have a bucket
in the States and in Canada, and we're almost
ready to go, we just have to make sure that
we have versioning turned on in both buckets,
both the source and destination. So we'll
go here to our new bucket, turn on versioning.
Okay, and I already know that we have versioning
turned on in our source. But we'll just take
a quick look here. So here it is turned on.
And so now we are ready to turn on cross region
replication. So we'll go ahead and create
our rule in our source bucket, our source
bucket is selected here. Then we'll go next.
And we will choose our destination bucket.
And so now we have a couple options here,
which can happen during replication. So we
can actually change the storage class, which
is a good idea if you want to save money.
So the other bucket is just like your backup
bucket. And you don't plan to really use those
files, you probably would want to change the
storage class there to save money. And you
can also send the this to someone else's bucket
in another AWS account. So maybe you your
use case is this bucket has a files and you
want to provide it to multiple clients. And
so you've used that replication rule to replicate
it to their, their buckets, okay, but we're
just this is going to be our buckets for the
time being. And we're going to go ahead here
and create a new role. And we'll just call
it cc R. us to Canada. Okay. I will just create
a new rule. So we have permissions to go ahead
and do that there. And we'll get a nice little
summary here and hit save. And we will wait
and we'll cross our fingers as As the replication
figuration was not found, so this sometimes
happens, it's not a really big deal here.
So just go back to replication. And it actually
did work, I think. So, sometimes what happens
is, the roll isn't created in time. So you
know, sometimes it's green, and sometimes
it's red, but just come back and double check
here because it definitely is set. So now
we have replication set up. So now we're going
to learn how to set up bucket policies. So
we can create custom rules about the type
of access we want to allow to our buckets.
So in order to do so we're going to go to
our exam pro 000 bucket, we're going to go
to permissions, and we're going to go to bucket
policy, okay. And so this is where we're going
to provide a policy in the format of Jason
file here, it's very hard to remember these.
So luckily, they have a little policy generator
down here, I'm gonna open it in a new tab.
And we're going to drop this down to s3, and
we're going to define what kind of access
control we want to have. So let's say we wanted
to deny anyone being able to upload new files
in this bucket. I don't know why you'd want
to do that. But maybe there's a use case.
So we're gonna say denied, we're gonna give
it a asterik here. So we can say this applies
to everyone. The service is going to be s3,
of course, and we're going to look for the
actions here. So we're just going to look
for the puts. So we'll say put bucket ACL.
And there should just be a regular put in
here. Oh, that's, that's bucket ACL. We want
objects. So we say bucket, put object and
put object ACL so we can't upload files. And
we'll have to provide the Arn and they give
you a bit of an indicator as to what the format
is here. That's going to be exam pro hyphen,
000, at Ford slash Asterix, so it's gonna
say any of the files within that bucket. And
we're gonna go add that statement and generate
that policy. And now we have our JSON. Okay,
so we'll copy that, go back over here, paste
it in, save it, cross your fingers, hope it
works. And it has saved Yeah, so you don't
get like a response here. I'm just gonna save
again, and then just refresh it to just be
100% sure here and go back to your bucket
policy. And there it persists. So our bucket
policy is now in place. So we should not be
able to upload new files. So let's go find
out if that is actually the case. So here
I am in the overview here and enterprise D.
And I want to upload a new file to to see
so let's go to our enterprise D and we have
a new person here we have Tom Alok, he is
a Romulan, and we do not want him in the enterprise
D here. So we're going to drag it over here
and see what happens, we're going to hit upload.
Okay. And you're going to see that it's successfully
uploaded. Okay,
so we're going to go ahead and do a refresh
here and see if it actually is there. And
it looked like it worked. But I guess it didn't,
because we do have that policy there. So there
you go. But let's just to be 100% sure that
our policy actually is working, because I
definitely don't see it there. We're gonna
go back there. And we're just going to remove
our policy. Okay, so we're gonna go ahead
here and just delete the policy, right? It's
where the interface shows it to you as if
you know, it's actually working. And so Tom
lock is definitely not in there. But our policy
has been removed. So now if we were to upload
it, Tom should be able to infiltrate the enterprise
D bucket here, we're going to do an upload
here. Okay. Let's see if we get a different
result. And there it is. So there you go.
So our bucket policy was working, you can
see that ABS can be a little bit misleading.
So you do have to double check things that
happened for me all the time. But there you
go, that is how you set up.
So we are on to the s3 cheat sheet. And this
is a very long cheat sheet because s3 is so
important to the eight of us associate certification,
so we need to know the service inside and
out. So s3 stands for simple storage service.
It's an object based storage, and allows you
to store unlimited amounts of data without
worrying of the underlying storage infrastructure.
s3 replicates data across at least three availability
zones to ensure 99.9% availability and 11
nines of durability on just contain your data.
So you can think of objects like files, objects,
objects can be sized anywhere from zero bytes
to five terabytes, I've highlighted zero bytes
in red because most people don't realize they
can be zero bytes in size. Buckets contain
objects and buckets can also contain folders,
which can in turn contain objects. And you
can also just think of buckets themselves
as folders. Buckets names are unique across
all AWS accounts. So you can treat them like
domain names. So there you your bucket name
has to be unique within within the entire
world. When you upload a file to s3 successfully
then you'll receive an HTTP 200 code Lifecycle
Management feature So this allows you to move
objects between different storage classes.
And objects can be deleted automatically based
on a schedule. So you will create lifecycle
lifecycle rules or policies to make that happen,
then you have versioning. So this allows you
to have
version IDs on your objects. So when you upload
a new object, the overtop of an existing object,
the old objects will still remain, you can
access any previous object based on their
version ID. When you delete an object, the
previous object will be restored. Once you
turn on versioning cannot be turned off, it
can only be suspended. Then we have MFA delete.
So this allows you to enforce all delete operations
to require an MFA token in order to delete
an object, so you must have versioning turned
on to use this, you can only turn on MFA delete
from the ADC Li and it's really just the root
account or the root user who's allowed to
delete these objects. All new buckets are
private by default, logging can be turned
on on a bucket. So you can track all the operations
performed on objects. Then you have access
control, which is configured using either
bucket policies or access control lists. So
we have bucket policies, which are Jason documents,
which let you write complex control access.
Then you have ACLs. And they are the legacy
legacy method. They came before bucket bucket
policies. And they're not depreciated. So
there's no full part in using them, but they're
just not used as often anymore. And it allows
you to grant object access to objects and
buckets with simple actions. And so now we're
on to the security portion. So security in
transit is something you have with s3, because
all the files uploaded are done over SSL.
And so you have SSC, which stands for server
side encryption. s3 has three options for
SSE. We have SSE A S. And so s3 handles the
key itself, and it uses a Aes 256 algorithm
as the encryption method, then you have SSE
kms. And as the name implies, it is using
a key management service, which is an envelope
encryption service. And so AWS manages the
the key and so do you, then you have SSE C,
and the C stands for work customer. So it's
a customer provided key, you actually upload
the key, and you have full control over key
but you also have to manage that key. All
right, s3 doesn't come with client side encryption,
it's up to you to encrypt your files locally,
and then upload them to s3, you could store
your client side key in kms. So that is an
option for you. But it's not that important
to actually have here on the cheat sheet.
You have also cross region replication. This
allows you to replicate files across regions
for greater durability, you must have versioning
turned on in the source and destination bucket
in order to use cross region replication.
And you can replicate a source bucket to a
bucket in another AWS account, then you have
transfer acceleration. This provides fast
and secure uploads from anywhere in the world
data is uploaded via a distinct URL to an
edge location. And data is then transported
to your s3 bucket via the AWS backbone network,
which is super fast, then you have pre signed
URLs. And this is a URL generated via the
HSC ally or SDK, it provides temporary access
to write or download to an object like data
to that actual object via that endpoint. Pre
signed URLs are commonly used to access private
objects. And the last thing is our storage
classes. And we have six different kinds of
storage classes started with standard. And
that's the default one. And it's fast. It's
has 99.99% availability, 11 nines of durability,
you access files within the milliseconds and
it replicates your data across at least three
azs. Then you have the intelligent tear, tearing
storage class. And this uses XML to analyze
your objects usage and determine the appropriate
storage to help you save money and just move
to those other storage classes which recovering
now, then you have standard and frequency
access. Review to IAA it's just as fast as
standard. It's cheaper to access files, if
you're only accessing files less than once
a month. So just one file in the month, if
you access it twice. Now it's the same class
of standard probably a little bit more because
there's an additional retrieval fee. When
you try to grab those files. It's 50% less
than standard. The trade off here is reduced
availability, then you have one zone IAA.
And as the name implies, it's not replicating
cross three azs just at least three Z's. It's
only in one az, so it's going to be super
fast. And the trade off here is it's going
to be 20% cheaper than standard IAA, but now
you also have reduced durability. And again,
it has a retrieval fee. Then you have glacier
and Glazier is for long term cold storage.
It's archival storage, and it's a very very,
very cheap the tradeoff here is that it's
going to take between minutes to hours for
you to actually access your files if you need
them. Then you have glacier deep archive,
it is the cheapest, the cheapest solution
or storage class on our list. And you can't
access your files for up to 12 hours. So if
that's how long it's going to take before
you can use them. So that is the s3 cheat
sheet. It was a very long cheat sheet. But
there's a lot of great information here. So
hey, this is Angie brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at AWS snowball, which is a
petabyte scale data transfer service. So move
data onto a database via a physical briefcase
computer. Alright, so let's say you needed
to get a lot of data onto AWS very quickly
and very inexpensively. Well, snowball is
going to help you out there because if you
were to try and transfer 100 terabytes over
a high speed internet to AWS, it could take
over 100 days where with a snowball, it will
take less than a week. And again, for cost.
If you had to transfer 100 terabytes over
high speed internet, it's gonna cost you 1000s
of dollars, where snowball is going to reduce
that cost by 1/5. Now we'll just go through
some of the features of snowball here, it
does come with an E ink display, it kind of
looks like your shipping label, but it is
digital, which is kind of cool. It's tamper
and weatherproof. The data is encrypted end
to end using tivity. Six bit encryption, it
has a Trusted Platform Module, TPM is just
this little chip here. And as it says here,
endpoint device that stores RSA encryption
keys specific to host systems for hardware
authentication. So that's a cool little hardware
feature. And for security purposes, data transfers
must be completed within 90 days of the snowball
being prepared. And this data is going to
come into s3, you can either import or export.
So not only can you you know use this to get
data into the cloud, it can be a way for you
to get data out of the cloud it snowball comes
in two sizes, we have 50 terabytes and 80
terabytes. Now you don't get to utilize all
the space on there. So in reality, it's really
42 terabytes and 72 terabytes. And you're
going to notice that it said this was a petabyte
scale migration, while they're suggesting
that you use multiple multiple snowballs to
get to petabytes. So you don't you don't transport
petabytes in one snowball, it's going to take
multiple snowballs to do that. Alright. Now
we're going to take a look here at Ada snowball
edge, which again, is a petabyte scale data
transfer service move data on database via
a physical briefcase computer, but it's going
to have more storage and onsite compute capacity
capabilities. So just looking at snowball
edge here in greater detail, you're going
to notice one aesthetic difference is that
it has these little orange bars, maybe that's
the way to distinguish snowball from snowball
edge, but it's similar to snowball, but with
more storage and with local processing. So
going through these features, instead of having
an ink display, it's going to have an LCD
display. So again, it's the shipping information.
But with other functionality. The huge advantage
here is that it can undertake local processing
and edge computing workloads. It also has
the ability to cluster so you can get a bunch
of these noble edges and have them work on
a single job kind of like having your own
little mini data center up to five to 10 devices.
And it comes in three options for device configuration.
So you can optimize for storage compute or
with GPU optimization. And the CPU amounts
are going to change in this device based on
what you need. And snowball edge comes in
two sizes. We have 100 terabytes, that's 83
terabytes of usage space. And then we have
the clustered version, and it's lesser, a
fewer amounts of terabytes. But of course,
you're gonna be using this in clusters. So
there's good reasons for that. So there you
go. That's still no, now we're taking a look
here at snowmobile, and it is a 45 foot long
shipping container pulled by a semi trailer
track, it can transfer up to 100 petabytes
personal mobiel. So in order to get to exabytes,
you're gonna need a few of these, but it definitely
is feasible. And it has some really cool security
features built in. We have GPS tracking, alarm
monitoring, 24 seven video surveillance and
an escort security vehicle while in transit.
Now that is an optional feature. I don't know
if it costs more, but it's definitely sounds
really cool. So you know, just to wrap this
up here, eight of us personnel will help you
connect your network to the snowmobile. And
when data transfer is complete, we'll drive
it back data bus and import it into s3 or
s3 Glacier. So
there you are. I'm for the cheat sheet and
it's for snowball, snowball edge and snowmobile.
So let's jump into it. So snowball and snowball
edge is a rugged container, which contains
a storage device. snowmobile is a 45 foot
long ruggedized shipping container pulled
by a semi trailer truck snowball and snowball
edge is for petabyte scale migration, whereas
snowmobile is for exabyte scale migration.
So the advantages here with snowball is low
cost so 1000s of dollars to transfer 100 terabytes
over high speed internet snowball comes at
1/5 of the price, then we have speed 100 terabytes
over 100 days to transfer over high speed
internet. Or you can use snowball, which takes
less than a week. And so then we talked about
snowball here. So snowball comes in two sizes,
we have 50 terabytes and 80 terabytes, but
the actual usable space is less so it's 42
and 72. Then you have snowball edge, it comes
in two sizes, we have 100 terabytes and 100
terabytes clustered. And then the usability
here is gonna be 83 and 45. snowmobile comes
in one size 100 petabytes per vehicle, and
you can both export or import data using snowball
or snowmobile Okay, and that also includes
snowball edge there, you can import into s3
or glacia snowball edge can undertake local
processing and edge low edge computing workloads.
snowball edge can use be used in a cluster
in groups of five to 10 devices. And snowball
edge provides three options for device configurations,
we have storage optimized, compute optimized
and GPU optimized and the variation there
is going to be how many CPUs are utilized
and GPU have is going to have more GPUs on
board there. So there you go, that that is
your snowball, snowball edge and snowmobile.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at Virtual Private Cloud known
as VPC. And this service allows you to provision
logically isolated sections of your database
cloud where you can launch eight of his resources
in a virtual network that you define.
So here we are looking at an architectural
diagram of a VPC with multiple networking
resources or components within it. And I just
want to emphasize how important it is to learn
VPC and all components inside and out because
it's for every single aidable certification
with the exception of the cloud practitioner.
So we definitely need to master all these
things. So the easiest way to remember what
a VPC is for is think of it as your own personal
data center, it gives you complete control
over your virtual networking environment.
All right, so the idea is that we have internet,
it flows into an internet gateway, it goes
to a router, the router goes to a route table,
the route table passes through knakal. And
the knakal sends the traffic to the public
and private subnets. And your resources could
be contained within a security group all within
a VPC. So there's a lot of moving parts. And
these are not even all the components. And
there's definitely a bunch of different configurations
we can look at. So looking at the core components,
these are the ones that we're going to learn
in depth, and there are a few more than these,
but these are the most important ones. So
we're going to learn what an internet gateway
is. We're gonna learn what a virtual private
gateway is route tables, knackles, security
groups, public and private subnets, Nat gateway
and instances customer gateway VPC endpoints
and VPC peering. So, this section is very
overwhelming. But you know, once you get it
down, it's it's pretty easy going forward.
So we just need to master all these things
and commit them to memory. Now that we kind
of have an idea, what's the purpose of VPC,
let's look at some of its key features, limitations
and some other little things we want to talk
about. So here on the right hand side, this
is the form to create a VPC, it's literally
four fields. It's that simple. You name it,
you give it an address, you can also give
it an additional ipv6 address. You can't be
or it's either this and this. And you can
set its tendencies to default or dedicated,
dedicated, meaning that it's running on dedicated
hardware. If you're an enterprise, you might
care about that. This is what the ipv6 cider
block would look like because you don't enter
it in Amazon generates one for you. So v PCs
are region specific. They do not span regions,
you can create up to five epcs per region.
Every region comes with a default VPC, you
can have 200 subnets per VPC, that's a lot
of subnets. You can create, as we said, Here,
an ipv4 cider block, you actually have to
create one it's a requirement. And in addition
to you can provide an ipv6 cider block. It's
good to know that when you create a VPC, it
doesn't cost you anything. That goes the same
for route tables, knackles, internet gateway
security groups subnets and VPC peering. However,
there are resources within the VPC that are
going to cost you money such as Nat gateways,
VPC endpoints, VPN gateways, customer gateways,
but most the time you'll be working with the
ones that don't cost any money so that there
shouldn't be too much of a concern of getting
over billed. One thing I do want to point
out is that when you do create a VPC, it doesn't
have DNS host names turned on by default.
If you're wondering what that option is for
what it does is when you launch easy two instances
and so here down below, I have an easy to
instance and it will get a public IP but it
will only get a Public DNS, which looks like
a domain name, like an address, and that's
literally what it is. But if this isn't turned
on that easy to instance, won't get one. So
if you're wondering, why isn't that there,
it's probably because your host names are
disabled and they are disabled by default,
you just got to turn that.
So we were
saying earlier that you get a default VPC
for every single region. And the idea behind
that is so that you can immediately launch
EC two instances without having to really
think about all the networking stuff you have
to set up. But for Eva certification, we do
need to know what is going on. And it's not
just a default dBc It comes with other things
and with specific configurations. And we definitely
need to know that for the exams. So the first
thing is it creates a VPC of cider block size
16. We're going to also get default subnets
with it. So for every single AZ in that region,
we're going to get a subnet per AZ and there
gonna be a cider block size 20. It's going
to create an internet gateway and connect
it to your default VPC. So that means that
our students is going to reach the internet,
it's going to come with a default security
group and associated with your default VPC.
So if you launch an EC two instance, it will
automatically default to the security group
unless you override it. It will also come
with by by default, a knakal. And associated
with your VPC, it will also default DHCP options.
One thing that it's implied is that you It
comes with a main route table, okay, so when
you create a VPC, it automatically comes to
the main route table. So I would assume that
that comes by default as well. So there are
all people.
So I just wanted to touch on this 0.0 dot
zero forward slash zero here, which is also
known as default. And what it is, is it represents
all possible IP addresses. Okay, and so you
know, when you're doing a device networking,
you're going to be using this to get the GW
to have a route like routing traffic to the
GW to the internet. When you're using a security
group, when you set up your inbound rules,
you're going to set 0.0 dot 0.0 to allow any
traffic from the internet to access your public
resources. So anytime you see this, just think
of it as giving access from anywhere or the
internet. Okay. We're looking at
VPC peering, which allows you to connect one
VPC to another over direct network route using
private IP addresses. So the idea is we have
VPC, a VPC Zb. And we want to treat it so
like the they behave like they're on the same
network. And that's what VPC peering connection
allows us to do. So it's very simple to create
a peering connection, we just give it a name,
we say V, what we want is the requester. So
that could be VP ca and then we want as the
acceptor which could be VP CB, and we can
say whether it's in my account, or another
account, or this region or another region.
So you can see that allows v PCs from same
or different regions to talk to each other.
There is some limitations around the configuration.
So you know, when you're peering, you're using
star configuration, so you'd have one central
VPC and then you might have four around it.
And so for each one, you're going to have
to have a peering connection. There's no transitive
peering. So what does that mean? Well, the
idea is like, let's say VPC c wants to talk
to VPC, B, the traffic's not going to flow
through a, you actually would have to create
another direct connection from C to B. So
it's only to the nearest neighbor, where that
communication is going to happen. And you
can't have overlapping cider blocks. So if
these had the same cider block, this was 172
31. This was 172 31, we're gonna have a conflict
and we're not gonna be able to talk to each
other. So that is the VPC peering in a nutshell.
Alright, so we're taking a look here at route
tables. The route tables are used to determine
where network traffic is directed, okay. And
so each subnet in your V PC must be associated
with a route table. And a subnet can only
be associated with one route table at a time,
but you can associate multiple subnets subnets
with the same route table. Alright, so now
down below, I have just like the most common
example of where you're using route tables.
And that's just allowing your easy two instances
to gain access to the internet. So you'd have
a public subnet where that easy to instance
resides and that's going to be associated
with a route table. That read route table
is going to have us routes in here. And here
you can see we have a route, which has the
internet gateway attached that allows access
to the internet. Okay, so there you go. That's
all there is to it. We're taking a look at
Internet gateway internet gateway allows your
VPC access to the internet and I N GW does
two things. It provides a target in your VPC
route tables for internet routable traffic.
And it can also perform network address translation
Nat, which we'll get into in another section
for instances that have been assigned a public
ipv4 address. Okay, so down below here, I
have a representation of how I GW works. So
the idea is that we have internet over here
and to access the internet, we need an internet
gateway, but to route traffic from our EC
two instances or anything, they're gonna have
to pass through a route table to get to a
router. And so we need to create a new route
in our route table for the ID W. So I gwi
hyphen, Id identifies that resource, and then
we're going to give it 0.0 point zero as the
destination. Alright, so that's all there
is to it. So we talked about how we could
use Nat gateways or Nat instances to gain
access to the internet for our EC two instances
that live in a private subnet. But let's say
you wanted to SSH into that easy to essence,
well, it's in a private subnet, so it doesn't
have a public IP address. So what you need
is you need an intermediate EC two instance
that you're going to SSH into. And then you're
going to jump from that box to this one, okay?
And that's why bastions are also known as
jump boxes. And this institute instance for
the bastion is hardened. So it should be very,
very secure, because this is going to be your
point of entry into your private EC two instances.
And some people might always ask, Well, if
a NAT instance, like Nat gateways, we can't
obviously turn into bastions, but a NAT instance
is just a new situation, it's Couldn't you
have it double as a bastion, and the possibility
of it is possible, but generally the way you
configure NATS and also, from a security perspective,
you'd never ever want to do that, you'd always
want to have a different EC two instance,
as your Bastion. Now, there is a service called
SYSTEMS MANAGER, session manager and it replaces
the need for bastions so that you don't have
to launch your own EC two instances. So generally,
that's recommended in AWS. But you know, bastions
are still being commonly used throughout a
lot of companies because it needs to meet
whatever their requirements are, and they're
just comfortable with them. So there you go.
So we're gonna take a look at Direct Connect,
and Direct Connect is in aid of a solution
for establishing dedicated network connections
from on premise locations to AWS, it's extremely
fast. And so depending on what configuration
you get, if it's in the lower bandwidth, we're
looking between 1550 megabytes to 500 megabytes,
or the higher bandwidth is one gigabytes to
10 gigabytes. So the transfer rate to your
on premise environment, the network to AWS,
is it considerably fast. And this can be really
important if you are an enterprise and you
want to keep the same level of performance
that you're used to. So yeah, the takeaway
here with Direct Connect is that it helps
reduce network costs increase bandwidth throughput,
it provides a more consistent network experience
than a typical internet internet based connection.
Okay, so that's all.
We're looking
at VPC endpoints, and they're used to privately
connect your V PC to other Ada services, and
VPC endpoint services. So I have a use case
here to make it crystal clear. So imagine
you have an EC two instance, and you want
to get something from your s3 bucket. So what
you normally do is use the ABS SDK and you
would make that call, and it would go out
of your internet gateway to the internet back
into the AWS network to get that file or or
object out of s3. So wouldn't it be more convenient
if we could just keep the traffic within the
AWS network and that is the purpose of a VPC
endpoint. It helps you keep traffic within
the EBS network. And the idea is now because
it does not leave a network, we do not require
a public IP address to communicate with these
services. I eliminates the need for an internet
gateway. So let's say we didn't need this
internet gateway, the only reason we were
using it was to get to s3, we can now eliminate
that and keep everything private. So you know,
there you go. There are two types of VPC endpoints
inter interface endpoints and gateway endpoints.
And we're going to get into that.
So we're going to look at the first type of
VPC endpoint and that is interface endpoints.
And they're called interface endpoints because
they actually provision an elastic network
interface, an actual network interface card
with a private IP address, and they serve
as an entry point for traffic going to a supported
service. If you read a bit more about interface
endpoints, they are powered by AWS private
link. There's not much to say here, that's
just what it is. So Access Services hostname
is easily securely by keeping your network
traffic within a bus network. This is always
confused me this branding of Eva's private
link. But you know, you might as well just
think of interface endpoints, and it is prevalent
to be in the same thing. Again, it does cost
something because it is speeding up and he
and I, and so you know, it's it's point 01
cents per hour. And so over a month's time,
if you had it on for the entire time, it's
going to cost around $7.50. And the interface
endpoint supports a variety of native services,
not everything. But here's a good list of
them for you.
The second type of VCP endpoint is a gateway
endpoint and a gateway endpoint. It has a
target for a specific route in your row table
used for traffic destined for a supported
database service. And this endpoint is 100%.
Free because you're just adding something
to your row table. And you're going to be
utilizing it mostly for Amazon s3 and dynamodb.
So you saw that first use case where I showed
you that we were getting the AC units in stock
yesterday that was using a gateway endpoint.
So there you go. Here we are at the VPC endpoint
cheat sheet and this is going to be a quick
one, so let's get to it. VPC endpoints help
keep traffic between awa services within the
AWS network. There are two kinds of VPC endpoints
interface endpoints and gateway endpoints.
interface endpoints cost money, whereas gateway
endpoints are free interface endpoints uses
a elastic network interface in the UI with
a private IP address part. And this was all
powered by private link. gateway endpoints
is a target for a specific route in your route
table. And interface endpoints support many
ad services, whereas gateway endpoints only
support dynamodb and s3.
So we're going to take a look at VPC flow
logs, which allows you to capture IP traffic
information in and out from your network interfaces
within your VPC. So you can turn on flow logs
at three different levels. You can turn it
on at the VPC level, which we're doing right
here. You can turn it on at a specific subnet,
or you can turn it on for a specific network
interface. The idea is this all trickles down.
So the turn off VBC is it's monitoring everything
below. And same thing with subnets. To find
VPC flow logs, you just go to go to the VPC
console, and there's gonna be a tab for flow
logs. Same thing with subnets and network
interface, we're gonna be able to create that
flow log. And so here is that forms Do you
have an idea what you can do here. So the
idea is you can choose to filter for only
the accepted or rejected or all. So I'm saying
it all, and it can deliver those logs to cloudwatch
logs, they can also deliver them to an s3
bucket If you would prefer them to go there
instead. So you know, that's the general stuff.
But once you create a flow log, you can't
really edit it, all you can do is delete it.
So there you go. So we now know what VPC flow
logs are for. But let's actually take a look
at what VPC flow logs look like. And so here
I have the structure up here of the data that
is stored on a VPC flow logs so it stores
these on individual lines. And immediately
below, we actually have an example of a VPC
flow log. And this is the full description
of all these attributes. And these are pretty
straightforward. The only thing I really want
you to go away with here is that the fact
that it stores the source IP address and the
destination IP address. There's some exam
questions and the probably at the pro level
or the specialty level where we're talking
about VPC flow logs. And the question might
have to do with like, you know, just the VPC
flow logs contain host names or does it contain
IP addresses? And, and the answer is it contains
IP addresses. So that's the big takeaway here
that I wanted to show. So now that we've learned
everything about VPC flow logs, here's your
cheat sheet for when you go sit the exam.
So the first thing is VPC flow logs monitors
the in and out traffic of your network interfaces
within your VPC. You can turn on flow logs
at the VPC subnet or network interface level.
VPC flow logs cannot be tagged like other
resources. You cannot change the configuration
of a flow log after it's been created. You
cannot enable full logs for epcs which are
appeared within your VPC unless it's the same
account. VPC flow logs can be delivered to
s3 or cloud watch logs. VPC flow logs contain
the source and destination IP addresses so
not the host names okay. And there's some
instance traffic that will not get monitored.
So instance traffic generated by Contact the
Avis DNS servers, Windows license activation
traffic from instances traffic to and from
instance metadata addresses DHCP traffic any
traffic to the reserved IP address of the
default VPC router. So there you go. Andrew
Brown from exam Pro, and we are looking at
network access control lists, also known as
knackles. It is an optional layer of security
that acts as a firewall for controlling traffic
in and out of subnets. So knackles act as
a virtual firewall at the subnet level. And
when you create a VPC, you automatically get
a knakal by default, just like security groups
knackles have both inbound and outbound rules
of the difference here is that you're going
to have the ability to allow or deny traffic
in either way. Okay, so for security groups,
you can only allow whereas knackles, you have
deny. Now, when you create these rules here,
it's pretty much the same as security groups
with the exception that we have this thing
called rule number And rule number is going
to determine the order of evaluation for these
rules, and the way it evaluates is going to
be from the lowest to the highest, the highest
rule number, it could be 32,766. And AWS recommends
that when you come up with these rule numbers,
you use increments of 10 or 100. So you have
some flexibility to create rules in between
if you need be, again, subnets are at the
subnet level. So in order for them to apply,
you need to associate subnets to knackles.
And subnets can only belong to a single knakal.
Okay, so yeah, where you have security groups,
you can have a instances that belong to multiple
ones for knackles. It's just a singular case,
okay? Alright,
we're just gonna look at a use case for knackles.
Here, it's going to be really around this
deny ability. So let's say there is a malicious
actor trying to gain access to our instances,
and we know the IP address, well, we can add
that as a rule to our knakal and deny that
IP address. And let's say we know that we
never need to SSH into these instances. And
we just want to additional guarantee in case
someone Miss configures, a security group
that SSH access is denied. So we'll just deny
on port 22. And now we have those two cases
covered. So there you go. So we're on to the
knackles cheat sheets. Let's jump into it.
So network access control list is commonly
known as nachal. v PCs are automatically given
default knakal, which allow all outbound and
inbound traffic. Each subnet with any VPC
must be associated with a knakal. subnets
can only be associated with one knakal. At
a time associating a subnet with a new knakal
will remove the previous Association. If a
knakal is not exclusively associated with
a subnet, the subnet will automatically be
associated with the default knakal knakal
has inbound and outbound rules just like security
groups, rules can either allow or deny traffic,
unlike security groups, which can only allow
knackles or stateless. So that means your
it's going to allow inbound traffic and also
outbound. When you create a knakal, it will
deny all traffic by default knackles contain
a number numbered list of rules that gets
evaluated in order from lowest to highest.
If you need to block a single IP address,
you could you could be a knackles. You cannot
do this via security groups because you cannot
have deny actions. Okay, so there you go.
Hey, it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro, we are
looking at security groups. And they help
protect our EC two instances by acting as
a virtual firewall controlling the inbound
and outbound traffic, as I just said, security
groups acts as a virtual firewall at the instance
level. So you would have an easy to instance
and you would attach to it security groups.
And so here is an easy to instance. And we've
attached a security group to it. So what does
it look like on the inside for security groups,
each security group contains a set of rules
that filter traffic coming into. So that's
inbound, and out of outbound to that easy
to instance. So here we have two tabs, inbound
and outbound. And we can set these are rules,
right. And we can set these rules with a particular
protocol and a port range. And also who's
allowed to have access. So in this case, I
want to be able to SSH into this YSU instance,
which uses the TCP protocol. And the standard
port for SSH is 22. And I'm going to allow
only my IP so anytime you see forward slash
32 that always means my IP. All right. So
that's all you have to do to add inbound and
outbound rules. There are no deny rules. So
all traffic is blocked by default unless a
rule specifically allows it. And multiple
instances across multiple subnets can belong
to a security group. So here I have three
different EC two instances, and they're all
in different subnets. And security groups
do not care about subnets, you just assign
EC two instance, to a security group. And,
you know, just in this case, and they're all
in the same one, and now they can all talk
to each other, okay?
You're I have three security group scenarios,
and they all pretty much do the same thing.
But the configuration is different to give
you a good idea of variation on how you can
achieve things. And so the idea is we have
a web application running on a situ instance.
And it is connecting to an RDS database to
get its information running in a private subnet.
Okay. And so in the first case, what we're
doing is we have an inbound rule on the SU
database saying allowing for anything from
5432, which is the Postgres port number, for
this specific IP address. And so it allows
us these two instance to connect to that RDS
database. And so the takeaway here is you
can specify the source to be an IP range,
or specific IP. And so this is very specific,
it's forward slash 32. And that's a nice way
of saying exactly one IP address. Now in the
second scenario, it looks very similar. And
the only difference is, instead of providing
an IP address as a source, we can provide
another security group. So now anything within
the security group is allowed to gain access
for inbound traffic on 5432. Okay, now, in
our last use case, down below, we have inbound
traffic on port 80, and inbound traffic on
port 22, for the SG public group, and then
we have the EC two instance and the RDS database
within its own security group. So the idea
is that that EC two instance is allowed to
talk to that RDS database, and that EC two
instance is not exposing the RDS database
to it well wouldn't, because it's in a private
subnets, that doesn't have a public IP address.
But the point is, is that this is to instance,
now is able to get traffic from the internet,
it's also able to accept someone from like
for an SSH access, okay. And so the big takeaway
here is that you can see that an instance
can belong to multiple security groups and
rules are permissive. So when we have two
security groups, and this one has allows,
and this is going to take precedence over
su stack, which doesn't have anything, you
know, because it's denied by default, everything,
but anything that allows is going to override
that, okay, so you can nest multiple security
groups onto one EC two instance. So just keep
that stuff. There are a few security group
limits I want you to know about. And so we'll
look at the first you can have up to 10,000
security groups in a single region, and it's
defaulted to 2500. If you want to go beyond
that 2500, you need to make a service limit
increase request to Eva support, you can have
60 inbound rules and 60 outbound rules per
security group. And you can have 16 security
groups per EMI. And that's defaulted to five.
Now, if you think about like, how many scripts
Can you have on an instance? Well, it's depending
on how many annise are actually attached to
that security group. So if you have to realize
that it's attached to a security group, then
by default, you'll have 10. Or if you have
the upper limit here, 16, you'll be able to
have 32 security groups on a single instance.
Okay, so those are the limits, you know, I
thought were worth telling. So we're gonna
take a look at our security groups cheat sheet.
So we're ready for exam time. So security
groups act as a firewall at the instance level,
unless allowed, specifically, all inbound
traffic is blocked by default, all outbound
traffic from the instance is allowed by default,
you can specify for the source to be either
an IP range, a single IP address or another
security group. security groups are stateful.
If traffic is allowed, inbound is also allowed
outbound. Okay, so that's what stateful means.
Any changes to your security group will take
effect immediately. ec two instances can belong
to multiple security groups. security groups
can contain multiple EC two instances, you
cannot block a specific IP address security
groups. For this, you need to use knackles.
Right? So again, it's allowed by default,
sorry, everything's denying you're only allowing
things okay. You can have up to 10,000 security
groups per region default is 2500. You can
have 60 inbound and 60 outbound rules per
security group. And you can have 16 security
groups associated to that. And I default is
five and I can see that I added an extra zero
there. So don't worry when you print out your
security scripts to cheat it will be all correct.
Okay.
We're looking
at network address translation, also known
as Nat. And this is the method of remapping
one IP address space into another. And so
here you can see we have our local network
with its own IP address space. And as it passes
through the NAT, it's going to change that
IP address. Well, why would we want to do
this? Well, there's two good reasons for this.
So if you have a private networking need to
help gain outbound access to the internet,
you need to use a NAT gateway to remap those
private IPS. If you have two networks, which
have conflicting network addresses, maybe
they actually have the same, you can use a
NAT to make the addresses more agreeable for
communication. So when we want to launch our
own Nat, we have two different options in
AWS, we have Nat instances, and Nat gateways.
So we're just going to go through the comparison
of these two. So before Nat gateways, all
there was was Nat instances, and so you have
to configure that instance, it's just the
regular situ instance, to do that remapping.
And so luckily, the community came up with
a bunch of Nat instances. And so through the
aect marketplace, you go to community am eyes,
you can still do this. And some people have
use cases for it. And you can launch a NAT
instance, okay, and so in order for Nat instances
to work, they have to be in a public subnet,
because there it has to be able to reach the
internet, if it wasn't a private subnet, there's
no way it's going to get to the internet.
So you would launch a NAT instance there,
and there you go, there'd be a few more steps
to configuration. But that's all you need
to know. Now, when we go over to Nat gateways,
um, it's a managed service. So it's going
to set up that easy to instance for you, you're
not going to have access to it, Avis is going
to win 100% manage it for you. But it's not
just going to launch one, it's going to have
a redundant instance for you. Because when
you launch your own Nat instances, if for
whatever reason it gets taken down, then you'd
have to run more than once. And now you have
to do all this work to make sure that these
instances are going to scale based on your
traffic or have the durability that you need.
So for Nat gateways, they take care of that
for you. And again, you would launch it in
a public subnet. The only thing that Nat gateway
doesn't do is it doesn't launch them automatically
across other azs for you. So you need to launch
a NAT gateway per AZ but you do get redundancy
for your instances. So those are the two methods.
And generally you want to use Nat gateways
when possible, because it is the new way of
doing it, but you could still use the legacy
way of doing it. So we're on to the NAT cheat
sheet and we have a lot of information here.
It's not that important for the solution architect
associate, it would definitely come up for
the sysops. Some of these details might matter.
So we'll just go through this here. So when
creating a NAT instance, you must disable
source and destination checks on the instance.
NAT instances must exist any public subnet,
you must have a route out of the private subnet
to the NAT instance, the size of a NAT instances
is determined how much traffic can be handled.
Highveld bill availability can be achieved
using auto scaling groups, multiple subnets
in different Z's and automate failover between
them using a script so you can see there's
a lot of manual labor. When you want to have
availability and durability and scalability
for Nat instances, it's all on on to you.
And then we'll go look at Nat gateway so Nat
gateways are redundant inside an availability
zone so they can survive failure of EC to
have an EC two instance. You can only have
one Nat gateway inside one AZ so they cannot
span multiple eyzies starts at five gigabytes
per second and scales all the way up to 45
gigabytes per second. NAT gateways are the
preferred setup for enterprise systems. There
is no requirement to patch Nat gateways and
there's no need to disable source and destination
checks for the NAT gateway. Unlike Nat instances,
Nat gateways are automatically assigned a
public IP address route tables for the NAT
gateway must be updated resources. in multiple
easy's sharing a gateway will lose internet
access if the gateway goes down unless you
create a gateway in each AZ and configure
route tables accordingly. So there you go.
That is your net. Hey, this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro and we are starting to VPC follow
along and this is a very long section because
we need to learn about all the kind of networking
components that we can create.
So we're going to learn how to create our
own VPC subnets, route tables, internet gateways,
security groups, Nat gateways knackles we're
going to touch it all okay, so it's very core
to learning about AWS And it's just great
to get it out of the way. So let's jump into
it. So let's start off by creating our own
VPC. So on the left hand side, I want you
to click on your VPC. And right away, you're
gonna see that we already have a default VPC
within this region of North Virginia. Okay,
your region might be different from mine,
it doesn't actually does kind of matter what
region you use, because different regions
have different amounts of available azs. So
I'm going to really strongly suggest that
you switch to North Virginia to make this
section a little bit smoother for you. But
just notice that the default VPC uses an ipv4
cider, cider block range of 172 31 0.0 forward
slash 16. Okay, and so if I was to change
regions, no matter what region will go to
us, West, Oregon, we're going to find that
we already have a default VPC on here as well.
And it's going to have the same a cider block
range, okay. So just be aware that at best
does give you a default VPC so that you can
start launching resources immediately without
having to worry about all this networking,
and there's no full power with using the default
VPC, it's totally acceptable to do so. But
we definitely need to know how to do this
ourselves. So we're going to create our own
VPC. Okay, and so I'm a big fan of Star Trek.
And so I'm going to name it after the planet
of Bayshore, which is a very well known planet
in the Star Trek universe. And I'm going to
have to provide my own cider block, it cannot
be one that already exists. So I can't use
that 172 range that AWS was using. So I'm
gonna do 10.0 dot 0.0, forward slash 16. And
there is a bit of a rhyme and rhythm to choosing
these, this one is a very commonly chosen
one. And so I mean, you might be looking at
this going, Okay, well, what is this whole
thing with the IP address slash afford 16.
And we will definitely explain that in a separate
video here. But just to give you a quick rundown,
you are choosing your IP address that you
want to have here. And this is the actual
range, and this is saying how many IP addresses
you want to allocate. Okay. Um, so yeah, we'll
cover that more later on. And so now we have
the option to set ipv6 cider, or a cider block
here. And so just to keep it simple, I'm going
to turn it off. But you know, obviously, ipv6
is supported on AWS. And it is the future
of, you know, our IP protocol. So it's definitely
something you might want to turn on. Okay,
and just be prepared for the future there,
that we have this tendency option, and this
is going to give us a dedicated hosts. For
our VPC, this is an expensive, expensive option.
So we're going to leave it to default and
go proceed and create our VPC. And so there
it has been created. And it was very fast,
it was just instantaneous there. So we're
going to click through to that link there.
And now we can see we have our VPC named Bayshore.
And I want you to notice that we have our
IP V for cider range, there is no ipv6 set.
And by default, it's going to give us a route
table and a knakal. Okay, and so we are going
to overwrite the row table because we're going
to want to learn how to do that by ourselves.
knackles is not so important. So we might
just glossed over that. But um, yeah, so there
you are. Now, there's just one more thing
we have to do. Because if you look down below
here, we don't have DNS resolution, or DNS,
or sorry, DNS hostnames is disabled by default.
And so if we launch an EC two instance, it's
not going to get a, a DNS, DNS hostname, that's
just like a URL. So you can access that ecsu
instance, we definitely want to turn that
on. So I'm going to drop this down to actions
and we're going to set a host names here to
enabled okay. And so now we will get that
and that will not cause this pain later down
the road. So now that we've created our VPC,
we want to actually make sure the internet
can reach it. And so we're going to next learn
about internet gateways. So we have our VPC,
but it has no way to reach the internet. And
so we're going to need an internet gateway.
Okay, so on the left hand side, I want you
to go to internet gateway. And we are going
to go ahead and create a new one. Okay. And
I'm just going to call it for internet gateway,
bay shores and people do it w e do it w doesn't
hurt. And so our internet gateway has been
created, and so we'll just click through to
that one. And so you're gonna see that it's
in a detached state. So internet gateways
can only be attached to a very specific VP,
VPC, it's a one to one relationship. So for
every VPC, you're going to have an internet
gateway. And so you can see it's attached
and there is no VPC ID. So I'm going to drop
this down and attach the VPC and then select
Bayshore there and attach it and there you
go. Now it's attached and we can see the ideas
associated. So we have an internet gateway,
but that still doesn't mean that things within
our network can Reach the internet, because
we have to add a route to our route table.
Okay, so just closing this tab here, you can
see that there already is a route table associated
with our VPC because it did create us a default
route table. So I'm just going to click through
to that one here to show you, okay, and you
can see that it's our main route tables, it's
set to main, but I want you to learn how to
create route tables. So we're going to make
one from scratch here. Okay. So we'll just
hit Create route table here. And we're just
going to name it our main route table or RG,
our internet road table, I don't know doesn't
matter. Okay, we'll just say RT, to shorten
that there and we will drop down and choose
Bayshore. And then we will go ahead and create
that route table. Okay, and so we'll just
hit close. And we will click off here. So
we can see all of our route tables. And so
here we have our, our, our main one here for
Bayshore. And then this is the one we created.
Okay, so if we click into this route table
here, you can see by default, it has the full
scope of our local network here. And so I
want to show you how to change this one to
our main. So we're just going to click on
this one here and switch it over to main,
so set as main row table. So the main row
table is whenever you know, just what is going
to be used by default. All right, and so we'll
just go ahead and delete the default one here
now, because we no longer need it. Alright,
and we will go select our new one here and
edit our routes. And we're going to add one
for the internet gateway here. So I'm gonna
just drop down here, or sorry, I'm just gonna
write 0.0 dot 0.0, forward slash, zero, which
means let's take take anything from anywhere
there. And then we're going to drop down,
select internet gateway, select Bayshore,
and hit save routes. Okay, and we'll hit close.
And so now we, we have a gateway. And we have
a way for our subnets to reach the internet.
So there you go. So now that we have a route
to the internet, it's time to create some
subnets. So we have some way of actually launching
our EC two instances, somewhere. Okay, so
on the left hand side, I want you to go to
subnets. And right away, you're going to start
to see some subnets. Here, these are the default
ones created with you with your default VPC.
And you can see that there's exactly six of
them. So there's exactly one for every availability
zone within each region. So the North Virginia
has six azs. So you're going to have six,
public subnets. Okay, the reason we know these
are public subnets. If we were to click on
one here and check the auto assign, is set
to Yes. So if a if this is set to Yes, that
means any EC two instance launch in the subnet
is going to get a public IP address. Hence,
it's going to be considered a public subnet.
Okay. So if we were to switch over to Canada
Central, because I just want to make a point
here, that if you are in a another region,
it's going to have a different amount of availability
zones, Canada only has two, which is a bit
sad, we would love to have a third one there,
you're going to see that we have exactly one
subnet for every availability zone. So we're
going to switch back to North Virginia here.
And we are going to proceed to create our
own subnets. So we're going to want to create
at least three subnets if we can. So because
the reason why is a lot of companies, especially
enterprise companies have to run it in at
least three availability zones for high availability.
Because if you know one goes out and you only
have another one, what happens if two goes
out. So there's that rule of you know, always
have at least, you know, two additional Okay,
so we're going to create three public subnets
and one, one private subnet, we're not going
to create three private subnets, just because
I don't want to be making subnets here all
day. But we'll just get to it here. So we're
going to create our first subnet, I'm going
to name this Bayshore public, okay, all right,
and we're going to select our VPC. And we're
going to just choose the US East one, eight,
and we're going to give it a cider block of
10.0 dot 0.0 forward slash 24. Now, notice,
this cider range is a smaller than the one
up here, I know the number is larger, but
from the perspective of how many IP addresses
it allocates, there's actually a fewer here,
so you are taking a slice of the pie from
the larger range here. So just be aware, you
can set this as 16, it's always going to be
less, less than in by less, I mean, a higher
number than 16. Okay, so we'll go ahead and
create our first public subnet here. And we'll
just hit close. And this is not by default
public because by default, the auto sign is
going to be set to No. So we're just going
to go up here and modify this and set it so
that it does auto assign ipv4 and now is is
considered a public subnet. So we're going
to go ahead and do that for our B and C here.
So it's going to be the same thing Bayshore
public,
be,
okay, choose that. We'll do B, we'll do 10.0
dot 1.0 24. Okay. And we're going to go create
that close. And we're going to that auto assign
that there. All right. And the next thing
we're going to do is create our next subnet
here so Bayshore How boring I beige or public.
See? And we will do that. And we'll go to
see here, it's going to be 10.0 dot 2.0, Ford
slash 24. Okay, we'll create that one. Okay,
let it close. And we will make sure did I
set that one? Yes, I did that I said that
one, not as of yet. And so we will modify
that there, okay. And we will create a another
subnet here, and this is going to be a beige,
your private a, okay. And we are going to
set that to eight here. And we're going to
set this to 10.0 dot 3.0 24. Okay, so this
is going to be our private subnet. Alright,
so we've created all of our subnets. So the
next thing we need to do is associate them
with a route table, actually, we don't have
to, because by default, it's going to use
the main, alright, so they're already automatically
associated there. But for our private one,
we're not going to be wanting to really use
the, the, the the main route table there,
we probably would want to create our own route
table for our private subnets there. So I'm
just gonna create a new one here, and we're
gonna just call it private RT. Okay, I'm going
to drop that down, choose Bayshore here. And
we're going to hit close, okay. And the idea
is that the, you know, we don't need the subnet
to reach the internet. So it doesn't really
make sense to be there. And then we could
set other things later on. Okay, so what I
want you to do is just change the association
here. So we're gonna just edit the route table
Association. And we're just going to change
that to be our private one. Okay. And so now
our route tables are set up. So we will move
on to the next step. So our subnets are ready.
And now we are able to launch some EC two
instances. So we can play around and learn
some of these other networking components.
So what I want you to do is go to the top
here and type in EC two. And we're going to
go to the EC two console. And we're going
to go to instances on the left hand side.
And we're going to launch ourselves a couple
of instances. So we're going to launch our
first instance, which is going to be for our
public subnet here. So we're going to choose
t to micro, we're going to go next, and we
are going to choose the Bayshore VPC that
we created. We're going to launch this in
the public subnet here public a, okay, and
we're going to need a new Im role. So I'm
just going to right click here and create
a new Im role because we're going to want
to give it access to both SSM for sessions
manager and also, so we have access to s3.
Okay, so just choosing EC to there. I'm going
to type in SSM, okay, SSM, there it is at
the top, that will type in s3, we're gonna
give it full access, we're going to go next,
we're going to go to next and we're going
to just type in my base, your EC two. Okay.
And we're going to hit Create role. Okay,
so now we have the role that we need for our
EC two instance, we're just going to refresh
that here, and then drop down and choose my
beige or EC two. Okay, and we are going to
want to provide it a script here to run. So
I already have a script pre prepared that
I will provide to you. And this is the public
user data.sh. All this is going to do. And
if you want to just take a peek here at what
it does, I guess they don't have it already
open here. But we will just quickly open this
up here. all it's going to do is it's going
to install an Apache server. And we're just
going to have a static website page here served
up. Okay, and so we're going to go ahead and
go to storage, nothing needs to be changed
here. We're going to add, we don't need to
add any tags. We're gonna go to security group
and we're going to create a new security group,
I'm going to call it um, my my beige your
EC two SG, okay. And we're going to make sure
that we have access to HTTP, because this
is a website, we're going to have to have
Port 80 open, we're going to restrict it down
to just us.
And we could also do that for SSH, so we might
as well do that there as well. Okay, we're
going to go ahead and review and launch this
EC two instance and already have a key pair
that is created. You'll just have to go ahead
and create one if you don't have one there.
And we'll just go ahead and launch that instance
there. Okay, great. So now, we have this EC
two instance here. Which is going to be for
our public segment. Okay. And we will go ahead
and launch another instance. So we'll go to
Amazon Lex to here, choose teach you micro.
And then this time we're going to choose our
private subnet. Okay, I do want to point out
that when you have this auto assign here,
see how it's by by default disabled, because
it's inheriting whatever the parents have
done has, whereas when we set it, the first
one, you might have not noticed, but it was
set to enable, okay. And we are going to also
give it the same role there, my beige or EC
two. And then this time around, we're going
to give it the other scripts here. So I have
a private script here, I'm just going to open
it up and show it to you. Okay, and so what
this script does, is a while it doesn't actually
need to install Apache, so we'll just remove
that, I guess it's just old. But anyway, what
it's going to do is it's going to reset the
password on the EC to user to chi win. Okay,
that's a character from Star Trek Deep Space
Nine. And we're also going to enable password
authentication. So we can SSH into this using
a password. And so that's all the script does
here. Okay, and so we are going to go ahead
and choose that file there. And choose that.
And we will move on to storage, storage is
totally fine. We're not going to add tags,
secure groups, we're gonna actually create
a new security group here. It's not necessarily
necessary, but I'm going to do anyway, so
I'm gonna say my private, private EC two,
SD, maybe put Bayshore in there. So we just
keep these all grouped together note, therefore,
it's only going to need SSH, we're not going
to have any access to the internet there.
So like, there's no website or anything running
on here. And so we'll go ahead and review
and launch. And then we're going to go launch
that instance, and choose our key pair. Okay,
great. So now we're just going to wait for
these two instances to spin up here. And then
we will play around with security groups and
knackles. So just had a quick coconut water.
And now I'm back here and our instances are
running, they don't usually take that long
to get started here. And so we probably should
have named these to make it a little bit easier.
So we need to determine which is our public
and private. And you can see right away, this
one has a public public DNS hostname, and
also it has its ip ip address. Okay, so this
is how we know this is the public one. So
I'm just going to say, base your public. Okay.
And this one here is definitely the private
one. All right. So we will say a base your
private. Okay. So, yeah, just to iterate over
here, if we were to look, here, you can see
we have the DNS and the public IP address.
And then for the private, there's nothing
set. Okay, so let's go see if our website
is working here. So I'm just going to copy
the public IP address, or we can take the
DNS when it doesn't matter. And we will paste
this in a new tab. And here we have our working
website. So our public IP address is definitely
working. Now, if we were to check our private
one, there is nothing there. So there's nothing
for us to copy, we can even copy this private
one and paste it in here. So there's no way
of accessing that website is that is running
on the private one there. And it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense to run your, your
website, in the private subnet there. So you
know, just to make a very clear example of
that, now that we have these two instances,
I guess it's a good opportunity to learn about
security groups. Okay, so we had created a
security group. And the reason why we were
able to access this instance, publicly was
that in our security group, we had an inbound
rule on port 80. So Port 80, is what websites
run on. And when we're accessing through the
web browser, there's and we are allowing my
IP here. So that's why I was allowed to access
it. So I just want to illustrate to you what
happens if I change my IP. So at the top here,
I have a VPN, it's a, it's a service, you
can you can buy, a lot of people use it so
that they can watch Netflix in other regions.
I use it for this purpose not to watch Netflix
somewhere else.
So don't get that in your mind there. But
I'm just going to turn it on. And I'm going
to change my IP. So I get I think this is
Brazil. And so I'm going to have an IP from
Brazil here shortly once it connects. And
so now if I were to go and access this here,
it shouldn't work. Okay, so I'm just going
to close that tab here. And it should just
hang Okay, so it's hanging because I'm not
using that IP. So that's how security groups
work. Okay, and so I'm just going to turn
that off. And I think I should have the same
one and it should resolve instantly there.
So great. So just showing you how the security
groups work for inbound rules. Okay, for outbound
rules, that's traffic going out to the internet,
it's almost always open like this. 0.0 dot
0.0 right. Because you'd want to be able to
download stuff, etc. So that is pretty normal
business. Okay. So now that now that we can
see that maybe we would like to show off how
knackles work compared to security groups
to security groups. As you can see if we were
just to open this one up here, okay. security
groups, by default, only can allow things
so everything is denied. And then you're always
opening things up. So you're adding allow
rules only, you can't add an explicit deny
rule. So we're knackles are a very useful
is that you can use it to block a very specific
IP addresses, okay, or IP ranges, if you will.
And you cannot do that for a security group.
Because how would you go about doing that?
So if I wanted to block access just to my
IP address, I guess I could only allow every
other IP address in the world except for mine.
But you can see how that would do undue burden.
So let's see if we can set our knakal to just
block our IP address here. Okay. So security
groups are associated with the actual EC two
instances, or? So the question is, is that,
how do we figure out the knackles and knackles
are associated with the subnets. Okay, so
in order to block our IP address for this
EC, two instance, we have to determine what
subnet it runs in. And so it runs in our beige
or public a right and so now we get to find
the knakal, that's associated with it. So
going up here to subnets, I'm going to go
to public a, and I'm going to see what knackles
are associated with it. And so it is this
knakal here, and we have some rules that we
can change. So let's actually try just blocking
my IP address here. And we will go just grab
it from here. Okay. All right. And just to
note, if you look here, see houses forward
slash 32. That is mean, that's a cider block
range of exactly one IP address. That's how
you specify a single IP address with forward
slash 32. But I'm going to go here and just
edit the knakal here, and we are going to
this is not the best way to do it. So I'm
just going to open it here. Okay.
And because I didn't get some edit options
there, I don't know why. And so we'll just
go up to inbound rules here, I'm
going to add a new rule. And it goes from
lowest to highest for these rules. So I'm
just going to add a new rule here. And I'm
going to put in rule 10. Okay, and I'm going
to block it here on the side arrange. And
I'm going to do it for Port 80. Okay, so this
and we're going to have an explicit deny,
okay, so this should, this should not allow
me to access that easy to instance, any any
longer. Okay, so we're going to go back to
our instances here, we're going to grab that
IP address there and paste it in there and
see if I still have access, and I do not okay,
so that knakal is now blocking it. So that's
how you block individual IP addresses there.
And I'm just going to go back and now edit
the rule here. And so we're just going to
remove this rule, and hit save. And then we're
going to go back here and hit refresh. Okay.
And I should now have access on I do. So there
you go. So that is security groups and knakal.
So I guess the next thing we can move on to
is how do we actually get access to the private
subnet, okay, and the the the ways around
that we have our private EC two instance.
And we don't have an IP address, so there's
no direct way to gain access to it. So we
can't just easily SSH into it. So this is
where we're going to need a bastion. Okay,
and so we're going to go ahead and go set
one up here. So what I want you to do is I
want you to launch a new instance here, I'm
just gonna open a new tab, just in case I
want this old tab here. And I'm just going
to hit on launch instance here. Okay, and
so I'm going to go to the marketplace here,
I'm gonna just type in Bastion. And so we
have some options here, there is this free
one Bastion host, SSH, but I'm going to be
using guacamole and there is an associated
cost here with it, they do have a trial version,
so you can get away without paying anything
for it. So I'm just going to proceed and select
guacamole. And anytime you're using something
from the marketplace, they generally will
have the instructions in here. So if you do
view additional details here, we're going
to get some extra information. And then we
would just scroll down here to usage information
such as usage instructions, and we're going
to see there is more information. I'm just
going to open up this tab here because I've
done this a few times. So I remember where
all this stuff is okay, and we're just going
to hit continue here. Okay, and we're going
to start setting up this instance. So we're
going to need a small so this one doesn't
allow you to go into micros. Okay, so there
is an associated cost there. We're going to
configure this instance, we're going to want
it in the same VPC as our private, okay, when
we have to launch this in a public subnet,
so just make sure that you select the public
one Here, okay. And we're going to need to
create a new Im role. And this is part of
guacamole these instructions here because
you need to give it some access so that it
can auto discover instances. Okay? And so
down here, they have the instructions here,
and they're just going to tell you to make
an IM role, we could launch a cloudformation
template to make this, but I would rather
just make it by hand here. So we're going
to grab this policy here, okay. And we are
going to make a new tab and make our way over
to I am, okay. And once we're in I am here,
we're going to have to make this policy. So
I'm going to make this policy. Okay, unless
I already have it. Let's see if it's already
in here. New, okay, good. And I'm gonna go
to JSON, paste that in there, review the policy,
I'm going to name it, they have a suggestion
here, what to name it, Glock AWS, that seems
fine to me. Okay, and here, you can see it's
gonna give us permissions to cloud watch an
STS. So we'll go ahead and create that policy.
It says it already exists. So I already have
it. So just go ahead and create that policy.
And I'm just going to skip the step for myself.
Okay, and we're just going to cancel there.
So I'm just going to type walk. I don't know
why it's not showing up, says it already exists.
Again, so yeah, there it is. So I already
have that policy. Okay, so I couldn't hit
that last step. But you'll be able to get
through that no problem. And then once you
have it, you're gonna have to create a new
role. So we're going to create a role here,
and it's going to be for EC two, we're going
to go next. And we're going to want I believe
EC to full access is that the right Oh, read
only access, okay. So we're going to want
to give this easy to read only access. And
we're also going to want to give it that new
GWAC role. So I'm going to type in type AWS
here. Oh, that's giving me a hard time here,
we'll just copy and paste the whole name in
here. There it is. And so those are the two,
two policies you need to have attached. And
then we're just going to name this something
here. So I'm gonna just call it my Glock,
Bastion. Okay, roll here. I'm going to create
that role. Okay, and so that role has now
been created, we're going to go back here,
refresh the IM roles, and we're going to see
if it exists. And there it is my Glock Bastion
role. Am I spell bashing wrong there, but
I don't think that really matters. And then
we will go to storage. There's nothing to
do here, we'll skip tags, we'll go to security
groups. And here you can see it comes with
some default configurations. So we're going
to leave those alone. And then we're going
to launch this EC two instance. Okay. So now
we're launching that it's taking a bit of
time here, but this is going to launch. And
as soon as this is done, we're going to come
back here and actually start using this Bastion
to get into our private instance. So our bashing
here is now already in provisioned. So let's
go ahead and just type in Bastion, so we don't
lose that later on, we can go grab either
the DNS or public IP, I'll just grab the DNS
one here. And we're going to get this connection,
not private warning, that's fine, because
we're definitely not using SSL here. So just
hit advanced, and then just click to proceed
here. Okay, and then it's might ask you to
allow we're going to definitely say allow
for that, because that's more of the advanced
functionality, guacamole there, which we might
touch in. At the end of this here, we're going
to need the username and password. So it has
a default, so we have block admin here, okay.
And then the password is going to be the name
of the instance ID. All right, and this is
all in the instructions here. I'm just speaking
you through it. And then we're going to hit
login here. And so now it has auto discovered
the instances which are in the VPC that is
launched. And so here, we have Bayshore, private.
So let's go ahead and try to connect to it.
Okay. So as soon as I click, it's going to
make this shell here. And so we'll go attempt
and login now. So our user is easy to user.
And I believe our password is KI wi n Chi
win. And we are in our instance, so there
you go. That's how we gain access to our private
instance here. Just before we start doing
some other things within this private easy
to I just want to touch on some of the functionality
of Bastion here, or sorry, guacamole, and
so why you might actually want to use the
bastion. So it does, it is a hardened instance,
it does allow you to authenticate via multiple
methods. So you can enable multi factor authentication
to use this. It also has the ability to do
screen recordings, so you can really be sure
what people are up to, okay, and then it just
has built in audit logs and etc, etc. So,
there's definitely some good reasons to use
a bastion, but we can also use a sessions
manager which does a lot of this for us with
the exception of screen recording within the
within AWS. But anyway, so now that we're
in our instance, let's go play around here
and see what we can do. So now that we are
in this private EC two instance, I just want
to show you that it doesn't have any internet
access. So if I was to ping something like
Google, right, okay, and I'm trying to get
information here to see how it's hanging,
and we're not getting a ping back, that's
because there is no route to the internet.
And so the way we're going to get a route
to the internet is by creating a NAT instance
or a NAT gateway. Generally, you want to use
a NAT gateway, there are cases use Nat instances.
So if you were trying to save money, you can
definitely save money by having to manage
a NAT instance by herself. But we're gonna
learn how to do Nat gateway, because that's
the way to this wants you to go. And so back
in our console, here, we are in EC two instances,
where we're going to have to switch over to
a V PC, okay, because that's where the NAT
gateway is. So on the left hand side, we can
scroll down and we are looking under VPC,
we have Nat gateways. And so we're going to
launch ourselves a NAT gateway, that gateways
do cost money. So they're not terribly expensive.
But you know, at the end of this, we'll tear
it down, okay. And so, the idea is that we
need to launch this Nat gateway in a public
VPC or sorry, public subnet, and so we're
gonna have to look, here, I'm gonna watch
it in the beige or public a doesn't matter
which one just has to be one of the public
ones. And we can also create an elastic IP
here. I don't know if it actually is required
to sign a pipe network, I don't know if it
really matters. Um, but we'll try to go ahead
and create this here without any IP, no, it's
required. So we'll just hit Create elastic
IP there. And that's just a static IP address.
So it's never changing. Okay. And so now that
we have that, as associated with our Nat gateway,
we'll go ahead and create that. And it looks
like it's been created. So once your Nat gateway
is created, the next thing we have to do is
edit your route table. So there actually is
a way for that VPC to our sorry, that private
instance to access the internet. Okay, so
let's go ahead and edit that road table.
And so we created a private road table specifically
for our private EC two. And so here, we're
going to add it the routes, okay. And we're
going to add a route for that private or to
that Nat gateway. Okay. So um, we're just
going to type in 0.0 dot 0.0, Ford slash zero.
And we are then just going to go ahead, yep.
And then we're going to go ahead and choose
our Nat gateway. And we're going to select
that there, and we're going to save that route.
Okay, so now our Nat gateway is configured.
And so there should be a way for our instance
to get to the internet. So let's go back and
do a ping. And back over here, in our private
EC two instance, we're just going to go ahead
and ping Google here. Okay, and we're going
to see if we get some pings back, and we do
so there you go. That's all we had to do to
access the internet. All right. So why would
our private easy to instance need to reach
the internet. So we have one one inbound traffic,
but we definitely want outbound because we
would probably want to update packages on
our EC two instance. So if we did a sudo,
yum, update, okay, we wouldn't be able to
do this without a outbound connection. All
right. So it's a way of like getting access
to the internet, only for the things that
we need for outbound connections. Okay. So
now that we've seen how we can set an outbound
connection to the Internet, let's talk about
how we could access other AWS services via
our private EC two instance here. So s3 would
be a very common one to utilize. So I'm just
going to go over to s3 here, I'm just going
to type in s3, and open this in a new tab,
I'm going to try to actually access some s3
files here. Okay. And so I should already
have a bucket in here called exam pro 000.
And I do have some images already in here
that we should be able to access. And we did
get that Iam role permissions to access that
stuff there. So the ACL, the ACL, I should
be already pre installed here. And so we'll
just type in AWS s3, and it should be, if
we wanted to copy a file locally, we'll type
in CP. And we're going to need to actually
just do LS, okay, so we'll do LS here, okay.
I don't think we have to go as advanced as
copying and doing other stuff here. But you
can definitely see that we have a way of accessing
s3 via the COI. So what would happen if we
removed that Nat gateway, would we still be
able to access s3? So let's go find out. All
right. I think you know the answer to this,
but let's just do it. And then I'll show you
a way that you can still access s3 without
a NAT gateway. All right. So we're going to
go ahead here and just delete this Nat gateway,
it's not like you can just turn them off so
you have to delete them. And we'll just wait
till that finishes deleting here. So our Nat
gateway has deleted after a few months. here
just hit the refresh button here just in case
because sometimes it will say it's deleting
when it's already done. And you don't want
to be waiting around for nothing. So
let's go back to our EC two instance here.
We'll just clear the screen here. And now
the question is, will we be able to access
AWS s3 via the via the CLR here, okay, and
so I hit Enter, and I'm waiting, waiting,
waiting. And it's just not going to complete
because it no longer has any way to access
s3. So the way it works when using the COI
through UC Davis is it's going to go out out
to the internet out of the universe network,
and then come back into nativas network to
then access s3. And so since there is no outbound
way of connecting to the internet, there's
no way we're going to be able to connect to
s3. Okay, so it seems a little bit silly,
because you'd say, Well, why wouldn't you
just keep the traffic within the network because
we're already on an easy to within AWS network,
and s3 is with Ava's network. And so that
brings us to endpoints, which is actually
how we can create a like our own little private
tunnel within the US network, so that we don't
have to leave up to the internet. So let's
go ahead and create an endpoint and see if
we can connect to s3 without having outbound
Connect. So we're going to proceed to create
our VPC endpoints on the left hand side, you're
going to choose endpoints, okay. And we're
going to create ourselves a new endpoint.
And this is where we're going to select it
for the service that we want to use. So this
is going to be for s3. But just before we
do that, I want you to select the VPC that
we want this for down below. And then we're
going to need this for s3. So we'll just scroll
down here and choose s3. Okay, and we're going
to get a blotch options here. Okay. And so
we're going to need to configure our route
tree, our route table. So we have that connection
there. And it's going to ask what route table
Do you want put it in, and we're going to
want to put it in our private one, because
that's where our private easy to instance
is. And then down below, we will have a policy
here. And so this is going to be great. So
we will just leave that as is, and we're going
to hit Create endpoint. Okay, so we're gonna
go back and hit close there. And it looks
like our endpoint is available immediately
there. And so now we're going to go find out
if we actually have access to s3. So back
over here we are in our private EC two instance.
And I'm just going to hit up and see if we
now have access and look at that. So we've
created our own private connection to s3 without
leaving the egress network.
Alright, so we had a fun time playing around
with our private EC two instance there. And
so we're pretty much wrapped up here for stuff.
I mean, there's other things here, but you
know, at the associate level, it's, there's
not much reason to get into all these other
things here. But I do want to show you one
more thing for VP C's, which are VPC flow
logs, okay, and so I want you to go over to
your VPC here, okay, and then I just want
you to go up and I want you to create a flow
log, so flow logs will track all the, the
traffic that is going through through your
VPC. Okay, and so it's just nice to know how
to create that. So we can have it to accept
reject, or all I'm going to set it to all
and it can either be delivered to cloudwatch
logs, or s3 Cloud watch is a very good destination
for that. In order to deliver that, we're
going to need a destination log group on I
don't have one. So in order to send this to
a log group, we're going to have to go to
cloud watch, okay. We'll just open this up
in a new tab here. Okay. And then once we're
here in cloud watch, we're going to create
ourselves a new cloud watch log, alright.
And we're just going to say actions create
log group, and we'll just call this Bayshore,
your VPC flow logs or VPC logs or flow logs,
okay. And we will hit Create there. And now
if we go back to here and hit refresh, we
may have that destination now available to
us. There it is. Okay, we might need an IM
role associated with this, to have permissions
to publish to cloud watch logs. So we're definitely
going to need permissions for that. Okay.
And I'll just pop back here with those credentials
here in two seconds. So I just wanted to collect
a little bit of flow log data, so I could
show it off to you to see what it looks like.
And so you know, under our VPC, we can see
that we have flow logs enabled, we had just
created that a log there a moment ago. And
just to get some data, I went to my EC two
instances, and we had that public one running
right. And so I just took that IP address.
And I just started refreshing the page. I
don't know if we actually looked at the actual
webpage I had here earlier on, but here it
is. And so I just hit enter, enter, enter
here a few times. And then we can go to our
cloud watch here and look for the log here
and so we should have some streams, okay.
And so if we just open that up, we can kind
of see what we have here. And so we have some
raw data. So I'll just change it to text.
And so here we can see the IP address of the
source and the destination and additional
information, okay, and that we got a 200 response.
Okay, so there you go. I'm just wanting to
give you a little quick peek into there.
So now we're done the VPC section, let's clean
up whatever we created here, so we're not
incurring any costs. So we're gonna make our
way over two EC two instances. And you can
easily filter out the instances which are
in that. That VPC here by going to VPC ID
here, and then just selecting the VPC. So
these are the three instances that are running,
and I'm just going to terminate them all.
Because you know, we don't want to spend up
our free credits or incur cost because of
that bash in there. So just hit terminate
there, and those things are going to now shut
down. We also have that VPC endpoint still
running, just double check to make sure your
Nat gateway isn't still there. So under the
back in the VPC section here, just make sure
that you had so and there we have our gateway
endpoint there for s3. So we'll just go ahead
and delete that. I don't believe it cost us
any money, but it doesn't hurt to get that
out of the way there. We'll also check our
elastic IPS. Now it did create a e IP when
we created that gateway, IPS that are not
being utilized cost us money. So we'll go
ahead and release that tip. Okay, we'll double
check our gateway. So under Nat gateways,
making sure nothing is running under there,
and we had deleted previously, so we're good,
we can go ahead and delete these other things
not so important. But we can go ahead and
attempt to delete them, it might throw an
error here. So we'll see what it says. Nope,
they're all deletes. That's great. So those
are deleted now. And then we have our route
table. So we can delete those two route tables,
okay. And we can get rid of our internet gateway,
so we can find that internet
gateway.
There it is, okay, we will detach it, okay.
And then we will go ahead and delete that
internet gateway, okay. And we'll go attempt
to delete our, our actual VPC now, we'll see
if there's any dependencies here. So if we
haven't deleted all the things that it wants,
from here, it's going to complain. So there
might be some security groups here, but we'll
find out in a second. Oh, just delete the
forest. Great. So it just deleted it there.
So we're all cleaned up. So there you go.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at identity access management
Iam, which manages access of AWS users and
resources. So now it's time to look at I am
core components. And we have these installed
identities. And those are going to be users
groups and roles. Let's go through those.
So a user is an end user who can log into
the console or interact with AWS resources
programmatically, then you have groups, and
that is when you take a bunch of users and
you put them into a logical grouping. So they
have shared permissions. That could be administrators,
developers, auditors, whatever you want to
call that, then you have roles and roles,
have policies associated with them. That's
what holds the permissions. And then you can
take a role and assign it to users or groups.
And then down below, you have policies. And
this is a JSON document, which defines the
rules in which permissions are loud. And so
those are the core components. But we'll get
more in detail to all these things. Next.
So now that we know the core components aren't,
let's talk about how we can mix and match
them. Starting at the top here, we have a
bunch of users in a user group. And if we
want to on mass, apply permissions, all we
have to do is create a role with the policies
attached to that role. And then once we attach
that role to that group, all these users have
that same permission great for administrators,
auditors, or developers. And this is generally
the way you want to use Iam when assigning
roles to users. You can also assign a role
directly to a user. And then there's also
a way of assigning a policy, which is called
inline policy directly to a user. Okay, so
why would you do this? Well, maybe you have
exactly one action, you want to attach this
user and you want to do it for a temporary
amount of time. You don't want to create a
managed role because it's never it's never
going to be reused for anybody else. There
are use cases for that. But generally, you
always want to stick with the top level here.
A role can have multiple policies attached
to it, okay. And also a role can be attached
to certain AWS resources. All right. Now,
there are cases where resources actually have
inline policies directly attached to them,
but there are cases where You have roles attached
to or somehow associated to resources, all
right. But generally, this is the mix and
match of it. If you were taking the eight
of a security certification, then this stuff
in detail really matters. But for the associate
and the pro level, you just need to conceptually
know what you can and cannot do. All right.
So in I am you have different types of policies,
the first being managed policies, these are
ones that are created by AWS out of convenience
for you for the most common permissions you
may need. So over here, we'd have Amazon easy
to full access, you can tell that it's a managed
policy, because it says it's managed by AWS,
and an even further indicator is this orange
box, okay? Then you have custom customer managed
policies, these are policies created by you,
the customer, they are edible, whereas in
the Manage policies, they are read only. They're
marked as customer managed, you don't have
that orange box. And then last are inline
policies. So inline policies, you don't manage
them, because they're like they're one and
done. They're intended to be attached directly
to a user or directly to a, a resource. And
they're, and they're not managed, so you can't
apply them to more than one identity or resource.
Okay, so those are your three types of roles.
So it's now time to actually look at a policy
here. And so we're just going to walk through
all the sections so we can fully understand
how these things are created. And the first
thing is the version and the version is the
policy language version. If this changes,
then that means all the rules here could change.
So this doesn't change very often, you can
see the last time was 2012. So it's going
to be years until they change it, if they
did make changes, it probably would be minor,
okay, then you have the statement. And so
the statement is just a container for the
other policy elements. So you can have a single
one here. So here I have an array, so we have
multiples. But if you didn't want to have
multiples, you just get rid of the the square
brackets there, you could have a single policy
element there. Now going into the actual policy
element, the first thing we have is Cid and
this is optional. It's just a way of labeling
your statements. So Cid probably stands for
statement identifier, you know, again, it's
optional, then you have the effect, the effect
can be either allow or deny. And that's going
to set the conditions or the the access for
the rest of the policy. The next thing is
we have the action. So actions can be individualized,
right. So here we have I am and we have an
individual one, or we can use asterisk to
select everything under s3. And these are
the actual actions the policy will allow or
deny. And so you can see we have a deny policy,
and we're denying access all to s3 for a very
specific user here, which gets us into the
principal. And the principal is kind of a
conditional field as well. And what you can
do is you can specify an account a user role
or federated user, to which you would like
to allow or deny access. So here we're really
saying, hey, Barkley, you're not allowed to
use s3, okay, then you have the resource,
that's the actual thing. That is we're allowing
or denying access to so in this case, it's
a very specific s3 bucket. And the last thing
is condition. And so condition is going to
vary based on the based on the resource, but
here we have one, and it does something, but
I'm just showing you that there is a condition
in here. So there you go, that is the makeup
of a policy, if you can master master these
things, it's going to make your life a whole
lot easier. But you know, just learn what
you need to learn.
So you can also set up password policies for
your users. So you can set like the minimum
password length or the rules to what makes
up a good password, you can also rotate out
passwords, so that is an option you have as
well. So it will expire after x days. And
then a user then must reset that password.
So just be aware that you have the ability
to password.
Let's take a look at access keys. Because
this is one of the ways you can interact with
AWS programmatically either through the ad
vcli or the SDK. So when you create a user
and you say it's allowed to have programmatic
access, it's going to then create an access
key for you, which is an ID and a secret access
key. One thing to note is that you just can
only have up to two access keys within their
accounts down below, you can see that we have
one, as soon as we add a second one, that
grey button for create access key will vanish.
And if we want more we would either have to
we'd have to remove keys, okay. But you know,
just be aware that that's what access keys
are and you can make them inactive and you're
only allowed to have Let's quickly talk about
MFA. So MFA can be turned on per user. But
there is a caveat to it where the user has
to be the one that turns it on. Because when
you turn it on, you have to connect it to
a device and your administrator is not going
to have the device notes on the user to do
so there is no option for the administrator
to go in and say, Hey, you have to use MFA.
So it cannot be enforced directly from an
administrator or root account. But what the
minister can do if if if they want is they
can restrict access to resources only to people
that are using MFA, so you can't make the
user account itself have MFA. But you can
definitely restrict access to API calls and
things like that. And this is Andrew Brown
from exam Pro, and we are going to do the
I am follow along. So let's make our way over
to the IM console. So just go up to services
here and type in Im, and we will get to learning
this a right right away. So here I am on the
IM dashboard, and we have a couple things
that a device wants us to do. It wants us
to set MFA on our root account. It also wants
us to apply an IM password policy, so that
our passwords stay very secure. So let's take
what they're saying in consideration and go
through this. Now I am logged in as the root
user. So we can go ahead and set MFA. So what
I want you to do is drop this down as your
root user and we'll go manage MFA. And we
will get to this here. So this is just a general
disclaimer here to help you get started here.
I don't ever want to see this again. So I'm
just going to hide it. And we're going to
go to MFA here and we're going to activate
MFA. So for MFA, we have a few options available.
We have a virtual MFA, this is what you're
probably most likely going to use where you
can use a mobile device or computer, then
you can use a u2f security key. So this is
like a UB key. And I actually have an OB key,
but we're not going to use it for this, but
it's a physical device, which holds the credentials,
okay, so you can take this key around with
you. And then there are other hardware mechanisms.
Okay, so but we're going to stick with virtual
MFA here. Okay, so we'll hit Continue. And
what it's going to do is it's going to you
need to install a compatible app on your mobile
phone. So if we take a look here, I bet you
authenticator is one of them. Okay. So if
you just scroll down here, we have a few different
kinds. I'm just looking for the virtual ones.
Yeah. So for Android or iPhone, we have Google
Authenticator or authy, two factor authentication.
So you're going to have to go install authenticator
on your phone. And then when you are ready
to do so you're going to have to show this
QR code. So I'm just going to click that and
show this to you here. And then you need to
pull out your phone. I know you can't see
me doing this, but I'm doing it right now.
Okay. And I'm not too worried that you're
seeing this because I'm going to change this
two factor authentication out here. So if
you decide that you want to also add this
to your phone, you're not going to get too
far. Okay, so I'm just trying to get my authenticator
app out here, and I'm gonna hit plus and the
thing and I can scan the barcode, okay. And
so I'm just going to put my camera over it
here. Okay, great. And so is is saved the
secret. All right, and so it's been added
to Google Authenticator. Now, now that I have
it in my application, I need to enter in to
two consecutive MFA codes. Okay, so this is
a little bit confusing. It took me a while
to figure this out. The first time I was using
AWS, the idea is that you need to set the
first one. So the first one I see is 089265.
Okay, and so I'm just going to wait for the
next one to expire, okay, so there's a little
circle that's going around. And I'm just waiting
for that to complete to put in a second one,
which just takes a little bit of time here.
Still going here. Great. And so I have new
numbers. So the numbers are 369626. Okay,
so it's not the same number, but it's two
consecutive numbers, and we'll hit assign
MFA. And now MFA has been set on my phone.
So now when I go and log in, it's going to
ask me to provide additional code. Okay, and
so now my root account is protected. So we're
gonna go back to our dashboard, and we're
gonna move on to password policies. Okay.
So let's take the recommendation down here
and manage our password policy. Okay. And
we are going to set a password policy. So
password policy allows us to enforce some
rules that we want to have on Your users.
And so to make passwords a lot stronger, so
we can say it should require at least one
upper letter, one lowercase letter, or at
least one number, a non non alphanumeric character,
enable the password expiration. So after 90
days, they're going to have to change the
password, you can have password expiration
requires the administrator reset, so you can't
just reset it, the admin will do it for you
allow users to change their own password is
something you could set as well. And then
you could say prevent password reuse. So for
the next five passwords, you can't reuse the
same one. Okay? So and I would probably put
this a big high numbers, so that is a very
high chance they won't use the same one. Okay,
so, um, yeah, there we go. We'll just hit
Save Changes. And now we have a password policy
in place. Okay. And so that's, that's how
that will be. So to make it easier for users
to log into the Iam console, you can provide
a customized sign in link here. And so here,
it has the account ID, or I think that's the
account ID but we want something nicer here.
So we can change it to whatever you want.
So I can call it Deep Space Nine. Okay. And
so now what we have is if I spelt that, right,
I think so yeah. So now that we have a more
convenient link that we can use to login with,
okay, so I'm just going to copy that for later,
because we're going to use it to login. I
mean, obviously, you can name it, whatever
you want. And I believe that these are just
like, I'm like picking like your Yahoo or
your your Gmail email, you have to be unique.
Okay, so you're not gonna be at least Deep
Space Nine, as long as I have to use I believe.
But yeah, okay, so maybe we'll move on to
actually creating a. So here I am under the
Users tab, and I am, and we already have an
existing user that I created for myself, when
I first set up this account, we're going to
create a new user so we can learn this process.
So we can fill the name here, Harry Kim, which
is the character from Star Trek Voyager, you
can create multiple users in one go here,
but I'm just gonna make one. Okay, I'm going
to give him programmatic access and also access
to the console. So you can log in. And I'm
going to have an auto generated password here,
so I don't have to worry about it. And you
can see that it will require them to reset
their password and they first sign in. So
going on to permissions, we need to usually
put our users within a group, we don't have
to, but it's highly recommended. And here
I have one called admin for edit, which has
add administrator access, I'm going to create
a new group here, and I'm going to call it
developers okay. And I'm going to give them
power access, okay, so it's not full access,
but it gives them quite a bit of control within
the system. Okay. And I'm just going to create
that group there. And so now I have a new
group. And I'm going to add Harry to that
group there. And we will proceed to the next
step here. So we have tags, ignore that we're
going to review and we're going to create
Harry Kim the user. Okay. And so what it's
done here is it's also created a secret access
key and a password. Okay, so if Harry wants
that programmatic access, he can use these
and we can send the an email with the, with
this information along to him. Okay.
And, yeah, we'll just close that there. Okay.
And then we will just poke around here in
Harry Kim for a little bit.
So just before we jump into Harry Kim, here,
you can see that he has never used his access
key. He, the last time his password was used
was today, which was set today. And there
is no activity and he does not have MFA. So
if we go into Harry Kim, we can look around
here. And we can see that he has policies
applied to him from a group. And you can also
individually attach permissions to him. So
we have the ability to give them permissions
via group. Or we can copy permissions from
existing user or we can attach policies directly
directly to them. So if we wanted to give
them s3, full access, we could do so here.
Okay. And then we can just apply those permissions
there. And so now he has those permissions.
We also have the ability to add inline policies.
Okay, so in here, we can add whatever we want.
And so we could use the visual editor here
and just add an inline policy. Okay, so I'm
just trying to think of something we could
give him access to some ABC to okay, but he
already has access to it because he's a power
user, but we're just going through the motions
of this here. So I'm gonna select EC two,
and we're going to give him just a list access,
okay. And we're going to say review policy,
okay. And so we have full, full access there.
And we can name the policy here so we can
say, full Harry, okay. Full hair, you see,
too. And we'll go ahead and create that policy,
their maximum policy size exceeds for Harry
Kim, I guess it's just that it has a lot of
stuff in there. So I'm gonna go previous,
okay, and I guess it's just a very large policy.
So I'm just going to pare that down there.
Okay. Again, this is just for show So it doesn't
really matter what we select here. And then
we'll go ahead and review that policy, and
then we will create that policy. Okay. And
so here we have an inline policy, or a policy
directly attached. And then we have a manage
policy, okay. And then we have a policy that
comes from a group. Alright. So that's policies,
we can see what group he belongs to here and
add them to additional groups, tags or tags,
we can see his security credentials here.
So we could manage whether we want to change
whether he has full access or not retroactively.
And we can fiddle with his password or reset
it for him here. And we can manage MFA. So
we can set MFA for this user. Normally, you
want the user to do it, by themselves, because
if you had to set MFA for them, as administrator,
they'd have to give me their phone right to
set this up. But I guess if they had, if you
had a yubikey, that set up the yubikey for
them, and they give them the UB key. And then
we have the access keys. So you can have up
to two access keys within your account here.
Okay, so I can go ahead and create a another
one, it's a good habit to actually create
both of them, because for security purposes,
if you take the ADA security certification,
one way of compromising account is always
taking up that extra slot, you can also make
these inactive. Okay? So if this becomes an
active, you can set them all right. But see,
we still can't create any additional keys,
we have to hit the x's here. And so then we
can create more access keys. Okay, if we were
using code commit, we could upload their SSH
key here. And so same thing, we can generate
a credentials for code commit. And then there's
access advisor. This is gives you general
advice of like what access they have, I think
Suzy can scroll down here and see what do
they actually have access to? And when did
they last access something? Okay. And then
there's the Arn to Harry Kim. So it's something
that we might want to utilize there. So we
got the full gambit of this here. Okay. And
so I'm just going to go ahead and delete Harry,
because we're pretty much done here. Okay.
Great. And so there we are. So that was the
run through with users. So just to wrap up
this section, we're just going to cover a
rules and policies here. So first, we'll go
into policies. And here we have a big list
of policies here that are managed by AWS,
they say they're managed over here, and you
can definitely tell because they're camelcase.
And they also have this nice little orange
box, okay. And so these are policies, which
you cannot edit, they're read only, but they're
a quick and fast way for you to start giving
access to your users. So if we were just to
take a look at one of them, like the EC 214,
or maybe just read only access, we can click
into them. And we can see kind of the summary
of what we get access to. But if we want to
actually see the real policy here, we can
see it in full. Alright. And so we do have
some additional things here to see actually
who is using this policy. So we can see that
we have a roll named
that I created here for a different follow
along and it's utilizing this policy right
now. We also have policy versions. So a policy
can have revisions over time, and to have
up to five of them, okay, so if you ever need
to roll back a policy or just see how things
have changed, we can see that here. And we
also have the access advisor, which tells
us who is utilizing this. So again, for Amazon
ECS, we're seeing that role being utilized
for this custom role that I've created. Okay,
so let's just actually copy the the Jason
here, so we can actually go try and make our
own policy. Okay, because we did create a
policy for Harry Kamba, it would be nice to
actually create one with the JSON here. So
we'll go back to the policy here. And we'll
create a new policy, we'll go to the JSON
editor here, and we will paste that in. And
we do cover this obviously, in the lecture
content, but you know, you have to specify
the version, then you need a statement. And
the statement has multiple, multiple actions
within here that you need to define. Okay.
And so here we have one that has an allow,
allow effect, and it is for the action, easy
to describe. And it's for all possible resources.
Okay, so we're going to go ahead and create
that there. And we're just going to name this
as my read, only easy to access, okay. We're
just gonna go ahead and create that policy.
Okay. And so we have that policy there. I'm
just going to search it there quickly. And
you can see that this is customer manage,
because it doesn't have the orange box. And
it says that it's customer managed. All right.
So let's just go ahead and go ahead and create
a role now. So we can go ahead and create
a role. And so generally, you want to choose
the role, who this role is for. We're gonna
say this is for EC two, okay, but you could
also set it for another ABC account. This
is for creating cross rules. Then you have
web identity and SAML. We're gonna stick with
services here and go to EC two and now we
have the option You need to choose their policies
and we can create or sorry, choose multiple
policies here. So I'm going to do my read,
only easy to hear, okay? But we could also
select on them, and I guess three, okay. And
I'm just going to skip tags because they don't
care. And we're going to go next review, I'm
going to say my role, alright, and shows the
policies that were attached there. And now
we can create that role. Okay. And so we now
have that role. And so we can now attach it,
we can attach that role to resource such such
as when we launched got easy to instance,
we could assign it that way, or, you know,
affiliate with a user but yeah, there you
go.
We're onto the IM cheat sheets. Let's jump
into it. So identity access management is
used to manage access to users and resources
I am is a universal system, so it's applied
to all regions at the same time, I am is also
a free service. A root account is the account
initially created when AWS is set up, and
so it has full administrator access. New Iam
accounts have no permissions by default until
granted, new users get assigned an access
key ID and secret when first created when
you give them programmatic access. Access
keys are are only used for the COI and SDK,
they cannot access the console. Access keys
are only shown once when created, if lost,
they must be deleted and recreated again,
always set up MFA for your root accounts.
Users must enable MFA on their own administrators
cannot turn it on for each user, I am allows
you, you to Set password policies to set minimum
password requirements or rotate passwords.
Then you have Iam identities, such as users,
groups and roles and we'll talk about them
now. So we have users, those are the end users
who log into the console or interact with
AWS resources programmatically, then you have
groups. So that is a logical group of users
that share all the same permission levels
of that group. So think administrators, developers,
auditors, then you have roles, which associates
permissions to a role, and then that role
is then assigned to users or groups. Then
you have policies. So that is a JSON document,
which grants permissions for specific users
groups, roles to access services, policies
are generally always attached to Iam identities,
you have some variety of policies, you have
managed policies, which are created by AWS,
that cannot be edited, then you have customer
managed policies, those are policies created
by you that are editable and you have inline
policies which are directly attached to the
user. So there you go, that is I am. Hey,
this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And we
are looking at Amazon cognito, which is a
decentralized way of managing authentication.
So think sign up sign in integration for your
apps, social identity providers, like connecting
with Facebook, or Google. So Amazon cognito
actually does multiple different things. And
we are going to look at three things in specific,
we're going to look at cognito user pools,
which is a user directory to authenticate
against identity providers, we're going to
look at cognito identity pools, which provides
temporary credentials for your users to access
native services. And we're gonna look at cognito
sync, which syncs users data and preferences
across all devices. So let's get to
so to fully understand Amazon cognito, we
have to understand the concepts of web identity
Federation and identity providers. So let's
go through these definitions. So for web identity
Federation, it's to exchange the identity
and security information between an identity
provider and an application. So now looking
at identity provider, it's a trusted provider
for your user identity that lets you authenticate
to access other services. So an identity provider
could be Facebook, Amazon, Google, Twitter,
GitHub, LinkedIn, you commonly see this on
websites where it allows you to log in with
a Twitter or GitHub account, that is an identity
provider. So that would be Twitter or GitHub.
And they're generally powered by different
protocols. So whenever you're doing this with
social social accounts, it's going to be with
OAuth. And so that can be powered by open
ID Connect, that's pretty much the standard
now, if there are other identity providers,
so if you needed a single sign on solution,
SAML is the most common one. Alright. So the
first thing we're looking at is cognito. User
pools, which is the most common use case for
cognito. And that is just a directory of your
users, which is decentralized here. And it's
going to handle actions such as signup sign
in account recoveries, that would be like
resetting a password account confirmation,
that would be like confirming your email after
sign up. And it has the ability to connect
to identity providers. So it does have its
own like email and password form that it can
take, but it can also leverage. Maybe if you
want to have Facebook Connect or Amazon connect
and etc. You can do that as well. The way
it persists a connection after it authenticate
is that generates a JW t. So that's how you're
going to persist that connection. So let's
look at more of the options so that we can
really bake in the utility here of user pools.
So here left hand side, we have a bunch of
different settings. And for attributes, we
can determine what should be our primary attribute
should be our username when they sign up,
or should it be email and phone phone number.
And if it is, you know, can they sign up or
sign in, if the email address hasn't been
verified, or the conditions around that, we
can set the restrictions on the password the
length, if it requires special characters,
we can see what kind of attributes are required
to collect on signup, if we need their birthday,
or email or etc. It has the capabilities of
turning on MFA. So if you want multi factor
authentication, very easy way to integrate
that if you want to have user campaigns, so
if you're used to like sending out campaigns
via MailChimp, you can easily integrate cognito
with pinpoint, which is user campaigns, right.
And you also can override a lot of functionality
using lambda. So anytime like a sign up or
sign in, or recovery passwords triggered,
there is a hook so that you can then trigger
lambda to do something with that. So that's
just some of the things that you do with cognito
user pools. But the most important thing to
remember is just it's a way of decentralizing
your authentication that's for for user pool.
All right. So now it's time to look at cognito
identity pools, identity pools provide temporary
natives credentials to access services such
as dynamodb, or s3, identity pools can be
thought of as the actual mechanism authorizing
access to the AWS resources. So you know,
the idea is you have an identity pool, you're
gonna say, who's allowed to generate those
AWS credentials, and then use the SDK to generate
those credentials. And then that application
can then access those at the services. So
just to really hit that home here, I do have
screenshots to give you an idea what that
is. So first, we're going to choose a provider.
So our provider can be authenticated. So we
can choose cognito, or even a variety of other
ones, or you can have it on authenticated.
So that is also an option for you. And then
after you create that identity pool, they
have an easy way for you to use the SDK. So
you could just drop down your platform and
you have the code and you're ready to go to
go get those credentials. If you're thinking
did I actually put in my real, real example
or identity pool ID there? It's not, it's
not I actually go in and replace all these.
So if you're ever wondering and watching these
videos, and you're seeing these things I always
replaced.
We're going to just touch on one more, which
is cognito. Sync. And so sync lets you sync
user data and preferences across all devices
with one line of code cognito, uses push notifications
to push those updates and synchronize data.
And under the hood, it's using simple notification
service to push this data to devices. And
the the data which is user data and preferences
is key value data. And it's actually stored
with the identity pool. So that's what you're
pushing back and forth. But the only thing
you need to know is what it does. And what
it does is it syncs user data and preferences
across all devices with one line of code.
So we're onto the Amazon cognito cheat sheets,
and let's jump into it. So cognito is a decentralized
managed authentication system. So when you
need to easily add authentication to your
mobile or desktop apps, think cognito. So
let's talk about user pools. So user pool
is the user directory allows users to authenticate
using OAuth two ipds, such as Facebook, Google
Amazon to connect to your web applications.
And cognito user pool isn't in itself an IPD.
All right, so it can be on that list as well.
User pools use JW T's to persist authentication.
Identity pools provide temporary database
credentials to access services, such as s3
dynamodb, cognito. Sync can sync user data
preferences across devices with one line of
code powered by SNS web identity Federation,
they're not going to ask you these questions.
But you need to know what these are exchange
identity and security information between
identity provider and an application. identity
provider is a trusted provider for your user
to authenticate or sorry to identify that
user. So you can use them to dedicate to access
other services. Then you have Oh IDC is a
type of identity provider which uses OAuth
and you have SAML which is a type of identity
provider which is used for single sign on
so there you go. We're done with cognito Hey,
this is Angie brown from exam Pro, and we
are going to take a look here at AWS command
line interface also known as COI, which control
multiple at the services from the command
line and automate them through scripts. So
COI lets you interact with AWS from anywhere
by simply using a command line. So down below
here I have a terminal and I'm using the AWS
CLI which starts with AWS so to get installed
on your computer. AWS has a script, a Python
script that you can use to install the COI.
But once it's installed, you're going to now
have the ability to type AWS within your terminal,
followed by a bunch of different commands.
And so the things that you can perform from
the CLR is you could list buckets, upload
data to s3, launch, stop, start and terminate
easy to instances, update security groups
create subnets, there's an endless amount
of things that you can do. All right. And
so I just wanted to point out a couple of
very important flags, flags are these things
where we have hyphen, hyphen, and then we
have a name here. And this is going to change
the behavior of these COI commands. So we
have output and so the outputs what's going
to be returned to us. And we have the option
between having Jason table and plain text.
I'm for profiles, if you are switching between
multiple AWS accounts, you can specify the
profile, which is going to reference to the
credentials file to quickly let you perform
CL actions under different accounts. So there
you go. So now we're going to take a look
at eight of a software development kit known
as SDK. And this allows you to control multiple
AWS services using popular programming languages.
So to understand what an SDK is, let's go
define that. So it is a set of tools and libraries
that you can use to create applications for
a specific software package. So in the case
for the Ava's SDK, it is a set of API libraries
that you you that let you integrate data services
into your applications. Okay, so that fits
pretty well into the distribution of an SDK.
And the SDK is available for the following
languages. We have c++, go Java, JavaScript,
dotnet, no, Jess, PHP, Python, and Ruby. And
so I just have an example of a couple of things
I wrote in the SDK. And one is a no Jess and
one is Ruby into the exact same script, it's
for ABS recognition for detecting labels,
but just to show you how similar it is among
different languages, so more or less the,
the syntax is going to be the same. But yeah,
that's all you need to know, in order to use
the line SDK, we're gonna have to do a little
bit work beforehand and enable programmatic
access for the user, where we want to be able
to use these development tools, okay. And
so when you turn on programmatic access for
user, you're going to then get an access key
and a secret. So then you can utilize these
services. And so down below, you can see I
have an access key and secret generated.
Now, once you have these, you're going to
want to store them somewhere. And you're going
to want to store them in your user's home
directory. And you're going to want them within
a hidden directory called dot AWS, and then
a file called credentials. Okay, so down below
here, I have an example of a credentials file.
And you'll see that we have default credentials.
So if we were to use CLR SDK, it's going to
use those ones by default if we don't specify
any. But if we were working with multiple
AWS accounts, we're going to end up with multiple
credentials. And so you can organize them
into something called profiles here. And so
I have one here for enterprise D, and D, Space
Nine. So now that we understand pragmatic
access, let's move on to learning about Ceylon.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are going to do the COI and SDK follow
along here. So let's go over to I am and create
ourselves a new user so we can generate some
database credentials. So now we're going to
go ahead and create a new user. And we're
going to give them programmatic access so
we can get a key and secret. I'm going to
name this user Spock. Okay. And we're going
to go next here. And we're going to give them
developer permissions, which is a power user
here. Okay, and you can do the same here,
if you don't have that, just go ahead and
create that group. Name it developers and
just select power access there, okay? power
with a capital I guess, there, okay. But I
already created it earlier with our I am,
I am walk through there or follow along. So
we're going to skip over to tags and a review.
And we're gonna create that user. Alright.
And so now we're gonna get an Access ID and
secret. So I actually want to hold on to these.
So I'm just gonna copy that there. And we're
gonna move over here and just paste that in.
Okay. And so we're just going to hold on to
these and now we need an environment where
we can actually do a bit of coding and use
the CLA and the best place to do that in AWS
is cloud nine. So we're gonna make our way
over to cloud nine, and we're gonna spin ourselves
up a new environment, okay. So here we are,
and still have these two other environments
here. I just seem to not be able to get rid
of them. Generally, they they do delete with
very little trouble because I messed with
the cloudformation stack, they're sticking
around here, but you won't have this problem.
So I'm just going to create a new environment
here. And we are going to go ahead and call
this Spock Dev. Okay, and we're gonna go to
the next step. And I'm just going to continuously
ignore these silly errors. And we're going
to use the smallest instance here, the TT
micro, which will be on the free tier, okay,
and we're going to use Amazon Linux. And this,
cloud nine will actually spin down after 30
minutes Non Us. So if you forget about it,
it will automatically turn itself off, start
us off, which is really nice. And we'll go
ahead and go to next step. And it's going
to then just give us a summary here, we'll
hit Create environment. And now we just have
to wait for this environment to start up.
So we'll just wait a few minutes here. So
our cloud nine environment is ready here.
Okay. And we have a terminal here, and it's
connected to any c two instance. And the first
thing I'm going to do is I just can't stand
this white theme. So I'm gonna go to themes
down here, go to UI themes, and we're going
to go to classic dark, okay, and that's gonna
be a lot easier on my eyes here. And so the
first thing we want to do is we want to plug
in our credentials here so that we can start
using the CLA. So the COI is already pre installed
on this instance here. So if I was to type
AWS, we already have access to it. But if
we wanted to learn how to install it, let's
actually just go through the motions of that.
Okay, so I just pulled up a couple of docs
here just to talk about the installation process
of the COI, we already have the COI installs
of a type universe, it's already here. So
it's going to be too hard to uninstall it
just to install it to show you here, but I'm
just going to kind of walk you through it
through these docks here just to get you an
idea how you do it. So the COI requires either
Python two or Python three. And so on the
Amazon Linux, I believe that it has both.
So if I was to type in pi and do virgin here,
okay.
Or just Python, sorry, I'm always thinking
of shorthands. This has version 3.6, point
eight, okay. And so when you go ahead and
install it, you're going to be using Pip.
So PIP is the way that you install things
in Python, okay, and so it could be PIP or
PIP three, it depends, because there used
to be Python two, and southern Python three
came out, they needed a way to distinguish
it. So they called it PIP three. But Python
two is no longer supported. So now PIP three
is just Pip. Okay, so you know, he's got to
play around based on your system, okay. But
generally, it's just Pip pip, install ATSC
Li. And that's all there is to it. And to
get Python install, your system is going to
vary, but generally, you know, it's just for
Amazon, Linux, it is a CentOS, or Red Hat
kind of flavor of Linux. So it's going to
use a Yum, install Python. And just for all
those other Unix distributions, it's mostly
going to be apt get Okay, so now that we know
how to install the CLA, I'm just gonna type
clear here and we are going to set up our
credentials. Alright, so we're gonna go ahead
and install our credentials here, they're
probably already installed, because cloud
nine is very good at setting you up with everything
that you need. But we're going to go through
the motions of it anyway. And just before
we do that, we need to install a one thing,
cloud nine here. And so I'm going to install
via node package manager c nine, which allows
us to open files from the terminal into Cloud
Nine here. And so the first thing I want you
to do is I want to go to your home directory,
you do that by typing Tilda, which is for
home, and forward slash, OK. And so now I
want you to do l LS, hyphen, LA, okay. And
it's going to list everything within this
directory, and we were looking for a directory
called dot AWS. Now, if you don't have this
one, you just type it MK Dir. And you do dot
AWS to create it, okay, but already exists
for us. Because again, cloud nine is very
good at setting things up for us. And then
in here, we're expecting to see a credentials
file that should contain our credential. So
typing see nine, the program we just installed
there, I'm just going to do credentials here,
okay. And it's going to open it up above here.
And you can already see that it's a set of
credentials for us, okay. And I'm just going
to flip over and just have a comparison here.
So we have some credentials. And it is for
I don't know who, but we have them and I'm
going to go ahead and add a new one, I'm just
going to make a new one down here called Spark,
okay. All right. And basically, what I'm doing
is I'm actually creating a profile here, so
that I can actually switch between credentials.
Okay. And I'm just going to copy and paste
them in here. Alright, and so I'm just going
to save that there. And so now I have a second
set of credentials within the credential file
there, and it is saved. And I'm just going
to go down to my terminal here and do clear.
And so now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to type in AWS s Three LS, and I'm going to
do hyphen, hyphen profile, I'm going to now
specify Spock. And that's going to use that
set of credentials there. And so now I've
done that using sparks credentials, and we
get a list of a bucket stuff. Okay? So now
if we wanted to copy something down from s3,
we're going to AWS s3, CP. And we are going
to go into that bucket there. So it's going
to be exam Pro, enterprise D, I have this
from memory. And we will do data dot jpg,
okay. And so what that's going to do is it's
going to download a file, but before I actually
run this here, okay, I'm just going to CD
dot dot and go back to my home directory here.
Okay. And I'm just going to copy this again
here and paste it and so I should be able
to download it. But again, I got to do a hyphen
having profile specifies proc Spark, because
I don't want to use the default profile there.
Okay, um, and, uh, complain, because I'm missing
the G on the end of that there, okay?
And it's still complaining. Maybe I have to
do s3 forward slash forward slash,
huh?
No, that's the command. Oh, you know why?
It's because when you use CP, you have to
actually specify the output file here. So
you need your source and your destination.
Okay, so I'm just gonna type Spock, or sorry,
data, sorry, data dot JPG there. Okay. And
that's going to download that file. So, I
mean, I already knew that I had something
for AWS there. So I'm just going to go to
AWS to show you that there. So if you want
to do the same thing as I did, you knew you
definitely need to go set up a bucket in s3.
Okay. So if I just go over here, we have the
exam, pro 00, enterprise D, and we have some
images there. Okay. So that's where I'm grabbing
that image from. And I could just move this
file into my environment directory, so I actually
can have access to it there. Okay, so I'm
just going to do MB data. And I'm just going
to move that one directory up here. Okay.
All right. And so now we have data over here,
okay. And so you know, that's how you'd go
about using the CLA with credentials. Okay.
Yeah, we just open that file there if we wanted
to preview it. Okay. So now let's, let's move
on to the SDK, and let's use our credentials
to do something programmatically. So now that
we know how to use the COI, and where to store
our credentials, let's go actually do something
programmatically with the SDK. And so I had
recently contributed to database docs, for
recognition. So I figured we could pull some
of that code and have some fun there. Okay.
So why don't you do is go to Google and type
in Avis docs recognition. And we're going
to click through here to Amazon recognition,
we're going to go to the developer developers
guide with HTML, apparently, they have a new
look, let's give it a go. Okay, there's always
something new here. I'm not sure if I like
it. But this is the new look to the docks.
And we're gonna need to find that code there.
So I think it is under detecting faces here.
And probably under detecting faces in an image,
okay. And so the code that I added was actually
the Ruby and the no GS one, okay, so we can
choose which one we want. I'm going to do
the Ruby one, because I think that's more
fun. And that's my language of choice. Okay.
And so I'm just going to go ahead and copy
this code here. Okay. And we're going to go
back to our cloud nine environment, I'm going
to create a new, a new file here, and I'm
just going to call this detect faces, ooh,
keep underscore their faces.rb. Okay. And
I'm just going to double click in here and
paste that code in. Alright. And what we're
going to have to do is we're going to need
to supply our credentials here, generally,
you do want to pass them in as environment
variables, that's a very safe way to provide
them. So we can give that a go. But in order
to get this working, we're going to have to
create a gem file in here. So I'm just going
to create a new file here, because we need
some dependencies here. And we're just going
to type in gem file, okay. And within this
gem file, we're going to have to provide the
gem recognition. Okay, so I'm just gonna go
over here and supply that there. There is
a few other lines here that we need to supply.
So I'm just gonna go off screen and go grab
them for you. Okay, so I just went off screen
here and grabbed that extra code here. This
is pretty boilerplate stuff that you have
to include in a gem file. Okay. And so what
this is going to do, it's going to install
of AWS SDK for Ruby, but specifically just
for recognition. So I do also have open up
here the AWS SDK, for Ruby and for no GS,
Python, etc. They all
I have one here. And so they tells you how
you can install gems. So for dealing with
recognition here, I'm just going to do a quick
search here for recognition. Okay, sometimes
it's just better to navigate on the left hand
side here. Alright, and so I'm just looking
for a recognition. Okay, and so if we want
to learn how to use this thing, usually a
lot of times with this, it's going to tell
you what gem you're gonna need to install.
So this is the one we are installing. And
then we click through here through client,
and then we can get an idea of all the kind
of operations we can perform. Okay, so when
I needed to figure out how to write this,
I actually went to the CLR here, and I just
kind of read through it and pieced it together
and looked at the output to figure that out.
Okay, so nothing too complicated there. But
anyway, we have all the stuff we need here.
So we need to make sure we're in our environment
directory here, which is that Spock dev directory.
So we're going to tilde out, which goes to
our home directory environment. Okay, we're
gonna do an ls hyphen, LA. And just make sure
that we can see that file there and the gem
file, okay, and then we can go ahead and do
a bundle install. All right, and so what that's
going to do is it's going to now install that
dependency. so here we can see that installed
the EVAs SDK, SDK, core and also recognition.
Okay. And so now we have all our dependencies
to run the script here. So the only thing
that we need to do here is we need to provide
it an input. So here, we can provide it a
specific bucket and a file, there's a way
to provide a locally, we did download this
file, but I figured what we'll do is we'll
actually provide the bucket here. So we will
say what's the bucket called exam pro 000.
And the next thing we need to do is define
the key. So it's probably the key here. So
I'm going to do enterprise D. Okay. And then
we're just going to supply data there. All
right. And we can pass these credentials via
the environment variables, we could just hard
code them and paste them in here. But that's
a bit sloppy. So we are going to go through
the full motions of providing them through
the environment here. And all we have to do
that is we're just going to paste in, like
so. Okay. And we're just going to copy that.
That's the first one. And then we're going
to do the password here. Oops. Okay. And hopefully,
this is going to work the first time and then
we'll have to do bundle, exactly. detect faces,
okay. And then this is how these are going
to get passed into there. And assuming that
my key and bucket are correct, then hopefully,
we will get some output back. Okay.
All right, it's just saying it couldn't detect
faces here, I just have to hit up here, I
think I just need to put the word Ruby in
front of here.
Okay, so my bad. Alright, and we is it working.
So we don't have the correct permissions here.
So we are a power user. So maybe we just don't
have enough permission. So I'm just going
to go off screen here and see what permissions
we need to be able to do this. So just playing
around a little bit here, and also reading
the documentation for the Ruby SDK, I figured
out what the problem was, it's just that we
don't need this forward slash here. So we
just take that out there, okay, and just run
what we ran last there, okay. And then we're
going to get some output back. And then it
just shows us that it detected a face. So
we have the coordinates of a face. And if
we used some additional tool there, we could
actually draw overtop of the image, a bounding
box to show where the face is detected. There's
some interesting information. So it detected
that the person in the image was male, and
that they were happy. Okay. So, you know,
if you think that that is happy, then that's
what recognition thinks, okay. And it also
detected the face between ages 32 and 48.
To be fair, data is an Android, so he has
a very unusual skin color. So you know, it's
very hard to do to determine that age, but
I would say that this is the acceptable age
range of the actor at the time of, so it totally
makes sense. Okay. Um, so yeah, and there
you go. So that is the pragmatic way of doing
it. Now, you don't ever really want to ever
store your credentials with on your server,
okay? Because you can always use Iam roles,
attach them to EC two instances, and then
that will safely provide credentials onto
your easy two instances, to have those privileges.
But it's important to know how to use the
SDK. And whenever you're in development working
on your local machine, or maybe you're in
cloud nine environment, you are going to have
to supply those credentials. Okay. So there
you go. So now that we are done with our ADA,
or SC Li and SDK, follow along here, let's
just do some cleanup. So I'm just going to
close this tab here for cloud nine. And we're
going to go over to cloud nine and we're going
to just delete that and Now again, it's not
going to be bad for you to have it hanging
around here, it's not going to cause you any
problems, it's going to shut down on its own.
But you know, if we don't need it, we might
as well get rid of it. Okay. And so I'm just
gonna have the word delete here. And hopefully
this one deletes as long as they don't fiddle
and delete these security groups before it
has an opportunity to delete. That should
have no problem for me here. And then we're
just going to go to our Im role, or sorry,
our user there. And what we really want to
do is since they're not being used anymore,
we want to expire those credentials. But I'm
actually going to also go ahead and delete
the user here. So they're going to be 100%
gone there. Okay, so there, that's all the
cleanup we had to do.
over onto the AWS ccli SDK cheat sheet so
let's jump into it. So COI stands for command
line interface SDK stands for software development
kit. The COI lets you enter interact with
AWS from anywhere by simply using a command
line. The SDK is a set of API libraries that
let you integrate Ada services into your applications.
promatic access must be enabled per user via
the Iam console to UCLA or SDK into its config
command is used to set up your database credentials
for this Eli, the CLA is installed via a Python
script credentials get stored in a plain text
file, whenever possible use roles instead
of at this credentials. I do have to put that
in there. And the SDK is available for the
following programming languages c++, go Java,
JavaScript, dotnet, no GS, PHP, Python and
Ruby. Okay, so for the solution architect
associate, they're probably not going to ask
you questions about the SDK, but for the developer,
there definitely are. So just keep that in.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at domain name systems also
abbreviated as DNS, and you can think of them
as the phonebook of the internet. DNS translates
domain names to IP addresses, so browsers
can find internet resources. So again, domain
name servers are a service which handles converting
a domain name such as exam prodotto, into
a rentable Internet Protocol address. So here
we have an example of an ipv4 address. And
this allows your computer to find specific
servers on the internet automatically, depending
what domain name you browse. so here we can
see it again. So we see example, CO, it looks
up the the domain name and determines that
it should go this IP address, which should
go to this server. So that is the process.
So we need to understand the concept of Internet
Protocol, also known as IP. So IP addresses
are what are uniquely used to identify computers
on a network. And it allows communication
between using them. And that is what the IP
is. And so IPS come in two variations. We
have ipv4, which you're probably most familiar
with, because it's been around longer. And
then we have ipv6, which looks a bit unusual,
but there are definitely benefits to it. So
ipv4 is an address space with 32 bits. And
this is the amount of available addresses
that are out there. And the issue with ipv4
is we're running out of IP addresses, okay,
because it's based on this, this way of writing
numbers, and there's a limit to how many numbers
are here. So to come up, or to combat that
solution. That's where ipv6 comes in. And
so ipv6 uses an address space of 128 bits.
And it has up to 340 on the sillian potential
addresses. And so basically, they've invented
a way so we will not run out of addresses,
okay, and this is what that address looks
like. So it's big and long, it's not as easy
to look look at as an IP, ipv4 address, but
we're never gonna run out of them. So you
know, come the future. We're gonna see this
implemented more, you can definitely use ipv6
on AWS, as well as ipv4, but you know, this
is future. So domain registers are the authorities
who have the ability to assign domain names
under one or more top level domains. And if
you're thinking about what are some common
registrar's, we have them listed down below.
So you've probably seen them before like Hostgator,
GoDaddy, domain.com. AWS is also their own
domain register with route 53. And name cheap,
okay, domain domains get registered through
the internet, which is a service provided
by the internet Corporation for Assigned Names
and Numbers, I can and enforces the uniqueness
of domain names all over the internet. And
when you register a domain name, it can be
found publicly in the central who is database.
So if you've ever wondered who owns a domain,
there's a high chance that you could go type
it in who is and they might have the registers
contact information. Now you can pay additional,
or in the case of revenue three, I don't think
there's any additional money to keep that
information private. But that's it. You have
a registered domain name. And you wonder why
somebody is calling you out of the blue, maybe
they've been looking you up through here.
So there you go domain. So we're looking
at the concept of top level domains. And so
if you've ever typed a domain name in and
you're wondering what that.com is, that is
the top level domain name. And there are domains
that also have second level domains. So in
the example, of.co.uk the.co is the second
level, top level domain names are controlled
by the Internet Assigned Numbers Authority.
And so anytime there's new ones, they're the
ones who are the number one authority on new
top level domains. These domains are managed
by different organizations. And it would surprise
you to see that there's hundreds upon hundreds
of top level domains. And you might not even
know about them, because these companies are
just sitting on them. But like, you can see
Disney has one for dot ABC. And then we have
a dot Academy one, and also AWS has their
own, which is dot AWS. Okay, so there you
go, that's top level. So when you have a domain
name, you're gonna have a bunch of records
that tell it what to do. And one that's very
important and is absolutely required is the
SLA, the start of authority. And the SLA is
a way for the domain admins to provide additional
information about the domain such as how often
it's updated, what's the admins email address,
if there was a failure with responding to
master? How many seconds should it tried to
fault failover to the secondary namespace,
so it can contain a bunch of information,
and you can see it on the right hand side
here. And you don't necessarily have to provide
all the information. But those are all the
options. And it comes in the format of one
big long string. So you can see, we can see
the format here. And we have an example. And
then we got an eight it was example. So there
you go. And yeah, there you can only actually
have one, so a record within a single zone.
So you can't have more than one. But yeah,
it's just to give additional information.
It's absolutely.
So now we're gonna take a look at address
records. And a records are one of the most
fundamental types of DNS records. And the
idea is that you're going to be able to convert
the name of a domain directly into an IP address.
Okay. So if you had testing domain comm, and
you wanted to point it to the ipv4 address
50 221 6834, you'd use an a record for it.
And one more thing I want to know about is
that you can use naked domain names, or root
domains, that's when you don't have any www.no.
subdomains as an A record. Okay. So canticle
names, also known as C names are another fundamental
DNS record used to resolve one domain name
to another rather than an IP address. So if
you wanted, for example, to send all your
naked domain traffic to the www route, you
could do so here, right? So here we have the
we're specifying the naked domain, and we're
going to send it to look like the www domain
for some reason, for some reason, I have four
W's in here. But you can't give me a hard
time because at least that error is consistent.
But yeah, that's all there is to it. So a
records are IP addresses, and C names are
domain. So besides the SLA, the second most
important record or records are the name server
records. And they're used by top level domain
servers to direct traffic to DNS to the DNS
server contain the authoritive DNS records.
If you don't have these records, your domain
name cannot do anything. Typically, you're
gonna see multiple name servers provided as
redundancy. Something like with GoDaddy, they're
gonna give you two, with AWS, you're gonna
have four. But the more the merrier. Okay,
and so you can see an example down below here.
So if you're managing your DNS records with
route 53, DNS records for the domain would
be pointing to AWS servers, and there we have
four we have a.com, it's probably the US dotnet.
I'm not sure that is co n.org. Okay, so we
have a lot of redundancy there. Oh, now I
want to talk about the concept of TTL Time
To Live and this is the length of time that
a DNS record gets cached on resolving servers
or the user's own local machine. So the lower
the TTL, the faster the changes to DNS records
will propagate across the internet. TTL is
always measured in seconds under ipv4, so
you're gonna see more TTL is here. So if it's
not super clear, it will make sense further
into this.
So it's time to wrap up DNS with another cheat
sheet. So let's get to it. So Domain Name
System, which is DNS is an internet service
that converts domain names into routable IP
addresses. We have two types of internet protocols.
We have ipv4, which is a 32 bit address space
and has a limited number of addresses. And
then we have an example of one there. And
then we have ipv6, which is 128 bit address
space and has unlimited number of addresses.
And we also have an example there as well.
Then we talked about top level domains. And
that's just the last part of a domain like.com,
then you have second level domains. And this
doesn't always happen. But it's usually the
second last part of the domain. So in.co.uk,
it's going to be the.co. Then there we have
domain registers. These are third party companies
who register don't you register domains through,
then you have name servers, they're the servers
which contain the DNS records of the domain,
then we have some records of interest here.
So we have the SLA. This contains information
about the DNS zone and associated DNS records,
we have a records, these are records which
directly convert a domain name into an IP
address, then we have a C name records. And
these are records, which lets you convert
a domain name into another domain name. And
then we have TT ELLs, and it's the time it
takes for DNS records, or it's the time that
a DNS record will be cached for a cache for
and the lower that time means, the faster
it will propagate or update. Okay, and there
you go. Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro. And we are looking at remedy three, which
is a highly available and scalable domain
name service. So whenever you think about
revenue three, the easiest way to remember
what it does is think of GoDaddy or Namecheap,
which are both DNS providers. But the difference
is that revenue three has more synergies with
AWS services. So you have a lot more rich
functionality that you could do on on AWS
than you could with one of these other DNS
providers. What can you do with revenue three,
you can register and manage domains, you can
create various record sets on a domain, you
can implement complex traffic flows such as
bluegreen, deploys, or fail overs, you can
continuously monitor records, via health checks,
and resolve epcs outside of AWS.
So here, I have a use case, and this is actually
how we use it at exam Pro is that we have
our domain name, you can purchase it or you
can have refer to three manage the the name
servers, which allow you to then set your
record sets within route 53. And so here we
have a bunch of different record sets for
subdomains. And we want those sub domains
to point to different resources on AWS. So
for our app, our app runs behind elastic load
balancer. If we need to work on an ami image,
we could launch a single EC two instance and
point that subdomain there for our API, if
it was powered by API gateway, we could use
that subdomain for that, for our static website
hosting, we would probably want to point to
CloudFront. So the WW dot points to a CloudFront
distribution. And for fun, and for learning,
we might run a minecraft server on a very
specific IP, probably would be elastic IP
because we wouldn't want it to change. And
that could be Minecraft exam pro quo. So there's
a basic example. But we're gonna jump into
all the different complex rules that we can
do in revenue three here. So in the previous
use case, we saw a bunch of sub domains, which
were pointing to AWS resources, well, how
do we create that link so that a remedy three
will point to those resources, and that is
by creating record sets. So here, I just have
the form for record sets. So you can see the
kind of the types of records that you can
create, but it's very simple, you just fill
in your sub domain or even leave the naked
domain and then you choose the type. And in
the case for a this is allows you to point
this sub domain to a specific IP address,
you just fill it in, that's all there is to
it. Okay, now, I do need to make note of this
alias option here, which is a special option
created by AWS. So here in the next slide
here, we've set alias to true. And what it
allows us to do is directly select specific
AWS resources. So we could select CloudFront,
Elastic Beanstalk, EOB, s3 VPC API gateway,
and why would you want to do this over making
a traditional type record? Well, the idea
here is that this alias has the ability to
detect changes of IP addresses. So it continuously
keeps pointing that endpoint to the correct
resource. Okay. So that's normally when if,
if and whenever you can use alias always use
alias because it just makes it easier to manage
the connections between resources via roughly
three records. That's, and the limitations
are listed here as follows.
So the major advantage of Route 53 is it's
seven types of routing policies. And we're
going to go through every single one here.
So we understand the use case, for all seven.
Before we get into that a really good way
to visualize how to work with these different
routing policies is through traffic flow.
And so traffic flow is a visual editor that
lets you create sophisticated routing configurations
within route 53. Another advantage of traffic
flow is that we can version these policy routes.
So if you created a complex routing policy,
and you wanted to change it tomorrow, you
could save it as version one, version two,
and roll, roll this one out or roll back to
that. And just to play around traffic flow,
it does cost a few dollars per policy record.
So this whole thing is one policy record.
But they don't charge you until you create
it. So if you do want to play around with
it, just just create a new traffic flow, and
name it and it will get, you'll get to this
visual editor. And it's not until you save
this. So you can play around with this to
get an idea of like all the different routing
rules and how you can come up with creative
solutions. But now that we've covered traffic
flow, and we know that there are seven routing
rules, let's go deep and look at what we can
do. We're gonna look at our first routing
policy, which is the simple routing policy.
And it's also the default routing policy.
So when you create a record setting here,
I have one called random, and we're on the
a type here. Down below, you're gonna see
that routing policy box that's always by default
set to simple. Okay, so what can we do with
simple The idea is that you have one record,
which is here, and you can provide either
a single IP address or multiple IP addresses.
And if it's just a single, that just means
that random is going to go to that first IP
address every single time. But if you have
multiples, it's going to pick one at random.
So it's good way to make like a, if you wanted
some kind of random thing made for a to b
testing, you could do this. And that is as
simple as it is. So there you go. So now we're
looking at weighted routing policies. And
so what a weighting routing policy lets you
do is allows you to split up traffic based
on different weights assigned. Okay, so down
below, we have app.example.co. And we would
create two record sets in roughly three, and
they'd be the exact same thing, they both
say app.example.com. But we'd set them both
to weighted and we give them two different
weights. So for this one, we would name it
stable. So we've named that one stable, give
it 85%. And then we make a new record set
with exact same sub domain and set this one
to 15% call experiment, okay. And the idea
is that when ever traffic, any traffic hits
app.example.co, it's going to look at the
two weighted values. 85% is gonna go to the
stable one. And for the 15%, it's going to
go to the experimental one. And a good use
case for that is to test a small amount of
traffic to minimize impact when you're testing
out new experimental features. So that's a
very good use case for a weighted routing.
Now we're going to take a look at latency
based routing. Okay, so lane based routing
allows you to direct traffic based on the
lowest network latency possible for your end
user based on a region. Okay, so the idea
is, let's say people want to hit AP dot exam
protocol. And they're coming from Toronto.
All right, so coming from Toronto, and the
idea is that we have, we've created two records,
which have latency with this sub domain, and
one is set to us West. So that's on the west
coast. And then we have one central Canada,
I believe that's located in Montreal. And
so the idea is that it's going to look here
and say, Okay, which one produces the least
amount of latency, it doesn't necessarily
mean that it has to be the closest one geographically,
just whoever has the lowest return in milliseconds
is the one that it's going to route traffic
to. And so in this case, it's 12 milliseconds.
And logically, things that are closer by should
be faster. And so the, so it's going to route
it to this lb, as opposed to that one. So
that's, that's how latency based routing works.
So now we're looking at another routing policy,
this one is for failover. So failover allows
you to create an Active Passive setup in situations
where you want a primary site in one location,
and a secondary data recovery site and another
one. Okay, another thing to note is that revenue
three automatically monitors via health checks
from your primary site to determine if that
that endpoint is healthy. If it determines
that it's in a failed state, then all the
traffic will be automatically redirected to
that secondary location. So here, we have
done following examples, we have app.example.co.
And we have a primary location and a secondary
one. All right. And so the idea is that
roughly three, it's going to check and it
determines that this one is unhealthy based
on a health check, it's going to then reroute
the traffic to our secondary locations. So
you'd have to create, you know, two routing
policies with the exact same. The exact same
domain, you just set which one is the primary
and which one is the secondary, it's that
simple. So here, we are looking at the geolocation
routing policy. And it allows you to direct
traffic based on the geolocation, geographical
location of where the request is originating
from. So down below, we have a request from
the US hitting app dot exam pro.co. And we
have a a record set for a geolocation that
set for North America. So since the US is
in North America, it's going to go to this
record set. Alright. And that's as
simple as that.
So we're going to look at geo proximity routing
policy, which is probably the most complex
routing policy is a bit confusing, because
it sounds a lot like geolocation, but it's
not. And we'll see shortly here, you cannot
create this using record sets, you have to
use traffic flow, because it is a lot more
complicated, and you need to visually see
what you're doing. And so it's gonna be crystal
clear, we're just going to go through here
and look at what it does. So the idea is that
you are choosing a region. So you can choose
one of the existing Eva's regions, or you
can give your own set of coordinates. And
the idea is that you're giving it a bias around
this location, and it's going to draw boundaries.
So the idea is that if we created a geo proximity
routing for these regions, this is what it
would look like. But if we were to give this
120 5% more bias, you're gonna see that here,
it was a bit smaller, now it's a bit larger,
but if we minus it, it's going to reduce it.
So this is the idea behind a geo proximity
where you have these boundaries, okay. Now,
just to look at in more detail here, the idea
is that you can set as many regions or points
as you want here. And so here, I just have
two as an example. So I have China chosen
over here. And this looks like we have Dublin
shows. So just an idea to show you a simple
example. Here's a really complicated one here,
I chose every single region just so you have
an idea of split. So the idea is you can choose
as little or as many as you want. And then
you can also give it custom coordinates. So
here I chose Hawaii. So I looked at the Hawaii
coordinates, plugged it in, and then I turned
the bias down to 80%. So that it would have
exactly around here and I could have honed
it in more. So it just gives you a really
clear picture of how geo proximity works.
And it really is boundary based and you have
to use traffic flow for that. So the last
routing policy we're going to look at is multivalue.
And multivalue is exactly like simple routing
policy. The only difference is that it uses
a health check. Okay, so the idea is that
if it picks one by random, it's going to check
if it's healthy. And if it's not, it's just
going to pick another one by random. So that
is the only difference between multivalue
and simple. So there you go.
Another really powerful feature of Route 53
is the ability to do health checks. Okay,
so the idea is that you can go create a health
check, and I can say for AP dot exam dot prodotto,
it will check on a regular basis to see whether
it is healthy or not. And that's a good way
to see at the DNS level if something's wrong
with your instance, or if you want to failover
so let's get into the details of here. So
we can check health every 30 seconds by default
and we can it can be reduced down to 10 seconds,
okay, a health check and initiate a failover.
If the status is returned unhealthy, a cloudwatch
alarm can be created to alert you of status
unhealthy, a health check can monitor other
health checks to create a chain of reactions.
You can have up to 50 in a single AWS account.
And the pricing is pretty affordable. So it's
50 cents. So that's two quarters for per endpoint
on AWS. And there are some additional features,
which is $1 per feature. Okay.
So if you're using route 53, you might wonder
well, how do I route traffic to my on premise
environment and that's where revenue three
resolver comes into play, formerly known as
dot two. resolver is a regional service that
lets you connect route DNS queries between
your VBC and your network. So it is a tool
for hybrid environments on premises and cloud.
And we have some options here. If we just
want to do inbound and outbound inbound only
or outbound Only. So that's all you really
need to know about it. And that's how you
do hybrid networking. So now we're taking
a look at revenue three cheat sheet, and we're
going to summarize everything that we have
learned about roughly three. So revenue three
is a DNS provider to register and manage domains
create record sets, think GoDaddy or namecheap.
Okay, there's seven different types of routing
policies, starting with simple routing policy,
which allows you to input a single or multiple
IP addresses to randomly choose an endpoint
at random, then you have weighted routing,
which splits up traffic between different
weights, assign some percentages, latency
based routing, which is based off of routing
traffic to the based on region for the lowest
possible latency for users. So it's not necessarily
the closest geolocation but the the lowest
latency, okay, we have a failover routing,
which uses a health check. And you set a primary
and a secondary, it's going to failover to
the secondary if the primary health check
fails, you have geolocation, which roads traffic
based on the geolocation. So this is based
on geolocation would be like North America
or Asia, then you have geo proximity routing,
which can only be done in traffic flow allows
you to set biases so you can set basically
like this map of boundaries, based on the
different ones that you have, you have multi
value answer, which is identical to a simple,
simple routing, the only difference being
that it uses a health check. In order to do
that. We looked at traffic flow, which is
a visual editor for changing routing policies,
you conversion those record those policy records
for easy rollback, we have alias record, which
is a device's Smart DNS record, which detects
IP changes freedoms resources and adjusts
them automatically always want to use alias
record, when you have the opportunity to do
so you have route 53 resolver, which is a
hybrid solution. So you can connect your on
premise and cloud so you can network between
them. And then you have health checks, which
can be created to monitor and and automatically
failover to another endpoint. And you can
have health checks, monitor other health checks
to create a chain of reactions, for detecting
issues for endpoints. Hey, this is Angie brown
from exam Pro. And we are looking at elastic
Compute Cloud EC two, which is a cloud computing
service. So choose your last storage memory,
network throughput and then launch and SSH
into your server within minutes. Alright,
so we're on to the introduction to EC two.
And so EC T was a highly configurable server.
It's a resizeable compute capacity, it takes
minutes to launch new instances, and anything
and everything I need is uses easy to instance
underneath. So whether it's RDS or our ECS,
or simple system manager, I highly, highly
believe that at AWS, they're all using easy
to okay. And so we said they're highly configurable.
So what are some of the options we have here?
Well, we get to choose an Amazon machine image,
which is going to have our last so whether
you want Red Hat, Ubuntu windows, Amazon,
Linux or Susi, then you choose your instance
type. And so this is going to tell you like
how much memory you want versus CPU. And here,
you can see that you can have very large instances.
So here is one server that costs $5 a month.
And here we have one that's $1,000 a month.
And this one has 36 CPUs and 60 gigabytes
of memory with 10 gigabyte performance, okay,
then you add your storage, so you could add
EBS or Fs and we have different volume types
we can attach. And then you can configure
your your instance. So you can secure it and
get your key pairs. You can have user data,
Im roles and placement groups, which we're
all going to talk about starting. All right,
so we're gonna look at instance types and
what their usage would be. So generally, when
you launch an EC two instance, it's almost
always going to be in the T two or the T three
family. And
yes, we have all these little acronyms which
represent different types of instance types.
So we have these more broad categories. And
then we have subcategories, or families have
instances that are specialized. Okay, so starting
with general purpose, it's a balance of compute
and compute memory and networking resources.
They're very good for web servers and code
repository. So you're going to be very familiar
with this level here. Then you have compute
optimized instances. So these are ideal for
compute bound applications that benefit from
high performance processors. And as the name
suggests, this is compute it's going to have
more computing power. Okay, so scientific
modeling, dedicated gaming servers, and ad
server engines. And notice they all start
with C. So that makes it a little bit easier
to remember. Then you have memory optimized
and as the name implies, it's going to have
more memory on the server. So fast performance
for workloads that process large data sets
in memory. So use cases in memory caches in
memory databases, Real Time big data analytics,
then you have accelerated optimized instances,
these are utilizing hardware accelerators
or co processors. They're going to be good
for machine learning, computational finance,
seismic analysis, speech recognition, really
cool. Future tech uses a lot of accelerated
optimized instances. And then you have storage
optimized. So this is for high sequential
reads and write access to very large data
sets on local storage. Two use cases might
be a no SQL database in memory or transactional
databases or data warehousing. So how is it
important? How important is it to know all
these families, it's not so important to associate
track at the professional track, you will
need to know themselves, all you need to know
are these general categories and what and
just kind of remember, which, which fits into
where and just their general purposes. All
right.
So in each family of EC two instance types,
so here we have the T two, we're gonna have
different sizes, and so we can see small,
medium, large x large, I just wanted to point
out that generally, the way the sizing works
is you're gonna always get double of whatever
the previous one was, generally, I say generally,
because it does vary. But the price is almost
always double. Okay, so from small to medium,
you can see the ram has doubled, the CPU has
doubled for medium large, isn't exactly doubled.
But for here, the CPU has doubled. Okay, but
the price definitely definitely has doubled,
almost nearly so it's almost always twice
inside. So general rule is, if you're wondering
when you should upgrade, if you need to have
something, then you're better off just going
to the next version.
So we're gonna look at the concept called
instance profile. And this is how your EC
two instances get permissions. Okay? So instead
of embedding your AWS credentials, your access
key and secret in your code, so your instance
has permissions to access certain services,
you can attach a role to an instance via an
instance profile. Okay, so the concept here
is you have any situ instance, and you have
an instance profile. And that's just the container
for a role. And then you have the role that
actually has the permissions. Alright. And
so I do need to point out that whenever you
have the chance to not embed a those credentials,
you should never embed them. Okay, that's
like a hard rule with AWS. And anytime you
see an exam question on that, definitely,
always remember that the way you set an instance
profile tuneecu instance, if you're using
the wizard, you're going to see the IM role
here. And so you're going to choose, you're
going to create one and then attach it. But
there's one thing that people don't see is
they don't see that instance profile, because
it's kind of like this invisible step. So
if you're using the console, it's actually
going to create it for you. If you're doing
this programmatically through cloud formation,
you'd actually have to create an instance
profile. So sometimes people don't realize
that this thing exists. Okay. We're gonna
take a look here at placement groups, the
placement groups let you choose the logical
placement of your instances to optimize for
communication performance, or durability.
And placement groups are absolutely free.
And they're optional, you do not have to launch
your EC two instance in within a placement
group. But you do get some benefits based
on your use case. So let's first look at cluster
so cluster PACs instances close together inside
an AZ and they're good for low latency network
performance for tightly coupled node to node
communication. So when you want servers to
be really close together, so communication
superfast, and they're well suited for high
performance computing HPC applications, but
clusters cannot be multi az, alright, then
you have partitions. And so partitions spread
instances across logical partitions. Each
partition does not share the underlying hardware.
So they're actually running on individual
racks here for each partition. They're well
suited for large distributed and replicated
workloads, such as Hadoop, Cassandra, and
Kafka, because these technologies use partitions
and now we have physical partitions. So that
makes total sense there, then you have spread
and so spread is when each instance is placed
on a different rack. And so, when you have
critical instances that should be kept separate
from each other. And this is the case where
you use this and you can spread a max of seven
instances and spreads can be multi az, okay,
whereas clusters are not allowed to go multi
AZ. So there you go. So user data is a script,
which will automatically run when launching
easy to instance. And this is really useful
when you want to install packages or apply
updates or anything you'd like before the
launch of a an instance. And so when you're
going through the easy to wizard, there's
this advanced details step where you can provide
your bash script here to do whatever you'd
like. So here I have it installing Apache,
and then it starts that server. If you were
Logging into an ECU instance. And you didn't
really know whether user data script was performed
on that instance, on launch, you could actually
use the this URL at 169 24 169 24. If you
were to curl that within that easy to instance,
with the user data, it would actually return
whatever script was run. So that's just good
to know. But yeah, user data scripts are very
useful. And I think you will be using one.
So metadata is additional information about
your EC two instance, which you can get at
runtime. Okay. So if you were to SSH into
your EC two instance, and run this curl command
with latest metadata on the end, you're going
to get all this information here. And so the
idea is that you could get information such
as the current public IP address, or the app
ID that was used to watch the students, or
maybe the instance type. And so the idea here
is that by being able to do this programmatically,
you could use a bash script, you could do
somebody with user data metadata to perform
all sorts of advanced Ada staging operations.
So yeah, better data is quite useful and great
for debugging. So yeah, it's time to look
at the EC two cheat sheet here. So let's jump
into it. So elastic Compute Cloud EC two is
a cloud computing service. So you configure
your EC two by choosing your storage, memory
and network throughput, and other options
as well. Then you launch an SSH into your
server within minutes. ec two comes in a variety
of instance types specialized for different
roles. So we have general purpose, that's
for balance of compute memory and network
resources, you have compute optimized, as
the name implies, you can get more computing
power here. So ideal for compute bound applications
that benefit from high performance processors,
then you have memory optimized. So that's
fast performance for workloads that process
large data sets in memory, then you have accelerated
optimized hardware accelerators or co processors,
then you have storage optimized that's high
sequential read and write access to very large
data sets on local storage, then you have
the concept of instant sizes. And so instant
sizes generally double in price and key attributes.
So if you're ever wondering when it's time
to upgrade, just think when you're need double
of what you need that time to upgrade, then
you have placement groups, and they let you
choose the logical placement of your instances
to optimize communication performance, durability,
and placement groups are free, it's not so
important to remember the types are because
I don't think we'll come up with a solution
architect associate. And then we have user
data. So a script that will be automatically
run when launching EC two instance, for metadata.
Metadata is about the current instance. So
you could access this metadata via a local
endpoint when SSH into an EC two instance.
So you have this curl command here with metadata,
and metadata could be the instance type, current
IP address, etc, etc. And then the last thing
is instance profile. This is a container for
an IM role that you can use to pass roll information
to an easy to instance, when the instance
starts. Alright, so there you go, that's easy.
So we're gonna take a look at the EC two pricing
model. And there are four ways we can pay
with EC two, we have on demand spot, reserved
and dedicated. And we're going to go through
each section and see where each one is.
We're gonna take first a look at on demand
pricing. And this is whenever you launch an
EC, two instance, it's going to by default
use on demand, and so on demand has no upfront
payment and no long term commitment. You're
only charged by the hour or by the man, it's
going to vary based on ecsu instance type.
And that's how the pricing is going to work.
And you might think, okay, what's the use
case here? Well, on demand is for applications
where the workload is short term spike, you're
in predictable. When you have a new app for
development, or you want to just run an experiment,
this is where on demand is going to be a good
fit for you. Know, we're taking a look at
reserved instances, also known as RI and these
are going to give you the best long term savings.
And it's designed for applications that have
steady state predictable usage or require
reserved capacity. So what you're doing is
you're saying to AWS, you know, I'm gonna
make a commitment to you. And I'm going to
be using this over next period of time, and
they're going to give you savings. Okay, so
this reduced pricing is going to be based
on three variables, we have term class offerings,
and payment options. We'll walk through these
things to see how they all work. So for payment
options, we have standard convertible and
scheduled standard is going to give us the
greatest savings with 75% reduced pricing.
And this is compared to obviously to on demand.
The thing here though, is that you cannot
change the ri attributes, attributes being
like instance type, right? So whatever you
have, you're you're stuck with it. Now if
you needed a bit more flexibility, because
you might need to have more room to grow in
the future. You'd look at convertible so the
savings aren't gonna be as great. We're looking
at it. To 54%. But now you have the ability
to let's say, change your instance type to
a larger size, you can't go smaller, you can
always go larger. And you're, but you're going
to have some flexibility there, then there's
scheduled, and this is when you need to reserve
instance, for a specific time period, this
could be the case where you always have a
workload that's predictable every single Friday
for a couple hours. And the idea is by telling
you Ws that you're going to be doing out on
schedule, they will give you savings there
that's going to vary. The other two things
is term and payment options. So the terms
is how long are you willing to commit one
year or three year contract, the greater the
terms, the greater the savings, and you have
payment options, so you have all the front
partial upfront and no upfront, no friends,
the most interesting one, because you could
say, you know, I'm going to use the server
for a year, and you and you'll just pay at
the end of the month. And so that is a really
good way of saving money. Right off the bat,
a lot of people don't seem to know that. So
you know, mix those three together. And that's
going to change the the outcome there. And
I do here have a graphic to show you that
you can select things and just show you how
they would estimate the actual cost for you.
A couple things you wanted about reserved
instances that can be shared between multiple
accounts within a single organization and
unreserved, our eyes can be sold in the reserved
instance marketplace. So if you do buy into
one or through your contract, you're not fully
out of luck, because you can always try to
resell it to somebody else who might want
to use it. So there you go. Now we're taking
a look at spot instances, and they have the
opportunity to give you the biggest savings
with 90% discount compared to on demand pricing.
There are some caveats, though. So eight of
us has all this unused compute capacity, so
they want to maximize utility of their idle
servers, it's no different than when a hotel
offers discounts to fill vacant suites, or
when the plane offers discounts to fill vacant
seats. Okay, so there's just easy two instances
lying around, it would be better to give people
discounts than for them to do nothing. So
the only caveat though is that when you use
spot instances, if another customer who wants
to pay on demand a higher price wants to use
it. And they need to give that capacity to
that on demand user, this instance can be
terminated at any given time, okay. And that's
going to be the trade off. So just looking
at termination, termination conditions down
below, instances can be terminated by Avis
at any time. If your instance is terminated
by AWS, you don't get charged for the partial
hour of usage. But if you were to terminate
an instance, you will still be charged for
any hour that it ran. Okay, so there you go.
That's the little caveat to it. But what would
you use abundances for if it can if these
incidents could be interrupted at any time?
Well, they're designed for applications that
have flexible Start and End Times or applications
that are only feasible at very low compute
costs. And so you can see I pulled out the
configuration graphic when you make spot.
So it's saying like, Is it for load balancing
workloads, flexible workloads, big data workloads
are defined duration workloads. So you can
see there is some definitions as to what kind
of utility you would have there. But there
you are.
So we're taking a look at dedicated host instances,
which is our most expensive option with EC
two pricing models. And it's designed to meet
regulatory requirements when you have strict
server bound licensing that won't support
multi tenancy or cloud deployments. So to
really understand dedicated hosts, we need
to understand multi tenant versus single tenant.
So whenever you launch an EC two instance,
and choosing on demand or or any of the other
types beside dedicated hosts, it's multi tenant,
meaning you are sharing the same hardware
as other AWS customers, and the only separation
between you and other customers is through
virtualized isolation, which is software,
okay, then you have single tenant and this
is when a single customer has dedicated hardware.
And so customers are separated through physical
isolation. All right. And so to just compare
these two I think of multi tenant is like
everyone living in an apartment, and single
tenant is everyone living in a house. Right?
So, you know, why would we want to have our
own dedicated hardware? Well, large enterprises
and organizations may have security concerns
or obligations about sharing the same hardware
with other AWS customers. So it really just
boils down to that with dedicated hosts. It
comes in an on demand flavor and a reserved
flavor. Okay, so you can save up to 70%. But
overall, dedicated hosts is way more expensive
than our other EC two pricing. Now we're on
to the CTU pricing cheat sheet and this one
is a two pager but we'll make our way through
it. So EC two has four pricing models we have
on demand spot reserved instances also known
as RI and dedicated looking first at on demand,
it requires the least commitment from you.
It is low cost and flexible, you only pay
per hour. And the use cases here are for short
term spiky, unpredictable workloads or first
time applications, it's going to be ideal
when you want workloads that cannot be interrupted,
whereas in spot, that's when you can have
interruption and we'll get to that here shortly.
So onto reserved instances, you can save up
to 75% off, it's gonna give you the best long
term value. The use case here are steady state
or predictable usage. You can resell unused
reserved instances and the reserved instance
marketplace the reduced pricing is going to
be based off of these three variables terms
class offering and payment option. So for
payment terms, we have a one year or a three
year contract. With payment options, we can
either pay all upfront, partial upfront or
no upfront. And we have three class offerings,
we have standard convertible and scheduled.
So for standard we're gonna get up to 75%
reduced pricing compared to on demand. But
you cannot change those ra attributes meaning
like, if you want to change to a larger instance
type, it's not going to be possible, you're
stuck with what you have. If you wanted more
flexibility we have convertible where you
can get up to 54% off, and you get that flexibility.
As long as those ra attributes are greater
than or equal in value, you can change those
values, then you have scheduled and this is
used. This is for reserved instances for specific
time periods. So maybe you want to run something
once a week for a few hours. And the savings
here are gonna vary. Now onto our last two
pricing models, we have spot pricing, which
is up to 90% off, it's gonna give you the
biggest savings, what you're doing here is
you're requesting spare computing capacity.
So you know, as we said earlier, it's like
hotel rooms where they're just trying to fill
the vacant suites. If you are if you're comfortable
with flexible Start and End Times spot price
is going to be good for you. The use case
here is if you can handle interruptions, so
servers randomly stopping and starting, it's
a very good use case is for non critical background
jobs. instances can be terminated by alias
at any time, if your instance is terminated
by a device, you won't get charged for that
partial hour of usage. If you terminate that
instance, you will be charged for any hour
that it ran in, okay. And the last is dedicated
hosting, it's the most expensive option. And
it's just dedicated servers, okay? And so
it can be it can be utilized in on demand
or reserves you can save up to 70% off. And
the use case here is when you need a guarantee
of isolette hardware. So this is like enterprise
requirements. So there you go, we made it
all the way through ECP.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at Amazon machine images ami
eyes, which is a template to configure new
instances. So an ami provides the information
required to launch an instance. So you can
turn your EC two instances into ami. So that
in turn, you can create copies of your servers,
okay. And so an ami holds the following, it's
going to have a template for the root volume
for the instance. And it's either going to
be an EBS snapshot, or an instant store template.
And that is going to contain your operating
system, your application server, your applications,
everything that actually makes up what you
want your AR ami to be, then you have launch
permissions, the controls which AWS accounts
can use for the AMI to launch instances, then
you have block device mapping, that specifies
volumes to attach to the instances when it's
launched. Alright, and so now I just have
that physical representation over here. So
you have your EBS snapshot, which is registered
to an ami and then you can launch that ami
or make a copy of an ami to make another ami,
okay, and analyze our region specific. And
we're going to get into that shortly. I just
wanted to talk about the use cases of ami,
and this is how I utilize it. So ami is help
you keep incremental changes to your OS application
code and system packages. Alright, so let's
say you have a web application and or web
server, and you create an ami on it. And it's
going to have some things you've already installed
on it. But let's say you had to come back
and install Redis because you want to run
something like sidekick, or now you need to
install image magic for image processing.
Or you need the cloudwatch agent because you
wanted to stream logs from your EC two instance
to cloud watch. And that's where you're going
to be creating those revisions, okay, and
it's just gonna be based on the names. amye
is generally utilized with SYSTEMS MANAGER
automation. So this is a service which will
routinely Patreon eyes with security updates.
And then you can bake those ami so they can
quickly launch them, which ties into launch
configuration. So when you're dealing with
auto scaling groups, those use launch configurations
and launch configurations have to have an
ami. So when you attach an ami to launch configuration
and you update the launch configuration in
your auto scaling group, it's going to roll
out Those updates to all those multiple instances.
So just to give you like a bigger picture
how ami is tied into the AWS ecosystem.
So I just quickly wanted to show you the Avis
marketplace. And so again, the marketplace
lets you purchase subscriptions to vendor
maintained amies. There can also be free ones
in here as well. But generally they are for
paid. And they come in additional costs on
top of your UC to instance. So here if you
wanted to use Microsoft's deep learning ami,
you couldn't, you'd have to pay whatever that
is per hour. But generally people are purchasing
from the marketplace security hardened ami
is a very popular so let's say you had to
run Amazon Linux and you wanted it to meet
the requirements of level one cis. Well, there
it is in the marketplace, and it only costs
you point 02. I guess that's two cents per
hour or $130 $130 per year. Yeah, so just
wanted to highlight.
So when you're creating an ami, you can create
an ami from an existing ecsu instance, it's
either running or stopped, okay, and all you
have to do to create an ami is drop down your
actions, go to image and create image. And
that's all there is to it.
Now we're gonna look
at how we would go about choosing our ami
and so AWS has hundreds of ami as you can
search and select from. And so they have something
called the community ami which are free ami
is maintained by the community. And then we
also have the ad bus marketplace, which are
free or paid ami is maintained by vendors.
And so here in front of me, this is where
you would actually go select an ami. But I
wanted to show you something that's interesting
because you can have an ami, so let's say
Amazon Lex two. And if you were to look at
it in North Virginia, and compare it to it
in another region, such as Canada Central,
you're going to notice that there's going
to be some variation there. And that's because
amies even though they are the same they they
are different to meet the needs of that region.
And so um, you know, you can see here for
Amazon looks to North Virginia, we can launch
it in x86 or arm, but only in Canada central
is 64 bit. Alright, so the way we can tell
that these API's are unique is that they have
ami IDs, so they're not one to one. And so
am eyes are region specific. And so they will
have different ami IDs per region. And you're
not going to just be able to take it an ID
from another region and launch it from another
region, there is some some things you have
to do to get an ami to another region. And
we will talk about that. The most important
thing here I just want to show you is that
we do have hundreds of API's to choose from.
And there is some variation between regions.
So when choosing ami that we do have a lot
of options open to us to filter down what
it is that we're looking for. And so you can
see that we could choose based on our LS whether
the root device type is EBS, or instant store,
whether it's for all regions, recurrent regions,
or maybe the architecture, so we do have a
bunch of filtration options available to us.
amies are categorized as either backed by
EBS or backed by instant store this is a very
important option here. And you're going to
notice that in the bottom left corner on there,
I just wanted to highlight because it is something
that's very important.
So
you can also make copies of your ami. And
this feature is also really important when
we're talking about am eyes because they are
region specific. So the only way you can get
an ami from one region to another is you have
to use the copy command. So you do copy ami
and then you'd have the ability to choose
to send that ami to another region. So there
we are. So we're onto the AMI cheat sheets.
Let's jump into it. So Amazon machine image,
also known as ami provides the information
required to launch an instance am eyes are
region specific. If you need to use an ami
in another region, you can copy an ami into
the destination region via the copy ami command.
You can create amies from an existing UC two
instance that's either running or stopped
then we have community amies and these are
free ami is maintained by the community then
there are 80 of us marketplace. amies and
these are free or paid subscription ami is
maintained by vendors am eyes have ami IDs,
the same ami so if you take Amazon links to
will vary in both ami ID and options, such
as the architecture option in different regions,
they are not exactly the same, they're different.
Okay, an ami holds the following information,
it's going to have a template for the root
volume for the instance. So that's either
going to be an EBS snapshot or an instance
store template. And that will contain operation
system, the application server and application
data Okay. And then you have the launch permissions
that controls which ad was accounts can be
used with the AMI to launch instances, and
a blocked device mapping that specifies the
volume to attach to the instances when it's
launched. So there is your MIT ci and good
luck. Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro. And we are looking at auto scaling groups.
So auto scaling groups lets you set scaling
rules, which will automatically launch additional
EC two instances or shutdown instances to
meet the current demand. So here's our introduction
to auto scaling groups. So auto scaling groups
revia to as G contains a collection of EC
two instances that are treated as a group
for the purpose of automatic scaling and management.
And automatic scaling can occur via capacity
settings, health check replacements, or scaling
policies, which is going to be a huge topic.
So the simplest way to use auto scaling groups
is just to work with the capacity settings
with nothing else set. And so we have desired
capacity, Min, and Max. Okay, so let's talk
through these three settings. So for min is
how many easy two instances should at least
be running, okay, Max is the number of easy
two instances allowed to be running and desired
capacity is how many easy two instances you
ideally want to run. So when min is set to
one, and let's say you had a new auto scaling
group, and you lost it, and there was nothing
running, it would always it would spin up
one. And if that server died, for whatever
reason, because when it was unhealthy, or
just crashed, for whatever reason, it's always
going to spin up at least one. And then you
have that upper cap, where it can never go
beyond two, because auto scaling groups could
trigger more instances. And this is like a
safety net to make sure that you know, you
just don't have lots and lots of servers running.
And desired capacity is what you ideally want
to run. So as you will try to get it to be
that value. But there's no guarantee that
it will always be that value. So that's capacity.
So another way that auto scaling can occur
with an auto scaling group is through health
checks. And down here, we actually have two
types, we have EC two and lb. So we're gonna
look at EC two first. So the idea here is
that when this is set, it's going to check
the seatoun instance to see if it's healthy.
And that's dependent on these two checks,
that's always performed on DC two instances.
And so if any of them fail, it's going to
be considered unhealthy. And the auto scaling
group is going to kill that EC two instance.
And if you have your minimum capacity set
to one, it's going to then spin up a new EC
two instance. So that's the that's easy to
type. Now let's go look at the lb type. So
for the lb type, the health check is performed
based on an E lb health check. And the E lb
can perform a health check by pinging an end
like an endpoint on that server could be HTTP
or HTTPS, and it expects a response. And you
can say I want a 200 back at this specific
endpoint or so here. That's actually what
we do. So if you have a web app, you might
make a HTML page called health check. And
it should return 200. And if it is, then it's
considered healthy. If that fails, then the
auto scaling group will kill that EC two instance.
And again, if your minimum is set to one is
going to spin up a healthy new EC two instance.
final and
most important way of scaling gets triggered
within an auto scaling group is scaling policies.
And there's three different types of scaling
policies. And we'll start with target tracking
scaling policy. And what that does is it maintains
a specific metric and a target value. What
does that mean? Well, down here, we can choose
a metric type. And so we'd say average CPU
utilization. And if it were to exceed our
target value, and we'd set our target value
to 75%. Here, then we could tell it to add
another server, okay, whenever we're adding
stuff, that means we're scaling out whenever
we are removing instances, we're moving servers,
and we're scaling in okay. The second type
of scaling policy is simple scaling policy.
And this scales when alarm is breached. So
we create whatever alarm we want. And we would
choose it here. And we can tell it to scale
out by adding instances, or scale in by removing
instances. Now, this scaling policy is no
longer recommended, because it's a legacy
policy. And now we have a new policy that
is similar but more robust. To replace this
one, you can still use it but you know, it's
not recommended and but still in the console.
But let's look at the one that replaces it
called scaling policies with steps. So same
concept you scale based on when alarm is breach,
but it can escalate based on the alarms value,
which changes over time. So before where you
just had a single value here, we could say
well, if we have this, this alarm and the
value is between one and two, then add one
instance and then when it goes between two
And three, then add another instance, or when
exceeds three to beyond, then add another
instance. So you can, it helps you grow based
on that alarm, that alarm as it changes, okay.
So earlier I was showing you that you can
do health checks based on l bees. But I wanted
to show you actually how you would associate
that lb to an auto scaling group. And so we
have classic load balancers. And then we have
application load balancer and network load
balancer. So there's a bit of variation based
on the load bouncer how you would connect
it, but it's pretty straightforward. So when
in the auto scaling group settings, we have
these two fields, classic load balancers and
target groups. And for classic load balancers,
we just select the load balancer, and now
it's associated. So it's as simple as that
it's very straightforward, but with the new
ways that there's a target group that's in
between the auto scaling group and the load
balancer, so you're associating the target
group. And so that's all there is to it. So
that's how you associate. So to give you the
big picture on what happens when you get a
burst of traffic, and auto scaling occurs,
I just wanted to walk through this architectural
diagram with you. So let's say we have a web
server and we have one EC two instance running,
okay, and all of a sudden, we get a burst
of traffic, and that traffic comes into roughly
three, revenue three points to our application
load balancer application load balancer has
a listener that sends the traffic to the target
group. And we have this these students since
which is associated with that target group.
And we have so much traffic that it causes
our CPU utilization to go over 75%. And once
it goes over 75%, because we had a target
scaling policy attached, that said anything
above 75%, spin up a new instance. That's
what the auto scaling group does. And so the
way it does is it uses a launch configuration,
which is attached to the auto scaling group.
And it launches a new EC two instance. So
that's just to give you the, like, full visibility
on the entire pipeline, how that actually
works.
So when you have an auto scaling group, and
it launches in institutions, how does it know
what configuration to use to launch a new
new ECU essence, and that is what a launch
configuration is. So when you have an auto
scaling group, you actually set what a launch
configuration you want to use. And a launch
configuration looks a lot like when you launch
a new EC two instance. So you go through and
you'd set all of these options. But instead
of launching an instance, at the end, it's
actually just saving the configuration. Hence,
it's called a launch configuration. A couple
of limitations around loss configurations
that you need to know is that a launch configuration
cannot be edited once it's been created. So
if you need to update or replace that launch
configuration, you need to either make a new
one, or they have this convenient button to
clone the existing configuration and make
some tweaks to it. There is something also
known as a launch template. And they are launching
figurations, just but with versioning. And
so it's AWS is new version of lock configuration.
And you know, generally when there's something
new, I might recommend that you use it, but
it seems so far that most of the community
still uses launch configuration. So the benefit
of versioning isn't a huge, doesn't have a
lot of value there. So, you know, I don't
I'm not pushing you to use launch templates,
but I just want you to know the difference
because it is a bit confusing because you
look at it, it looks like pretty much the
same thing. And it just has version in here
and we can review the auto scaling group cheat
sheet. So an S g is a collection of up to
two instances group for scaling and management
scaling out is when you add servers scaling
is when you remove servers scaling up is when
you increase the size of an instance so like
you'd update the launch configuration with
a larger size. The size of an ASC is based
on the min max and desired capacity. Target
scaling policy scales based on when a target
value of a metric is breached. So example
average CPU utilization exceeds 75% simple
scaling policy triggers a scaling when an
alarm is breach. Scaling policy with steps
is the new version simple scaling policy allows
you to create steps based on escalation alarm
values. desired capacity is how many instances
you want to ideally run. An ESG will always
launch instances to meet the minimum capacity.
health checks determine the current state
of an instance in nasg. health checks can
be run against either an EOB or needs to do
instance, when an auto scaling when an auto
scaling group launches a new instance it will
use a launch configuration which holds the
configuration values of that new instance.
For example, maybe the AMI instance type of
roll launch configurations cannot be edited
and must be cloned or a new one created. Launch
configurations must be manually updated in
by editing the auto scaling group. setting.
So there you go. And that's everything with
auto scale. Hey, it's Andrew Brown from exam
Pro. And we are looking at elastic load balancers,
also abbreviated to lb, which distributes
incoming application traffic across multiple
targets such as you see two instances containers,
IP addresses or lambda functions. So let's
learn a little bit What a load bouncer is.
So load balancer can be physical hardware
or virtual software that accepts incoming
traffic and then distributes that traffic
to multiple targets. They can balance the
load via different rules. These rules vary
based on the type of load balancers. So for
elastic load balancer, we actually have three
load balancers to choose from. And we're going
to go into depth for each one, we'll just
list them out here. So we have application
load balancer, network, load balancer, and
classic load balancer.
Understand the flow of traffic for lbs, we
need to understand the three components involved.
And we have listeners rules and target groups.
And these things are going to vary based on
our load balancers, which we're going to find
out very shortly here. Let's quickly just
summarize what these things are. And then
see them in context with some visualization.
So the first one our listeners, and they listen
for incoming traffic, and they evaluate it
against a specific port, whether that's Port
80, or 443, then you have rules and rules
can decide what to do with traffic. And so
that's pretty straightforward. Then you have
target groups and target groups is a way of
collecting all the easy two instances you
want to route traffic to in logical groups.
So let's go take a look first at application
load bouncer and network load balancer. So
here on the right hand side, I have traffic
coming in through repartee three, that points
to our load balancer. And once it goes, our
load balancer goes to the listener, it's good
check what port it's running on. So if it's
on port 80, I have a simple rule here, which
is going to redirect it to Port 443. So it's
gonna go this listener, and this listener
has a rule attached to it, and it's going
to forward it to target one. And that target
one contains all these two instances. Okay.
And down below here, we can just see where
the listeners are. So I have listener at 443.
And this is for application load balancer,
you can see I also can attach a SSL certificate
here. But if you look over at rules, and these
rules are not going to appear for network
load balancer, but they are going to appear
for a lb. And so I have some more complex
rules. If you're using lb, it simply just
forwards it to a target, you don't get more
rich options, which will show you those richer
options in a future slide. But let's talk
about classic load balancer. So classic load
balancer is, is much simpler. And so you have
traffic coming in it goes to CLB. You have
your listeners, they listen on those ports,
and you have registered targets. So there
isn't target groups, you just have Lucy see
two instances that are associated with a classic
load balancer. Let's take a deeper look at
all three load balancers starting with application
load balancer. So application load balancer,
also known as a lb is designed to balance
HTTP and HTTPS traffic. It operates at layer
seven of the OSI model, which makes a lot
of sense because layer seven is application
lb has a feature called request routing, which
allows you to add routing rules to your listeners
based on the HTTP protocol. So we saw previously,
when we were looking at rules, it was only
for a lb that is this is that request routing
rules, you can attach a web application firewall
to a lb. And that makes sense because they're
both application specific. And if you want
to think of the use case for application load
balancer, well, it's great for web applications.
So now let's take a look at network load balancer,
which is designed to balance TCP and UDP traffic.
It operates at the layer four of the OSI model,
which is the transport layer, and it can handle
millions of requests per second while still
maintaining extremely low latency. It can
perform cross zone load balancing, which we'll
talk about later on. It's great for you know,
multiplayer video games, or when network performance
is the most critical thing to your application.
Let's take a look at classic load balancers.
So it was AWS is first load balancer. So it
is a legacy load balancer. It can balance
HTTP or TCP traffic, but not at the same time.
It can use layer seven specific features such
as sticky sessions. It can also use a strict
layer for for bouncing purely TCP applications.
So that's what I'm talking about where it
can do one or the other. It can perform cross
zone load balancing, which we will talk about
later on and I put this one in here. Because
it is kind of an exam question, I don't know
if it still appears, but it will respond with
a 504 error in case of timeout if the underlying
application is not responding. And an application
can be not respond spawning would be example
as the web server or maybe the database itself.
So classic load balancer is not recommended
for use anymore, but it's still around, you
can utilize it. But you know, it's recommended
to use nlb or lb, when possible.
So let's look at the concept of sticky sessions.
So sticky Sessions is an advanced load balancing
method that allows you to bind a user session
to a specific EC two instance. And this is
useful when you have specific information
that's only stored locally on a single instance.
And so you need to keep on sending that person
to the same instance. So over here, I have
the diagram that shows how this works. So
on step one, we wrote traffic to the first
EC two instance, and it sets a cookie and
so the next time that person comes through,
we check to see if that cookie exists. And
we're gonna send it to that same EC two instance.
Now, this feature only works for classic load
balancer and application load balancer, it's
not available for nlb. And if you need to
set it for application load balancer, it has
to be set on the target group and not individually
easy to instance. So here's a scenario you
might have to worry about. So let's say you
have a user that's requesting something from
your web application, and you need to know
what their IP address is. So, you know, the
request goes through and then on the EC two
instance, you look for it, but it turns out
that it's not actually their IP address. It's
the IP address of the load balancer. So how
do we actually see the user's IP address?
Well, that's through the x forwarded for header,
which is a standardized header when dealing
with load balancers. So the x forwarded for
header is a command method for identifying
the originating IP address of a connecting,
or client connecting to a web server through
HTTP proxy or a load balancer. So you would
just forward make sure that in your web application
that you're using that header, and then you
just have to read it within your web application
to get that user's IP address. So we're taking
a look at health checks for elastic load balancer.
And the purpose behind health checks is to
help you route traffic away from unhealthy
instances, to healthy instances. And how do
we determine if a instances unhealthy waltz
through all these options, which for a lb
lb is set on the target group or for classic
load balancers directly set on the load balancer
itself. So the idea is we are going to ping
the server at a specific URL at a with a specific
protocol and get an expected specific response
back. And if that happens more than once over
a specific interval that we specify, then
we're going to mark it as unhealthy and the
load balancer is not going to send any more
traffic to it, it's going to set it as out
of service. Okay. So that's how it works.
One thing that you really need to know is
that e lb does not terminate unhealthy instances
is just going to redirect traffic to healthy
instances. So that's all you need to know.
So here, we're taking a look at cross zone
load balancing, which is a feature that's
only available for classic and network load
balancer. And we're going to look at it when
it's enabled, and then when it's disabled
and see what the difference is. So when it's
enabled, requests are distributed evenly across
the instances in all the enabled availability
zones. So here we have a bunch of UC two instances
in two different Z's, and you can see the
traffic is even across all of them. Okay?
Now, when it's disabled requests are distributed
evenly across instances, it's in only its
availability zone. So here, we can see in
az a, it's evenly distributed within this
AZ and then the same thing over here. And
then down below, if you want to know how to
enable cross zone load balancing, it's under
the description tab, and you'd edit the attributes.
And then you just check box on cross zone
load balancing. Now we're looking at an application
load balancer specific feature called request
routing, which allows you to apply rules to
incoming requests, and then for to redirect
that traffic. And we can check on a few different
conditions here. So we have six in total.
So we have the header host header source IP
path is to be header is to be header method,
or query string. And then you can see we have
some then options, we can forward redirect
returned to fixed response or authenticate.
So let's just look at a use case down here
where we actually have 1234 or five different
examples. And so one thing you could do is
you could use this to route traffic based
on subdomain. So if you want an app to sub
domain app to go to Target, prod and QA to
go to the target QA, you can do that you can
either do it also on the path. So you could
have Ford slash prod and foresights qa and
that would route to the respective target
groups, you could do it as a query string,
you could use it by looking at HTTP header.
Or you could say all the get methods go to
prod on a why you'd want to do this, but you
could and then all the post methods would
go to QA. So that is request request routing
in a nutshell.
We made it to the end of the elastic load
balancer section and on to the cheat sheet.
So there are three elastic load balancers,
network application and classic load balancer.
an elastic load balancer must have at least
two availability zones for it to work. Elastic
load balancers cannot go cross region you
must create one per region lbs have listeners
rules and target groups to route traffic and
OBS have listeners and target groups to route
traffic. And CL B's use listeners and EC two
instances are directly registered as targets
to the CLB. For application load balancer,
it uses HTTP s or eight or without the S traffic.
And then as the name implies, it's good for
web applications. Network load balancer is
for TCP, UDP, and is good for high network
throughput. So think maybe like multiplayer
video games, classic load balancer is legacy.
And it's recommended to use a lb, or nlb when
you can, then you have the x forwarded for.
And the idea here is to get the original IP
of the incoming traffic passing through the
lb, you can attach web application firewall
to a lb. Because you know web application
firewall has application the name and nlb
and CLB do not, you can attach an Amazon certification
manager SSL certificate. So that's an ACM
to any of the L B's for to get SSL. For a
lb you have advanced request routing rules,
where you can route based on subdomain, header
path and other SP information. And then you
have sticky sessions, which can be enabled
for CLB or lb. And the idea is that it helps
the session remember, what would you say to
instance, based on cookie.
All right, so it's time to get some hands
on experience with EC two and I want you to
make your way over to the ECG console here
by going up to services and typing EC two
and click through and you should arrive at
the EC to dashboard. Okay, I want you to take
a look on the left hand side here because
it's not just easy two instances that are
under here, we're going to have ami eyes.
Okay, we're going to have elastic block store,
we're going to have some networking security.
So we have our security groups, our elastic
IPS are key pairs, we're going to have load
balancing, we're going to have auto scaling,
okay, so a lot of times when you're looking
for these things, they happen to be under
the sea to console here, okay, but um, now
that we've familiar, familiarize ourselves
with the overview here, let's actually go
ahead and launch our first instance. Alright,
so we're gonna proceed to launch our first
instance here, and we're gonna get this really
nice wizard here. And we're gonna have to
work our way through these seven steps. So
let's first start with choosing your ami,
your Amazon machine image. And so an ami,
it's a template that contains the software
configuration. So the operating system, the
application server and applications required
to launch your instance, right. And we have
some really same choices here we have Amazon
Linux two, which is my go to, but if you wanted
something else, like red hat or or Susi or
Ubuntu or or Microsoft Windows, eight of us
has a bunch of amies that they support they
manage, okay, and so if you were to pay for
AWS support, and you were to use these ami
is you're gonna get a lot of help around them.
Now if you want more options, besides the
ones that are provided from AWS, there is
the marketplace and also community ami. So
if we go to community am eyes, and we're just
going to take a peek here, we can see that
we can filter based on less than architecture
etc. But let's say we wanted a WordPress ami,
something was pre loaded with WordPress, we
have some here. And if we wanted to get a
paid paid one, one that is actually provided
by a vendor and that they support it and you
pay some money to make sure that it's in good
shape, maybe as good security or just kept
up to date. You can do that. So here's WordPress
by bitnami. Alright, and that's a very common
one to launch for WordPress on here. But you
know, we're just going to stick to the defaults
here and go back to the Quickstart and we're
going to launch an Amazon Linux two ami, alright,
and we'll just proceed to a clicking select
here. So now we're on to our second option,
which is to choose our instance type, okay,
and this is going to determine how many CPUs
you're going to be using. realizing how much
memory you're going to have are going to be
backed by an EBS or instant store. And also
Are there going to be limitations around our
network performance. And so you can filter
based on the types that you want. And we learned
this earlier that there are a bunch of different
categories, we're going to stay in the general
purpose family here, which are the first that
are listed, we're always going to see T two
and T two micro is a very same choice and
also a free choice if we have our free tier
here. Okay, and so we will select it and proceed
to instance details. So now it's time to configure
our instance. And the first option available
to us is how many instances we want to run.
So if you wanted to launch 100, all at once,
you can do so and put it in an auto scaling
group, or they were going to stick with one
to be cost effective, then we have the option
here to turn this into a spot instance. And
that will help us save a considerable amount
of money. But I think for the time being we
will stick with on demand. Next we need to
determine what VPC and subnet we're going
to want to launch this into. I'm going to
stick with the default VPC and the default
sub network, I should say it will pick one
at random for me, we're definitely going to
want to have a public IP address. So we're
going to allow that to be enabled, you could
put this easy to insert into a placement group,
you'd have to create a placement group first.
But we're not going to do that because we
don't have the need for it. And we're going
to need an IM role. So I'm going to go ahead
here and right click and create a new tab
here and create a new Im role for us to give
this easy to some permissions. And so we're
gonna go to UC to here, we're going to go
next, I want you to type in SSM for system,
simple SYSTEMS MANAGER. And we're going to
get this one role for SSM. We hit Next, we're
going to go next to review, I'm going to say
my EC to EC to URL, okay. And we're gonna
create that role, close this tab, and we're
gonna hit that refresh there and then associate
this Im role to our instance here. The reason
I did that, and is because I want us to have
the ability to use simple SYSTEMS MANAGER
sessions manager, because there are two different
ways that we can log into our EC two instance,
after it is launched, we can SSH into it,
or we can use SYSTEMS MANAGER in order to
use this sessions manager, we're going to
have to
have that Im role with those permissions,
the default behavior will it will shut down,
that's or do a stop, that's good to me. If
we wanted detailed monitoring, we could turn
that on would cost additional, if we want
to protect against accidental accidental termination,
that is also a very good option. But again,
this is a test here. So we'll probably be
tearing this down pretty quick. So we don't
need to have that enabled, then we have Tennessee
option. So if we get a dedicated host, that's
going to be very expensive. But that'd be
very good if you are on, you know, an enterprise
organization that has to meet certain requirements.
So there are use cases for that. And the last
option here is under the advanced details,
you might have to drop this down and open
it. And this is that script that allows us
to set something up initially when the server
launches. And we have a script here that we
want to run. So I'm going to just copy paste
that in there. And what it's going to do is
when the EC two instance launches, it's going
to set us up without a proxy server and started
that server. So we have a very basic website.
Okay. And so yeah, we're all done here, we
can move on to storage. So now we're going
to look at adding storage to our EC two instance.
And by default, we're going to always have
a root volume, which we cannot remove. But
if we wanted to add additional volumes here
and choose their, their mounting directory,
we could do so there. And we do have a lot
of different options available to us for volume
types. But we only want one for the sake of
this tutorial. So we'll just remove that we
can set the size, we're gonna leave it to
eight. If we want to have this root volume
persist on the case that the CPU is terminated,
so the volume doesn't get deleted, we can
uncheck box, this is a very good idea. In
most cases, you want to keep that unchecked.
But for us, we want to make cleanup very easy.
So we're going to keep that on. And then we
have encryption. And so we can turn on encryption
here using kms. The default key, we're just
going to leave it off for the time being and
yeah, we'll proceed to tags here. And we're
just gonna skip over tags. Now tags are good
to set. Honestly, I just I'm very lazy, I
never set them. But if you want to group your
resources across a city or anything, you want
to consistently set tags, but we're just gonna
skip that and go on to security groups. So
now we need to configure some security groups
here for this easy to instance. And then we
don't have any, so we're gonna have to create
a new one, but we could choose an existing
one if there was one, but we're gonna go ahead
and name it here because I really don't like
the default name. So we'll just say my SG
four For EC two, okay, and we're gonna set
some inbound rules here. And so we have SSH
and that stuff, something that we definitely
want to do, I'm going to set it to my IP,
because I don't want to have the ability for
anyone to SSH into this instance, I want to
really lock it down to my own. We're gonna
add another instance here, because this is
running an Apache server. And we do want to
expose the Port 80 there, so I'm going to
drop that down, it's going to automatically
like Port 80. And we do want this to be internet
accessible. But if we want to be very explicit,
I'm just gonna say anywhere, okay, and I'm
gonna make a note here, just saying, like
my home, and, you know, for paci, you know,
it doesn't hurt to put these notes in here.
And then we'll go ahead and review. So now
it's time to just review and make sure everything
we set in the wizard here is what we want
it to be. So you know, we just review it.
And if you're happy with it, we can proceed
to launch. So now when you hit launch, it's
going to ask you to create a key pair, okay.
And this is going to be so that we can actually
SSH into the instance and access it. So I'm
going to drop down here, I'm going to create
a new key pair pair here. And I'm going to
call it o m, I'm going to call it my EC two.
And I'm going to go ahead and download that
pair there. And we're going to go ahead and
launch that instance. Alright. And so now
it says that that instance, is being created.
So we can go ahead and click on the name here.
And so now it is spinning up, I do suggest
that you do on tick here so that we can see
all of our ECS instances. And what we're going
to be waiting for is to move from a pending
state into a green state, I forget the name
of it, I guess enabled or created. And then
after it goes green, we're going to be waiting
for our two status checks to pass. And if
those two status checks pass, which will show
up under here, we have our system says check
out our instance status check. That means
the instance is going to be ready and available,
it's going to run that user data script that
we have. So once again, at one with these
two checks are done. It's Oh, sorry, green
is running. Great. So now we're waiting for
these checks. And once they are complete,
we're going to be able to use our public IP
address here, either this one here, or even
this DNS record, and we're going to see if
our, our
if our, our servers running. Okay, so if that
works, then we will be in good shape here.
Okay, so we're just going to wait for that
session. So our two checks have passed, meaning
that our instance is now ready to attempt
to access via either the public IP or the
public DNS record, we can use either or I
like using the public DNS record. And so I'm
just going to copy it using the little clipboard
feature there, make a new tab in my browser,
and paste it in there. And I'm going to get
the Apache test page, meaning that our user
data script worked, and it's successfully
installed and started Apache here. So that's
all great. Now, um, so now, you know, our
instances are in good working order. But let's
say we had to log into our instance to debug
it or do something with it. That's where we're
gonna have to know how to either SSH in, which
is usually the method that most people like
to do. Or we can use simple systems sessions
manager, which is the recommended way by AWS.
Okay, so I'm gonna show you both methods,
methods here, starting with sessions manager.
But just before we do that, I just want to
name our instance something here to make our
lives a little bit easier here, you just have
to click the little pencil there and rename
it. So I'm just rename it to my server. And
we'll pop down services here and type SSM
for simple SYSTEMS MANAGER and make a new
tab here, click off here. So we have our space
here, and we will go to the SYSTEMS MANAGER
console. Now, on the left hand side, we are
looking for sessions manager, which is all
the way down here. And we're just going to
click that. And we are going to start a new
session. So we're going to choose the instance
we want to connect to. So just hit start instance
here. Okay. And here, we have my server, which
is the instance we want to connect to, we'll
hit start session, and it will gain access
to this instance, immediately. So there is
next to no wait. And we are in this instance,
the only thing I don't like is that it logs
you in as the root user, which to me is very
over permissive. But we can get to the correct
user here. For for Amazon links to instances,
it always has an EC to user, that is the user
that you want to be doing things under. So
I'm just going to switch over to that user
here just quickly here. Okay, and so now I'm
the correct user and I can go about doing
whatever it is that I want to do here. Okay.
Right. So, so there you go. So that's the
sessions manager, I'm just going to terminate
here to terminate that instance. And again,
the huge benefit here is that you get sessions
history so you can get a history of who has
logged in and done like gone into server to
do something. And, you know, the other thing
is that you don't have to share around that
key pair. Because when you launch a sudo instance,
you only have that one key pair, and you really
don't want to share that around. So this does
remove that obstacle for you. Also, because
people have to log in the console, there are
people leave your company, you know, you're
also denying them access there, and you don't
have to retract that key pair from them. So
it is a lot easier to use sessions manager.
The downside, though, is that it just has
a very simplistic terminal within the browser.
So if you're used to more rich features from
your, your OS terminal, that is a big downside.
That's why people still SSH in, which is now
the next method we are going to use to gain
access to our EC two instance. So in order
to do that, we are going to need a terminal
Okay, and I just moved that, that key pair
onto my desktop, when you download, it probably
went to your download. So just for convenience,
I've moved it here. And what we're going to
do is we are going to use our SSH command
here, and we're going to log in as the aect
user because that's the user you should be
logging
in as, as soon as you have to log in as when
you SSH into it, we're just going to grab
the public IP, now we could use the public
DNS record, but the IP address is a bit shorter
here, so it's a bit nicer. And then we're
gonna use a hyphen flag to specify the private
key that we want to pass along. That's on
our desktop here, I'm actually already on
the desktop, so I don't have to do anything
additional here. So we're just going to pass
along, so we're gonna hit enter, okay. And
we're just going to wait here, and we got
a Permission denied. Now, if this is the first
time you've logged the server, it might ask
you to for a fingerprint where you will type
in Yes. Okay, it didn't ask me that. So that's
totally fine. But you're going to see that
it's giving me a 644, because the the private
key is to open so it is required that your
private key files are not accessible by others.
So database wants to really make sure that
you lock down those permissions. And so if
we just take an LS hyphen, Li here, we can
see that it has quite a few permissions here.
And we could just lock that down by typing
chmod 400. Okay. And then if we just take
a look here, again, now it's locked down here.
So if we try to SSH in again, okay, we should
have better luck, this time around. It's not
as fast as sessions manager, but it will get
you in the door there. There we are. And we
are logged in as the user, okay, and we'd
go about our business doing whatever it is
that we'd want to do. Now, we did talk about
in the, the the actual journey about user
data metadata, and this is the best opportunity
to take a look there. So we have this private,
this private addresses only accessible when
you're inside your EC two instance. So you
can gain additional information. First one
is the user data one, okay, so if I just was
to paste that in there, and it's just curl
a cp 169 254, once it's done to the four latest
user data, and if I were to hit enter, it
will return the script that actually was a
performed on launch. Okay, so if you were
to debug and easy to instance, and it wasn't,
you know, you're like working for another
company, and you didn't launch that instance,
and you really wanted to know, what was, uh,
what was performed on launch, you could use
that to find out, then we have the metadata
endpoint, and that is a way for us to get
a lot of different rich information. So it's
the same thing, it's just gonna have metadata
on the end there with with a Ford slash, and
you have all these different options. Okay.
So let's say we wanted to get the IP address
here of this instance, we could just append
IP public ipv4 on there, okay. And there you
go. So, you know, that is how you log into,
into an instance via SSH or, or such sessions
manager. And that's how we get some user data
and metadata after the fact. So when we had
launched a cc two instance, we didn't actually
encrypt the root volume, okay. And so if you
were to launch an instance, I just want to
quickly just show you what I'm talking about
here. And we go to storage here. We just didn't
we didn't go down here and select this. Alright,
so let's say we had to retro actively apply
encryption, well, it's not as easy as just
a drop down here, we have to go through a
bunch of steps, but we definitely need to
know how to do this. Okay, so how would we
go about that? Well, we go to a volumes on
the left hand side here, and we'd find our
running volume. So here is the volume that
we want to encrypt that is unencrypted. And
so what we do is we would first create a snapshot
of it, okay. And so I would say, um, we'll
say my volume. Okay. We'll go ahead and create
that snapshot. And we'll go back here, and
we're just going to wait for this snapshot
to complete it's going to take a little bit
of time here. But once it comes back here,
we'll move on to the next step. So our progress
is at now at 100%. And we can see that this
snapshot is unencrypted. Okay, so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna go up to actions at
the top here, make a copy of the snapshot.
And this is where we're gonna have the ability
to apply encryption. Alright, and we're just
going to use the default kms key here, which
is a pretty good default to use. And we're
gonna hit copy. And that's going to now initiate
a copy here. So we'll just visit our snapshots
page ever. Now we're just going to wait for
this to create our copy. So our progress is
at 100%. It's encrypted, even though it's
it's pending and 0% down there. Sometimes
if you hit refresh, that will just get your
interface up to date here. I'm just going
to turn this off here. So you can see that
we have our volume here. And then we have
our, our snapshot there. I don't really like
the name of the description, I wonder if I
can change that. No, so that's fine, though.
But anyway, we now have our unencrypted and
our encrypted volume. So if we wanted to have
this encrypted one launch, all we're gonna
have to do here is launch the seats aect,
or sorry, create a an image from this volume
here. So I'm just gonna hit Create image.
And this is
going to create an image from our EBS snapshot,
okay, so that's going to be our ami. And I'm
just gonna say, my server here, okay. And,
yeah, this all looks good to me. And we'll
just go ahead and hit Create. Alright, and
we'll click through here to our ami. And so
we're just going to wait here, actually, I
think it's instantly created. So our ami is
ready to launch. Okay. So if we want to now
have our server with a version that is encrypted,
we can just go ahead here and launch a new
instance. And it's going to pull up our big
interface here. And we'll just quickly go
through it. So t to micro is good. We have
one instance, we're going to drop down to
our, our AC t roll here, we're going to have
to again, copy our startup script here. Okay.
I'm actually I guess not, because if we if
we created a snapshot of our instance, this
would already be installed. So we don't have
to do that again. So that's good. And then
we'll go to our storage, and there is our
encrypted volume. Okay, we'll go to security
groups, and we're just going to select that
existing one there. And then we're gonna go
to review, and we're going to launch, okay,
and we're gonna choose the existing one. So
we'll say launch instance. Okay. And we'll
go back here, and we just check box off here,
we're gonna actually have two instances running,
you can see I have a few terminated ones,
those are just old ones there. But this is
the one we have running here. So once this
is running, we'll have this here. And we'll
just double check to make sure it's working.
But we'll talk about, you know, how do we
manage launching multiple instances here next.
So our new instance is now a running, I'm
just going to name it to my new server. So
we can distinguish it from our old one. And
I want to see if that root device is actually
encrypted, because that was our big goal here.
And so we're going to open this up in a new
tab here and look at our, our volume and is
indeed encrypted. So we definitely were successful
there. Now, the main question, is our server
still running our Apache test page here? So
I'm going to grab the new IP for the new server
and take a look here, and we're going to find
that Apache isn't running. So you know, what
happened? Why is it not working? And there's
a really good reason for that. If we go over
to our script, when we first use this user
data script on our first server, what it did
was it installed Apache, and then it started
Apache, okay. But that doesn't mean that it
kept Apache running if there was a restart.
So the thing is, is that when we when we made
an a, an ami, or like a copy of our volume,
it had the installed part, but there's nothing
that says on launch, start up, start Apache,
okay, so what we need to do is we need to
enable this command, which will always have
a paci start on boot, or stop or start or
restart. Okay. So let's go ahead and actually
turn that on and get our server running. And
we are going to use sessions manager to do
that. So we'll go back to SYSTEMS MANAGER
here. If it's not there, just type SSM and
you can just right click and make a new tab
there. And we're going to go down to sessions
manager. And we are going to start a new session,
we are going to choose my new server if you
named it that makes it a lot easier to find
it. And it will get us into that server lickety
split. And we are going to switch to the EC
to user because we don't want to do this as
root. And what we're going to do is first
start our service because it'd be nice to
see that it is working. So we'll go back to
this IP here and is now working. And now we
want to work on reboots. I'm going to copy
this command, paste it in, hit on and it's
going to create a symlink for the service.
Okay, and so now when we restart the server,
this should work. So what I want you to do
I want you to just close this tab here, leave
this one open. And we will go back to this
server here. And we're going to reboot it.
So we're going to go, reboot. And so if our
command does what we hope it will do, that
means that it will always work on reboot.
Okay.
Great. So it is, it should be rebooting now.
I'm pretty sure. And let me just do that one
more time.
Sure, you want to reboot? Yes. There we go.
Was it really that fast? Oh, I think it just
booted really fast. Okay, so I guess it's
finished booting. And we'll just go here,
and it's still working so great. So I always
get that confused, because if you stop and
start instance, it takes a long time reboots
can be very quick. So now that we have this
instance, here, the only only issue is that
if we were to create a copy of this instance,
we want to bake in that new functionality.
So we need to create a new ami of that instance.
Okay, so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
go to our images and create a new image, and
we're gonna call this, my servers 000. And
we're gonna say what we did to this. So what
we were doing was ensuring Apache restarts
on boot. On reboot, okay, and then we will
create our image, okay. And we will let that
image proceed there, it failed. Oh, I've never
I never get failure. That's interesting. Um,
well, that's fine. We'll just do a refresh
here. Honestly, I've never had an image fail
on me. So what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to try that one more time here. My servers,
there was a zero, restart Apache on reboot,
okay. And we will create that image again.
Okay, we'll go back here. And we'll just see
if that creates it, there just takes a little
bit time. And so I'll come back here. So sometimes
instances can fail or like ami, or snapshots
can fail, and it's just AWS. So in those cases,
you just retry again. But it rarely happens
to me. So. But yeah, we'll see you after this
is done. Our ami is now available. And if
I was to remove this filter, here, we'd see
our original ami, where we installed, install
the paci and, but it doesn't run it by default.
So if we were to launch this one, we'd have
our problems that we had previous but this
one would always start Apache, okay, now we
have a couple servers here, I want you to
kill both of them because we do not need them
anymore. Okay, we're going to terminate them.
And we're going to learn about auto scaling
groups. All right. So whenever we want to
have a server always running, this is going
to be a good use case for it. So before we
can go ahead and create an auto scaling group,
I want you to go create a launch configuration,
okay. And so I just clicked that down there
below, and we are going to create a configuration,
and we can choose our ami, but we want to
actually use one, one of our own ami, so I'm
gonna go my ami here, and I'm going to select
this one, which is the Apache server, it's
going to be T two micro, we want the role
to be my EC two, we're going to name this
my server lc 000. LC stands for launch configuration
there. That's just my convention, you can
do whatever you want. We're going to have
this volume encrypted by default, because
if you use an ami that is encrypted, you can't
unencrypted. Okay, we'll go to our security
groups. And we will drop this down and select
the security group we created previously here.
Yeah, miss that one, we'll go to review. And
we will create our launch configuration, choose
our existing key pair there and launch our
or sorry, create our launch configuration.
Okay, so we've created launch configuration,
you'll see that process was very similar to
an EC two instance. And that was just that
was saving all the settings because an ami
doesn't save all the settings rights and a
launch configuration saves all of those settings.
So now that we have our launch configuration,
we can go ahead and launch an auto scaling
group, okay. And this is going to help us
keep a server always continuously running.
So we'll go ahead and create our our auto
scaling group, we're going to use our launch
configuration here. We're gonna go next steps.
We're going to name it we'll just say as G
or say my server is G. ACS SD stands for auto
scaling group, we're going to have one an
instance of one size, we're going to launch
it into default subnet, we are going to have
to choose a couple here. So we'll do a and
b. Let's check advanced details. We're going
to leave that alone. We're going to go to
the next step. And we're going to leave that
alone. We're going to see notifications. We're
gonna leave that alone tags alone. Oops, I
think I went backwards here review and we
are going to create that auto scaling group.
So now we're going to hit close and we're
going to check out that ESG here. And so look
at that it's set to one desired one min and
one max. Okay, it's using that ami. So now.
Now what it's going to do, it's going to just
start spinning up that server. So the way
this works, if I just go to the Edit options,
here, we have these three values, okay, and
so minimum is the minimum number of instances
the
auto scaling group should have at any time,
so there's not at least one server running.
Okay, it's going to start it up. And we can
never have beyond one server. So there's a,
there's a chance where if you have auto scaling
groups, it would try to trigger and go beyond
the max. So this Max is like a, like a safety
so that we don't end up with too many servers.
And then we have desired capacity. And that's
the desired number of instances we want to
be running. And this value actually changes
based on auto scaling groups, it will adjust
it. So generally, you want to be at this number,
etc. A lot of times I'll have this. Yeah,
exactly. You know, I might have like two,
for very simple applications, and then this
would be one in one. Okay. But anyway, this
instance, is automatically starting, okay.
And it looks like it's in service. It doesn't
assume me it's running. Because if I go to
instances over here, okay, and we take a look,
here we have it, and it's initializing. All
right. So what is the big benefit to USGS
is the fact that, you know, if this instance
got terminated for any reason, the ASU will
spin up another one, right. So we're just
going to wait a little bit of time here for
this, to get it to two checks here. And then
we will attempt to kill it and see if the
auto scaling group spins up a new one. So
our instances running that was launched our
auto scaling group. And let's just double
check to make sure that it's working. It's
always good to do sanity checks here in our
Apache page is still operational. So now the
real question is, is that if we are to terminate
this instance, will the auto scaling group
launch a new instance, because it should,
it should detect that it's unhealthy and launch
a new one. So this is terminating here, and
we're gonna go to our auto scaling group here.
And we are going to just see if it's going
to monitor, so it's saying that it's terminating,
so it can actually tell that it's terminating,
and it's unhealthy, okay. And so it's going
to determine that there are no instances it's
going to start up another one here shortly.
Okay. So we are just going to give it a little
bit of time here. And so now we have no instances
running, right. And so it should detect very
shortly, okay. And there is that health grace
check period. So we are just waiting a little
bit of time here. Okay, and great. So now
it's starting up a new EC two instance, because
it determined that we're not running. So our
ASC is working as expected. Okay. So, yeah,
there you go. So I think maybe the next thing
we want to do is, let's say we wanted to change
our Apache page, that index to have some kind
of different text on there. And we can learn
how to actually update that. So we'll have
to create a new oma ami and then swap out
our launch configuration so that the auto
scaling group can update that page. So we'll
just go back here. And we'll just wait for
this to complete so we can SSH in. And we
will do that next. So we had terminated our
previous instance. And the auto scaling group
spun up a new one, and is now running. So
let's just double check to make sure our party
page is still there. And it is and so now
let's go through the process of figuring out
how to update this page, so that when we spin
up new instances, with our auto scaling group,
they all have the latest changes, okay, so
what we're going to have to do is we're going
to need to update our launch configuration,
but we're also gonna have to bake a new ami.
And even before we do that, we need to SSH
or get into an instance and update the default
page. So what we're going to do is go to services
and type SSM and open up SYSTEMS MANAGER,
okay. And we'll just click off here, so this
is not in our way, and we will go down to
sessions manager here. Okay, start a new session,
we're going to choose the unnamed one because
that was the one last by the auto scaling
group. And we will instantly get into our
instance here and we are going to have to
switch over to the user because we do not
want to do this as root. Okay, and so if my
memory is still good, Apache stores their
their pages in HTML, var ww HTML in it is
great. And so we're just going to create a
new page here. So I'm gonna do sudo touch
index HTML, it's going to create a new file.
Alright, and now we're going to want to edit
that I'm going to use VA you can use nano
here nano is a lot easier to use VI is every
single thing is a hotkey. So you might regret
launching and vi here, but this is what I'm
most familiar with. So I'm going to just open
that here. And I already have a page prepared.
And obviously you'll have access to this too,
for this tutorial series. And I'm just going
to copy this in here and we're going to Paste
that there. And I'm just going to write and
quit to save that file. Okay, and then we're
going to go back,
we'll kill this. Before we kill it, let's
just double check to make sure it works. So
we're going to go back to this instance, grab
that IP, paste it in there. And there we are,
we have our Star Trek reference page from
the very famous episode in the pale moonlight
here. So our page is now been replaced. Great.
So now that we have this in place, the next
thing we need to do is get it so that when
we launch a new auto scaling group, it will
have that page, right. And so I said that
we need to create an ami. So let's we're going
to do so we are going to get the current instance
here. And we are going to create a new image
and we are going to follow our naming convention,
I can't remember what I called it. So I'm
just going to go double check it here quickly
here. Because you only get the opportunity
to name this one. So you want to get them
right. So we will go here and name it. What
was it my server my image, I'm getting confused.
Now my server, okay. So we'll say my server
001, I really wish they'd show you the previous
names there. And we'd say, update default
party, or create our own custom index HTML
page for a party. Okay, so there we go. And
we are going to create that image. Great.
And we will go to View pending ami here. And
we will just wait until that is complete.
And we will continue on to updating our launch
configuration. So our image there is now available.
If we were just to click off here, we can
see we have our ami, so this one has the Apache
server where it doesn't restart on boot. So
you have to manually do it. This one starts
up Apache, but it has the default page. And
then this one actually has our custom page.
Okay, so we need to get this new ami into
our auto scaling group. So the way we're going
to do that is we're going to update the launch
configuration. Okay, so launch configurations
are read only, you cannot edit it and change
the AMI. So we'll have to create a copy of
that launch template, or some last configuration,
careful, there's launch templates, it's like
the new way of doing launch configurations.
But people still use launch. Launch config.
So we're just gonna go to actions here and
create a copy of launch configuration. Okay,
and it's gonna go all the way to the end step,
which is not very helpful. But we're going
to go all the way back to the beginning here.
And we're going to remove our zeros zero here
was click that off there, we'll choose one,
it probably will warn us saying Yeah, do you
want to do this? Yes, of course. And we're
going to leave all the settings the same,
we're going to go to configure details, because
it does a stupid copy thing here. And I'm
just going to name it one. And you got to
be careful here because you do not get the
opportunity to rename these. So it's just
nice to have consistency there. And we will
just proceed to add storage to make sure everything's
fine. Yes, it's opposite encrypted security
group, it tried to make a new one. So we're
going to be careful there and make sure it
uses our existing one, we don't need to continuously
create lots of security groups that we don't
need, we're going to review it, we're going
to create the lock configuration we're going
to associate with our key pair as usual. Okay,
and now this launch configuration is ready.
So now that we have a new launch configuration,
in order to launch this, what we need to do
is go to our auto scaling group, okay. And
what we will do is, we're going to edit it,
okay, and we are just going to drop it down
and choose one. Alright. So now what we can
do is we can either, we'll just hit Save here,
but let's say we want this new instance to
take place. What we can do here is just terminate
this old one, and now the new the new auto
scaling group should spin up and use the new
launch configuration. Okay, I'm just paranoid
here. And you should always be in a device,
I'm just going to double check to make sure
that I did set that correctly. Sometimes I
hit save, and it just doesn't take effect.
And this is the new launch configuration being
set for ASD. So we'll go back here. Okay.
And we're just going to stop this instance.
And the new one that's spun up should have
that page that we created there. So I'll just
terminate here. And I'll talk to you here
in a moment we get back, ok. Our new instances
running here, and let's take a peek to see
if it's showing our web page here. And it
is, so we are in good shape here. We successfully
updated that launch configuration for the
auto scaling group. And so now anytime a new
instance is launched, it will have all all
our latest changes. So auto scaling groups
are great because, you know, they just ensure
that there's always at least one server running.
But what happens if the entire availability
zone goes out? All right, it's not. It's not
going to help if the auto scaling group is
set in that AZ. So what we're going to have
to do is create high availability using the
load balancers so that we can run instances
in more than one
one AZ at any given time. Okay, so let's go
ahead and layer in our auto scaling group
into our load balancer. So what I want you
to do is make a new tab here, and we are going
to create a load balancer. Okay, it's not
terribly hard, we'll just get through here.
And we'll just create a load balancer here.
And we have three options provided to us application
load balancer network load balancer, and classic
load balancer, okay. And we're going to make
an application load balancer. Alright, and
I'm just going to name this al are my, my
lb, okay, and it's going to be internet facing,
we're going to use ipv4 because that's the
easiest to work with, we're gonna use the
HTTP Port 80 protocol, because we don't have
a custom domain name. So we're gonna just
have to stick with that. We're gonna want
to run this in multiple azs. It's always good
to run it at least three public AZ. So that's,
I'm going to select those there. Okay, we're
going to proceed to security here, prove your
load balancers, security settings don't seem
to have any here. We'll we'll go next here.
And we are going to create a new security
group actually. And this is going to be the
security group for the lb here. So we'll say
Alp. Let's what's the SD, that's always thing
I like to put on the on the end there. And
we can leave the default description in there.
And so we want it. So anything on port 80
is accessible from anywhere. So to me, that
is a good rule. And we will go to the next
step here. And we will have to create our
target group. Okay, so the target group is
what points to the actual easy two instances,
okay, so we will just make a new one, and
we'll just call it my target group. And we
will call it the production one here, because
you can have multiple levels to say tg prod,
because you can have multiple target groups,
okay. And it's going to be for instances where
use HTTP protocol, the health check is actually
going to be the default page. That's pretty
good to me. And we're going to go ahead and
register some targets. And so here we can
individually register targets, but we actually
want to associate it via the auto scaling
group. So we're not going to do it this way.
We're just gonna go next and create this load
balancer here. And it takes a very little
time to do so. Okay. And I mean, it says it's
provisioning. So I guess we'll have to wait
a little bit here. But what we want to do
is we want to get those auto scaling groups
associated with our target group. Okay. And
so the way we'll go about doing that is we're
going to go to our auto scaling group. And
we are going to go ahead and go to actions,
edit this here. And we are going to associate
to tg prod. So that's how it's going to know
how to the load balancing browser, it's good
to know how to associate with the the auto
scaling group. And we will also change your
health check to EOB. Because that is a lot
better. Here. We're going to save that there.
And we are going to go back to load balancers
and see how that is progressing. Remember
how long it takes for an lb to spin up. Generally,
a very quick still says it's provisioning.
But while that is going, we have an opportunity
to talk about some of the settings here. So
the load bouncer has listeners, right. And
so it created a listener for us through that
wizard there. And so we have one here that
listens on port 80. And they always have rules.
And that rule is it's going to always forward
to the the target group we had selected. So
we wanted to edit it or do some more things
with those rules, we can hit rules here. and
here we can see Port 80. So if by default,
everything by default, is going to be Port
80, it's going to then forward it to that
target group. So if we wanted to here add
another rule here, we could add rules such
as all sorts of kinds. So we could say if
the path here was secret page, okay, we could
then make an action and forward it to a target
group that that has some very special servers
in it. Okay, so there are some very advanced
rules that we can set in here, we're going
to leave them alone, I just wanted to give
you a little a little tour of that. And so
yeah, we're just gonna have to wait for this
to finish here. And once it's done provisioning,
we're going to see if we can get traffic through
our load balancer. So our lb is ready. Now
just make sure you press that refresh up there,
because a lot of the times these things are
ready and you're just sitting there because
the UI does not refresh. So always hit the
refresh there once in a while. And let's just
see if our load balancer is working and routing
traffic to our single instance there. So down
below, we do have our DNS DNS name. So this
is a way that we would access our load balancer
there and there you go. So now everything's
being routed through the load balancer. Now,
if we were to go back
to this EC two instance here, okay, we might
want to actually restrict traffic so that
you can't ever directly go to the instance
only through the load balancer. Alright, so
I'm just going to copy this IP here. Okay,
and so I'm able to access this through the
IP address, which is not too bad. But let's
say I didn't want to be able to access it
through Yeah, through here, okay, so it always
has to be directly through the load balancer.
And the way we can do that is we can just
go adjust this auto scaling group, or sorry,
the security group. So that it it denies traffic
from Port 80. Now, I kind of like having these,
the the security group around for the CTO
instance. And so what I want to do is I want
to actually create a new security group just
for the auto scaling group. Okay, so we'll
go to security groups here. And we will create
a new security group and we're going to call
it my I don't think I was very consistent
here. So yeah, yeah, kinda. So we'll say,
my ESG security group. And so for this, we
are going to allow us to use SSH. Honestly,
we don't really need to SSH anymore because
we can use SYSTEMS MANAGER. But if the case
we wanted to do that, we can set that rule
there. And so we will allow inbound traffic
that way. And we will also allow inbound traffic
for Port 80, but only only from the load balancer.
So in here, we can actually supply a security
group of another one here. So for the load
balancer, I don't remember what's called Oh,
I can move this nice. And so the other one
is called a lb. So I'm just going to start
typing a lb here. And now we are allowing
any traffic, just from on port 80. From that
load bouncer. Okay, so we're going to hit
Create there, oh, I gotta give it a description.
So my SD scritti. Group, okay. I know, you
always have to provide those descriptions,
it's kind of annoying. Okay, and so now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna go back to our
auto scaling group, we might actually, we
might have to make a new launch configuration,
because there's no the the the security group
is associated with the launch configuration.
So I think that's what we're gonna have to
do here. So we're gonna have to create a new
ami, or new launch configuration, you can
see this is a very common pattern here, copy
the launch configuration here. And we're going
to want to go back, we're gonna want to use
the same, sorry, we're gonna wanna use the
same ami, we're not changing anything here,
we just want to make sure that it's using
the new security group here. So we will go
to the ASC one here. Okay. And I think that's
all I want to do. I'm just gonna double check,
make sure all our settings are the same. Oh,
yeah, does this stupid copy thing. So we'll
just do 002 there. And yeah, everything is
in good shape, we will just double check here.
Yep. And we will all create that new launch
configuration there, close it. Okay, we'll
go to our auto scaling group. And we're going
to go to actions, edit, as always, and go
to version two here. Okay, and we are going
to save it. Alright. And the next thing we're
going to do is we are going to terminate this
instance here, because we want the new security
group to take effect, okay. So we're going
to terminate that instance, if we stopped,
it also would do it. But we want to get rid
of the server here. So we'll terminate it,
we're going to go back to our auto scaling
group, okay, because we want to by default,
run at least in three azs. To get that, that
full availability there. So what I'm going
to do is I'm going to change our desire to
three, our min to three and our max to three.
Okay? And, um, I'm going to add an additional
subnet here, we need See here, okay, so that
I can actually do that. And, yeah, now I'm
kind of expecting this AZ to, to launch in
all three, okay. If I just go back here and
edit here. Yeah. So now all three Z's appear
there. Because if we didn't have that there,
I don't think the load balancer would have
been able to do that it would have launched
two and one is the one another. So now we
have those there. And what we're gonna do
is we're just going to wait for these three
servers to spin up here. Okay. There's two,
where's my third one? Give me a third one.
But yeah, we set it to three. So the third
one will will appear here shortly. And we
will just resume here once they all appear.
So our three EC two instances have launched,
I was a bit worried about the last one, but
it eventually made its way here and look at
the azs. One is an A one is in B and one is
in C. So we have high availability. So if
two available availability zones go out, we're
always going to have a third server running.
So we're going to be in very good shape. Now,
the other thing we were doing is we wanted
to make sure that people couldn't directly
access the servers and had to be through the
load balancer. So let's go discover that right
now. So if I pull up this IP should change
I'll be accessible via the IP or public DNS
here and I try this here. It's never loading.
That's great. That's what we want. Okay, so
the question is, is now if we go to our load
balancer, do, we still have access to our
our instances here, through that DNS record
here, okay. So we're gonna copy that. And
we do. So, you know, the good reason for that
is that we always want to restrict our traffic
through like this narrow pipeline. Because
if everything always passes through the load
balancer, then we can get richer analytics
on and put things in front of there. One thing
we can do with a load balancer is attach a
laugh, web application firewall, which is
a really good thing to do. And so if you have
people accessing things directly, not through
the load balancer, then they wouldn't pass
it a laugh, okay, so it's just creating those
nice choke points there. And so now that we
have our lb, I guess the next step would be
really to serve this website up via a custom
domain name. So yeah, let's do a bit with
route 53 and get a custom domain.
So now it's time to learn how to use route
53 to get a custom domain name, because, you
know, we do have this URL for our website,
but it's kind of ugly. And we want to go custom
here. And we want to learn how to integrate
router d3 into our load balancer. So let's
go up at the top here, type a route 53. Okay,
and we're going to register our domain. Now,
this does cost money. So I guess you could
skip it or just watch here. But you know,
to get the full effect, I really do think
you should go out and purchase a very inexpensive
domain. And so
we're gonna go to the top here, and I'm going
to register a new domain, I'm going to get
a.com if I can, unless there's something cheaper.
I mean, there are cheaper ones. I guess I
don't have to be so frugal, okay, and I'm
going to try to get I know what domain I want.
And as always, it's going to be Star Trek,
I'm gonna see if I can get the friendly lion.
So we'll type in frame your lines here and
check if it's available. And it is, so that's
going to be our domain name. So I'm going
to add it to my cart here. We'll have our
subtotal. We'll hit Continue. And now we have
a bunch of information to fill in. And I just
want to point out down below that you can
have privacy protection turned on. So normally,
with other services like GoDaddy, you'd have
to pay an additional fee in order to have
yourself protected. So it doesn't display
your information on who is okay. So if you're
wondering, I'm talking about if you go to
who is here.
Domain tools, I believe it this is this one
here? I'm not sure why Oh, here it is. There
we go. I clicked the wrong one.
Okay, and so if we were to go to who is here,
we can generally look up anything we want.
So if we typed in like google.com, okay. I
say I'm not a robot. Okay. Generally, there
is like additional information here. And it
can provide like someone's phone number and
the company here. And sometimes you want to
keep this information, private. And so that
is what this option here is going to do. So
if you've ever had a random call from somebody,
you wonder how they got your phone number,
maybe you registered a domain name, and it
wasn't a had privacy turned on. But anyway,
I'm gonna go ahead and fill this out. And
then I'm going to show you the steps afterwards.
Okay. All right. So we're on to the next page
here. And I did substitute my private information
here. And if you do call this number, you
are looking forward to some tasty, tasty pizza
hot in Toronto. And so on this page here,
it's gonna ask us if we want to automatically
renew our domain, I'm gonna say yes, because
I think I want to keep this domain. And I'm
just going to agree to the terms and conditions,
it's going to cost $12 USD. Unfortunately,
it's not Canadian dollars. So it's a little
bit more expensive. But for me, it is worth
it, we're going to go ahead and complete our
purchase. Okay, and so it says we've registered
the domain. And so it has been successfully
registered. So there we go. Cool. So I just
want to show you that the domain is in pending.
So we are just waiting to get some emails
from AWS. And once we get those emails, we
will confirm them. And we should have our
domain very shortly. They say it can take
up to three days, I've never had to wait that
long to get a domain it's pretty quick, especially
with dot coms. So as those emails come in,
I will then switch over to our email and show
you what those look like. So our first email
has arrived is from Amazon registar. And it's
just it's a confirmation. And there's nothing
for us to confirm. It's just saying, hey,
you are now using Amazon register. That's
the thing that actually registers the domains
behind revenue three. And this is not really
the email we care about, but I just want to
show you so if you're wondering, you know
what it's about. Okay, so our second email
came in here. It didn't take too long here.
I think I made maybe waited about 15 minutes
and it says I've successfully registered the
Frankie Alliance calm and So now, we are ready
to start using this domain. So we're gonna
go back to row 53. Here, I'm just going to
get out of my email. So our domain name is
registered. And we can see it appearing under
the register domains, it's no longer in the
pending state. So let's go all the way up
to hosted zones, because either of us will
will have created one by default for us. And
we can go ahead and start hooking up this
domain to our load balancer. So I'm going
to click in to the Frankie Alliance, okay.
And right off the bat, we have some ns records,
we have an SLA record. So they've really set
us up here. And we're going to create our
first record set. And we're going to want
to hook up our www dot, okay, and we are going
to want to use alias and we're going to choose
the target, and we're gonna choose our E lb.
Okay, and so we're gonna leave it on simple
routing. And we're gonna create that. And
now our www dot should start pointing to our
domain name, I'm pretty sure this takes effect,
like immediately, this is a new domain name.
So I'm not sure if it has to propagate through
all the DNS records around the world. So this
doesn't work. I'm not going to get too upset
about this here, but I'm gonna cross my fingers
and can't be reached, okay, so it doesn't
work just as of yet. So what I'm going to
do is, I'm just going to give it a little
bit of time here, just to see if it does take
effect here, because everything is hooked
up correctly. And we will be back here shortly.
So I took a quick break there had some coconut
water came back refreshed, and now our website's
working, I didn't have to do anything, it
just sometimes takes a little bit time to
propagate over the internet, those those changes
there. So now our next thing we need to resolve
is the fact that this isn't secure. Okay.
And so AWS has a server certificate, a service
called Amazon certification manager, certificate
manager, and it'll allows you to get free
SSL certificates. But just be sure, when you
do go to the service, we're going to click
on provision certificates and not private,
these ones are very expensive, they're $500.
Initially, and you really want to just provision
a certificate, I wish they'd say free or public
over here. So it's less confusing, you're
only ever going to see the splash screen once,
for the first time you've ever created a certificate
within a zone. So hopefully, that's not too
confusing there. But it does ask you again,
if you want public or private, you definitely
definitely want the public certificate, not
the private, okay, so we're going to request
a certificate, and we are going to put our
domain name in. So just to cover all our bases
here, I'm going to put in the naked domain,
I'm also going to put in a wildcard. So all
our sub domains are included here, this is
going to catch all cases. And we'll just hit
next here,
we're going to use DNS validation. Email validation
is the older mechanism here for validation.
Everyone does DNS validation, okay, and we're
gonna hit review, then we're gonna hit confirm
request. And this is going to start spinning
here. And now what's gonna ask for us for
to do is to validate that we have ownership
of that domain. And so we can verify this
here. And luckily, we can just drop this down
and create a record in row feet, roughly three.
So this is what they do, they put a C name
in your, your DNS records here. And that's
how we know that we own that domain name.
And we're gonna do it for both here. Okay,
and so now we're just gonna have to wait for
these to validate here and it shouldn't take
too long. So I took a quick break there had
some coconut water came back refreshed, and
now our website's working, I didn't have to
do anything, it just sometimes takes a little
bit time to propagate over the internet, those
those changes there. So now our next thing
we need to resolve is the fact that this isn't
secure. Okay. And so AWS has a server certificate,
a service called Amazon certification manager,
certificate manager and allows you to get
free SSL certificates. But just be sure, when
you do go to the service, we're going to click
on provision certificates and not private,
these ones are very expensive. They're $500.
Initially, and you really want to just provision
a certificate, which let's say free or public
over here, so it's less confusing. You're
only ever going to see the splash screen once,
for the first time you've ever created a certificate
within a zone. So hopefully, that's not too
confusing there. But it does ask you again,
if you want public or private, you definitely
definitely want the public certificate, not
the private, okay, so we're going to request
a certificate, and we are going to put our
domain name in. So I'm going to do this and
just so I don't type it wrong, and we're going
to go back to row 53 and grab our domain name,
okay. And there it is. So I'm just going to
copy it there. Go back here, and I'm going
to give it wildcard so it just saves you a
lot of time if you wildcard it Okay, so you
don't have to keep on adding certificates
for subdomains you don't cover but we have
wildcard it so we're gonna hit next. And then
we need to validate that we own That domain
name. And since we're using record three,
it's going to be very easy, we can just use
the DNS validation method, nobody uses email
anymore. It's like very old method. So we're
always going to do DNS. And so we're going
to go to the next step here and say review.
And we're going to say, confirm and request.
And now we just need to confirm ownership.
So they will issue us a free SSL certificate.
So we see pending validation, okay, we're
going to drop down here. And what we're going
to have here is a button. And what this is
going to do is it's going to automatically
create the C name record in roughly three,
this is the way certificate manager is going
to confirm that we own the domain, because
we can add it to the domain, that means we
must own it. And so they have a one button
press for us to do that there. So that's a
very convenient, okay, and this should not
take too long to confirm. So we'll hit continue
here. Okay, and it's in pending validation.
And so we're just going to wait a little bit
here, just like we did for the website update.
And we'll do I will do a refresh because it
says a sack page, so you will have to hit
this a few times. So that certificate has
been issued, the console didn't directly take
me to the screen. So I did have to go to the
top here, type ACM, like this, and to get
here and hit refresh. But again, this only
takes a few minutes when you are using route
53. And so um, you know, just be aware, that's
how long it should take. And so now that it's
been issued, we can go ahead and attach it
to our load balancers. So we're gonna go back
to the C two console. On the left hand side,
we're going to go to load balancers. And we're
going to make sure our load balancers selected
there, go to listeners, and we're going to
add another 14443, which is SSL. And we're
going to forward this to our target production
group here. Okay. And then this is where we
get to attach your SSL certificate. So we're
going to drop that down to Frankie Alliance,
and we're going to hit save. Okay, and so
now, we're able to listen on port four, or
sorry, 4443. Here, we do have this little
caution symbol is saying that we can't actually
receive inbound traffic for 443. So we're
gonna have to update our security group. So
going down to a security group here, we will
click it,
and it is the alrb security group that we're
looking for. So this one here, we're going
to go to inbound rules
we're going to edit, we're going to add a
new rule, and we're going to set it for HTTP
s. So there we go. So now, we can accept traffic
on 443. And it is attached there. So now we
should be able to, we should be able to have
a protected or secure URL there when we access
our domain name. So I'm just gonna grab the
name. So don't make any spelling mistakes
here. And we'll paste it in here. And there
we go. It's secure. So um, yeah, so there
we are. Okay, great. So we're all done this
fall along here. And I just want to make sure
that we just do some cleanup here to make
sure that we aren't being charged for things,
we don't need any more. So the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to just terminate
our load balancer there, which is not too
difficult to do. So we'll just go ahead there
and go to actions and just go ahead and delete,
and delete that, it should be pretty quick.
And wow, that was very fast. So now on to
our auto scaling groups. So that's the next
thing, we need to go ahead and delete there.
And so we're just gonna drop down to actions
there and go delete. Now, when you delete
the auto scaling group, it will automatically
delete those easy two instances there. But
it's good to keep a little eye on them there.
So we're going to pop over to here for a minute.
And you can see they're not terminating just
yet. So we're gonna wait on that auto scaling
group. And so once that scaling group has
been deleted, and this might take a little
bit of time here, it will definitely get rid
of those easy two instances for us. That took
an incredibly long time to delete that auto
scaling group. I don't know why. But we'll
go back to our instances here. And we will
see if they are still running. So you can
see they've all been terminated. So when that
auto scaling group is deleted, it's going
to take down the EC two instances with it,
we're probably also going to want to go to
route 53. And remove those, those dead endpoints
there because there is a way of compromising
those, if you are a very smart, so we'll just
go ahead and delete that record because it's
pointing to nothing right now. Right. And
so there you go, that was our cleanup. So
we're all in good shape. And hopefully you
found the the section.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at elastic file system Fs,
which is a scalable elastic cloud native NFS
file system. So you can attach a single file
system to multiple EC two instances and you
don't have to worry about running out or managing
disk space. Alright, so now we are looking
at EF s and it is a file storage service for
easy to instances, storage capacity is going
to grow up to petabytes worth and shrink automatically
based on your data stored so that's why it
has elastic in its name that drive is going
to change to meet whatever the demand you
are Having stored now, um, the huge huge advantage
here is that you can have multiple EC two
instances in the same VPC mount to a single
e Fs volume. So it's like they're all sharing
the same drive. And it's not just easy two
instances, it's any any of them in a single
VPC. That's amazing. And so in order for you
easy two instances, to actually mount FSX,
it does have to install the NFS version 4.1
client, which totally makes sense, because
Fs is using that protocol, the NFS version
four protocol. And so Fs, it will create multiple
targets in all your VPC subnets. So this is
how it's able to allow you to mount in different
subnets or different Z's here. And so we'll
just see a create a bunch of Mount points
and that's what you will mount. And the way
it builds, it's going to, it's going to be
based on the space that you're using, it's
going to be 30 cents for a gigabyte, month
over month reoccurring. Okay. So there you
go. Hey, this is Angie brown from exam Pro,
and we are going to do a quick EF s follow
along. So we're going to launch to EC two
instances, connect them both IE Fs and see
if they can share files between them from
a one DFS, okay, so what we're going to need
to do is make our way to the DFS console here,
okay. And we're going to get here and we're
going to create a new file system, we are
going to launch this in our default VPC, you're
going to see that it's going to create mount
targets for every single availability zone
for us here, okay. And so it's also going
to use the default security group. Okay, and
so we're gonna go next, we're gonna skip tags,
we do have the ability to do Lifecycle Management.
So this is no different than s3, allowing
you to reduce costs by moving stuff that you're
not using as frequently into infrequent access.
So you get a cheaper, cheaper storage cost
there. So that's really nice. We're going
to be comfortable with using bursting here.
We're going to stick with general purpose,
and we're going to turn on encryption, okay,
it's good practice to use encryption here,
especially when you're doing the certifications.
You want to know what what you can encrypt.
Okay, so, AWS has a default kms key for us.
So we can go to next here. And we're just
going to do a quick review. And we're going
to create that file system. Okay. So it's
going to take a little bit of time here to
create that file system. Well, while that's
going, I think we can go prep our EC two instances.
Okay. So yeah, it's just going to take a bit
of time. So if we are looking at our Fs volume
here, we can still see that our mount targets
are creating. So let's go ahead and create
those EC two instances. So in the ECG console,
you can get there just by typing EC two, and
we are going to launch a couple of instances.
So we will choose Amazon Lex two, because
that's always a good choice, we'll stick with
T two micros because that is part of the free
tier, we're going to go next. And we're going
to launch two of these fellows here. Okay,
and we got to make sure that we are launching
this in the same VPC as a DFS, which is the
default one, okay? We're not going to worry
about what which subnet because we're gonna
be able access it from anywhere. And I want
you to create a new role here. So we're gonna
go here and create a new role. Okay, and we've
created this multiple times through our fall
alongs. But just in case you've missed it,
we're going to go ahead and create a role
go to EC to go next. And we're going to choose
SSM for SYSTEMS MANAGER, okay, and we're going
to hit next and then next, and then we're
going to type in a my will say Fs DC to role,
okay, and we will create that role. Alright.
And so that's going to allow us to access
these instances via session manager, which
is the preferred way over SSH. So we will
just hit refresh here and then see if it is
there. And there it is. Okay, and we're just
going to need to also just attach a user data
script here, because we need to configure
these instances here to
to be able to use EF s, okay, so there is
this little thing you do have to install.
And so we're just gonna make that easy here,
it's gonna install it for both our instances.
Alright, and so we're gonna go ahead and go
to storage. And then we're going to go to
tags, and we're gonna go to security groups,
and we're gonna make a new security group
for this here. Okay? So I'm just going to
call it my EC to a u Fs. sg, alright. And
I mean, we don't really plan on doing much
with this here. So I'm just going to go ahead
and review and launch and then we will get
our key pair here. Not that our key pair matters
because we are going to use sessions manager
to gain access to these instances. Okay, so
now as these are spinning up, let's go take
a look back over here and see if these endpoints
are done creating. Now it says they're still
creating but you know, the ages constantly
can never trust it. So we'll go up here and
do a refresh here and see if they are done
crazy and they are all available. Okay? So
we do actually have something instructions
on how to set these up here with us. So if
we just click here, it's going to tell us
that we need to install this here onto our
EC two instances for it to work. And we have
absolutely done that. And then when we scroll
down here, we need to then mount the EF Fs.
Okay, and so since we are using encryption,
we're going to have to use this command here.
Okay, and so that's what we're going to do,
we're going to have to use sessions manager
to log in, and then mount it using the following
command. Okay, so we're going to go back to
EC two instances, and we're just going to
wait till those style checks are complete.
Okay, so as these are initializing here, I
bet we should probably go set our security
groups. So I'm going to go over to security
groups here. And I'm going to look for our
default one, because I believe that's what
we launched, our DFS is in, I probably should
have created our own security group here,
but that's totally fine. So it's going to
be 2198. Okay, and so we're, that's what we're
looking for is 2918. And it is this one here,
and it's the default here, okay, and we're
just going to add an inbound rule here. And
we're going to have a Roy here from an old
an old following here, this will just remove
that. And we'll look for NFS. Okay, that's
gonna set it for 2049. And now we just need
to allow the security group for our, our EC
to there's so I believe we called it and so
I just start typing mine. So we have my EC
two Fs SG. And so now we shouldn't have any
issues with mounting, because we probably
do need that to gain access. Okay, and so
we're gonna go and now we'll go back and see
how our instances are doing. So it looks like
they're ready to go. So now that they're,
they're in good shape, we can actually go
gain access to them. So what we're going to
do is we're going to go to SYSTEMS MANAGER,
so type SSM and make a new tab here, okay.
And we're going to wait for this to load here
and on the left hand side, we're going to
go to sessions manager. And we're going to
start a session. And so there are both of
our instances, we probably should go name
them, it'll just make our lives a lot easier.
So I'm going to say EC two Fs, a, okay. And
then we have E, F, E, AC to DFS B. All right,
so we'll just go back here, do a refresh.
And there are two instances. So we need to
launch an instance for this one, okay. And
I'm gonna have to start there. And then I'm
gonna have to make another session here and
start it for a B. All right. Okay, and so
now we have these two here, and we're going
to have to switch to the correct user. So
we are as root user, we don't want to be that
we want to be the easy to user. Okay, so we
will switch over to EC two for a consuming
this one's a doesn't really matter at this
point, because you know, doesn't, but it will
just switch over here to the user here. Alright,
so now we are set up here, and we can go ahead
and mount mounted there. So it's just a matter
of copying this entire command. So we are
going to need the sudo in there. So just make
sure you include it. And we're just going
to paste that in there. And we're going to
mount, okay, and it just says it doesn't exist.
So we'll just Alright, so that can fail because
it has nothing to mount to. So we actually
have to create a directory for it. Okay, so
just here in the home directory, I'm just
going to go make MK dir, and type in Fs. Okay,
and then we will just go up, and then we will
mount it. And so now it should mount to that
new directory. So it is mounted. We're going
to do the same story over here. Okay, so just
to save us some time, I'm just going to copy
these commands over, okay. All right. Oops,
we forgot the M there on the front. Okay.
And then we will just copy over the same command
here. And we will also mount Fs, okay, so
they should both be mounted now. And so I'm
just going to do an ls, and we're going to
go into that directory there. Okay. And we
are just going to create any kind of files,
I'm gonna say, touch on touch, base, your
dot txt. Okay, so I've touched that file,
we cannot do that there. So I'll just type
in sudo. And so I'll do an ls within that
directory. And so that file is there. So now
if I go over to this one here, and do an ls
and go into Fs, and do an ls, there is that
file. Okay. So that's how you can access files,
across instances using DFS. So that's all
you need to know. So we're, we are done. Okay,
so we'll just terminate this instance here,
okay. And we will also terminate this instance
here. Great, we will close that sessions manager,
we will just kill our instances here. Okay.
Because we are all done. And we'll go over
to DFS. So it's only only costs for when we're
consuming stuff, but since we're done with
it, let's go ahead and tear this down. Okay,
and we need to just copy this fella in here.
And we're all good to go. So there you are,
that is EF s. Alright, so we're onto the ZFS
cheat sheet here. So elastic file system.
VFS supports the network files. System version
four protocol you pay per gigabyte of storage
per month. volumes can scale to petabyte size
storage volumes will shrink and grow to meet
current data stored. So that's why it's elastic
can support 1000s of concurrent connections
over NFS. Your data is stored across multiple
agencies within a region. So you have good
durability there can mount multiple EC two
instances to a single Fs as long as they're
all in the same VPC. It creates a mount points
in all your VPC subnets. So you can mount
from anywhere within your VPC and it provides
read after write consistency. So there you
go. That's
the
Hey, this is Angie brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at elastic block store also
known as EBS, which is a virtual hard drive
in the cloud create new volumes attached easy
to instances, backup via snapshots and easy
encryption. So before we jump into EBS, I
wanted to lay some foundational knowledge
that's going to help us understand why certain
storage mediums are better than others based
on their use case. So let's talk about IOP.
So IOP stands for input output per second
it is the speed at which non contiguous reads
and writes can be performed on a storage medium.
So when someone says hi IO, there, they're
saying that this medium has the ability to
do lots of small fast reads and writes. Then
we have the concept of throughput. So this
is the data transfer rate to and from the
storage medium in megabytes per second. Then
you have bandwidth, which sounds very similar,
but it's different. And so bandwidth is the
measurement of total possible speed of data
movement along the network. So to really distinguish
between the throughput and the bandwidth,
we're going to use the pipe in water example.
So think of bandwidth as the pipe and throughput
as the water. Okay, so now let's jump into
EBS. So we are now on to talking about EBS
and it is a highly available durable solution
for attaching persistent block storage volumes
to easy to instances, volumes are automatically
replicated within their AZ to protect them
from component failure. And we have five types
of EBS storage to choose from we have general
purpose provision, I Ops, throughput, optimized
HDD, cold, HDD and EBS. Magnetic, okay, and
so we do have some short definitions here,
but we're going to cover them again here.
Alright, so we're gonna look at the different
volume types for EBS, and just try to understand
their use cases. And so again, there are five
types, and we're gonna go through each one
starting with general purpose. And it is as
the name implies, good for general usage without
specific requirements. So you're gonna be
using this for most workloads like your web
apps, and has a good balance between price
and performance for the actual attributes
underneath it, it can have a volume size between
one gigabytes and 16 terabytes, and a max
I ops of 16,000 per second. Moving on to provision
I ops SSD, it's really good when you need
fast input and output, or the more verbose
description is when you need mission critical,
low latency or high throughput. So it's not
just eye Ops, it's also high throughput as
well, it's going to be great for large databases.
So you know, think RDS, or Cassandra. And
the way you know, when you should start using
provision I ops if you exceed 16,000, I often
see that's where the limit is for general
purpose. So when you need to go beyond that,
you're going to want to use this one, or if
the throughput is greater than 250 megabytes
there as well. Now, the volume size here can
between four gigabytes and 16 terabytes, and
we can have a max I ops of 64,000. Okay, moving
on to our hard disk drives, we have throughput,
optimized HDD, and it is a low cost. It's
designed for frequency, frequently accessed.
data and the throughput and throughput intensive
workloads, it's going to be great for data
warehousing, big data and log processing stuff
where we have a lot of data. The volume size,
you can see by default is a lot larger, we
have 500 gigabytes to 15 terabytes in the
max I ops is 500. Moving over to cold HDD,
this is the lowest costing hard drive here.
It's less for less frequently used workloads,
you're going to have things for storage, okay,
so if you want to put backups or file storage,
this is going to be a good drive for that.
And it has the same volume size as the throughput
one is just not as the throughput is lower
here, and we're have a max I ops of 250. Moving
on to EBS magnetic, we're looking at very
inexpensive storage for long term archival
storage, where you're going to have between
500 gigabytes and 15 terabytes and a max I
ops as As 40 to 200, okay, and so generally
it's using previous generation hard drives.
So that's why we get that low cost there.
But yeah, there is the full spectrum of volume
types for you here, on on EBS.
So we're gonna look at some different storage
volumes starting with hard disk drives. So
hard disk drives, is a magnetic storage that
uses rotating platters on an actuator arm
and a magnetic head. So look, we got this
round thing, an arm and a little needle, or
head on the end of it remind you something,
it's like a record player, right? So h acds
is very good at writing a continuous amount
of data. So the idea is that once the arm
goes down, you have lots of data, it's really
good at just writing a bunch of data. Where
hard disk drives do not accelerate is when
you have many small reads and writes. Okay,
so that's high IO, okay. And the reason why
is just think about the arm, the arm would
have to like, lift up, move to where it needs
to right, go down and then right, and then
lift up again. And so there's a lot of physical
movement there. And that's going to limit
its ability to have high i O. So hard disk
drives are really good for throughput, because
again, it's continuous amounts of data. And
so that means fast amounts of data being written
continuously. So it's gonna be great for throughput.
But you know, the caveat here is does it does
have physical moving parts, right? Now we're
taking a look at our next storage volume,
solid state drives SSDs. And they're different
because they don't have any physical moving
parts, they use integrated circuits to transport
the data and store it on to things like flash
memory here. And so SSDs are typically more
resistant to physical shock. They're very
quiet, because there's no moving parts. And
they have quicker access times and lower latency.
So they're really, really good at frequently
reads and writes. So they're going to have
a high i O, they can also have really good
throughput. But generally when we're thinking
about SSD, we just think hio Okay, so there
you go. So looking at our last storage volume,
here, we have magnetic tape. And if you've
ever seen an old computer, you've seen magnetic
tape because they look like film, right? You
have these big reels of magnetic tape, and
we still use them today, because they are
highly durable. They last for decades. And
they're extremely cheap to produce. So if
it isn't broke, why throw it out. Now, we
don't really use magnetic tape in this way
anymore with big spools, or sorry, reels,
what we do is we have a tape drive down below
and you can insert a cartridge into it, which
contains the magnetic tape. Okay, so there
you go. So I want to talk about how we can
move our volumes around. So if you wanted
to move your volume from one AZ to another,
what you'd have to do is you have to create
a snapshot. And then once you create that
snapshot, you'd create an ami from that snapshot.
And then you could launch an EC two instance
into another availability zone. Now for regions,
there's a little bit more work involved, it's
going to be the same process to begin with,
we're going to create a snapshot. And from
there, we're going to create an ami from that
snapshot. But in order to get into another
region, we're going to have to copy that ami.
So we're gonna use that copy ami command into
region B, and then we're going to launch IBC
two instance. And so that's how we're going
to get our volumes from one region to another.
Okay.
So now we're taking a look at how to encrypt
our root volume. And so when you create an
EC two instance, there is a little through
the launch wizard, there is a storage step.
And so here we can see our storage volume,
that's going to be our root. And we actually
have a box over here where we just drop it
down and encrypt it based on the method that
we want. This wasn't possible prior, I don't
know how many years ago was maybe last year
or something. But um, you weren't able to
encrypt a volume on creation, but you definitely
can now. Now what happens if we have a volume
that we created that was unencrypted, and
now we want to apply encryption to it? Well,
we're gonna have to go through a little bit
more effort here. And here are the steps below.
So the first thing we're going to do is take
a snapshot of that unencrypted volume. And
then once we have that snapshot, we're going
to copy or use the copy command to create
another snapshot. And with that, we actually
will have the option to encrypt it. And so
we will encrypt that copy giving us an encrypted
snapshot. And then from there, we will launch
a new EC two instance with that encrypted
ami and then launch a new EC two instance
from That ami and so that's how we're gonna
get an encrypted root volume. So there you
go. So when you launch an EC two instance,
it can be backed by either an EBS volume or
an instance store volume. And there's going
to be some cases when you want to use one
or over the other, but 99.9% of the time,
you're going to be wanting to use an EBS volume.
And so the EBS volume is a durable block level
storage device that you can attach to a single
EC two instance. Now the instant store volume
is a temporary storage type located on disk
that are physically attached to a host machine.
And so the key word here is one is durable
and one is temporary. All right. And you know,
anytime we talk about instant stores, a Ferial
is another word that comes up. And so if you
ever see that word, it means lasting for a
very short time. Okay, so that makes total
sense why they're called that sometimes. And
so for an EBS volume, if you, if you want
to use it within institutions, it's going
to the volume is going to be created from
an EBS snapshot with an instance or store
volume, it's going to be created from a template
stored in s3. Now, the way you use these volumes
is going to also affect the behavior you see
too, because you can stop and start an EC
two instance. And the data is going to re
persist when it starts back up. Again, when
you look at an instance store volume, you
cannot stop the instance, if you terminate
it, you're going to lose all that data because
it's a temporary storage type, you might be
able to reboot it, but you won't be able to
stop the volume, okay, so you might just have
reboot and terminate as your only two options
there. And also, you know, when an EC two
instance launches up, it goes through status
checks, and so the one it goes through is
like a host check. If that were to fail, then
also the data would be lost there. But generally,
when you're spinning up an EC two instance,
you don't have any data you're not too worried
about any way, but that's just a consideration
to list out there. And so we're gonna talk
about the use cases. So, so EBS volumes are
ideal when you want data to persist. In most
cases, you'll want to use an EBS, EBS backed
volume. And for instance store it's ideal
for temporary backup for storing an applications
cash logs or random data. So this is data
where when the server is not running you,
it should go away. Okay, so there you go.
That's the difference between EBS volumes
and instant store
volume.
So we're done with EBS, and we're looking
at the EBS cheat sheet so let's jump into
it. So elastic block store EBS is a virtual
hard disk, and snapshots are a point in time
copy of that disk. volumes exist on EBS snapshots
exist on s3. snapshots are incremental only
changes made since the last snapshots are
moved to to s3. Initial snapshots of an EC
two instance will take a large crate then
subsequent snapshots of taking snapshots of
a volume the EC two instance should be stopped
before snapshotting you can take snapshots
while the instance is still running, you can
create amies from volumes or from snapshots.
EBS volumes are just define that what they
are here a durable block level storage device
that you can attach to a single EC two instance.
EBS volumes can be modified on the fly so
you can increase their storage type or their
volume size. volumes always exists in the
same AZ as easy to instance. And then looking
at instance store volumes a temporary storage
type located on disks that are physically
attached to a host machine. Instant storage
volumes are serial meaning that cannot be
if they cannot be stopped. If the host fails
and you lose your data. Okay, EBS backed instances
can be stopped and you will not lose any data.
By default root volumes are deleted on termination.
EBS volumes can have termination protection,
so don't delete the volume on termination.
And snapshots or restored encrypted volumes
will also be encrypted. You cannot share a
snapshot if it has been encrypted and unencrypted
snapshots can be shared with other Eva's counts
or made public. So there you go. That's your
EBS tg
Hey, this is Angie brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at CloudFront, which is a CDN
a content distribution network. It creates
cache copies of your website at various edge
locations around the world. So to understand
what CloudFront is, we need to understand
what a content delivery network is. So a CDN
is a distributed network of servers, which
deliver webpages and content to users based
on their geographical location, the origin
of the web page and a content delivery server.
So over here, I have a graphical representation
of a CDN specifically for CloudFront. And
so the idea is that you have your content
hosted somewhere. So here the origin is s3
and the idea is that the server CloudFront
is going to distribute a copy of your website
on multiple edge locations which are just
servers around the world that are nearby to
the user. So when a user from Toronto tries
to access our content, it's not going to go
to the s3 bucket, it's going to go to CloudFront.
And CloudFront is going to then route it to
the nearest edge location so that this user
has the lowest latency. And that's the concept
behind.
So it's time to look at the core components
for CloudFront. And we'll start with origin,
which is where the original files are located.
And generally, this is going to be an s3 bucket.
Because the most common use case for CloudFront
is static website hosting. However, you can
also specify origin to be an easy to instance,
on elastic load balancer or route 53. The
next thing is the actual distribution itself.
So distribution is a collection of edge locations,
which define how cache content should behave.
So this definition, here is the thing that
actually says, Hey, I'm going to pull from
origin. And I want this to update the cache,
whatever whatever frequency or use HTTPS,
or that should be encrypted. So that is the
settings for the distribution. And then there's
the edge locations. And an edge location is
just a server. And it is a server that is
nearby to the actual user that stores that
cache content. So those are the three components
to so we need to look at the distribution
component of CloudFront in a bit more detail,
because there's a lot of things that we can
set in here. And I'm not even showing you
them all, but let's just go through it. So
we have an idea, the kinds of things we can
do with it. So again, a distribution is a
collection of edge locations. And the first
thing you're going to do is you're going to
specify the origin. And again, that's going
to be s3 ec two lb or refer d3. And when you
said your distribution, what's really going
to determine the cost and also how much it's
going to replicate across is the price class.
So here, you can see, if you choose all edge
locations, it's gonna be the best performance
because your website is going to be accessible
from anywhere in the world. But you know,
if you're operating just in North America
and the EU, you can limit the amount of servers
it replicates to. There are two types of distributions,
we have web, which is for websites, and rtmp,
which is for streaming media, okay, um, you
can actually serve up streaming video under
web as well. But rtmp is a very specific protocol.
So it is its own thing. When you set up behaviors,
there's a lot of options we have. So we could
redirect all the traffic to be HTTPS, we could
restrict specific HTTP methods. So if we don't
want to have puts, we can say we not include
those. Or we can restrict the viewer access,
which we'll look into a little bit more detail
here, we can set the TTL, which is time to
expiry, or Time To Live sorry, which says
like after, we could say every two minutes,
the content should expire and then refresh
it right, depending on how, how stale we want
our content to be. There is a thing called
invalidations in CloudFront, which allow you
to manually set so you don't have to wait
for the TTL. to expire, you could just say
I want to expire these files, this is very
useful when you are pushing changes to your
s3 bucket because you're gonna have to go
manually create that invalidation. So those
changes will immediately appear. You can also
serve back at error pages. So if you need
a custom 404, you can do that through CloudFront.
And then you can set restrictions. So if you
for whatever reason, aren't operating in specific
countries, and you don't want those countries
to consume a lot of traffic, which might cost
you money, you can just restrict them saying
I'm blocking these countries, or or you could
do the other way and say I only whitelist
these countries, these are the only countries
that are allowed to view things from CloudFront.
So there's one interesting feature I do want
to highlight on CloudFront, which is lambda
edge and lambda edge are lambda functions
that override the behavior of requests and
responses that are flowing to and from CloudFront.
And so we have four that are available to
us, we have the viewer requests, the origin
requests, the origin response, and the viewer
response, okay, and so on our on our CloudFront
distribution under probably behavior, we can
associate lambda functions. And that allows
us to intercept and do things with this, what
would you possibly use lambda edge for a very
common use case would let's say you have protected
content, and you want to authenticate it against
something like cognito. So only users that
are within your cognito authentication system
are allowed to access that content. That's
actually something we do on exam pro for the
video content here. So you know, that is one
method for protecting stuff, but there's a
lot of creative solutions here with you can
use lambda edge, you could use it to serve
up a to b testing websites, so you could have
it. So when the viewer request comes in, you
have a roll of the die, and it will change
what it serves back. So it could be, it could
set up a or set up B. And that's something
we also do in the exam pro marketing website.
So there's a lot of opportunities here with
lambda edge. I don't know if it'll show up
in the exam, I'm sure eventually it will.
And it's just really interesting. So I thought
it was worth
an hour talking about cloud front protection.
So CloudFront might be serving up your static
website, but you might have protected content,
such as video content, like on exam Pro, or
other content that you don't want to be easily
accessible. And so when you're setting up
your CloudFront distribution, you have this
option to restrict viewer access. And so that
means that in order to view content, you're
going to have to use signed URLs or signed
cookies. Now, when you do check this on, it
actually will create you an origin identity
access, and oh AI. And what that is, it's
a virtual user identity that it will be used
to give CloudFront distributions permission
to fetch private objects. And so those private
objects generally mean from an s3 bucket that's
private, right. And as soon as that set up,
and that's automatically set up for you. Now
you can go ahead and use sign URLs inside
cookies. So one of these things well, the
idea behind it is a sign URL is just a URL
that CloudFront will provide you that gives
you temporary access to those private cash
objects. Now, you might have heard of pre
signed URLs, and that is an s3 feature. And
it's similar nature. But it's very easy to
get these two mixed up because sign URLs and
pre signed URLs sound very similar. But just
know that pre signed URLs are for s3 and sign
URLs are for CloudFront, then you have signed
cookies, okay. And so it's similar to sign
URLs, the only difference is that you're you
passing along a cookie with your request to
allow users to access multiple files, so you
don't have to, every single time generate
a signed cookie, you set it once, as long
as that cookie is valid and pass along, you
can access as many files as you want. This
is extremely useful for video streaming, and
we use it on exam Pro, we could not do video
streaming protected with sign URLs, because
all the video streams are delivered in parts,
right, so a cookie has to get set. So that
that is your options for protecting cloud.
It's time to get some hands on experience
with CloudFront here and create our first
distribution. But before we do that, we need
something to serve up to the CDN. Okay, um,
so we had an s3 section earlier, where I uploaded
a bunch of images from Star Trek The Next
Generation. And so for you, you can do the
same or you just need to make a bucket and
have some images within that bucket so that
we have something to serve up, okay. So once
you have your bucket of images prepared, we're
going to go make our way to the CloudFront
console here. And so just type in CloudFront,
and then click there. And you'll get to the
same place as me here, we can go ahead and
create our first distribution. So we're gonna
be presented with two options, we have web
and rtmp. Now rtmp is for the Adobe Flash
media server protocol. So since nobody really
uses flash anymore, we can just kind of ignore
this distribution option. And we're going
to go with web, okay. And then we're going
to have a bunch of options, but don't get
overwhelmed, because it's not too tricky.
So the first thing we want to do is set our
origin. So where is this distribution going
to get its files that wants to serve up, it's
going to be from s3. So we're going to click
into here, we're going to get a drop down
and we're going to choose our s3 bucket, then
we have path, we'll leave that alone, we have
origin ID, we'll leave that alone. And then
we have restrict bucket access. So this is
a cool option. So the thing is, is that let's
say you only want two people to access your,
your bucket resources through CloudFront.
Because right now, if we go to s3 console,
I think we made was data public, right? And
if we were to look at this URL, okay, this
is publicly accessible. But let's say we wanted
to force all traffic through cloud front,
because we don't we want to the conference
can track things. So we get some rich analytics
there. And we just don't want people directly
accessing this ugly URL. Well, that's where
this option comes in, restrict bucket access,
okay, and it will, it will create an origin
identity access for us, but we're gonna leave
it to No, I just want you to know about that.
And then down to the actual behavior settings,
we have the ability to redirect HTTP to HTTPS.
That seems like a very sane setting. We can
allow these to be methods, we're only going
to be ever getting things we're never going
to be put or posting things. And then we'll
scroll down, scroll down, we can set our TTL.
The defaults are very good. And then down
here, we have restrict viewer access. So if
we wanted to restrict the viewer access to
require signed URLs of site cookies to protect
access to our content, we'd press yes here
But again, we just want this to be publicly
available. So we're going to set it to No.
Okay. And then down below, we have distribution
settings. And this is going to really affect
our price of the cost we're going to pay here,
as it says price class, okay,
and so we can either distribute all copies
of our files to every single edge location,
or we can just say US, Canada, Europe, or
just US, Canada, yeah, Europe, Asia, Middle
East Africa, or just the the main three. So
I want to be cost saving here. So I'm really
going to cost us a lot anyway. But I think
that if we set it to the lowest cost here
that it will take less time for the distribution
to replicate here in this tutorial go a lot
faster, okay, then we have the ability to
set an alternate domain name, this is important
if we are using a CloudFront certificate,
and we want a custom domain name, which we
would do in a another follow along but not
in this one here. Okay, and if this was a
website, we would set the default route here
to index dot HTML. Okay, so that's pretty
much all we need to know here. And we'll go
ahead and create our distribution, okay, and
so our distribution is going to be in progress.
And we're going to wait for it to distribute
those files to all those edge locations. Okay,
and so this will just take a little bit of
time here, he usually takes I don't know,
like three to five minutes. So we'll, we'll
resume the video when this is done. So creating
that distribution took a lot longer than I
was hoping for, it was more like 15 minutes,
but I think the initial one always takes a
very long time. And then then after whenever
you update things, it still takes a bit of
time, but it's not 15 minutes, more like five
minutes. Okay. But anyway, um, so our distribution
is created. Here, we have an ID, we have a
domain name, and we're just going to click
in to this distribution. And we're going to
see all the options we have here. So we have
general origins, behaviors, error pages, restrictions,
and validations. And tags. Okay, so when we
were creating the distribution, we configured
both general origins and behaviors all in
one go. Okay. And so if we wanted to override
the behaviors from before, we just looked
at it here, we're not going to change anything
here. But I just want to show you that we
have these options previous. And just to see
that they are broken up between these three
tabs here. So if I go to Edit, there's some
information here and some information there.
Okay. So now that we have our distribution
working, we have this domain name here. And
if we had, if we had used our own SSL, from
the Amazon certification manager, we could
add a custom domain, but we didn't. So we
just have the domain that is provided with
us. And this is how we're going to actually
access our our cache file. So what I want
you to do is copy that there. I'm just going
to place it here in a text editor here. And
the idea here is we want to then, from the
enterprise D poll, one of the images here.
So if we have data, we'll just take the front
of it there, okay. And we are going to just
assemble a new URL. So we're going to try
data first here, and data should work without
issue. Okay. And so now we are serving this
up from CloudFront. So that is how it works
now, but data is set to public access. Okay,
so that isn't much of a trick there. But for
all these other ones, I just want to make
sure that he has public access here and it
is set here yep to public access. But let's
look at someone that actually doesn't have
public access, such as Keiko, she does not
have public access. So the question is, will
CloudFront make files that do not have public
access set in here publicly accessible, that's
what we're going to find out. Okay. So we're
just going to then assemble an another URL
here, but this time with Keiko, okay, and
we're gonna see if we can access her All right.
Okay, oops, I copied the wrong link. Just
copy that one more time. Okay, and there you
go. So Keiko is not available. And this is
because she is not publicly accessible. Okay.
So just because you create a CloudFront distribution
doesn't necessarily mean that these files
will be accessible. So if we were to go to
Keiko now and then set her to public, would
she be accessible now through CloudFront?
Okay, so now she is all right. So so just
keep that in mind that when you create a CloudFront
distribution, you're going to get these URLs
and unless you explicitly set the objects
in here to be publicly accessible, they're
not going to be publicly accessible. Okay.
But yeah, that's all there is to it. So we
created our conference. So we need to touch
on one more thing here with CloudFront. And
that is invalidation. So, up here we have
this Keiko image which is being served up
by CloudFront. But let's say we want to replace
it. Okay, so in order to replace images on
CloudFront, it's not as simple as just replacing
an s3. So here we have Keiko, right, and this
is the current image. And so let's say we
wanted to replace that and so I have another
version of Keiko here. I'm just going to upload
it here. And that's going to replace the existing
One, okay.
And so I'm just going to make sure that the
new one is here. So I'm just going to right
click or sorry, gonna hit open here, make
sure it's set to public. And then I'm just
going to click the link here. And it still
now it's the new one, right, so here we have
the new one. And if we were to go to the CloudFront
distribution and refresh, it's still the old
image, okay, because in order for these new
changes to propagate, you have to invalidate
the old, the old cache, okay, and that's where
invalidation is come into play. So, to invalidate
the old cache, we can go in here to create
invalidations. And we can put a wildcard to
expire everything or we could just expire.
Keiko. So, for Keiko, she's at Ford slash
enterprise D. So we would just paste that
in there. And we have now created an invalidation.
And this is going to take five, five minutes,
I'm not going to wait around to show you this
because I know it's going to work. But I just
want you to know that if you update something
in order, in order for it to work, you have
to create a validation. So it's time to look
at the CloudFront cheat sheet. And let's get
to it. So CloudFront is a CDN a content distribution
network. It makes websites load fast by serving
cache content that is nearby CloudFront distributes
cached copies at edge locations, edge locations
aren't just read only you can actually write
to them. So you can do puts to them. We didn't
really cover that in the core content. But
it's good to know CloudFront has a feature
called TTL, which is time to live and that
defines how long until a cache expires. Okay,
so if you set it to expire every hour, every
day, that's how fresh or I guess you'd say
how stale your content is going to be. When
you invalidate your cash, you're forcing it
to immediately expire. So just understand
that invalidations means you're you're refreshing
your cash, okay? refreshing the cast does
cost money because of the transfer cost to
update edge locations, right. So if you have
a file, and it's and it's expired, it then
has to then send that file to 1020, whatever
amount of servers it is, and there's always
that outbound transfer cost, okay? origin
is the address of where the original copies
of your files reside. And again, that can
be a three EC two, lb raffa, d three, then
you have distribution, which defines a collection
of edge locations and behavior on how it should
handle your cache content. We have two types
of distributions, we have the web distribution,
also known as web, which is for static website
content. And then you have rtmp, which is
for streaming media, again, that is a very
specific protocol, you can serve up video
streaming via the web distribution. Then we
have origin identity access, which is used
to access private s3 buckets. If we want to
access cash content that is protected, we
need to use sign URLs or signed cookies, again,
don't get signed roles confused with pre signed
URLs, which is an s3 feature, but it's pretty
much the same in terms of giving you access
to something, then you have lambda edge, which
allows you to pass each request through a
lambda to change the behavior of the response
or the request. Okay, so there you go. That
is cloud front in a nutshell. Hey, this is
Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And we are looking
at relational database service RDS, which
is a managed relational database service and
supports multiple SQL engines, easy to scale,
backup and secure. So jumping into RDS RDS
is a relational database service. And it is
the AV solution for relational databases.
So there are six relational database options
currently available to us. So we have Amazon
Aurora, which we have a whole section dedicated
on MySQL, Maria dB, Postgres, which is what
we use it exam Pro, Oracle and Microsoft SQL.
So let's look at what we can do for encryption,
so you can turn on encryption at rest for
all RDS engines, I've noticed that you might
not be able to turn on encryption for older
versions of some engine. So sometimes this
option is not available, but generally it
always is. And also, when you do turn on encryption,
it's also going to encrypt, as well as your
automated backups, your snapshots and your
read replicas related to that database. And
encryption is handled by AWS key management
service kms, because it always is. So you
can see it's as simple as turning on encryption,
and you can either use the default key or
provide another kms key that you were taking
a look here at RDS backups. Okay, so we have
two solutions available to us starting with
automated backups, we're going to do is you're
going to choose a retention period between
one and 35 days. Now generally, most people
we're going to set this to seven, and if you
were to set it to zero, that's actually how
you turn
it off. So when they say that, automated backups
are enabled, Default, they just mean that
they fill it in with like seven by default
for you. And you can just turn that to zero,
it's going to store transaction logs throughout
the day, all the data is going to be stored
inside s3, and there is no additional charge
for those. Those backups, okay, you're going
to define when you want backups do occur through
a backup windows. So here you can see UTC
six, and the duration can't be longer than
a half an hour. And then storage and IO may
be suspended during backup. So just understand
that you might have some issues during that
period of time. So you might really want to
choose that time carefully. Now, the other
way is manual snapshots. And all you have
to do is drop down actions and take a snapshot.
So it is a manual process. Now, if your primary
database or your RDS was instance was deleted,
you're still going to have the snapshot. So
if you do want to restore a previous snapshot,
you totally can do that. Okay, they don't
go when you delete the RDS.
So let's learn how to actually restore a backup
now. And it's as simple as dropping down actions
here and choosing restore to point in time.
So when recovering, AWS will take the most
recent daily backup and apply transaction
log data relevant to that day. This allows
point in time recovery down to a second inside
the retention period. backup data is never
restored over top of an existing instance,
what it's going to do is when you restore
an automated backup, or manual snapshot, it's
going to create a new instance, from that
create, for the created restored database,
okay. And so when you do make this new restored
RDS instance, it's going to have a new DNS
endpoint. And you are going to have to do
a little bit of manual labor here because
you're going to want to delete your old instance,
and then use this new endpoint for your applications.
Okay. So we're going to be looking at multi
AZ deployment. And this ensures your database
remains available if another AZ becomes unavailable.
So what it's going to do, it's going to make
an exact copy of the database in another availability
zone, and it is automatically going to synchronize
those changes from the primary database, the
master database over to the standby database.
Okay. So the thing about this standby is that
it is a slave database, it is not receiving
any real time traffic, it is just there's
a backup to take the place of the master database
in the case of the AZ goes down. So over here
we have automatic failover protection. So
if the AZ does go down, then failover will
occur, it's going to point there's like a
URL or address that that says that points
to the database. So it's going to point to
the slave and the slave is going to be promoted
to master and now it is your master database.
All right, so that's multi AZ going to take
a look at Reed replicas, and they allow you
to run multiple copies of your database. These
copies only allow reads, so you can't do writes
to them. And it's intended to alleviate the
workload of your primary database, also known
as your master database to improve performance.
Okay, so in order to use read replicas, you
must have automatic backups enabled. And in
order to create a replica, you're just dropping
down actions here and hitting create read
replica as easy as that. And it uses a synchronous
replication between your master and your read
replica. So you can have up to five replicas
of the database, each read replica will have
its own DNS endpoint. You can have multi AZ
replicas, cross region replicas, and even
replicas of replicas. replicas can be promoted
to their own database, but this will break
replication, which makes a lot of sense, and
no automatic failover. So if the primary copy
fails, you must manually update your roles
to point at copy.
So now it's time to compare multi AZ and read
replicas because it's very important to know
the difference between the two. So for replication,
multi AZ has synchronous replication and read
replicas have a synchronous replication for
what is actually active on multi AZ it's just
gonna be the primary instance. So the standby
doesn't do anything, it's just there. If the
primary the primary instance becomes unavailable,
then it becomes the primary instance where
read replicas the primary and all the replicas
are being utilized. Okay, we're going to have
autom automated backups are taken from the
standby word read replicas there are no backups
configured by default, multi AZ as the name
implies, will span to azs. within a single
region. replicas are within a single AZ but
they can be multi AZ cross az, or cross region.
Okay. When upgrades are occurring, it's going
to happen on the primary database for multi
AZ when upgrade upgrades. To create and read
replicas, it's going to be independent from
the source instance. And then lastly, we have
failover. So automatic failover will happen
to standby. And so for read replicas, you're
not going to have that automatic failover,
you're gonna have to manually promote a, one
of those replicas to become the standalone
data. Hey, it's Angie brown from exam Pro,
and we are looking at Amazon RDS. And so we
are going to create our own RDS database,
as well as an aurora database, as well as
looking how to migrate from RDS to Aurora.
And also maybe we'll look at some backup solutions
there and some of the other superflous features
that RDS supplies us. If you're wondering
how do you get to the console here, you go
the top here, type RDS, and click that and
you will end up in the same place as I am.
So let's get to it and create our first database.
Okay, and we're going to do that by going
on the left hand side here to databases, and
clicking Create database. So here we are in
the RDS creation interface. And the first
thing we're presented with is with crates,
standard crate and easy crate, I assume that
this would eliminate some options for us,
we're going to stick with standard, because
we want to have full control over what we're
doing here of the next thing is to choose
your engine. And so we're going to Aurora
later. And we're going to spin up a Postgres
database, which is very popular amongst Ruby
on Rails developers, which is my primary web
framework that I like to use, then under templates,
this is a more configuration for you that
allows you to get started very easily. So
if you leave this to production here, I want
to show you the cost because it's laughably
really inexpensive. It's $632, because it's
doing a bunch of stuff here is running more
than one AZ it's using a very large EC two
instance, and it has provisioned I Ops, okay.
And so for our use case, I don't think we
want to spend $632. But if you were like an
enterprise, it makes sense why they would
do that. But if you aren't paying attention,
that's very expensive. And there's obviously
the free tier, which is what we will want
to use here. But we will configure this so
that it will end up as free tier here. And
we will learn the options as we go through
it. So the first thing is we're going to have
to have a database, so we'll just keep our
database name as database one, then we need
to set a master password. So we will set it
as Postgres. And we'll see if we can get to
get away with that. Obviously, when you make
your real password, you'd use a password generator,
or let it auto generate one. So it's very
long in length. But I just want to be able
to work with this database very easily for
the purpose of you know, this, this follow
along, okay, then we have our DB instance
size. So for the DB instance size, you can
see it's set to standard classes m, I would
say the standard class is more like burstable,
which are t twos. And so this is what we're
used to when we're saving money. So we have
the T two micro if you are a very small startup,
you would probably be starting on T two micro
and do totally fine for you. So we're going
to change it to T two micro okay. And the
next thing is storage class. so here we can
choose I provisioned I ops. And so we have
faster, oh, I Ops, right, but we're gonna
go general here, because we don't need, we
don't need that crazy amount of I ops there.
And that's going to reduce storage, there
is this ability to do storage, auto scaling.
So this is kind of nice, where it dynamically
will scale your database to your needs. Um,
I think I will just leave that on, I don't
see why we wouldn't want to keep that on unless
there's additional cost to don't believe there
is. Then there's multi AZ and so that would
set up a nother database for us in another
availability zone in a standby, I don't think
we need that. So we're going to turn that
off. But just to show you how easy it is to
turn that on, then we're going to need to
choose our VPC, it's very important, whatever
web application you are deploying that your
your RDS databases in the same VPC or it's
going to be a bit of trouble trying to connect
to it. So we'll just leave that in the default
there. There's some additional
connectivity options here. And so we is a
subnet group. So we're gonna have to default,
we're, we're gonna ask whether we want this
to be publicly accessible. Generally, you're
not going to want a public IP address. But
if we want to interact with this database
very easily, I'm going to set it to Yes, for
the for the sake of this follow along, because
it would be nice to put some data into this
database, interact with it with table plus,
and then we'll go ahead and delete it. Okay.
Then down below, we have a VPC security group,
I'm thinking that it will probably create
one for us by default, so we'll leave it with
the default one, which is totally fine. We
can choose our preference for AZ I don't care,
we'll leave it by default. And then we have
the port number 5432, which is the standard
port number there. You might want to change
it just for the sake of security reasons.
Because if you change the port number then
people have to guess what it is. And there's
some additional configurations here. So what
we have is the initial database name, if you're
not specify when RDS does not create a database
Okay, so we probably want to name our database
here. So I'm just going to name the database
one here. You can also authenticate using
IMDb authentication. So if that is one way
you want to authenticate to your database,
that is definitely a really nice way of doing
that. So you might want to have that checkbox
on, then you have backups, okay, and so backups
are enabled automatically, and they're set
for seven days. If you want to turn backups,
which I definitely do, I'm gonna set it to
zero days, if we had left that on and created
our RDS instance, it would take forever to
create because immediately after it starts
up, it's going to then create a backup. And
that just takes a long time, you can set the
backup window here and select when you want
to have it run, there is the chance of interruptions
during a backup window. So you definitely
want to pick this one, it's it's not the most
important usage by your users, we can enable
performance insights, I'm pretty sure I thought
that was only accessible for certain classes
of database performance, advanced database
performance monitoring, and offers free tier
for seven days of rolling, okay, sure, we'll
turn it on. But at one point, you had to have
a higher tier to be able to use this, then
we have the retention period here for performance
insights, I guess it's seven days we'll leave
that there appear appears to be encrypted
by default. That seems like a good thing there.
There's an account, Id kind of ignore my kindly
ignore my account ID for this account. But
this is a burner account. So it's not like
you're going to be able to do anything with
that ID. We have enhanced monitoring, I don't
need that. So I'm going to turn that off,
that seems kind of expensive. We can export
our logs, that is a good thing to have. We
can have it so it automatically upgrades minor
versions, that is a very good thing to set,
you can also set the window for that, we can
turn on deletion protection, I'm not going
to have that on because I'm going to want
to delete this lickety split. And so there
we go. And so it says 1544. But I know that
this is free tier because it's using the T
to micro and so we get things so even though
it doesn't say it's free, I definitely know
it's free. But this gives you the true costs.
So after your feature would run out, this
is what it would cost about $15 per month
at the lowest tier, the lowest thing you can
get on on AWS for for your RDS instance. Okay,
so let's go ahead and create that database.
So I failed creating my database, because
it turns out database is a reserved word for
this engine. And that's totally fine. So we're
gonna have to scroll up here and change the
database name. And so I'm just going to change
it to Babylon five. And we're going to go
ahead and create that. And this time, we're
going to get our database. And so now we're
just waiting for our database to be created
here. And so we just saw the region AZ pop
into existence here, and it is currently being
created, you might have to hit refresh here
a few times. So we'll just wait a little bit
here until this status has changed. So our
database is available. And now we can actually
try to make a connection to it and maybe put
in some SQL and run a query. And so before
we can try to even make a connection, we need
to edit our security group, okay, because
we are going to need access via Port 5432
to connect to that instance there. So we'll
just edit our inbound rules. And we're going
to drop down and look for Postgres in here.
So there's 5432. And we're gonna set to only
rip because we don't want make this publicly
accessible. And we will hit save, okay. And
so now if we want to make connection, we should
have no trouble here. I'm just going to close
that tab, and we're going to have to collect
some information, you're going to need to
use a tool such as table Plus, if you are
on Mac or Windows, it's free to download and
install if you're on Linux, or you could use
B, I think it's called D Beaver. Okay, so
that's an open source
SQL tool here. And so I'm gonna just make
a new connection here. And we're just going
to choose Postgres, we're going to fill in
some information. So I called this Babylon
five. Okay, and that was the name of the database
as well, Babylon five. All right, and the
username was Postgres. And the very, not secure
password is, is Postgres as well, again, if
you are doing this for production, or any
case, you should really generate a very long
password there. And then we need the host,
the host is going to be this endpoint here,
okay. And the port is 5432 by default, so
I don't have to do anything special here.
I'm just gonna hit test and see if we connect.
Okay, and so it went green. So that is great.
I'm gonna hit save. So I can save myself some
trouble here. I will just double, double click
and make a connection. There's a bit of latency
here when you are connecting to RDS and just
running things. So if you don't see things
immediately, I just give it a little bit time
or hit the refresh here. But I already have
a SQL script prepared here. I'm just going
to show it to you. So this is a script and
what it does, actually should have been shouldn't
have been called the Babylon five database
because I'm mixing Star Trek with Babylon
five. Ridiculous, right? But this is a bunch
of starship classes from Star Trek and a bunch
of starships from Star Trek here. And I'm
going to run the script to get us some data
here. Okay, and so if we do it for table plus,
we're gonna go import from SQL dump. And I
have it on my desktop here called Starfleet
ship registry, I'm gonna hit open. Okay, I'm
going to import, I'm just going to run that
script and import us our data here into Postgres.
Now, if you're using a different database
type is MySQL, Oracle, I can't guarantee that
this will work. But it will definitely work
for Postgres, because SQL does vary based
on engines, okay, and so it says it's successfully
done, it even tells us to do a refresh here,
there is a nice refresh button up there that
you can click, and we're gonna wait for our
tables to appear. So there we are, we have
our ship classes. And we also have our starships.
Okay, I just want to run one query here to
make sure queries are working, I'm sure it's
gonna work. And we're gonna go over here,
and we're just going to get out, we're going
to want to pull all the starships that are
of ship class defiant. Okay, and we'll just
make a new query here and or run the old say,
run all Okay, and so there you go. So we're
getting data. So that's how you can connect
to your RDS database, you just have to open
up that that port number there, if you are
to connect this to your web application, what
you probably want to do for your security
group, is to just allow 5432 to the security
group of the web application. Okay, so here,
I gave my access to my IP, right. But you
know, you just have whatever your your security
group is, you know, here. So if you had one
for your EC two instances, your auto scaling,
auto scaling group that holds two instances,
you just put that in there. Alright. So now
that we have our database running, I figured
it'd be cool to go check out performance insights,
which I'm really excited about, because this
service used to be only available to a certain
expensive tier, so you had to pay, I don't
know, it was like, like a T to large before
you can utilize this. But now it looks like
AWS has brought it down all the way to the
T to micro. And it just gives you some rich
performance insights into your application
here. So here actually ran that query, it
actually shows me kind of the performance
over time. So this is really great to see
here. I bet if I was to perform another query,
it would repair so I could probably just run
the same one here. And we could just change
it to a different class. So we're just going
to go here and change it. Let's pick one at
random like this one here. Okay. And I'll
just run that there. And so I ran that query.
And I'm not sure how real time this is, because
I've actually never had a chance to use it
until now, because I just never, never wanted
to upgrade for that there. So it looks like
it does take a little bit of time for those
queries to appear. But I did run a query there.
So I bet it will come in, it probably is he
says fast past five minutes. So I'm going
to assume that it's at a five minute interval.
So if we waited five minutes, I'm sure this
query would show up there. But just nice to
know that you can get these kind of rich analytics
here, because normally, you'd have to pay
for data dog or some other third party service.
And now it's free with AWS. So I just want
to quickly show you that you can reserve instances
with RDS just like EC two, and you can start
saving money. So just go to the reserved instances
tab here
and go to purchase a reserved DB instances.
And we're going to have to wait a little bit
of time here for this to load, it's probably
because it's getting the most up to date information
about pricing. And so what we're going to
do is just go through this here and just kind
of get an idea of the difference in cost.
So we're going to drop down and choose Postgres
as our database, I always seem to have to
select that twice. Okay, but now I have Postgres
selected, we are using a T to micro Okay,
we are not doing multi AZ one term seems great
to me, we will first start with no upfront,
we only want one DB instance. And we'll look
at what we're getting. So here, it's going
to tell us what we're going to save. So it's
gonna say it's at 0.0 14 cents per hour. So
to compare this, I have the pricing up here.
So for a tea to micro, it is a point 00 18
there, okay? And so that's your savings there.
So if you just fiddle with this, you'll see
now it's 007, which is considerably cheaper,
and you have all up front and that can't be
right. So 000 I guess that would be the case
because you you've already paid for it. So
there'll be no hourly charge that makes total
sense. But now you have an idea of what that
cost is for the year. So for $111 your, your
your, your cost is totally covered for you.
And so if we wanted to actually calculate
the full cost here, we would just go here
and generally the number is between watching
grab the full full price here to get a comparison.
Where is our TT micro buddy here? Here it
is. So I always just do 730 times because
that's generally how many hours there are
in a month, seven 730 by that so that you
have basically a $14 charge. So you say 14
times 12. Okay. And so it's $168 for the year.
So if you're paying upfront for one year,
we are saving about 50 bucks. If we go on
for three years, we're saving more money,
I'm not gonna do the math on that, but you
get the idea. So just be aware those options
are available to us at the T to micro stage,
it's not a huge impact. But when you get to
these larger instances, you realize you definitely
want your savings. Okay, so yeah. So I'm going
to show you how to create a snapshot for your
database, it's pretty darn straightforward.
We're going to go into our database, go to
our maintenance and backups. If we had backups,
you know, they'll be turned on here. And so
just to take a snapshot, which is the manual
process of backing up, we can name our snapshot,
whatever he wants, like to say, first snapshot
there. Okay, and then we'll just press take
snapshot. And it's just going to go from into
creating state. And we're just going to now
wait for that snapshot to complete. So our
snapshot is now available to us. And so there's
a few things we can do with it. This only
took about seven minutes. I didn't wait that
long for the snapshot here. But if we go to
the top here to actions, there's a few things
we can do, we can restore our snapshots. So
that's the first thing we're going to look
at here. And so you're gonna be presented
with a bunch of options to pretty much spin
up a new RDS instance here. And so the reason
why you might want to do this is you have
a database, and you have outrun or outlived
the size that you're currently using. So if
you're using that T to micro, which is super
small here, we'll just use, we'll just show
t three micro here as an as an example. And
you wanted to increase the neck size, you
would do so. And you could also switch to
multi AZ change your storage type
here etc. And then you could restore it, which
will spin up a new RDS instance, okay. And
then you just kill your old one and move your
endpoints over to this one. Alright.
So that's one thing we can do here. With restoring
a snapshot, the other is migrating a snapshot,
okay. And so we'll look into that next here.
So just before we get onto a migrate snapshot,
let's take a look at copy and share. So copy
allows you to move your snapshot to another
region. So if you need to migrate your snapshot
somewhere else, this is how you're going to
go about doing that. And then you can also
enable encryption. So if you don't have encryption
enabled, this is a good opportunity for you
to encrypt your snapshots. So when you launch
an RDS instance, it will be encrypted. Okay,
just like an easy to instance. And so then
we have the ability to share. So now let's
say you wanted to make this snapshot available
to other people via other AWS accounts, where
you'd add their ID here. And so now they would
be able to reference that snapshot ID and
utilize it. Or you can also set it to public.
So that anyone, anyone could access the snapshot.
But you know, we're we're just going to leave
that alone, just so you are aware of those
two options. Now the one that is of most interest
is migrating. So this is how you're going
to create an aurora database, okay, so you
can just directly create an aurora database,
but if you wanted to migrate from your RDS,
Postgres to Aurora, Postgres, this is how
you're going to go about it. Okay, so we're
just going to choose, obviously, Aurora, Postgres,
because we're dealing with a Postgres database
here, that we have our engine version, okay.
So this is an opportunity where we could upgrade
our version, we're going to change our instance
class. Now, Aurora instances are a lot larger
than your normal RDS instances. So we're not
going to have a teaching micro here, you might
want to skip this step, because it is kind
of expensive, and you might forget about it.
So you don't want to leave this thing running.
So down below, I'm gonna just choose t to
medium because that is the least expensive
option I have here. And I'm just going to
end up doing this anyway. So it's not a big
deal. Then we can choose our VPC, we're going
to leave it to the default here, we can make
it publicly accessible. I'm gonna leave it
publicly accessible here, because I don't
care. Um, and yeah, so there you go. And we'll
just scroll down here, and we will migrate.
Okay. And so you might get a complaint here,
sometimes I get that. And so what I normally
do is I just go ahead and hit migrate again.
Okay. Let me just drop down the version, maybe
it won't let us do it for version 10.6. Okay,
and we'll hit migrate one more time. Funny,
as soon as you choose 10.7, you have to re
choose your instance class there. So I'll
go back to T two t three medium there and
now hit migrate. Okay, so now it's going to
go ahead and create that cluster there. So
it's going to go ahead and create that cluster.
You can see here, we had a two to previous
failed attempts there when I hit a save there,
so those will vanish. But we're just going
to wait a while for this to spin up. So our
migration has completed. And so our RDS instance
is now running on Aurora. So let's just take
a quick peek inside of here, it did take a
considerable amount of time, I think I was
waiting about like 20 minutes for this Aurora
instance to get up here. And so right away,
you're gonna see that we have a cluster. And
then we have the writer underneath.
We have
two endpoints, one for writing and one for
reading. And you can obviously create your
own custom endpoints here. But we're just
going to go back here and I just want to show
you that you can connect to this database.
So going back to table plus, we're going to
create a new connection and inherited all
the settings from our previous database. So
just grabbing the reader endpoint here, I'm
just going to paste in the host name. We called
the user was Postgres. The password was Postgres.
Not very secure password. By the way, the
database is called Babylon five. Okay, and
we'll just say this is our Aurora, Aurora,
Babylon five. babbie. Ilan five. I don't know
why having such a hard time spelling that
today. is okay. I think I spelt it wrong there.
Oh, okay. But anyway, let's just test our
connection to see here if it works definitely
have spelled something wrong here. Okay, there
we go. So it's the same the same credentials,
right, just the host has changed. And I can
obviously connect to that. And we will see,
we'll have read only access to our data there.
So yeah, it's the same process. Yeah, and
there you go. So just just to peek around
here, you can create additional readers. So
you know, so you have more read replicas,
we also have this option for activity stream,
which is for auditing all the activity. So
this might be for an enterprise requirement
there for you. But we're pretty much done
with this cluster here. So I'm just going
to go to databases here. And I'm just going
to terminate it here. And so when we want
to terminate that here, we have, we can go
down here and just delete, and we just type
in delete me. Okay, and that's going to take
out the whole thing here. Okay. So once this
is done here, we'll just have to hit refresh
there. And this will take a considerable long
time, see, it's deleting both, then this URL
will be gone here. So yeah, there you are.
So um, we created an RDS Postgres database,
we connected to it. We created, we migrated
it to Aurora. But I wanted to show you a little
bit more with Aurora. Because I don't feel
like we got to look at all the options here.
And we're only going to be able to see that
by creating a new instance here. So we're
going to stick with the standard create there,
we're going to have Amazon Aurora, we have
the option between MySQL and Postgres, we're
going to select Postgres, and which is going
to have on the version 10.7 there. And what
I really want to show you here is this database
feature setting. So we had this set here,
which had one writer and multiple readers.
And so you're continuously paying for
for
Aurora there, and it's very expensive. But
we have this option called serverless. And
serverless is a very inexpensive option. So
let's say we were building a web application,
and it was in development, so only some few
clients were using it, or it was only just
be using being used sporadically throughout
the month, not a lot of usage, then serverless
is going to be a very cost effective option
for us to use Aurora and also a way for us
to scale up to using Aurora when we need to
full time. Okay, so what I'm going to do is
just go and set up a serverless. Aurora database
here, we're going to have a call database
to we're going to also call it Postgres give
it that very weak password. And this is the
big thing here. So we have this capacity setting.
So this is only showing up because we have
serverless I'm pretty sure if we checkbox
that off, it doesn't appear. So now just we
just choose our DB instance size, okay, but
we're gonna go back up here and go to serverless.
And so the idea here is that we are choosing
I believe it's called ACU is the acronym for
this capacity in here, but we're gonna choose
our minimum and our maximum. So at our minimum,
we want to use two gigabytes of RAM and a
maximum we want that okay, and we have some
scaling options here, which we're going to
ignore, we're going to launch this in our
default VPC. And then he did they do have
a clear warning here. Once you create your
database, you cannot change your VPC selection.
But I mean, that's the case of these two instances
or whatever you can't you always have to create
a new one right? But I guess some people aren't
aware of that. We are going to leave these
alone here. There is this option here for
websites Data API. So this allows you to access
and run SQL via an HTTP endpoint. This is
extremely convenient way of accessing your,
your, your database here, and it's only available
here because we are using serverless. Okay.
And this is the same thing with like the Query
Builder. So if you're using the query builder,
query editor, which is called that there,
by having this enabled, then we can do both,
okay, and we can have a retention period,
I'm going to set it to one day, I wish I could
set it to zero. But with Aurora, you have
to have something set up, you can't have backups
turned off. And it's going to have encryption
by default. So you can see that it's really
making sure that we make all the smart decisions
here, and we have deletion protection, I'm
gonna turn that off, because I definitely
want to be able to delete this, and we're
gonna hit create database. Okay, so there
you go, we're going to just wait for that
to create, and then we're going to see how
we can use it with the query editor here,
maybe loaded up with some data, and etc. So
our service is now available to us. And so
let's go actually connect to it and play around
with our server. And in order to connect to
Aurora serverless is a little bit different,
because you have to be within the same VPC,
we're not going to be able to use table plus.
So in order to do or to connect to it, we're
gonna have to launch an EC two instance. But
to make things really easy, we're going to
use Cloud Nine, okay, because cloud nine is
a an ID that's backed by easy to instance,
it already has the MySQL client installed.
So it's going to make it really easy for us.
So what I want you to do is go to services
here and type in cloud nine. And we will make
our way over to the cloud nine console here.
And we'll create ourselves a new environment.
And so I'm just going to call this MySQL,
Aurora serverless, okay, because that's all
we're gonna use this for. Okay. And we're
gonna hit next step. And we're going to create
a new EC two instance, we're gonna leave it
at T two micro, the smallest instance there,
we're going to launch it with Amazon Linux,
it's going to shut down automatically after
30 minutes. So that's great for us. And we'll
go ahead and hit next step. Okay, and then
we will create that environment. And now we
just have to wait for that ID to spin up here.
Okay. So it shouldn't take too long. just
takes a few minutes. All right. So our cloud
nine environment here is ready here. And down
below, we have our environment. And so I can
type MySQL, okay. And you can see that the
client is installed, but we didn't actually
specify any information. So there's no way
it's going to connect anything here. But let's
go ahead and let's go to our RDS because we
need to prepare this so we can actually make
a connection here for cloud nine. So let's
go into the database here and grab this endpoint
here. And I've actually prepped a little follow
over here with the stuff that we need. So
we're gonna need to prepare this command.
But before we even do this, okay, we are going
to need to update our security group, okay,
because we're going to need to grant access
to the security group of that EC, or that
cloud nine environment. So also, on the right
hand side, we'll open our left hand side,
we'll open up school groups, again here. And
we're going to look for this, this person's
or this a cloud environment. So we have one,
here, it's this one up here. Okay, and so
I just need this, the actual name, the group
ID of the security group. And we'll go back
to our serverless, or our service security
group here, and we're going to edit it here,
this looks like it's using the default one,
which is kind of a mess, we shouldn't be using
this one. But I'm going to go ahead here and
just remove those, and we'll drop down and
choose MySQL, MySQL, Aurora, if I can find
it in here. There it is. Okay, and we'll just
paste that in there. And so that is going
to allow the cloud nine environment to connect
to, or have permission to connect to the Aurora
serverless there. So going back to our environment,
now we're ready to try out that line. So here
is our line here. And so we're just going
to copy that whole thing in there and paste
it in. Okay, it's gonna prompt for password,
and we made it password 123. And there we
are. So we're connected to our database there.
And so if we wanted to create whatever we
want, it would just be as we were doing with
Postgres there. So there you go. That's, that's
how you create a Aurora serverless database.
And that's how you would go about connecting
to it. So now it's just time to do a bit of
cleanup here. So we are not incurring any
costs. Now, Aurora serverless, doesn't cost
any money while it's running. So it's not
going to cost you anything. I did terminate
these other instances earlier on. So you just
have to go to the top here and hit Delete.
And we don't want to create a final snapshot
and we will delete that cluster. The other
thing that we need to consider deleting is
this cloud nine environment again, it will
automatically shut down after 30 minutes.
So it's not going to cost you things the long
term but you know just to keep it out of your
account. You can go ahead here and delete.
You can see I was attempting An earlier one
here with Aurora serverless Postgres that
didn't work and I messed up the cloudformation
templates, I can't get rid of that one, but
this one will delete here and that's all I
got to do to clean up for this section of
the RDS cheat sheet and this one is a two
pager. So RDS is a relational database service
and its AWS solution for relational databases.
Artists instances are managed by AWS so you
cannot SSH into the VM running the database.
There are six relational database options
currently available. So we have Aurora, MySQL,
Marya dB, Postgres, Oracle and Microsoft SQL
Server. Multi AZ is an option you can turn
on which makes an exact copy of a database
and another AZ that that is only a standby
for multi AZ it is automatically synchronizes
changes in the database over to the standby
copy. Multi AZ has automatic failover protection
so if one AZ goes down, failover will occur
and the standby slave will be promoted to
master. Then we have read replicas replicas
allow you to run multiple copies of your database.
These copies only allow reads and no writes
and is intended to alleviate the workload
of your primary database to improve performance.
replicas use a synchronous replication, you
must have automatic backups enabled to use
read replicas. You can have up to five read
replicas you can combine read replicas. With
multi AZ you can have read replicas in another
region. So we have cross region read replicas,
read replicas can be promoted to their own
database. But this breaks replication. You
can have read replicas of read replicas, RDS
has two backup solutions. We have automated
backups and database snapshots to be manual
snapshots. But it means the same thing. So
automated backups, you choose a retention
period between one and 35 days, there is no
additional cost for backup storage, you define
your backup window, then you have manual snapshots.
So you might you manually create backup backups.
If you delete your primary, the manual snapshots
will still exist, and you can they can be
restored. When you restore an instance it
will create a new database, you just need
to delete your old database and point traffic
to the new restore database. And you can turn
on encryption at rest for RDS via kms. So
there you go. That's
it. This is Angie brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at Aurora which is a fully
managed Postgres or MySQL compatible database,
designed by default to scale and is fine tuned
to be really really, really fast. Looking
more here at Aurora, it combines the speed
and availability of a high end database with
the simplicity and cost effectiveness of an
open source database. So Aurora can either
run on MySQL or Postgres compatible engines.
And the advantage of using Aurora over just
a standard RDS, Postgres or MySQL engine,
is the fact that it's fine tuned to be super
for performance. So if you're using MySQL,
it's five times faster than your traditional
MySQL. And the Postgres version is three times
more performant than the traditional Postgres.
And the big benefit is the cost. So it's 1/10
10th the cost of other solutions offering
similar performance and availability.
So let's talk about Aurora scaling, which
is one of its managed features. So it starts
with 10 gigabytes of storage initially, and
can scale in 10 gigabyte increments all the
way up to 64 terabytes, so you have a lot
of room for growth here. And storage is auto
scaling. So just happens automatically. for
computing power computing, resources can scale
all the way up to 32 VPC use, and up to 244
gigabytes of memory.
Let's take a look at aurors availability and
you can see that it's extremely available
because it runs six copies of your data across
three availability, availability zones, with
two in each single AZ Okay, so if you were
to lose two copies of your data, it would
not affect right availability. If you were
to lose three copies of your data, it would
not affect read availability. So this thing
is super super bomb. Now looking at fault
tolerance and durability for Aurora backups
and failover are handled automatically if
you wanted to share your data to another Eva's
account snapshots can be shared. It also comes
with self healing for your storage so data
blocks and disk are continuously scan for
errors and repaired automatically. Looking
at replication for Aurora There are two types
of replicas available we have Amazon or more
replicas in MySQL read replicas knows for
MySQL we can only have up to five for performance
impact on primary is high. It does not have
auto Automatic failover However, it does have
support for user defined replication delay,
or for different data or schema versus primary.
So you have to decide for yourself, which
one makes more sense for you. But just for
exams, you might need to know there's two
different types. If for whatever reason they
had you looked into Aurora pricing, you'd
find out, it's really expensive if you aren't
using it for high production applications.
So if you're a hobbyist, like me, and you
still want to use Aurora, Aurora has Aurora
serverless, which is just another mode that
it runs in. And the advantage here is that
it only runs when you need it to and it can
scale up and down based on your applications
needs. And so when you set serverless, in
the database features, you're going to have
this capacity settings, so you can set the
minimum and maximum capacity for a work capacity
units, also abbreviated as ACU. And so here
it's between two and 384 ac use. And that's
what it's going to charge you based on only
when it's consumed. So when would you want
to use a word serverless, what's really good
for low volume blog sites, maybe a chatbot.
Maybe you've built an MVP that you are demoing
out to clients, so it's not used very often,
but you plan on using your word down the road.
So that's the use case for Aurora. It works
with both MySQL and Postgres. For over a year,
Postgres wasn't there, but now it is here.
There are some limitations on the versions
of Postgres and MySQL are bicycles, you can
use it, it used to be only MySQL 5.6. But
last time I checked, I saw 5.6 and 5.7. For
my school. And for Postgres, I saw a lot of
versions. So there is a lot of flexibility
there for you. But there are some limitations
around that. There's also other things that
it can't do that Aurora can do. But it's a
big long list. I'm not going to listen here,
but I just want you to know, the utility of
Aurora thermal. We've finished the raw section
and now on to the raw cheat sheet where we're
going to summarize everything that we've learned.
So when you need a fully managed Postgres
or MySQL database that needs to scale, have
automatic backups, high availability, and
fault tolerance. Think Aurora, Aurora can
run on my skull or Postgres database engines.
Aurora, MySQL is five times faster over regular
MySQL, and Aurora, Postgres is three times
faster over regular Postgres. Aurora is 1/10.
The cost over its competitors with similar
performance availability options, over replicate
six copies of your database across three eyzies.
Aurora is allowed up to 15 Aurora replicas
on Aurora database can span multiple regions
via Aurora global database. Aurora serverless,
allows you to stop start Aurora and scale
automatically while keeping costs low. And
the ideal use case for serverless is for new
projects or projects with infrequent database
usage. So there you go. That's everything
you need to know about.
We are looking at Amazon redshift, which is
a fully managed petabyte size data warehouse.
So what we use a data warehouse for we would
use it to analyze massive amounts of data
via complex SQL queries. Amazon redshift is
a columnar store database. So to really understand
what redshift is, we need to understand what
a data warehouse is to understand what a data
warehouse is, it's good to compare it against
a database and understand this, we need to
set some foundational knowledge and understand
what a database transaction is. So let's define
a database transaction. A transaction symbolizes
a unit of work performed within a database
management system. So an example of a transaction
or reads and writes that's as simple as that.
And for database and data warehouse, they're
going to treat transactions differently. And
so for a database, which we have an online
transactional processing system and OLTP,
the the transactions are going to be short.
So look at the bottom here, we say short transaction.
So that means small and simple queries with
an emphasis on writes. Okay, so why would
we want short transactions? Well, for OLTP?
Well, a database was built to store current
transactions, and enables fast access to specific
transactions for ongoing business processes.
So they're just talking about I have a web
app. And we need to be very responsive for
the current user for reads and writes. Okay,
and so that could be adding an item to your
shopping list. That could be sign up that
could be doing any sorts of thing in a web
application. And generally, these are backed
by a single source. So a single source would
be Postgres on could be running on RDS. And
so that's the idea behind a database. So if
we go over to the data warehouse side, it
runs on an online analytical processing system,
an OLAP. And all apps are all about long transaction
so long and complex SQL queries with an emphasis
on reads. So a data warehouse is built to
store large quantities of historical data.
and enable fast and complicated complex queries
across all data. So the utility here is business
intelligence tools generating reports. And
a data warehouse isn't a single source it
is it takes data from multiple sources. So
dynamodb, EMR, s3, Postgres all over the place,
data is coming into one place so that we can
run complex queries, and not too frequently.
So now that we know what a data warehouse
warehouse is, let's talk about the reasons
why you'd want to use redshift. So redshift
the Pricing starts at 25 cents per hour with
no upfront costs or commitments. It scales
up to petabytes, petabytes of data for $1,000
per terabyte per year. redshift is price less
than 1/10. The cost of most similar services
redshift is used for business intelligence
redshift uses OLAP redshift is a columnar
store database. It was the second time we've
mentioned this. And we really need to understand
what a column or storage database is to really
understand the power behind redshift and data
warehouses. So columnar storage for database
is database tables is an important factor
in optimizing an analytic query performance
because it drastically reduces the overall
disk IO requirements and reduces the amount
of data you need to load from the disk. So
columnar storage is the reason why redshift
is so darn fast. And we're going to look at
that in more detail here. So let's really
cement our knowledge with redshift and show
a use case example. So here I have, I want
to build my own business intelligence tool.
And I have a bunch of different sources. So
I have data coming from EMR, I have data coming
from s3, I have data coming from dynamodb.
And I'm going to copy that data however I
want. There's a copy command, I'm going to
copy that data into redshift. Okay, so but
once that data is in there, you say, Well,
how do I interact and access redshift data?
Normally, you know, most services use the
ABS SDK. But this case, we're not using native
SDK, because we just may need to make a generic
SQL connection to redshift. And so if we were
using Java, and generally you probably will
be using Java, if you're using redshift, you'd
be using j JDBC, or ODBC, which are third
party libraries to connect and query redshift
data. So, you know, I said columnar storage
is very important to redshifts performance.
And so let's conceptually understand what
that means. So what would we normally use
with a database would be reading via the rows,
whereas an in an OLAP, or reading versus columns,
because if we're going to be looking at a
lot of data and crunching it, we it's better
to look at it at columns, okay. Because that
way, if we're reading columns, that allows
us to store that data as the same database
datatype for allow for easy compression, that
means that we're going to be able to load
data a lot quicker. And because we're always
looking at massive amounts of data, at the
same time, we can pull in only the columns
that we need in bulk, okay,
and so that's gonna give us much faster performance
for our use case, which is like business intelligence
tools. So redshift configuration, you can
set it up in two different cluster types.
So you have single node, which is a great
way to get started on redshift, if you don't
have a lot of money you want to play around,
you can just launch a single node of 160 gigabytes,
or you can launch an multimo, multi node.
And so when you launch a multi node, you always
have a leader node, and then you have compute
nodes. And you can add up to 128 compute nodes,
so you have a lot of computing power behind
you. Now, I just want to point out that when
you do spin up redshift and multi node, you're
gonna see there's a maximum set of 32. And
I just said, there's 128. So what's going
on here? Well, it's just one of those same
defaults, where AWS wants to be really sure
that you want more than 32. Because you know,
if you come in day one, someone had 128, they
want to make sure that they have the money
to pay for it. So if you need more than 32
nodes, you just have to go ask a request for
a certain service limit increase. Now besides
there being different cluster types, there's
also different node types. And so we have
two that are labeled here we have DC dense
compute and dense storage DS, okay. And they
are as what they say they are one is optimized
for computing power, and one is optimized
for storage. So you know, depending on your
use case, you're going to choose what type
of node you want. Notice that there are no
smalls or micros, we all we only start at
large here. Because if you're doing redshift,
you're working with large amounts of data.
So you know, that makes total sense. compression
is something that is the most important thing
in terms of speed. So redshift uses multiple
compression techniques to achieve a significant
compression. Relative to traditional relational
data stores. Similar data is stored sequentially
on disk. It does not require indexes or materialized
views, which saves a lot of space compared
to traditional systems when loading data to
An empty table data is sampled. And the most
appropriate compression scheme is selected
automatically. So this is all great information
for the exam, you know, it's not so important
remember this. So you know what redshift is,
is utilized for these Nitty gritties at F
or the associate is not so, important. redshift
processing. So, redshift uses massively parallel
processing, which they aggrandize or initializes
MPP, it automatically distributes data and
query loads across all nodes, and lets you
easily add new nodes to your data warehouse
while still maintaining fast query performance.
So yeah, it's easy to add more compute power
on demand. Okay, and so we got redshift backups
of backups are enabled by default, with a
one day retention period, and retention periods
can be modified up to 35 days. All right.
redshift always attempts to maintain at least
three copies of your data. One is the original
copy. The second is a replica on the compute
nodes. And then the third is a backup copy
of s3. And so redshift also could asynchronously
replicate your snapshots to s3 in a different
region. So you know, if you need to move your
data region per region, you have that option
as well. For redshift billing, the compute
node hours, the total number of hours ran
across all nodes in the billing period, build
one unit per node per hour, and you're not
charged for the leader nodes per hour. So
when you spin up a cluster, and you only have
one compute node, and one one leader node,
you're just paying for the compute node. For
backups, backups are stored on s3 and you're
billed the s3 storage fees, right. So you
know, just same same thing as usual. And data
data transfer build only only transfers within
a VPC not outside up outside of it. Okay.
redshift security. So we have data in transit
encrypt using SSL data rest, we can encrypt
using a Aes 256 encryption. database encryption
can be applied using kms. Or you can use Cloud
HSM and here you can see it's just as easy
as applying it. redshift availability. So
redshift is single AZ super important to remember
this because a lot of services are multi AZ
but redshift is not one of them maybe in the
future, but maybe not. To run in multi AZ
you would have to run multiple redshift clusters
in a different AZ with with same inputs. So
you're basically just running a clone, it's
all manual labor, right? So there's no managed
automatic way of doing multi AZ snapshots
can be restored to a different AZ in the event
of an outage occurs. And just to wrap everything
up, we have a really good redshift cheat sheet
here definitely recommend you print this out
for your exam. And we're going to go through
everything again. So data can be loaded from
s3 EMR. dynamodb, or multiple data sources
on remote hosts. redshift is columns columnar
store database, which can give you SQL like
queries and is an is an OLAP. redshift can
handle petabytes worth of data redshift is
for data warehousing. redshifts most common
use cases business intelligence redshift can
only run in one AZ so it's a sink, it's single
AZ it's not multi AZ redshift can run via
a single node or multi node for clusters.
A single node is 150 gigabytes in size. A
multi node is comprised of the leader node
and multiple compute nodes. You are billed
per hour for each node excluding the leader
node in multi node, you're not billed for
the leader node. just repeating that again
there, you can have up to 128 compute nodes.
Again, I said earlier that the maximum by
default was 32. But they're not going to ask
you what the default is. redshift has two
kinds of node types dense compute and dense
storage. And it should be pretty obvious when
you should use one or the other redshift attempts
to back backup your data three times the original
on the compute node on a three similar data
is stored on a disk sequentially for faster
reads. Read of data database can be encrypted
via kms, or cloud HSM backup retention is
default to one day and can be increased to
a maximum of 35 days. redshift can asynchronously
backup to your snaps to your backup via snapshot
to another region delivered via s3. And redshift
uses massively parallel processing to distribute
queries and data across all loads. And in
the case of an empty empty table when importing
redshift will sample the data to create a
schema. So there you go. That's redshift in
a nutshell, and that should help you for the
exams.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at Dynamo DB which is a key
value and document database, a no SQL database
which can guarantee consistent reading rights
at any scale. So let's just double check a
couple things before we jump into Dynamo dB.
So what is a no SQL database? Well today It
is neither relational and does not use SQL
to query the data for results, hence the no
SQL part, no SQL databases, the method of
how they store data is different. dynamodb
does both key value store and document store.
So key value stores when you simply have a
key, and a value and nothing more. And then
document store is where you have structured
data, right? So this whole thing here would
be a single value in the database. So again,
dynamodb is a no SQL key value and document
database for internet skills applications.
It has a lot of functionality behind it is
fully managed multi region. Multi master durable,
is a durable database, built in security,
Backup and Restore. And in memory caching.
The big takeaway why you'd want to use dynamodb
is that you just say what you need, you say
I need 100 reads per second, or 100 writes
per second, and you're guaranteed to get that
it's just based on what you're willing to
pay. Okay, so scaling is not an issue here,
it's just do you want to pay that amount for
whatever capacity you need. So when we're
talking about durability, dynamodb does store
its data across three regions. And we definitely
have fast reads and writes because it's using
SSD drives. So that's the level of durability.
And the next thing we're going to look into
is the consistency because it replicates data
across different regions, you could be reading
a copies of data, and we might run into inconsistency.
So we need to talk about those caveats.
So I just wanted to touch on table structure
here. Because Dynamo DB does use different
terminologies instead of what a relational
database uses. So instead of a roll, they
call it an item instead of a column or a cell
or whatever you want to call it, they just
call it an attribute. And then the other most
important thing is the primary key which is
made up with a with a partition key and a
sort key. And that's all you need to know
for the solution architect associate for the
other certifications, we have to really know
this stuff. But this is all we need to know
for this case.
So consistency is something that's a very
important concept when we're dealing with
dynamodb. Because when data is written to
the database, it has to then copy it to those
other regions. And so if someone was reading
from region C, when an update was occurring
there is that there's that chance that you're
reading it before it has the opportunity to
write it. Okay. And so dynamodb gives us a
couple options to give us choices on our use
case. And we'll go through the two. And so
the first one is eventual consistent reads,
which is the default functionality. And the
idea here is when copies are being updated,
it is possible for you to read and be returned
inconsistent copy, okay. But the trade off
here is the reads are fast, but there's no
guarantee of consistency, all copies of data,
eventually will become generally consistent
within a second. Okay, so the here that the
trade off is that you know, you could be reading
it before it's updated. But generally it will
be up to date. So you have to decide whether
that's the trade off you want. That's default
option. The other one is strongly consistent
reads, okay, and this is one all copies are
being updated and you attempt to read it,
it will not return a result until all copies
are consistent, you have a guarantee of consistency.
But the trade off is higher latency, so slower
reads, but that the reads are going to be
as slow as a second because all copies of
data will be consistent within a second. So
if you can wait up to a second in the case
of a right, then that's what you'll have to
do. for eventual consistent reads. If you
can tolerate something being consistent because
it's not important, then those are your two
options. So we're on to the dynamodb cheat
sheet. If you are studying for the developer
associate this would be two pages long but
since this is for the solution architect associate
it this is a lot shorter. Okay, so dynamodb
is a fully managed no SQL key value and document
database. applications that contain large
amounts of data but require predictable read
and write performance while scaling is a good
fit for dynamodb dynamodb scales with whatever
read and write capacity you specify per second
dynamodb can be set to have eventually consistent
reads which is the default option and strongly
consistent reads, eventually consistent reads,
data is returned immediately, but data can
be inconsistent copies of data will be generally
consistent within one second. Strongly consistent
reads will wait until data is consistent data
will never be inconsistent, but latency will
be higher, only up to a second though. Copies
of data will be consistent within within a
guarantee of one second or at you know exactly
one second dynamodb stores three copies of
data on SSD drives across three regions. And
there you go, that's all you need. Hey, this
is Andrew Brown. And we are looking at Eva's
cloud formation, which is a templating language
that defines AWS resources to be provisioned,
or automating the creation of resources via
code. And all these concepts are called infrastructure
as code which we will cover again in just
a moment here. So to understand cloud formation,
we need to understand infrastructure as code
because that is what cloudformation is. So
let's reiterate over what infrastructure is
code is. So it's the process of managing and
provision computer data centers. So in our
case, it's AWS, through machine readable definition
files. And so in this case, it's cloudformation,
template YAML, or JSON files, rather than
the physical hardware configuration or interactive
configuration tools. So the idea is to stop
doing things manually, right. So if you launch
resources in AWS, you're used to configuring
in the console all those resources, but through
a scripting language, we can automate that
process. So now let's think about what is
the use case for cloud formation. And so here,
I have an example, where let's pretend that
we have our own minecraft server business,
and people sign up on our website and pay
a monthly subscription, and we will run that
server for them. So the first thing they're
going to do is they're gonna tell us where
they want the server to run. So they have
low latency and what size of servers so the
larger the server, the more performant the
server will be. And so they give us those
two inputs. And then we somehow send that
to a lambda function, and that lambda function
triggers to launch a new cloudformation stack
using our cloud formation template, which
defines, you know, how to launch that server,
that easy to instance, running Minecraft and
a security group and what region and what
size. And when it's finished creating, we
can monitor maybe using cloud watch events
that it's done, and using the outputs from
that cloud formation stack, send the IP address
of the new minecraft server to the user, so
they can log in and start using their servers.
So that's way of automating our infrastructure.
So we're gonna look at what a cloudformation
template looks like. And this is actually
one we're going to use later on to show you
how to launch a very simple Apache server.
But cloudformation comes in two variations.
It comes in JSON, and YAML. So why is there
two different formats? Well, JSON just came
first. And YAML is is an intent based language,
which is just more concise. So it's literally
the same thing, except it's in that base.
So we don't have to do all these curlies.
And so you end up with something that is,
in length, half the size. Most people prefer
to write YAML files, but there are edge cases
where you might want to use JSON. But just
be aware of these two different formats. And
it doesn't matter which one you use, just
use what works best for you. Now we're looking
at the anatomy of a cloud formation template.
And so these are made up of a bunch of different
sections. And here are all the sections listed
out here. And we'll work our way from top
to bottom. And so the first one is metadata.
So that allows you to provide additional information
about the template, I don't have one of the
example here and I rarely ever use metadata.
But you know, it's just about additional information,
then you have the description. So that is
just describing what you want this template
to do. And you can write whatever you want
here. And so I described this template to
launch new students, it's running Apache,
and it's hard coded work for us East one,
then you have parameters and parameters is
something you can use a lot, which is you
defining what inputs are allowed to be passed
within to this template at runtime. So one
thing we want to ask the user is what size
of instance type Do you want to use, it's
defaulted to micro, but they can choose between
micro and nano. Okay, so we can have as many
parameters as we want, which we'll use throughout
our template to reference, then you have mappings,
which is like a lookup table, it maps keys
to values, so you can change your values to
something else. A good example of this would
be, let's say, you have a region. And for
each region, the image ID string is different.
So you'd have the region keys mapped to different
image IDs based on the region. So that's a
very common use for mappings. Then you'd have
conditions these are like your FL statements
within your template don't have an examples
here. But that's all you need to know. Transform
is very difficult to explain, if you don't
know macros are but the idea it's like applying
a mod to the actual template. And it will
actually change what you're allowed to use
in the template. So if I define a transform
template, the rules here could be wildly different,
different based on what kind of extra functionality
that transform adds. We see that with Sam,
the serverless application model is a transform.
So if you ever take a look at that you'll
have a better understanding of what I'm talking
about there. Then you have resources which
is the main show to the whole template. These
are the actual resources you are defining
that will be provisioned. So think any kind
of resource I enroll etc. instance lamda RDS
anything, right? And then you have outputs
and outputs is, it's just what you want to
see as the end results. So like, when I create
the server, it's we don't know the IP address
is until it spins it up. And so I'm saying
down here, get me the public IP address. And
then in the console, we can see that IP address,
so that we don't have to, like look at the
PC to console pull it out. The other advantage
of outputs is that you can pass information
on to other cloudformation templates or created
like a chain of effects because we have these
outputs. But the number one thing you need
to remember is what makes a valid template.
And there's only one thing that is required,
and that is specifying at least one resource.
All these other fields are optional, but resource
is mandatory, and you have to have at least
one resource. So if you're looking for cloudformation
templates to learn by example, Ava's quickstarts
is a great place to do it, because they have
a variety of different categories, where we
have templates that are pre built by AWS partners
and the APN. And they actually usually show
the architectural diagram, but the idea is
you launch the template, you don't even have
to run it, you can just press a button here
and then actually see the raw template. And
that's going to help you understand how to
connect all this stuff together. Because if
you go through the ages documentation, you're
going to have to spend a lot of time figuring
that out where this might speed that up if
this is your interest. So I just wanted to
point that out for you. It's not really important
for the exam, it's not going to come up as
an exam question. It's just a learning resource
that I want you to
consider.
We're on to the cloudformation cheat sheet,
please consider that this is specific for
the solution architect associate. Whereas
for the SIS ops associate, this would be a
much longer cheat sheet because you have to
know it more in detail. I did add a few additional
things we did not cover in the core content
just in case they do creep up on the exam.
I don't think they will, but I threw them
in there just in case. And so let's get through
this list. So when being asked to automate
the provisioning of resources, think cloudformation.
When infrastructure as code is mentioned,
think cloud formation. cloudformation can
be written in either JSON or YAML. When cloudformation
encounters an error, it will roll back with
rollback and progress again, might not show
up an example, I'm putting it in their cloudformation
templates larger than half a megabyte, arc
too large. In that case, you'd have to upload
from s3. So the most important thing is you
can upload templates directly or you can provide
a link to an object in an s3 bucket. Okay,
nested stacks help you break up cloudformation
templates into smaller reusable templates
that can be composed into larger templates.
At least one resource under Resources must
be defined for a cloudformation template to
be valid. And then we talk about all the sections.
So we have metadata that's for extra information
about your template description that describes
what your template should do parameters how
you get users inputs into the template, transforms
and applies macros, outputs, these are values
you can use to important to other stacks.
So it's just output variables. mappings is
like a lookup table. So it maps keys to values
resources, define the resources you want to
provision. And again, I repeat it, at least
one resources required. All these other sections
are optional, and conditions, which these
are like your FL statements within your cloudformation
templates. So there you go. We're all done
with cloudformation. Hey, this is Andrew Brown
from exam Pro. And we are looking at cloudwatch,
which is a collection of monitoring services
for logging, reacting and visualizing log
data. So I just want you to know that cloud
watch is not just one service, it's multiple
services under one name. So we have cloudwatch,
logs, cloudwatch metrics, cloud watch events,
cloud watch alarms, and cloud watch dashboards,
I'm not going to go through the list here,
because we're going to cover each section
and then we'll cover it in the cheat sheet.
But just so you know, the most important thing
to know is that their cloud watch is not a
single service, it's multiple services. So
it's time to look at cloudwatch logs, which
is the core service of cloud watch. All the
other cloud services are built on top of this
one. And it is used to monitor store and access
your log file. So here we have a log file.
And logs belong within a log group that cannot
exist outside of the Law Group. So here I
have one called production dot log, which
is a Ruby on Rails application. And it contains
multiple log files over a given period of
time, and this is inside of those log files.
And we have the ability to like filter that
information and do other things with it. So
log files are stored indefinitely by default,
and they never expire. Okay, so you don't
ever have to worry about losing this data.
And most Eva's services are integrated cloudwatch
logs by default. Now there are some cases
where there's actually multiple cases where
you have to turn on cloud watch logs, or you
have to add Iam permissions. So like when
you're creating a lambda function, the default
permissions allow you to write to logs. But
the thing is, you wouldn't normally realize
that you're enabling it. So anyway, that's
cloud watch. So now we're going to take a
look at cloudwatch metrics, which is built
on top of logs. And the idea behind this is
it represents a time ordered set of data points,
or you can think of it as a variable to monitor
so within the logs, we'll have that data and
extracts it out as data points, and then we
can graph it, right. So in this case, I'm
showing you for an EC two instance. So you
have some network in coming into that EC two
instance. And you can choose that specific
metric, and then get a visual of it. So that
is cloudwatch metrics. Now, these metrics
are predefined for you. So you don't have
to do anything. to leverage this, you just
have to have logs enabled on specific services.
And these metrics will become available when
data arrives. Okay.
So now we're going to take a look at cloudwatch
events, which builds off of metrics and logs
to allow you to react to your data and and
take an action on that, right. So we can specify
an event source based on an event pattern
or a schedule, and that's going to then trigger
to do something in a target, okay. And a very
good use case for this would be to schedule
something that you'd normally do on a cron
tab. So maybe you need to backup a server
once a day. So you trigger that, and then
there's probably like, EBS snapshot in here.
But you know, that's the idea behind it here.
Okay, so you can either trigger based on a
pattern or a timeframe. And it has a lot of
different inputs here, it's not even worth
going through them all. But EBS snapshot,
and lambda are the most common. So we're looking
at cloudwatch metrics, and we had a bunch
of predefined ones that came for us. But let's
say we wanted to make our own custom metric,
well, we can do that. And all we have to do
is by using the avsc ally, the command line
interface, or the SDK, software development
kit, we can programmatically send data for
custom metrics. So here I have a custom metric
for the enterprise D, which is namespace and
Starfleet. And we're collecting dimensions
such as hole integrity, shields and thrusters.
Okay, so we can send any kind of data that
we want on and publish that to cloudwatch
metrics. Now another cool feature about custom
metrics is that it opens the opportunity for
us to have high resolution metrics, which
can only be done through custom metrics. So
if you want data, a lot like edit even more
granular level of blow one minute, with high
resolution metrics, you can go down to one
second, and we have these intervals, you can
do it one second, five, second, 10, second,
30 seconds. But generally, you know, if you
can turn it on, you're probably gonna want
to go as low as possible. The higher the frequency,
the more it's going to cost you. So do have
that in consideration. But the only way to
get high resolution metrics is through a custom
metric. So now we're taking a look at cloudwatch
alarms, which triggers a notification based
on a metric when it is breached based on a
defined threshold. Very common use case is
building alarms. It's like one of the first
things you want to do when you set up your
AWS account. And so here we have some options
when we go set our alarm. So we can say whether
it's static, or its anomaly, what is the condition?
So does it trigger this question, when it's
greater than equal then lower than etc? And
what's the amount so you know, my account,
I'm watching for $1,000, if it's under $1,000,
I don't care. And if it goes over, please
send me an email about it. And that is the
utility there. So there you go. cloudwatch
alert. So now it's time to look at Cloud watch
dashboards, which, as the name implies, allows
you to create dashboards. And this is based
off of cloudwatch metrics. So here, we have
a dashboard in front of it. And we add widgets.
And we have all sorts of kinds here, graphs,
bar charts, and etc. And you drag them on
you pick your options, and then you have to
just make sure you hit that Save button. And
there you go. So it's really not that complicated.
Just when you need a visualization of your
data. You know, think about using cloud watch.
So I just wanted to quickly touch on availability
of data, and how often cloudwatch updates
the metrics that are available to you because
it varies on service and the one we really
need to know is these two because it does
creep been to a few exam questions. So by
default, when you're using EC two, it monitors
at a five minute, minute interval. And if
you want to get down to one minute, you have
to turn on detailed monitoring, which costs
money, okay? For all other services, it's
going to be between one minute to three minute
to five minute, there might be a few other
services that have detailed monitoring, I
feel like the elastic cache might have it.
But generally, all you have to worry about
is for EC to the majority of services are
by default one minute. So that's why I just
had to really emphasize this because you see,
two does not default to one minute, it's five
minutes. And to get that one minute, you have
to turn on detailed monitoring. I just want
to make you aware that cloudwatch doesn't
track everything you'd normally think it would
track for an easy to incidence. And specifically,
if you wanted to know like your memory utilization,
or how much disk space was left on your server,
it does not track that by default. Because
those are host level metrics. Those
are more in detailed metrics. And in order
to gather that information, you need to install
the cloud watch agent and the cloud watch
agent is a script, which can be installed
via SYSTEMS MANAGER run command, it probably
comes pre installed on Amazon, Linux one and
Amazon x two. And so you know, if you need
those more detailed metrics, such as memory
and disk space, you're gonna have to install
that. But these ones you already have by default,
so there is disk usage, there is network usage
and CPU usage. The disk usage here is limited.
I camera what they are the top my head, but
it's not like disk space, like, am I 40% left
in disk space, okay. So you know, just be
aware of these two things, okay.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are going to do a very short follow along
here for cloudwatch. So if you're taking the
solution, architect associate, you don't need
to know a considerable amount about cloud
watch in terms of details, that's more for
the sysop associate. But we do need to generally
know what's going on here. So maybe the first
thing we should learn how to do is create
an alarm. Okay, so alarms are triggers based
on when certain thresholds, metrics trigger
a certain threshold. So I have a bunch here
already, because I was creating some dynamodb
tables, whenever you create dynamodb, you
always get a bunch of alarms, I'm going to
go ahead here and create a new alarm, the
most common alarm to create is a building
a building alarm. So maybe we could go ahead
and do that. So under billing, we're going
to choose total estimated charge, we're gonna
choose USD, I'm going to select metric, okay.
And, you know, we can choose the period of
time we want it to happen, we have the static
and anomaly detection, we have whether we
need to determine when it should get triggered.
So we would say when we go over $1,000, okay,
we should get a Rubes $1,000 USD. Okay. So
it's not letting me fill it in there. There
we go. When we hit that metric there, then
we should get an email about it. All right.
And so we are going to go ahead and just hit
next there. And for this alarm to work, we
need to have an SNS topic. Okay, so we're
gonna create a new topic here. And I'm just
gonna say Andrew at exam pro.co. All right.
And what we'll end up doing here is we'll
just hit next, oops, we have to create topic
button there. Okay, so it's created that topic,
we'll hit next. And we'll just define this
as billing alarm. Okay. And we will hit next
here, and we will create the alarm. And so
now we have an alarm. So anytime billing goes
over $1,000, it's going to send us an email,
it's very unlikely this is going to happen
within this account. Because I'm not spending
that much here. It does have to wait for some
data to come in. So it will say insufficient
data to begin with. And it's still waiting
for pending confirmation. So it is waiting
for us to confirm that SNS topic. So I'm just
going to hop over to my email and just confirm
that for you very quickly here. And so in
very short amount of time I've received here
a subscription. So I'm just gonna hit confirm
subscription here. Okay, it's just going to
show that I've confirmed that, okay. And I'm
just going to go ahead and close that here.
And we'll just give this a refresh. Alright,
so that pending confirmation is gone. So that
means that this billing alarm isn't an OK
status, and it is able to send me emails,
when that does occur. Okay, so there's a few
different ways to set alarms, sometimes you
can directly do it with an EC too. So I just
want to show you here, okay. So we're just
going to go to over DC to I don't think we
have anything running over here right now.
Okay, and so I'm just going to launch a new
instance because I just want to show that
to you. We're going to go to Amazon Linux
two. We're going to go to configuration next.
Now there is this option here for detailed
monitoring. And this is going to provide monitoring
at for every minute as opposed to every five
minutes by default. Okay, so this does cost
additional money. But I'm just going to turn
it on here. For the sake of this, follow along.
Okay, I'm just going to give it a key pair
here. And then I'm just going to go to View
instances here. And I just want to show you
that under the monitoring tab, we do get a
bunch of metrics here about this EC two instance.
And if you wanted to create an alarm, it's
very convenient, you can actually just do
it from here. So if you have an EC two instance,
and you want to send an alarm for this here,
it could be for a variety thing. So take action,
so send a notification here. And also, you
could stop the instance. So we could say,
when the CPU utilization goes over 50%, shut
down the server. Okay. And so that's one very
easy way to create alarms. All right. Okay,
um, so, you know, just, it's, it's good to
know that a lot of services are like that,
I bet if we went over to dynamodb, I bet it's
the same thing. So if we go over to Dynamo
dB, okay, and we go to tables here, and we
were using this for a another tutorial here
and we create an alarm, okay, it's the same
story. So you're gonna want to take a peek
at different services, because they do give
you some basic configurations, though that
make make it very easy to set up alarms, you
can, of course, always do it through here.
But it's a lot easier to do that through a
lot of the services. Okay. And so I think
maybe what we'll do here is look at events.
Next, we're going to take a look now at cloudwatch
events, which has been renamed to Amazon event
bridge. So these are exactly the same service.
So AWS added some additional functionality,
such as the ability to create additional event
buses, and to use partner event sources. And
so they gave it a rebranding, okay.
So the way it works is, and we'll just do
this through cloudwatch events here. And then
we'll also do it through the new interface.
But the idea is, you generally will create
rules within cloud watch. And so you have
the ability to do from an event pattern, okay?
Or from a schedule. All right. So we are going
to actually just do from schedule, because
that's the easiest one to show here. And so
based on a schedule, we could say every day,
all right, once a day, I want to create a
backup of a aect volume. So we have a bunch
of options here. Okay. And this is a very
common one. So I actually have a minecraft
server that I run, I like to backup the volume
at least once a day. And so this is the way
I would go about doing that. So here, I just
have to supply it. Oops, we actually want
to do the snapshot here. And so I would just
have to supply the volume. So here I have
an easy to instance running from earlier in
this fall along here. And so I'm just going
to provide the volume ID there. Okay. And
so once that is there, I can hit configure
details and say EBS snapshot, okay. Or we
just say volume, snapshot doesn't matter.
Just I'm being picky here. And we'll create
that. And so now we have that rule. So once
a day, it's going to create that snapshot
for us, we're gonna go ahead and do that event
bridge, you're gonna see it's the same process.
It's just this new UX, or UI design. Whether
it is a improvement over the old one is questionable,
because it's a very thing that people always
argue about with AWS is the changes to the
interface here, we're going to see the same
thing of that pattern and schedule, I'm going
to go to schedule here, we're going to choose
a one day, alright. And you can see now we
choose our Event Bus. And so we're whenever
we're creating rules here, it's always using
the default Event Bus. But we can definitely
create other event buses and use partner events.
Okay. And we're just gonna drop this down
here and choose Create a snapshot here. I
don't know if it's still my clipboard it is,
there we go. And we'll just create that. So
you're gonna see that we can see both of them
here. Okay, so we can see UBS one and snapshot.
And if we go back to our rules here, we should
be able to see both, is it just the one or
both? Yeah, so they're both so you can just
see that they're the exact same service. Okay.
And just to wrap up talking about Amazon event
bridge, I just want to show you that you can
create multiple event buses here. So if we
go and create an event bus, you can actually
create an event bus that is shared from another
AWS account. Okay, so you could actually react
to within your system, an event from another
actual account, which is kind of cool. And
then you also have your partner event sources.
So here you could react to data with a data
dog or something with has to do with login.
So you know, there are some ways to react
cross account. Okay, so that's just the point
I wanted to make there. All right. And we're
going to just check one more thing out here,
which is a cloud watch dashboard. So college
dashboards allows you to create a bunch of
metrics and put it on a dashboard. So I'm
just going to make one here my EC to dashboard
because we do have an EC two instance running
And what we can do here is just start adding
things. So I could add a line graph, okay.
And we do have a running EC two instance.
So we should be able to get some information
there. So let's say per instance metrics here,
and we will see if we can find anything that's
running should be something running here,
I actually, you know what, I think it's just
this one here, we didn't name that instance.
That's why I'm not seeing anything there.
Okay, I'm just gonna create that there. And
so you know, a lot, a lot of stuff is happening
with that instance. So that's why we're not
seeing any data there. But if there was, we
would start to see some spikes there. But
all you need to know is that you can create
dashboards in these, we can create widgets
based on metric information. And just be sure
to hit that save dashboard button. It's very
non intuitive. This interface here, so maybe
this will get a refresh one day, but yeah,
there you go. That's dashboards. So that wraps
up the cloud watch section here. So what we're
gonna want to do is, we're just going to want
to tear down whatever we created. So let's
go to our dashboard. And I believe we can
delete it, how do we go about doing it, we
go to delete dashboard, these dashboards us
get like a few free but they do cost in the
long term, then we're going to tear down are
on our alarm, because these actually alarms
do cost money. If you have a lot of them,
so Mize will get rid of ones that we aren't
using. Okay, then we will go to our rules
here. And we will just go ahead and delete
these rules, okay, I'm just disabling them,
I actually want to delete them. Okay, and
I believe I started an EC two instance. So
we're gonna just go over to our instances
here, and terminate. Okay, so there we go.
That's a full cleanup there. Of course, if
you're doing the SIS Ops, where you have to
know, cloud watch in greater detail, but this
is just generally what you need to know, for
the solution architect associate. And likely
the developer is you're on to the cloud watch
cheat sheet. So let's jump into it. So Cloud
watch is a collection of monitoring services.
We have dashboards, events, alarms, logs and
metrics, starting with logs. First, it is
the core service to all of cloud watch. And
it logs data from Ada services. So a very
common thing that you might love would be
CPU utilization. Then we go on to metrics
and metrics builds off of logs, and it represents
a time ordered set of data points. It is a
variable to monitor. So let's go back to CPU
utilization and visualize it as a line graph.
That is what metrics is done, we go on to
cloudwatch events, which triggers an event
based on a condition, a very common use case
is maybe you need to take a snapshot of your
server every hour, I like to think of events
as a serverless crontab, because that's how
I use it. Then you have alarms, which triggers
notifications based on a metric when a defined
threshold is breached. So a very common use
case are a building alarm. So if we go over
$1,000, I want an email about it, you got
to tell me, then you got cloudwatch dashboards,
as the name implies, it's a dashboard. So
it creates visualizations based on metrics.
There are a couple of exceptions when we're
dealing with end to end cloud watch. And the
first is that it monitors at an interval of
five minutes. And if you want to get that
one minute interval, you have to turn on detailed
monitoring, most services do monitor at one
minute intervals. And if they don't, it's
going to be the one three or five minute interval.
logs must belong to a log group cloudwatch
agents need to be installed on EC to host
if you want to get memory usage or decides
because that doesn't come by default. You
can stream custom log files to to cloud watch
logs. So maybe if you're gonna have a Ruby
on Rails app, you have a production log, and
you want to get that in cloud watch logs,
you can do that. And then the last thing is
cloud watch metrics. metrics allow you to
track high resolution metrics. So that you
can have sub minute intervals, tracking all
the way down to one second. So if you need
something more granular, you can only do that
through cloud metrics. So there you go. That's
the cloud watch.
Hey, this is Angie brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at Cloud trail which is used
for logging API calls between AWS services.
And the way I like to think about this service.
It's when you need to know who to blame. Okay,
so as I said earlier, cloud trail is used
to monitor API calls and actions made on an
AWS account. And whenever you see these keywords
governance, compliance, operational auditing
or risk auditing, it's a good indicator, they're
probably talking about Eva's cloud trail.
Now, I have a record over here to give you
an example of the kinds of things that cloud
trail tracks to help you know how you can
blame someone What's up, something's gone
wrong. And so we have the where, when, who
and what so the where, so we have the account
ID what, like which account did it happen
in and Have the IP address of the person who
created that request the lens. So the time
it actually happened, the who. So we have
the user agent, which is, you know, you could
say, I could tell you the operating system,
the language, the method of making this API
call the user itself. so here we can see Worf
made this call, and, and what so to what service,
and you know, it'll say what region and what
service. So this service, it's using, I am
here, I in the action, so it's creating a
user. So there you go, that is cloud trail
in a nutshell.
So within your database account, you actually
already have cloud trail logging things by
default, and it will collect into the last
90 days under the event history here. And
we get a nice little interface here. And we
can filter out these events. Now, if you need
logging be on 90 days. And that is a very
common use case, which you definitely want
to create your own trail, you'd have to create
a custom trail. The only downside when you
create a custom trail is that it doesn't have
a gooey like here, such as event history.
So there is some manual labor involved to
visualize that information. And a very common
method is to use Amazon, Athena. So if you
see cloud trail, Amazon, Athena being mentioned
in unison, there's that reason for that, okay.
So there's a bunch of trail options, I want
to highlight and you need to know these, they're
very important for cloud trail. So the first
thing you need to know is that a trail can
be set to log in all regions. So we have the
ability here, say yes, and now, no region
is missed. If you are using an organization,
you'll have multiple accounts, and you want
to have coverage across all those. So in a
single trail, you can check box on applied
to my entire organization, you can encrypt
your cloud trail logs, what you definitely
want to do using server side encryption via
key management service, which abbreviate is
SSE kms. And you want to enable log file validation,
because this is going to tell whether someone's
actually tampered with your logs. So it's
not going to prevent someone from being able
to tamper from your logs. But it's going to
at least let you know how much you can trust
your logs.
So I do want to emphasize that cloud trail
can deliver its events to cloudwatch. So there's
an option After you create the trail where
you can configure, and then it will send your
events to cloud watch logs. All right, I know
cloud trail and cloud watch are confusing,
because they seem like they have overlapping
of responsibilities. And there are a lot of
aidable services that are like that. But you
know, just know that you can send cloud trail
events to cloud watch logs, not the other
way around. And there is that ability to.
There are different types of events in cloud
trail, we have measurement events, and data
events. And generally, you're always looking
at management events, because that's what's
turned on by default. And there's a lot of
those events. So I can't really list them
all out for you here. But I can give you a
general idea what those events are. So here
are four categories. So it could be configuring
security. So you have attached rule policy,
you'd be registering devices, it would be
configuring rules for routing data, it'd be
setting up logging. Okay. So 90% of events
in cloud trail are management events. And
then you have data events. And data events
are actually only for two services currently.
So if you were creating your trail, you'd
see tabs, and I assume as one, they have other
services that can leverage data events, we'll
see more tabs here. But really, it's just
s3 and lambda. And they're turned off by default,
for good reason. Because these events are
high volume. They occur very frequently. Okay.
And so this is tracking more in detail s3,
events, such as get object, delete object
put object, if it's a lambda, it'd be every
time it gets invoked. So those are just higher
there. And so those are turned off by default.
Okay. So now it's time to take a quick tour
of cloud trail and create our very own trail,
which is something you definitely want to
do in your account. But before we jump into
doing that, let's go over to event history
and see what we have here. So AWS, by default
will track events in the last 90 days. And
this is a great safeguard if you have yet
to create your own trail. And so we have some
event history here. And if we were just to
expand any of them doesn't matter which one
and click View event, we get to, we get to
see what the raw data looks like here for
a specific event. And we do have this nice
interface where we can search via time ranges
and some additional information. But if you
need data Now beyond 90 days, you're going
to have to create a trail. And also just to
analyze this, because we're not going to have
this interface, we're gonna have to use Athena
to really make sense of any cloud trail information.
But now that we have learned that we do have
event history available to us, let's move
on to creating our own trail. Let's go ahead
and create our first trail. And I'm just going
to name my trail here exam pro trail, I do
want you to notice that you can apply a trail
to all regions, and you definitely want to
do that, then we have management events, where
we can decide whether we want to have read
only or write only events, we're going to
want all of them, then you have data events.
Now these can get expensive, because s3 and
lambda, the events that they're tracking are
high frequency events. So you can imagine
how often someone might access something from
an s3 bucket, such as a get or put. So they
definitely do not include these. And you have
to check them on here to have the inclusion
of them. So if you do want to track data events,
we would just say for all our s3 buckets,
or specify them and lambdas are also high
frequency because we would track the invocations
of lambdas. And you could be in the 1000s
upon millions there. So these are sanely not
included by default. Now down below, we need
to choose our storage location, we're going
to let it create a new s3 bucket. For us,
that seems like a good choice, we're going
to drop down advanced here at it because it
had some really good tidbits here. So we can
turn on encryption, which is definitely something
we want to do with kms. And so I apparently
have a key already here. So I'm just gonna
add that I don't know if that's the default
key. I don't know, if you get a default key
with cloud trail, usually, you'd have one
in there. But I'm just going to select that
one there, then we have enable log file validation.
So we definitely want to have this to Yes,
it's going to check whether someone's ever
tampered with our logs, and whether we should
not be able to trust her logs. And then we
could send a notification about log file delivery,
this is kind of annoying, so I don't want
to do that. And then we should be able to
create our trail as soon as we name our bucket
here. So we will go ahead and just name it
will say exam pro trails, assuming I don't
have one in another account. Okay, and so
it doesn't like that one, that's fine. So
I'm just going to create a new kms key here.
kms keys do cost a buck purse, if you want
to skip the step you can totally do. So I'm
just going to create one for this here called
exam pro trails.
Okay. Great. And so now it has created that
trail. And we'll just use the site here. And
then maybe we'll take a peek here in that
s3 bucket when we do have some data. Alright,
I do want to point out one more thing is that
you couldn't set the the cloud watch event
to track across all organizations, I didn't
see that option there. It's probably because
I'm in a sub account. So if I was in my, if
you have an alias organization, right, and
this was the root account, I bet I could probably
turn it on to work across all accounts. So
we didn't have that option there. But just
be aware that it is there. And you can turn
a trail to be across all organizations. So
I just had to switch into my route organization
account, because I definitely wanted to show
you that this option does exist here. So when
you create a trail, we have applied all regions,
but we also can apply to all organizations,
which means all the accounts within an organization.
Okay. So you know, just be aware of that.
So now that our trail is created, I just want
you to click into and be aware that there's
an additional feature that wasn't available
to us when we were creating the trail. And
that is the ability to send our cloud trail
events to cloud watch logs. So if you want
to go ahead and do that, you can configure
that and create an IM role and send it to
a log or cloud watch log group. There are
additional fees apply here. And it's not that
important to go through the motions of this.
But just be aware that that is a capability
that you can do with patrol. So I said earlier
that this will collect beyond 90 days, but
you're not going to have that nice interface
that you have an event history here. So how
would you go about analyzing that log, and
I said you could use Amazon Athena. So luckily,
they have this link here. That's going to
save you a bunch of setup to do that. So if
you were to click this here, and choose the
s3 bucket, which is this one here, it's going
to create that table for you and Athena, we
used to have to do this manually, it was quite
the pain. So it's very nice that they they've
added this one link here, and I can just hit
create table. And so what that's going to
do, it's going to create that table in Athena
for us and we can jump over to Athena. Okay.
And um, yeah, it should be created here. Just
give it a little refresh here. I guess we'll
just click Get Started. I'm not sure why it's
not showing up here. We're getting the splash
screen. But we'll go in here and our table
is there. So we get this little goofy tutorial.
I don't want to go threat. But on that table
has now been created. And we have a bunch
of stuff here. There is a way of running a
sample query, I think he could go here and
it was preview table. And that will create
us a query. And then we it will just run the
query. And so we can start getting data. So
the cool advantage here is that if we want
to query our data, just like using SQL, you
can do so here. And Athena, I'm not doing
this on a day to day basis. So I can't say
I'm the best at it. But you know, if we gave
this a try here and tried to query something,
maybe based on event type, I wonder if we
could just like group by event type here.
So that is definitely a option. So we say
distinct. Okay, and I want to be distinct
on maybe, event type here.
Okay.
doesn't like that little bit, just take that
out there. Great. So
there we go. So that was just like a way so
I can see all the unique event types, I just
take the limit off there, the query will take
longer. And so we do have that one there.
But anyway, the point is, is that you have
this way of using SQL to query your logs.
Obviously, we don't have much in our logs,
but it's just important for you to know that
you can do that. And there's that one button,
press enter to create that table and then
start querying your logs. So we're onto the
cloud trail cheat sheet, and let's get to
it. So Cloud trail logs calls between eight
of us services. When you see the keywords
such as governance, compliance, audit, operational
auditing and risk auditing, it's a high chance
they're talking about cloud trail when you
need to know who to blame. Think cloud trail
cloud trail by default logs events data for
the past 90 days via event history. To track
beyond 90 days, you need to create a trail
to ensure logs have not been tampered with,
you need to turn on log file validation option.
Cloud trail logs can be encrypted using kms.
Cloud trail can be set to log across all service
accounts in an organization and all regions
in an account. Cloud trail logs can be streamed
to cloud watch logs, trails are outputted
to s3 buckets that you specify cloud trail
logs come in two kinds. We have a management
events and data events, management events,
log management operations, so you know, attach
roll policy, data events, log data operations
for resources. And there's only really two
candidates here s3 and lambda. So think get
object delete object put put object did events
are disabled by default when creating a trail
trail log trail logs in s3 and can be analyzed
using Athena I'm gonna have to reword that
one. But yeah, that is your teaching. Hey,
this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And we
are looking at AWS lambda, which lets you
run code without provisioning or managing
servers. And servers are automatically started
and stopped when needed. You can think of
as lambdas as serverless functions, because
that's what they're called. And it's pay per
invocation. So as we just said it was lambda
is a compute service that lets you run code
without provisioning or managing servers.
Lambda executes your code only when needed
and scales automatically to a few or to 1000
lambda functions concurrently. In seconds,
you pay only for the compute time you consume,
there is no charge when your code is not running.
So the main highlights is lambda is cheap,
lambda is serverless. And lambda scales automatically.
Now, in order to use lambda, you are just
uploading your code and you have up to seven
options that are supported by AWS. So we have
Ruby, Python, Java, go PowerShell, no GS,
and C sharp. If you want to use something
outside of this list, you can create your
own custom runtimes that are not supported.
So eight support is not going to help you
with them, but you can definitely run them
on it. So when we're thinking about how to
use Avis lambda, there is a variety of use
cases because lambda is like glue, it helps
you connect different services together. And
so I have to use use cases in front of you
here. So the first is processing thumbnail.
So imagine you are a web service, and users
are allowed to upload their profile photo.
So what you normally do is you would store
that in an s3 bucket. Now you can set event
triggers on s3 buckets so that it would go
trigger a lambda and then that image would
get pulled from that bucket. And using something
like Sharpe j s or image magic, you could
then take that profile photo and then crop
it to a thumbnail and then store it back into
the bucket. Okay, another use case would be
contact email form. So this is the same thing
example if user email form, it's exactly this.
When you fill in the contact email form, it
sends that form data to an API gateway. endpoint,
which then triggers a lambda function, and
then you have this lambda function that evaluates
whether the form data is valid or not. If
it's not valid, it's gonna say, hey, you need
to make these corrections. Or if it if it's
good, it's going to then create a record in
the in our dynamodb table, which is the records
are called items. And it's also going to send
out an email notification to the company so
that we know that you've contacted us via
SNS. All right, so there you go.
So to invoke a lambda to make it execute,
we can either use the AWS SDK, or we can trigger
it from another database service. And we have
a big long list here. And this is definitely
not the full list. So you can see that we
can do API gateway, we just showed that with
the email contact form, if you have IoT devices,
you could trigger a lambda function, your
maybe you want your Echo Dot using an Alexa
skill would trigger a lambda, Al B's CloudFront,
cloudwatch, dynamodb, kinesis, s3, SNS Sq
s. And I can even think of other ones outside
of here, like guard duty and config, there's
a bunch, okay, so you can see that a dress
integrates with a lot of stuff, it also can
integrate with third party party, or partnered
third party database partners. And that's
powered through Amazon event bridge, which
is just event bridges very much like cloud
watch events. But with some additional functionality
there. And you can see we can integrate with
data dog one, login page pager duty. So just
to give you a scope of the possible triggers
available, I just want to touch on lambda
pricing here, quickly. So the first million
requests like the first functions, you execute
our free per month, okay? So if you're a startup,
and you're not doing over a million requests
per month, and a lot aren't, you're basically
not paying anything for compute after that
is 20 cents per additional million requests.
So very, very inexpensive. There, the other
costs to it, besides just how often things
are requested. It's also you know, how many
how long the duration is. So the first 400
gigabytes of seconds is free. Thereafter,
it's going to be this very, very small amount,
for every gigabyte per second, okay, this
also is going to this value is going to change
based on the amount of memory you use, I bet
you This is for the lowest amount 128 megabytes,
most of the times, you're not going to see
yourself increasing beyond 512. That's really
high. But yeah, I always feel that I'm between
128 and 256. Now just to do a calculation
just to give an idea of total pricing. So
let's say we had a lambda function that's
at 128 megabytes with the lowest, we have
30 million executions per month, those are
requests, and the duration is 200 milliseconds.
For those lambda functions, we're only paying
$5.83. So you can see that lambda is extremely
inexpensive. So I just wanted to give you
a quick tour of the actual ad bus lamda interface,
just so you can get an idea how everything
works together. So you would choose your runtime.
So here we're using Ruby. And then you can
upload your code, you have different ways,
you can either edit it in line, so they have
like CLOUD NINE integrated here. So you can
just start writing code. If it's too large,
then you either have to upload in a zip or
provided via s3. So there are some limitations.
And the larger gets eventually you'll end
up on s3, when you want to import a lambda,
and then you have your triggers. And there's
a lot of different triggers. But for this
lambda function, it's using dynamodb. So when
a record is inserted into dynamodb, it goes
to dynamodb streams. And then it triggers
this lambda function. And then we have on
the right hand side, the outputs and those
outputs. It's the lambda function that actually
has to call those services. But you create
an IM role. And whatever you have permissions
to it will actually show you here on the right
hand side. So here Here you can see this lambda
is allowed to interact with cloud watch logs,
dynamodb and kinesis. firehose. So there you
go. We are looking at default limits for AWS
lambda. It's not all of them, but it's the
ones that I think are most important for you
to know. So by default, you can only have
1000 lambdas running concurrently. Okay,
so if you want to have more, you'd have to
go ask AWS support. It's possible there could
be an exam question where it's like, Hey,
you want to run X amount of lambdas. And they're
not running or something. This could be because
of that limit. You are able to store temporary
files on a on a lambda as it's running, and
has a limit of up to 500 megabytes. When you
create a lambda by default, it's going to
be running in no VPC. And so sometimes there
are services such as RDS where you can only
rack them if You are in the same VPC. So you
might actually have to change the VPC. In
some use cases, when you do set a lambda to
a VPC, it's going to lose internet access,
I'm not to say that you cannot expose it because
it's in a security group. So there might be
some way to do it. But that is a consideration
there, you can set the timeout to be a maximum
of 15 minutes. So you don't really if you
had to go beyond 15 minutes, and this is where
you probably want to use fargate, which is
similar to Avis lambda, but there's a lot
more work in setup and your your charge per
second as opposed to milliseconds. But just
be aware, if you need anything beyond 50 milliseconds,
you're gonna want fargate. And the last thing
is memory. So you can set memory memory starts
at 128 megabytes and goes up all the way to
3008 megabytes, the more megabytes you use,
the more expensive it's going to be paired
with how long the duration is, and it This
goes up in 64 megabyte increments, okay. So
there you go, there's the most important do
you know. So one of the most important concepts
to ages lambda is cold starts, because this
is one of the negative trade offs of using
serverless functions. So, you know, database
has servers pre configured, so they're just
lying around, and they're in a turned off
state for your runtime environment. So when
a lambda is invoked, the servers need to then
be turned on, your code needs to be copied
over. And so during that time, there's going
to be a delay when that function will initially
run. And that's what we call a code cold start.
So over here, you can see I have a lambda
function, it gets triggered, and there is
no server for it to run on. And so what's
gonna happen is that servers gonna have to
start and we're going to copy that code, and
there's gonna be a period of delay. Now, if
you were to invoke that function, again, what's
going to happen is, it has to be recent, right?
If if the same function, so the codes already
there, and and the servers already running,
then you're going to not have that delay,
that cold starts not going to be there. And
that's when your servers actually warm. All
right. So, you know, serverless functions
are cheap, but everything comes with the trade
off. And so serverless functions, cold starts
can cause delays in the user experience. And
this is actually a problem directly for us
on exam Pro, because we didn't use serverless
architecture, because we wanted everything
to be extremely fast, because, you know, using
other providers, we weren't happy with the
delay and experience. Now there are ways around
cold starts, which is called pre warming.
So what you can do is you can invoke the a
function so that it starts prematurely so
that when someone actually uses it, it's always
going to stay warm, or you can take a lambda
and then give it more responsibility so that
more things are passing through it so it stays
warm, more constant. And you know that cold
starts is becoming less and less issue at
going forward because cloud providers are
trying to find solutions to reduce those times,
or to mitigate them, but they are still a
problem. So just be very aware of this one
caveat to thermal. We're on
to the lamda cheat sheet. So lambdas are serverless
functions, you upload your code and it runs
without you managing or provisioning any servers.
Lambda is serverless. You don't need to worry
about the underlying architecture. Lambda
is a good fit for short running tasks where
you don't need to customize the OS environment.
If you need long running tasks greater than
15 minutes, and a custom OS environment then
consider using fargate. There are seven runtime
language environments officially supported
by lambda, you have Ruby, Python, Java, Node
JS, C sharp PowerShell and go. You pay per
invocation. So that's the duration, the amount
of memory used, rounded up to the nearest
100 milliseconds, and you are at and you're
also paid based on the amount of requests
so the first 1 million requests per month
are free. You can adjust the duration timeout
to be up to 15 minutes, and the memory up
to 3008 megabytes, you can trigger lambdas
from the SDK or multiple AWS services, such
as s3 API gateway dynamodb. Lambda is by default
run in no VPC to interact with some services,
you need to have your lambdas in the same
VPC. So, you know, in the case of RDS, you'd
have to have your lambda in the same VPC as
RDS lambdas can scale to 1000 concurrent functions
in a second 1000 is the default if you want
to increase this you have to go make an EVA
service limit increase with Ada support and
lambdas have cold starts if a function has
not been recently executed, there will be
a delay. Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam
pro and we are looking at simple queue service
also known as Sq s which is a fully managed
queuing service that is enables you to decouple
and scale micro services, distributed systems
and serverless applications. So to fully understand
SQL, we need to understand what a queueing
system is. And so a queueing system is just
a type of messaging system, which provides
asynchronous communication and decouples.
Processes via messages could also be known
as events from a sender and receiver. But
in the case for a streaming system, also known
as a producer and consumer. So, looking at
a queueing system, when you have messages
coming in, they're usually being deleted on
the way out. So as soon as they're consumed
or deleted, it's for simple communication,
it's not really for real time. And just to
interact with the queue. And the messages,
they're both the sender and receiver have
to pull to see what to do. So it's not reactive.
Okay, we got some examples of queueing systems
below, we have sidekick, sq, S, rabbit, rabbit
and queue, which is debatable because it could
be considered a streaming service. And so
now let's look at the streaming side to see
how it compares against a queueing system.
So a streaming system can react to events
from multiple consumers. So like, if you have
multiple people that want to do something
with that event, they can all do something
with it, because it doesn't get immediately
deleted, it lives in the Event Stream for
a long period of time. And the advantage of
having a message hang around in that Event
Stream allows you to apply complex operations.
So that's the huge difference is that one
is reactive and one is not one allows you
to do multiple things with the messages and
retains it in the queue. One deletes it and
doesn't doesn't really think too hard about
what it's doing. Okay, so there's your comparative
between queuing and streaming. And we're going
to continue on with Sq s here, which is a
queueing system. So the number one thing I
want you to think of when you think of SQL
says application integration, it's for connecting
isolette applications together, acting as
a bridge of communication, and Sq s happens
to use messages and queues for that you can
see Sq s appears in the Ava's console under
application integration. So these are all
services that do application integration Sq
S is one of them. And as we said it uses a
queue. So accuse a temporary repository for
messages that are waiting to be processed,
right. So just think of going to the bank,
and everyone is waiting that line, that is
the queue. And the way you interact with that
queue is through the Avis SDK. So you have
to write code that was going to publish messages
to the queue. And then when you want to read
them, you're going to have to use the AWS
SDK to pull messages. And so Sq S is pull
based, you have to pull things, it's not pushed
based, okay.
So to make this crystal clear, I have an SQL
use case here. And so we have a mobile app,
and we have a web app, and they want to talk
to each other. And so using the Avis SDK,
the mobile app sends a message to the queue.
And now the web app, what it has to do is
it has to use the Avis SDK and pull the cue
whenever it wants. So it's up to the this
app to code in how frequently it will check.
But it's going to see if there's anything
in the queue. And if there is a message, it's
going to pull it down, do something with it
and report back to the queue that it's consumed
it meaning to tell the queue to go ahead and
delete that message from the queue. All right,
now this app on the mobile left hand side
to know whether it's been consumed, it's going
to have to, on its own schedule, periodically
check to pull to see if that message is still
in the queue, if it no longer is, that's how
it knows. So that is the process of using
SQL between two applications. So let's look
at some SQL limits starting with message size.
So the message size can be between one byte
to 256 kilobytes, if you want it to go beyond
that message size, you can use the Amazon
SQL extended client library only for Java,
it's not for anything else to extend that
necessarily up to two gigabytes in size. And
so the way that would work is that the message
would be stored in s3 and the library would
reference that s3 object, right? So you're
not actually pushing two gigabytes to SQL
is just loosely looking to something in an
s3 bucket. Message retention. So message retention
is how long SQL will hold on a message before
dropping it from the queue. And so the message
retention by default is four days, and you
have a message retention retention that can
be adjusted from a minimum of 60 seconds to
a maximum of 14 days.
SQL is a queueing system. So let's talk about
the two different types of queues. We have
standard queue which allows for a nearly unlimited
number of transactions per second when your
transaction is just like messages, and it
guarantees that a message will be delivered
at least once. However, the trade off here
is that more than one copy of the message
could be Potentially delivered. And that would
cause things to happen out of order. So if
ordering really matters to you just consider
there's that caveat here with standard queues,
however, you do get nearly unlimited transactions.
So that's a trade off. It does try to provide
its best effort at to ensure messages stay
generally in the order that they were delivered.
But again, there's no guarantee. Now, if you
need a guarantee of the, the ordering of messages,
that's where we're going to use feefo, also
known as first in first out, well, that's
what it stands for, right. And the idea here
is that, you know, a message comes into the
queue and leaves the queue. The trade off
here is the number of transactions you can
do per second. So we don't have nearly unlimited
per second where we have a cap up to 300.
So there you go.
So how do we prevent another app from reading
a message while another one is busy with that
message. And the idea behind this is we want
to avoid someone doing the same amount of
work that's already being done by somebody
else. And that's where visibility timeout
comes into play. So visibility timeout is
the period of time that it meant that messages
are invisible DSU Sq sq. So when a reader
picks up that message, we set a visibility
timeout, which could be between zero to 12
hours. By default, it's 30 seconds. And so
no one else can touch that message. And so
what's going to happen is that whoever picked
up that message, they're going to work on
it. And they're going to report back to the
queue that, you know, we finished working
with it, it's going to get deleted from the
queue. Okay. But what happens, if they don't
complete it within the within the visibility
timeout frame, what's going to happen is that
message is now going to become visible, and
anyone can pick up that job, okay. And so
there is one consideration you have to think
of, and that's when you build out your web
apps, that you you bake in the time, so that
if if the job is going to be like if it's
if 30 seconds have expired, then you should
probably kill that job, because otherwise
you might end up this issue where you have
the same messaging being delivered twice.
And that could be an issue. Okay, so just
to consideration for visibility. Don't ask
us we have two different ways of doing polling
we have short versus long. Polling is the
method in which we retrieve messages from
the queue. And by default, SQL uses short
polling, and short polling returns messages
immediately, even if the message queue being
pulled is empty. So short polling can be a
bit wasteful, because if there's nothing to
pull, then you're just calling you're just
making calls for no particular reason. But
there could be a use case where you need a
message right away. So short polling is the
use case you want. But the majority of use
cases, the majority of use cases, you should
be using long polling, which is bizarre, that's
not by default, but that's what it is. So
long polling waits until a message arrives
in the queue, or the long pole timeout expires.
Okay. And long polling makes it inexpensive
to retrieve messages from the queue as soon
as messages are available, using long polling
will reduce the cost because you can reduce
the number of empty receives, right. So if
there's nothing to pull, then you're wasting
your time, right? If you want to enable long
polling if you have to do it within the SDK,
and so what you're doing is you're setting
the receive message request with a wait time.
So by doing that, that's how you set long
polling. Let's take a look at our simple queue
service cheat sheet that's going to help you
pass your exam. So first, we have Sq S is
a queuing service using messages with a queue
so think sidekick or rabbit mq, if that helps
if you know the services, sq S is used for
application integration. It lets you decouple
services and apps so that they can talk to
each other. Okay, to read Sq s, you need to
pull the queue using the ABS SDK Sq S is not
push based. Okay, it's not reactive. sq s
supports both standard and first in first
out FIFO queues. Standard queues allow for
unlimited messages per second does not guarantee
the order of delivery always delivers at least
once and you must protect against duplicate
messages being processed feefo first in first
out maintains the order messages with a limit
of 300. So that's the trade off there. There
are two kinds of polling short by default
and long. Short polling returns messages immediately
even if the message queue is being pulled
as empty. Long polling waits until messages
arrive in the queue or the long pole time
expires. in the majority of cases long polling
is preferred over short polling majority okay.
Visibility timeout is the period of the time
that messages are invisible to the Sq sq.
messages will be deleted from the queue after
a job has been processed. Before the visibility
timeout expires. If the visibility timeout
expires in a job will become visible to The
queue again, the the default visibility timeout
is 30 seconds, timeout can be between zero
seconds to a maximum of 12 hours. I highlighted
that zero seconds because that is a trick
question. Sometimes on the exams, people don't
realize you can do it for zero seconds, sq
s can retain messages from 60 seconds to 14
days by default, is four days. So 14 days
is two weeks. That's an easy way to remember
it. Message sizes can be between one byte
to two and 56 kilobytes. And using the extended
client library for Java can be extended to
two gigabytes. So there you go, we're done
with SQL.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at simple notification service
also known as SNS, which lets you subscribe
and send notifications via text message email,
web hooks, lambdas Sq s and mobile notification.
Alright, so to fully understand SNS, we need
to understand the concept of pub sub. And
so pub sub is a publish subscribe pattern
commonly implemented in messaging systems.
So in a pub sub system, the sender of messages,
also known as the publisher here, doesn't
send the message directly to the receiver.
Instead, they're going to send the messages
to an Event Bus. And the event pumps categorizes
the messages into groups. And then the receiver
of messages known as the subscriber here subscribes
to these groups. And so whenever a new message
appears within their subscription, the messages
are immediately delivered to them. So it's
not unlike registering for a magazine. All
right, so, you know, down below, we have that
kind of representation. So we have those publishers,
and they're publishing to the Event Bus which
have groups in them, and then that's gonna
send it off to those subscribers, okay, so
it's pushing it all along the way here, okay,
so publishers have no knowledge of who their
subscribers are. Subscribers Do not pull for
messages, they're gonna get pushed to them.
messages are instead automatically immediately
pushed to subscribers and messages and events
are interchangeable terms in pub sub. So if
you see me saying messages and events, it's
the same darn thing. So we're now looking
at SNS here. So SNS is a highly available,
durable, secure, fully managed pub sub messaging
service that enables you to decouple microservices
distributed systems and serverless applications.
So whenever we talking about decoupling, we're
talking about application integration, which
is like a family of Ada services that connect
one service to another. Another service is
also Sq s. And SNS is also application integration.
So down below, we can see our pub sub systems.
So we have our publishers on the left side
and our subscribers on the right side. And
our event bus is SNS Okay, so for the publisher,
we have a few options here. It's basically
anything that can programmatically use the
EVAs API. So the SDK and COI uses the Avis
API underneath. And so that's going to be
the way publishers are going to publish their
messages or events onto an SNS topic. There's
also other services on AWS that can trigger
or publish to SNS topics cloud watch, definitely
can, because you'd be using those for building
alarms. And then on the right hand side, you
have your subscribers and we have a bunch
of different outputs, which we're going to
go through. But here you can see we have lambda
Sq s email, and HTTPS protocol. So publishers
push events to an SNS topic. So that's how
they get into the topic. And then subscribers
subscribe to the SNS topic to have events
pushed to them. Okay. And then down below,
you can see I have a very boring description
of SNS topic, which is it's a logical access
point and communication channel. So that makes
a nap. That makes sense. So let's move on.
We're gonna take a deeper look here at SNS,
topics and topics allow you to group multiple
subscriptions together, a topic is able to
deliver to multiple protocols at once. So
it could be sending out email, text, message,
HTTPS, all the sorts of protocols we saw earlier.
And publishers don't care about the subscribers
protocol, okay, because it's sending a message
event, it's giving you the topic and saying,
you figure it out, this is the message I want
to send out. And it knows what subscribers
it has. And so the topic, when it delivers
messages, it will automatically format it
for the message according to the subscribers
chosen protocol. Okay. And the last thing
I want you to know is that you can encrypt
your topics via kms key management service.
And you know, so it's just as easy as turning
it on and picking your key.
So now we're taking a look at subscriptions.
And subscriptions are something you create
on a topic, okay, and so here I have a subscription
that is an email subscription. And the endpoint
is obviously going to be an email. So I provided
my email there. If you want to say hello,
give send me an email. And it's just as simple
as clicking that button and filling in those
options. Now you have to choose your protocol.
And here we have our full list here on the
right hand side. So we'll just go through
it. So we have a sheet phps. And you're going
to want to be using this for web hooks. So
the idea is that this is usually going to
be an API endpoint to your web applications
that's going to listen for incoming messages
from SNS, then you can send out emails. Now,
there's another service called ACS, which
specializes in sending out emails. And so
SNS is really good for internal email notifications,
because you don't necessarily have your custom
domain name. And also, the emails have to
be plain text only. There's some other limitations
around that. So they're really, really good
for internal notifications, maybe like billing
alarms, or maybe someone signed up on your
platform you want to know about it, then they
also have an email JSON. So this is going
to send you JSON via email, then you have
Sq s. So you can send an SNS message to Sq
s. So that's an option you have there. You
can also have SNS trigger a lambda functions.
So that's a very useful feature as well. And
you can also send text messages that we'll
be using the SMS protocol. And the last one
here is platform application endpoints. And
that's for mobile push. So like a bunch of
different devices, laptops, and phones have
notification systems in them. And so this
will integrate with that. And we're just gonna
actually talk about that a bit more here.
So I wanted to talk a bit more about this
platform application endpoint. And this is
for doing mobile push. Okay, so we have a
bunch of different mobile devices, and even
laptops that use notification systems in them.
And so here you can see a big list, we have
ADM, which is Amazon device messaging, we
have Apple, Badu Firebase, which is Google.
And then we have two for Microsoft. So we
have Microsoft push, and Windows push, okay.
And so you can with this protocol, push out
to that stuff. And the advantage here, you're
gonna when you push notification messages
to these mobile endpoints, it can appear in
the mobile app just like message alerts, badges,
updates, or even sound alerts. So that's pretty
cool. Okay, so I just want you to be aware
of that. Alright, so on to the SNS cheat sheet.
So simple notification service, also known
as SNS, is a fully managed pub sub messaging
service. SNS is for application integration.
It allows decoupled services and apps to communicate
with each other. We have a topic which is
a logical access point and communication channel,
a topic is able to deliver to multiple protocols.
You can encrypt topics via kms. And then you
have your publishers, and they use the EVAs
API via the CLA or the SDK to push messages
to a topic. Many Eva's services, integrate
with SNS and act as publishers. Okay, so think
cloud watch and other things. Then you have
subscriptions. So you can subscribe, which
consists subscribe to topics. When a topic
receives a message, it automatically immediately
pushes messages to subscribers. All messages
published to SNS are stored redundantly across
multi az, which isn't something we talked
in the core content, but it's good to know.
And then we have the following protocols we
can use. So we have HTTP, HTTPS. This is great
for web hooks into your web application. We
have emails good for internal email notification.
Remember, it's only plain text if you need
rich text. And custom domains are going to
be using sts for that. Then you have email
JSON, very similar to email just sending Jason
along the way. You can also send your your
SNS messages into an ESA s Sq sq. You can
trigger lambdas you can send text messages.
And then the last one is you have platform
application endpoints, which is mobile push,
okay. And that's going to be for systems like
Apple, Google, Microsoft, Purdue, all right.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at elastic cache, which is
used for managing caching services, which
either run on Redis or memcached. So to fully
understand what elastic cache is, we need
to answer a couple questions. And that is,
what is caching what is an in memory data
store. So let's start with caching. So caching
is the process of storing data in a cache.
And a cache is a temporary storage area. So
caches are optimized for fast retrieval with
the trade off. The data is not durable, okay.
And we'll explain what not like what it means
when we're saying it's not durable. So now
let's talk about in memory data store, because
that is what elastic cache is. So it's when
data is stored in memory. So memory, literally
think RAM, because that's what it's going
in. And the trade off is high volatility.
Okay. So when I say it's very volatile, that
means low durability. So what does that mean?
It just means the risk of data being lost,
okay, because, again, this is a temporary
storage area. And the trade off is we're going
to have fast access to that data. All right.
So that is generally what a cache and memory
data store is. So with elastic cache, we can
deploy, run and scale popular open source
compatible in memory data stores. One cool
feature is that it will frequently identify
queries that you Use often and will store
those in cash so you get an additional performance
boost. One caveat, I found out when using
this in production for my own use cases is
that alasa cash is only accessible to two
resources offering in the same VPC. So here
I have an easy to instance, as long as the
same VPC can connect to elastic cache, if
you're trying to connect something outside
of AWS, such as digitalocean, that is not
possible to connect that elastic cache. And
if it's outside of this VPC, you're not gonna
be able to make that connection, probably
through peering or some other efforts, you
could do that. But you know, generally, you
want to be using elastic cache or the servers
that use it to be in the same VPC. And we
said that it runs open source compatible in
memory data stores. And the two options we
have here are mem cache, and Redis. And we're
going to talk about the difference between
those two in the next slide. for lots of cash,
we have two different engines, we can launch
we have memcached, and Redis. And there is
a difference between these two engines, we
don't really need to know in great detail,
you know, all the differences. But we do have
this nice big chart that shows you that Redis
takes more boxes, then mem cache. So you can
see that Redis can do snapshots, replication,
transact transactions, pub sub, and support
geospatial support. So you might think that
Redis is the clear winner here. But it really
comes down to your use case. So mem cache
is generally preferred for caching HTML fragments.
And mem cache is a simple key value store.
And that trade off there is that even though
it's simpler and has less features, it's going
to be extremely fast. And then you have Redis
on the other side, where he has different
kinds of operations that you can do on your
data in different data structures that are
available to you. It's really good for leaderboards,
or tracking unrenewed notification, any kind
of like real time cached information that
has some logic to it. Redis is going to be
your choice there. It's very fast, we could
argue to say who is faster than the other
because on the internet, some people say Redis
is overtaking memcached, even in the most
basic stuff, but generally, you know for for
the exam, memcached is technically are generally
considered faster for HTML fragments, okay.
But you know, it doesn't really matter because
on the exam, they're not gonna really ask
you to choose between memcached and Redis.
But you do need to know the difference. So
we are on to the elastic cache cheat sheet.
It's a very short cheat sheet, but we got
to get through it. So elastic cache is a managed
in memory caching service. Elastic cache can
launch either memcached or Redis. mem cache
is a simple key value store preferred for
caching HTML fragments is arguably faster
than Redis. Redis has richer data types and
operations, great for leaderboards, geospatial
data, or keeping track of unread notifications,
a cache is a temporary storage area. Most
frequently identical queries are stored in
the cache and resources only within the same
VPC may connect to lots of cash to ensure
low latency. So there you go. That's the last
thing.
So now we're taking a look at high availability
architecture, also known as h A. And this
is the ability for a system to remain available.
Okay. And so what we need to do is we need
to think about what could cause a service
to become unavailable. And the solution we
need to implement in order to ensure high
availability. So starting with number one,
we're dealing with the scenario where when
an availability zone becomes unavailable,
now remember, an AZ is just the data center.
So you can imagine a data center becoming
flooded for some reason. And so now all the
servers there are not operational. So what
would you need to do? Well, you need to have
easy two instances in another data center.
Okay. And so how would you route traffic from
one AZ to another? Well, that's where we will
use an elastic load balancer so that that
way we can be multi AZ. Now, what would happen
if two ACS went out? Well, then you'd need
a third one. And a lot of enterprises have
this as a minimum requirement, we have to
be running at least in three azs. Okay, moving
on to our next scenario, what happens when
a region becomes unavailable? So let's say
there is a meteor strike. It's a very unlikely
scenario. But um, we need a scenario which
would take out an entire region, all the data
centers in that geographical location. And
so what you're going to need is going to need
instances running in another region. So how
would you facilitate the routing of traffic
from one region to another, that's going to
be route 53. Okay, so that's the solution
there. Now, what happens when you have a web
application that becomes unresponsive because
of too much traffic? All right. So if you're
having too much traffic coming to your platform,
well, then you're probably going to need more
EC two instances to handle the demand. And
that's where we're going to use auto scaling
groups which have the ability to scale based
on the amount of traffic that's coming in
and So now what happens if we have an instance
that becomes unavailable, because there's
an instance failure. So something with the
hardware or the virtual software is failing,
and so it's no longer healthy? Well, again,
that's where we can have auto scaling groups,
because we can say, we will set the minimum
amount of instances. So let's say we have
always three running to handle the load minimum.
And if one fails, then it's going to spin
up another one. And also, of course, the lb
would run traffic to other instances and other
AZ. So we have high availability. And now
we have our last scenario here. So what happens
when our web application becomes unresponsive
due to distance and geographical location?
So let's say someone's accessing our web application
from Asia, and we are in North America. And
the distance is causing unavailability? Well,
we have a couple options here, we can use
a CloudFront. And so CloudFront could cache
our static content or even our dynamic content
to some degree. So that there's there's content
nearby to that user, which gives them back
availability, or we could just be running
our our content, or sorry, our servers in
another region that's nearby. And we use route
53 routing policy for geo geolocation. So
it's, so if we have servers that are in Asia,
that it's going to route traffic to that those
servers. Okay, so there you go. That's the
rundown for high availability.
We're looking at scale up versus scale out.
So when utilization increases, and we're reaching
capacity, we can either scale up known as
vertical scaling, or we can scale out known
as horizontal scaling. So in the case for
scale up, all we're doing is we're just increasing
the instance size to meet that capacity. And
the trade offs here is this is going to be
simple to manage, because we're just increasing
the instance. But we're gonna have lower available
availability. So if a single instance fails,
the service is going to become unavailable.
Now for scale out known as horizontal scaling,
while we're going to do is we're going to
add more instances. And so the advantage here
is we're gonna have higher availability, because
if a single instance fails, it doesn't matter,
we're gonna have more complexity to manage.
So more servers means more, more of a headache,
okay? So what I would suggest you to do is
you generally want to scale out first to get
more availability. And then you want to then
scale up so that you keep simplicity, okay.
So you do want to use both these methods,
it's just it has to do on the specific scenario
that's in front of you.
Hey, this is Angie brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at Elastic Beanstalk, which
allows you to quickly deploy and manage web
apps on AWS without worrying about infrastructure.
So the easiest way to think of Elastic Beanstalk
is I always compare it to Heroku. So I always
say it's the Heroku of AWS. So you choose
a platform, you upload your code, and it runs
without little worry for developers knowing
the actual underlying infrastructure, okay.
It just does not recommend it for production
applications, when each of us is saying that
they really are talking about enterprise or
large companies. for startups, you know, I
know ones that are still using it three years
in, so it's totally fine for those use cases.
But if you do see exam questions where they're
talking about, like, you have a workload,
it's just for developers, they don't want
to have to really think about what they're
doing Elastic Beanstalk is going to be that
choice. So what kind of what kind of things
does Elastic Beanstalk set up for you? Well,
it's going to set up you a load balancer,
auto scaling groups, maybe the database, easy
to instance, pre configured with the platform
that you're running on. So if you're running
a Rails application, you choose Ruby. If you're
running large Ral you choose PHP, you can
also create your own custom platforms and
run them on Elastic Beanstalk. Another thing
that's really important to know is that Elastic
Beanstalk can run Docker eyes environments.
So here we have multi container and Docker.
It does have some nice security features where
if you have RDS connected, it can rotate out
those passwords for you. And it does have
a couple of deployment methodologies in there.
By default, it's in place, but it can also
do bluegreen deployment, and it can do monitoring
for you. And down below, you just see these
little boxes, that's just me showing you that
when you go into Elastic Beanstalk, you'd
have all these boxes to do some fine tuning
but more or less, you just choose if you want
high availability or you want it to be cheap,
and it will then just choose all these options
for you. So that is all you need to know about
Elastic Beanstalk for the solution architect
is Andrew Brown from exam Pro, and we are
going to learn how to utilize Elastic Beanstalk.
So we can quickly deploy, monitor and scale
our applications quickly and easily. Okay,
so we're going to go ahead here and hit get
started. And we're going to upload or create
a new application here we're going to name
it Express j s because that's what we're going
to be utilizing here. Express is just example,
a To choose a platform to be no j s, okay,
and so now we're at this option where we can
utilize a sample application, which is totally
something we can do. Or we can upload our
own code. So for this, I really want you to
learn a few of the caveats of Elastic Beanstalk.
And you're only going to learn that if you
upload your own code, you can definitely just
do sample application, just watch the videos
to follow along. But the next thing we're
going to do is we're going to prep a application
where I have a sample repo here, we're going
to go and talk about some of the things we
need to configure and upload in the next video.
All right. Alright, so I prepared this expressjs
application. So we can learn the caveats of
Elastic Beanstalk. And I even have the instructions
here, if you didn't want to just use this
premade one and you want to go the extra effort
to make your own, I do have the instructions
here emitting how to install no GS, you have
to figure that out for yourself. But um, you
know, just using this application here, we're
going to go ahead and you can either download
the zip, or clone it, I'm going to clone it,
because that's the way I like to do it. And
we'll go over to our terminal here. And I'm
just going to clone that to my desktop. Okay.
And it won't take long to here. And there
we go. We have it cloned. We'll go inside
of it, I'm just going to open up the folder
here. So you can
get an idea of the contents of this Express
JS application. So with most applications,
we just want to make sure that it runs before
we upload it here. So I'm going to do npm
install. Okay, it's gonna install all the
dependencies, you just saw a node modules
directory created. And I'm just going to run
my application, I have a nice little script
here. To do that, it's going to start on localhost.
And here's our application. So it's a very
simple application references a very popular
episode of Star Trek The Next Generation.
And so we're going to go back and just kill
our application here. And now we're going
to start preparing this application for for
Elastic Beanstalk. So when you have an Elastic
Beanstalk application, it needs to know how
to actually run this application, okay. And
the way it's going to go ahead and do that
is through a hidden directory with a couple
of hidden files. So if you scroll down in
my example, here, I'm going to tell you that
you need to create a couple, you need to create
a hidden folder called Eb extensions. And
inside that folder is going to contain different
types of configuration files. And it's going
to tell Elastic Beanstalk how to run this
application. So for no GS, we want it to execute
the NPM start command, which is going to start
up the server to run this application. We
also need it to serve static files. So we
have another configuration file in here to
serve those static files. Now this.eb extensions,
it's actually already part of the repository,
so you don't have to go ahead and create them.
But a very common mistake that people have
with Elastic Beanstalk is they fail to upload
that hidden folder, because they simply don't
see it. Okay. So if you are on your on a Mac
here, you can hit Control Shift period, which
is going to show those hidden folders for
Windows and Unix, you're gonna have to figure
that out for yourself here. But just be aware
that you need to include this folder for packaging.
Alright, so now we know that our application
runs on and we can see all the files we need,
we're going to go ahead and packages. So I'm
going to grab what we need here. We don't
need the docks. That's just something that
I added here just to get that nice graphic
in there for you. And I believe that's all
we need, we could exclude the readme, we're
going to exclude the dot get directory because
sometimes they contain sensitive credentials.
But the most important thing is this.eb. Extension.
So I'm going to go ahead here and zip this
into an archive. Okay, and so now I have that
ready to upload. Okay. And just one more caveat
here is that you saw me do an npm install
to install the dependencies for this application.
Well, how is Elastic Beanstalk? going to do
that, okay, so it actually does it automatically.
And this is pretty much for most environments
have it's going to be a Ruby application,
it's going to do bundle install. And if you
have requirements and your Django application
is going to do it, but for Elastic Beanstalk
for a no Jess, it's going to automatically
run npm install for you. Okay, so you don't
have to worry about that. Um, but anyway,
we've prepared the archive. And so now we
can proceed to actually uploading this archive
into Alaska. So I left this screen open, because
we had to make a detour and package our code
into an archive. And so now we're ready to
upload our code. So just make sure you have
upload your code selected here and we'll click
Upload. And just before we upload, I want
you to notice that you can either upload a
local archive or you can provide it via a
s3 URL and you will have to do this once you
exceed 512. megabytes, which isn't a very
hard thing to do, because applications definitely
get larger. So just be aware of that. But
we still have a very small application here,
it's only five megabytes, five, five megabytes
here. So we can definitely upload this directly.
I do want to point out that we did zip the
node modules, and this directory is usually
very large. So I bet if I excluded this, this
would have been less than a megabyte. But
for convenience, I just included it. But we
did see previous that Elastic Beanstalk does
do an npm install automatically for us. So
if we had admitted this, it would be installed
in the server, okay. But I'm just going to
upload this archive, it is five megabytes
in size. So it will take a little bit of time
here, when we hit the upload button, but just
before we do, we need to set our version label.
Now I'm going to name this version 0.0. point
one. And it's a good idea to try to match
the versioning here with your Git tags, because
in git, you can tag specific cabinets with
specific versions, okay, and we're going to
go ahead and upload this, okay. And this will
just take a little bit of time, my Internet's
not the fastest here. So five megabytes is
going to take a minute or so here.
Okay, great. So we've uploaded that code here.
And we have version 0.0. point one. And so
now we can talk about more advanced configuration,
we could go ahead and create this application.
But I want to just show you all the little
things that you can configure in Alaska. So
let's look at a bit more advanced configurations
here and just make sure that we aren't getting
overbilled because we spun up resources, we
didn't realize we're gonna cost us money.
So the preset configuration here is on the
low cost here. So it's going to be essentially
free. If we were to launch this here, which
is great for learning, but let's talk about
if we actually set it to high availability.
So if we set it to high availability, we're
going to get a load balancer. So a load bouncer
generally costs at least $15 USD per month.
So by having a low cost, we're saving that
money there. And when we set it to high availability,
it's going to set it in an auto scaling group,
okay, between one to four instances, with
low cost, it will only run a single server,
you can see that is set to a tee to micro,
which is the free tier. And we could adjust
that there if we want. And then we have updates.
So the deployment method right now is all
at once. And so if we were to deploy our application,
again, let's say it's already been uploaded,
and we deploy it again, using all at once,
we're going to have downtime, because it's
going to take that server off offline, and
then put a new server up with the code in
order to deploy that code. And so we can actually
use bluegreen deployment to mitigate that,
and I'm just going to pop in here to show
you so all at once means that it's going to,
it's going to shut down and start up a new
server in place. And then immutable means
it's going to create a new server in isolation,
okay, so just be aware of those options there.
But um, there's that. And we can also create
our database and attach it here as well. Sometimes,
that is a great idea. Because if you create
an RDS database, so here, I could select like
MySQL and Postgres, right, and you provide
the username and password. But the advantage
of creating your art RDS database with Elastic
Beanstalk is that it's going to automatically
rotate your RDS passwords for you for for
security purposes. So that's a very good thing
to have here. I generally do not like creating
my RDS instances with Elastic Beanstalk, I
create them separately and hook them up to
my application. But just be aware that you
can go ahead and do that. And I think that's
like the most important options there. But
we're just going to make sure that we are
set to the low cost free tier here with T
to micro, okay. And we'll go ahead and create
our app. And here we go. And so now, what
we're going to see is some information here
as it creates our application. And this does
take a few minutes here anytime you launch,
because it has to launch at two instance.
But it always takes about, you know, three
to five minutes to spin up a fresh instance.
So I will probably clip this video. So this
proceeds a lot quicker here. So that deploy
finished there. And it redirected me to this,
this dashboard here. So if you are still on
that old screen, and you need to get to the
same place as me just go up to express j s
sample up here and just click into your environment
and we will be in the same place. So did this
work. So it created us a URL here and we will
view it and there you go. Our application
is running on Elastic Beanstalk. Alright.
Now if you're looking up here and saying well,
what if I wanted to get my custom domain here?
That's where row 53 would come into play.
So in roughly two, three, you would point
it to your elastic IP, which is the case here,
because we created a single instance to be
cost saving, and attached an elastic IP for
us. If we had done the high availability option,
which created a load bouncer, we would be
pointing roughly three, two, that load balancer.
And that's how we get our custom domain on
Elastic Beanstalk. And let's just quickly
look at what it was doing as it was creating
here. So if we go to events, we're gonna get
all the same information. As we were in that
prior, you know, that black terminal screen
where it was showing us progress. It's the
exact same information here. So it created
an environment for us it, um, had environment
data that it uploaded to s3, it created a
security group, it created an elastic IP on
and then it spun up that easy to essence and
it took three minutes. And this is what I
said it would take between three to five minutes
to spin up an EC two instance, if we had chose
to create an RDS instance, in our configuration
to create that initial RDS always takes about
10 to 15 minutes because it has to create
that that initial backup. But then from then
on, if we did other deploys, would only take
the three to five minutes. Okay, so there
you go. That's all we need to really know
for Elastic Beanstalk for the solution architect.
So just so we're not wasting our free tier
credits, we should tear down this Elastic
Beanstalk environment. So I'm going to go
up here to actions. And we are going to terminate
this environment here. And we're going to
have to provide its name so it's up here.
So I'm just going to copy it, paste it in
and hit terminate, okay, and this is a bit
slow. But we'll let it go here. And it's going
to hopefully destroy this environment. Sometimes
it does fail, you'll have to give it another
try there. But once that is done, then you
might want to go ahead and destroy it. Delete
the application, okay? So, but it's not necessarily
sorry to delete the application. It's just
necessary to destroy this environment here,
because this is actually running instances.
All right. So we'll just wait here. shouldn't
take too long, just a couple minutes. All
right. So we finished terminating, and it
redirected me here. And we can see the previous
terminated environment. And now just to fully
clean everything up here, we can delete the
application. Now, there's no cost to keep
this application around. It's really the environments
that contain that running resources. But just
to be tidy here, we'll go ahead and delete
that there. And we'll provide its name and
should be relatively quick, they're in Great.
So the environment and also the application
is destroyed. So we're fully or fully cleaned
up. So onto the Elastic Beanstalk cheat sheet.
And this is very minimal for the solution
architect associate, if you're doing other
exams, where Elastic Beanstalk is more important,
because there's going to be like two pages,
okay, so just keep that in mind. But let's
get through this cheat sheet. So Elastic Beanstalk
handles the deployment from capacity provisioning,
and load balancing, auto scaling, to application
health monitoring when you want to run a web
app, but you don't want to have to think about
the underlying infrastructure. You want to
think Elastic Beanstalk. It costs nothing
to use Elastic Beanstalk only the resources
it provision. So RDS lb easy to recommend
it for test or development apps, not Rebecca
recommended for production use, you can choose
from the following pre configured platforms,
you got Java, dotnet, PHP, node, js, Python,
Ruby, go and Docker. And you can run Docker
eyes environments on Elastic Beanstalk. So
there you go.
Hey, this is Angie brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at API gateway, which is a
fully managed service to create, publish,
maintain, monitor and secure API's at any
scale. So API gateway is a solution for creating
secure API's in your cloud environment at
any scale. So down below, I have a representation
of how API gateway works. So on the left hand
side, you'd have your usual suspects, you'd
have your mobile app, your web app, or even
an IoT device. And they would be making HTTP
requests to your API, which is generally a
URL. And so API gateway provides you a URL
that it generates, so that you can do that.
And then in API gateway, you create your endpoint.
So here I have like endpoints for tasks with
different methods. And the idea here is that
it's likely to create these virtual endpoints
so that you can then point them to AWS services,
the most common common use service is lambda.
But yeah, so the easiest way to think about
API gateway and this is really 80 of us this
definition is that the API acts as the front
door for applications to access data, business
logic and functionality for back end services.
So it's just a virtual, a bunch of virtual
endpoints to connect to AWS So let's just
talk about some of the key features API gateway.
So API gateway handles all tasks involving
accepting and processing up to hundreds of
1000s of concurrent API calls, including traffic
management, authorization and monitoring.
So it allows you to track and control any
usage of your API, you can throttle requests
to help prevent attacks, you can expose atbs
endpoints to define a RESTful API is highly
scalable. So everything happens automatically
and is cost effective. And you can send each
API endpoint to a different target, and maintain
multiple versions of your API.
All right, so let's look at how we actually
configure API and the components involved.
So the first most important thing are resources.
Okay, so resources over here is Ford slash
projects. And so you know, they literally
just are URLs, that's what resources are.
And in a API gateway project, you're gonna
want to be creating multiple multiples of
these resources, right, because you're not
gonna just have one endpoint. And so here
we have a forward slash projects. And underneath,
you can see we have another resource, which
is a child of this Parent Resource, which
would create this full URL here for you, you
see this weird hyphen ID syntax that is actually
a variable. So that would be replaced with
like three or four. But you know, what you
need to know is that resources are URLs, and
they can have children, okay? Then what you're
going to want to do is you're going to want
to apply methods to your resources. So methods
are your HTTP methods. So it's the usual write,
delete patch, post, put options head, okay.
And you can define multiple resources. So
if you wanted to do a get to projects, ID,
you could do that. And you could also do a
post. And now those are unique endpoints.
So both GET and POST are going to have different
functionality. But yeah, you just need to
define all that stuff, right? So yeah, a resource
can have multiple methods, resources can have
children, you know. And so once we've defined
our API using resources and methods, the next
thing is to actually get our API published.
And in order to do that, you're going to need
a bunch of different stages setup. And so
stages is just the is just like a way of versioning,
your, your API for published versions. And
you're normally going to do this based on
your environment. So you would have like production,
QA, for quality assurance, staging, maybe
you'd have one for developers. So yeah, so
you'll create those stages. Now once you create
a stage, you're going to get a unique URL
that's automatically generated from AWS. So
here, I have one, and this is the called the
invoke URL, and this is the endpoint, you're
actually going to hit. So you do this, like
Ford slash prod. And then whatever your endpoints
are. So we saw in the previous example, we
had Ford slash tasks and projects, you just
depend on there and make the appropriate method,
whatever it is, GET or POST. And that's how
you're gonna interact with API gateway. Now,
you might look at this and say, I don't really
like the look of this URL, I wish I can use
a custom one, you can definitely do that in
API gateway. So you could make this like API
dot exam pro CO, instead of this big ugly
URL. But again, for each staging, they're
going to have one. So here, it's prod. So
there'd be one here, QA and staging. All right.
And so in order to deploy these versions to
the staging, you'd, you'd go to your actual
API, and you'd have to do deploy API action.
Every time you make a change, you have to
do the deploy API actually doesn't automatically
happen. That's something that confused me
for some time, because you think you made
this endpoint? Why aren't they working? It's
generally because you have to do so we looked
at how to define the API, and also how to
deploy it. The last thing is actually how
do we configure those endpoints. So when you
select the method for your resource, you're
going to choose your integration type. And
so we have a bunch of different ones. So we
got lambda HTTP and Mach one, you can send
it to another ad of a service, which this
option is very confusing, but it's supposed
to be there. And you have VPC link. So I would
go to your on premise environment or your
local data center or local. Network. Okay.
So you do have those integration types. And
then once you do that, the options are going
to vary, but the most common one is lambda
function. And so we're going to see is generally
this and the idea is that you get to configure
for the the request coming in and the response
going out. Okay, so you could apply authorizations,
yes is off none. So you can make it so they
have to authenticate or Authorize. And then
you can say you have some configuration lambda,
and you have some manipulation on the response
going out. Okay.
So get a bit of cost saving here and a bit
of less of a burden on your API, what you
can do is you can turn on API gateway cache,
so you can cache the results of common endpoints.
Okay. So when enabled on the stage API gateway
caches response from your endpoint for a specific
TTL. Okay, so let's just a period of time
have expired right, or Time To Live. API gateway
responds to requests by looking up the responses
from the cache. So instead of making a request
to the endpoint, okay, and the reason you're
gonna want to do this is going to reduce the
number of calls To your endpoint, which is
going to save you money. And it's going to
prove latency for the requests made to your
API, which is going to lead to a great experience.
So definitely, you might want to turn on.
So we're gonna look at cores now. And this
stands for cross origin resource sharing.
And this is to address the issue of same origin
policy. So same origin policy protects us
against Xs s attacks, but there are times
when we actually do want to access things
from another domain name, okay, that's not
from our own. And so that's what corps allows
you to do causes kind of like this document
or these header files, which say, Okay, this
domain is okay. To run scripts on. Okay. And
so an API gateway, this is something we're
going to be commonly turning on. Because by
default, cores is not enabled. And so you're
gonna have to enable it for the entire API
or particular endpoints, like the cores that
you want to like the headers, you want to
be passed along with those endpoints. And
so here, you'd say, Okay, well, posts are
allowed options are allowed and see where
it says access cross origin allow, you're
doing a wildcard saying everything's allowed.
Okay? So that's how you would set it. But
you know, just understand what causes and
korres is a is these headers that say, this
domain is allowed, allowed access to run these
things from this location, okay. And so of
course, is always enforced by the client cores
being the browser. Okay, so the core, that
means that the browser is going to look for
cores, and if it has cores, then it's going
to, you know, do something, okay. So there
you go. So there's this common vulnerability
called cross site scripting, exe, s s attacks.
And this is when you have a script, which
is trying to be executed from another website,
on your website. And it's for malicious reasons.
Because a lot of people when they're trying
to do something malicious, they're not going
to be doing it from your site, because that's
from you. It's gonna be from somebody else.
So in order to prevent that, by default, web
browsers are going to restrict the ability
to execute scripts that are cross site from
another site. But in order to allow scripts
to be executed, you need a same origin policy,
okay? That's the concept of the browser saying,
Okay, these scripts are allowed to execute
from another website. So again, web browsers
do enforce this by default. But if you're
using tools, such as postman and curl, they're
going to ignore same origin policy. So if
you're ever wondering why something's not
working, cross site, it's going to likely
be this.
Right, so we're on to the API gateway cheat
sheet. So API gateway is a solution for creating
secure API's in your cloud environment at
any scale, create API's that act as a front
door for applications to access data, business
logic or functionality from back end services,
API gateway thralls, API endpoints at 10,000
requests per second. We didn't mention that
in the core content, but it's definitely exam
question that might come up where they're
like, Oh, you have something, you're going
beyond 10,000. And it's not working? Well.
That's the reason why is that there's a hard
limit of 10,000 requests per second. And then
you have to ask for a increase a service level
increase at the support stages allow you to
have multiple published versions of your API.
So prod staging QA. Each stage has an invoke
URL, which is the endpoint you use to interact
with your API, you can use a custom domain,
domain for your invoke URL. So it could be
API dot example code to be a bit prettier.
You need to publish your API via the deploy
API action, you choose which which stage you
want to publish your API. And you have to
do this every single time you make a change.
It's annoying, but you have to do it. Resources
are URLs. So just think forward slash projects.
resources can have child resources, resources.
So the child here being hyphen, Id edit hyphen,
hyphen, hyphen is like a syntax is saying
this is a custom variable. That could be three,
four to sign an exam question, but it's good
for you to know. You define multiple methods
on your resources. So you're gonna have your
get post, delete, whatever you want. cores
issues are common with API gateway cores can
be enabled on all or individual endpoints.
caching improves latency and reduces the amount
of calls made to your endpoint. Same origin
policies help to prevent excess attacks, same
origin policies ignore tools like postman
or curl. So similar to policies just don't
work with those or don't work. But it just
the ease that so you can work with those tools.
cores is also enforced by the client client
would be the browser. So cores, the browser
is going to definitely look for course headers
and interpret them. You can require authorization
to to your API via Ava's cognito or a custom
lambda. So just so you know, you can protect
the calls to
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro, and
we are looking at Amazon kinesis, which is
a scalable and durable real time data streaming
service. As to ingest and analyze data in
real time from multiple sources. So again,
Amazon kinesis is AWS is fully managed solution
for collecting, processing and analyzing street
streaming data in the cloud. So when you need
real time, think kinesis. So some examples
where kinesis would be of use stock prices,
game data, social media data, geospatial data,
clickstream data, and kinesis has four types
of streams, we have kinesis data streams,
kinesis, firehose delivery streams, kinesis,
data analytics, and kinesis video analytics,
and we're going to go through all four of
them. So we're gonna first take a look at
kinesis data streams. And the way it works
is you have producers on the left hand side,
which are going to produce data, which is
going to send it to the kinesis data stream,
and that data stream is going to then ingest
that data. And it has shards, so it's going
to take that data and distributed amongst
its shards. And then it has consumers. And
so consumers with data streams, you have to
manually configure those yourself using some
code. But the idea is you have these two instances
that are specialized to then consume that
data and then send it to something in particular.
So we have a consumer that is specialized
to sending data to redshift than dynamodb
than s3, and then EMR, okay, so whatever you
want the consumer to send it to, it can send
it wherever it wants. But the great thing
about data streams is that when data enters
into the stream, it persists for quite a while.
So it will be there for 24 hours, by default,
you could extend it up to 160 68 hours. So
if you need to do more with that data, and
you want to run it through multiple consumers,
or you want to do something else with it,
you can definitely do that with it. The way
you pay for kinesis data streams, it's like
spinning up a new CPU instance, except you're
spinning up shards, okay. And that's what's
going to be the cost there. So as long as
the shard is running, you pay X amount of
costs for X amount of shards. And that is
kinesis data. So onto kinesis firehose delivery
stream, similar to data streams, but it's
a lot simpler. So the way it works is that
it also has producers and those producers
send data into kinesis firehose. The difference
here is that as soon as data is ingested,
so like a consumer consumes that data, it
immediately disappears from the queue. Okay,
so data is not being persisted. The other
trade off here is that you can only choose
one consumer. So you have a few options, you
can choose s3, redshift, Elasticsearch, or
Splunk, generally, people are going to be
outputting to s3. So there's a lot more simplicity
here. But there's also limitations around
it. The nice thing though, is you don't have
to write any code to consume data. But that's
the trade off is you don't have any flexibility
on how you want to consume the data, it's
very limited. firehose can do some manipulations
to the data that is flowing through it, I
can transform the data. So if you have something
where you want it from JSON, you want to convert
it to parkette. There are limited options
for this. But the idea is that you can put
it into the right data format, so that if
it gets inserted into s3, so maybe Athena
would be consuming that, that it's now in
parkette file, which is optimized for Athena,
it can also compress the file. So just simply
zip them, right. There's different compression
methods, and it can also secure them. So there's
that advantage. The big advantage is firehose
is very inexpensive, because you only pay
for what you consume. So only data that's
ingested is what you what you pay for you
kind of think of it like I don't know, even
lambda or fargate. So the idea is you're not
paying for those running shards, okay. And
it's just simpler to use. And so if you don't
need data retention, it's a very good. Okay,
on to kinesis video streams. And as the name
implies, it is for ingesting video data. So
you have producers, and that's going to be
sending either video or audio encoded data.
And that could be from security cameras, web
cameras, or maybe even a mobile phone. And
that data is going to go into kinesis video
streams, it's going to secure and retain that
encoded data so that you can consume it from
services that are used for analyzing video
and audio data. So you got Sage maker recognition,
or maybe you need to use TensorFlow or you
have a custom video processing or you have
something that has like HL based video playback.
So that's all there is to it. It's just so
you can analyze and process a video streams
applying like ml or video processing service.
Now we're gonna take a look at kinesis data
analytics. And the way it works is that it
takes an input stream and then it has an output
stream. And these can either be firehose or
data streams. And the idea is you're going
to be passing information data analytics What
this service lets you do is it lets you run
custom SQL queries so that you can analyze
your data in real time. So if you have to
do real time reporting, this is the service
you're going to want to use. The only downside
is that you have to use two streams. So it
can get a little bit expensive. But for data
analytics, it's it's really great. So that's
all there is. So it's time to look at kinesis
cheat sheet. So Amazon kinesis is the ADA
solution for collecting, processing and analyzing
streaming data in the cloud. When you need
real time, think kinesis. There are four types
of streams, the first being kinesis data streams,
and that's a you're paying per shard that's
running. So think of an EC two instance, you're
always paying for the time it's running. So
kinesis data streams is just like that data
can persist within that stream data is ordered,
and every consumer keeps its own position,
consumers have to be manually added. So they
have to be coded to consume, which gives you
a lot of custom flexibility. Data persists
for 24 hours by default, up to 168 hours.
Now looking at kinesis firehose, you only
pay for the data that is ingested, okay, so
think of like lambdas, or fargate. The idea
is that you're not paying for a server that's
running all the time. It's just data, it's
ingested, data immediately disappears. Once
it's processed consumer, you only have the
choice from a predefined set of services to
either get s3, redshift, Elasticsearch, or
Splunk. And they're not custom. So you're
stuck with what you got kinesis data analytics
allows you to perform queries in real time.
So it needs kinesis data streams or farfalle
firehose as the input and the output, so you
have to have two additional streams to use
a service which makes it a little bit of expensive.
Then you have kinesis video analytics, which
is for securely ingesting and storing video
and audio encoder data to consumers such as
Sage maker, recognition or other services
to apply machine learning and video processing.
to actually send data to the streams, you
have to either use kpl, which is the kinesis
Producer library, which is like a Java library
to write to a stream. Or you can write data
to a stream using the ABS SDK kpl is more
efficient, but you have to choose what you
need to do in your situation. So there is
the kinesis cheat sheet.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown. And we are looking
at AWS storage gateway, which is used for
extending and backing up on premise storage
to storage gateway provides you seamless and
secure integration between your organization's
on premise IT environment, and ABS AWS storage
infrastructure, we can securely store our
data to the newest cloud. And it's scalable
and cost effective in uses virtual machine
images in order to facilitate this on your
on premise system. So it supports both VMware
ESXi and Microsoft Hyper V. And once it's
installed and activate, you can use Eva's
console to create your gateway. Okay, so there
is an on premise component and a cloud component
to connect those two things. And we have three
different types of gateways, which we're going
to get into now. So the three types of gateways,
we have file gateway, which uses NFS, or SMB,
which is used for storing your files in s3,
then you have volume gateway, which is using
iSCSI. And this is intended as a backup solution.
And we have two different methods of storing
those volumes. And then the last is tape gateway,
which, which is for backing up your virtual
tape library. Here we're looking at file gateway.
And what it does is it allows you to use either
the NFS, or SMB protocol, so that you can
create a mount point so that you can treat
s3, just like a local hard drive or local
file system. And so I always think of file
gateway as extending your local storage onto
s3. Okay, and there's some details here we
want to talk about, so ownership permissions,
and timestamps are all stored with an s3 metadata.
For the objects that are associated with the
file, Once the file is transferred to s3,
it can be managed as a native s3 objects and
bucket policies versioning lifecycle Lifecycle
Management, cross region replication apply
directly to your object stored in your bucket.
So not only do you get to use s3, like a normal
file system or hard drive, you also get all
the benefits of s3.
Now we're going to look at the second type
of storage gateway volume gateway. So volume
gateway presents your application with disk
volumes using internet small computer systems
interface. So iSCSI block protocol. Okay,
so the idea is that you have your local storage
volume and using this protocol through storage
gateway, we're going to able to interact with
s3 and store a backup of our storage volume
as an EBS snapshot, this is going to depend
on the type of volume gateway we use because
there are two different types and we'll get
into that out of the slide. But let's just
get through what we have here in front of
us. So the data is written to the volumes
and can be asynchronously backed up as a point
in time snapshot of the volume and stored
in cloud as an EBS snapshots. snapshots are
incremental backups that capture only change
blocks in the volume. All snapshots, storage
is also compressed to help minimize your storage
charges. So I like to think of this as giving
you the power of EBS locally, because if you
were to use EBS on AWS. It does all these
cool things for you, right, but so it's just
treating your local drives as like EBS drives,
and it's doing this alter s3. So let's let's
go look at the two different types here. So
the first type is volume gateway for storage
vault volumes. And the key thing is that it's
where the primary data is being stored. Okay,
so the primary data is stored locally while
asynchronously backing up the data to AWS.
So you're all your local data is here, and
then you just get your backup on AWS. So it
provides on premise applications with low
latency access to the entire data set while
still providing durable offset backups. It
creates storage volumes and mounts them as
ice FCS devices from your on premise servers.
As we saw in the last illustration, any data
written to the stored volumes are stored on
your on premise storage hardware. That's what
this is saying here with the primary data.
EBS snapshots are backed up to a database
s3 and stored volumes can be between one gigabyte
to 16 terabytes in size. Let's take a look
at cached volume. So the difference here between
stored volumes cache volumes is the primary
data stored on AWS. And we are caching the
most frequently accessed files. So that's
the difference here. And the key thing to
remember between storage volume or storage
volumes and cache volumes is where the primary
data is. So why would we want to do this?
Well, it minimizes the need to scale your
on premise storage infrastructure while still
providing your applications with low latency
data access, create storage volumes up to
32 terabytes in size and attach them as I
SCSI devices, from your on premise servers,
your gateway stores data that you will write
to these volumes in s3 and retain recently
read data in your on premise storage. So just
caching those most frequently files, gateway
cache and upload buffer storage cache volumes
can be between one gigabyte and 32 gigabytes
in size. So there you go, that is volume gateway.
We're looking at the third type of storage
gateway tape gateway. And as the name implies,
it's for backing up virtual tape libraries
to AWS. So it's a durable cost effective solution
to archive your data in AWS. You can leverage
existing tape based backup application infrastructure,
stores data virtual tape cartridges that you
create on your tape gateway, each tape gateway
is pre configured with a media changer and
tape drives. I know I'm not showing that in
here. But you know, I think it's just better
to see the simpler visualization, but which
are available to your existing client backup
applications. Ice SCSI devices, you add tape
cartridges as you need to archive your data,
and it supports these these different tape
tape services. Okay, so got veem you got backup,
exact net backup. There's also one from Symantec,
Symantec that's called Backup Exec, I don't
know, used to be there got bought out, I don't
know. So I just listed this one. So maybe
I made a mistake there. But it's not a big
deal. But the point is, is that you have virtual
tape libraries, and you want to store them
on s3, and it's going to be using s3 Glacier
because of course that is for long, long storage.
So there you go. That's it.
So we're at the end of storage gateway. And
here I have a storage gateway cheat sheet
which summarizes everything that we've learned.
So let's start at the top here, storage gateway
connects on premise storage to Cloud Storage.
So it's a hybrid storage solution. There are
three types of gateways file gateway, volume,
gateway and tape gateway, Vol gateway, lets
s3 act as a local file system using NFS or
SMB. And the easy way to think about this
is think of like a local hard drive being
extended into s3. Okay. Volume gateway is
used for backups and has two types stored
and cached. Stored volume gateway continuously
backs backs up local storage to s3 as EBS
snapshots, and it's important for you remember
that the primary data is on premises that's
what's going to help you remember the difference
between stored and cached. Storage volumes
are between one gigabyte to 16 terabytes in
size, cache volume gateway caches the most
frequently used files on premise and the primary
data is stored on s3 again, remember the difference
between where the primary data is being stored.
cache volumes are one gigabytes, between three
to gigabytes in size and tape gateway backs
up virtual tapes to s3 Glacier for long archival
storage. So there you go, we're all done with
storage. Hey, this is Andrew Brown. And we
are going to do another follow along. And
this is going to touch multiple services.
The core to it is lambda, but we're going
to do static website hosting, use dynamodb
use SNS and API gateway, we're all going to
glue it together, because I have built here
a contact form, and we are going to get it
hosted and make it serverless. Okay, so let's
get to it. So, um, we're gonna first try to
get this website here hosted on s3, okay,
and so what I want you to do is make your
way to the s3 console, you can just go up
to services here and type s3 and click here
and you will arrive at the same location.
And we're going to need two buckets. So I've
already registered a domain called Frankie
Lyons calm here in route 53. Okay, and we're
going to have to copy that name exactly here
and create two buckets, okay, and these buckets
are going to have to be the exact name as
the domain name. So we're going to first do
the naked domain, which is just Frankie Lyons,
calm, okay. And then we're going to need to
do the second one here, once this creates,
it's taking its sweet time, we're gonna have
to do that with the sub domain, okay. And
so now we have both our buckets, okay. And
so now we're going to click into each one
in turn on static website hosting. So going
to management over here, or sorry, properties,
there is a box here called static website
hosting. And we're going to have this one
redirect to our subdomain here. So we'll do
ww dot, I'm not even gonna try to spell that.
So I'm just gonna copy paste it in there.
Okay. And we're just going to hit save. Alright,
and so we have a static website hosting redirect
set up here. And then we're going to go to
back to Amazon s3 and turn on static website
hosting for this one here. So we're going
to go to properties, and set static website
hosting and use this bucket. And we're going
to make it index dot HTML error dot html.
And yeah, that's good. So now we have our
other stuff turned on, this is going to need
to be public facing because it is a bucket.
So we're going to go over to our permissions
here and edit the block public access. And
we're going to have to hit Save here, okay.
And we just need to type confirm. Okay. And
now we should be able to, we should be able
to upload content here. So let's go ahead
and upload our website here. So I do have
it on my, my desktop here under a folder called
web. So this is all the stuff that we need
to run it probably not the package dot JSON
stuff. So I'm just going to go ahead here
and grab this, okay. And we're just going
to click and drag that there. And we'll just
upload it. Okay, and that won't take too long
here. And now if we want to preview the static
website hosting, we're going to go to our
properties here, and just right click on this
endpoint to or I guess you can right click,
we'll just copy it. Okay. And we'll just give
it a paste and give it a look here. So we're
getting a 403 forbidden, um, this shouldn't
be the case, because we have it. Oh, you know,
it's not WW. Oh, no, and just www. So that's
a bit confusing, because we should have this
turned on. So I think what it is, is that
I need to update the bucket policy. Okay,
so I'm just going to go off screen here and
grab the bucket policy, it's on the database
documentations, I just can't remember it off
the top my head. So I just did a quick Google
on static website hosting bucket policy. And
I arrived here on a device docs. And so what
we need is we need this policy here. Okay.
And so I'm just going to go copy it here.
And I'm going to go back to s3, and I'm going
to paste in this bucket policy. Now I do need
to change this to match the bucket name here.
So we'll just copy that here at the top. Okay,
and so what we're doing is we're saying allow,
allow read access to all the files within
this bucket, okay. And this said, we can name
it whatever you want, it's actually optional,
I'm just gonna remove it to clean it up here,
okay. And we should be able to save this.
Okay, and we are and now this bucket has public
access. So if we go back to this portal three
here, and do refresh, our website is now up.
So there is a few other things we need to
do. So this form when we submit it, I wanted
to send off an email via SNS, and I also want
it to, I want it to also stored in Dynamo
dB, so we have a reference of it. So let's
go ahead and set up an SNS topic and then
we'll proceed to do Alright, so let's make
our way over to SNS here. So I'm just gonna
go back up to the top here. Just click down
services here and type SNS and we're going
to open this up in a new tab. Because it's
great to have all these things open. And we'll
just clear out these ones here. Okay? And
we're going to get to SNS here, and what I'm
going to do is on the first time I'm here,
so I get this big display here, but a lot
of times, you can just click the hamburger
here and get to what you want. So I'm just
going to go to topics on the left hand side,
because that's what we need to create here.
I'm going to create a topic. And I'm going
to name this topic, um, Frankie Alliance.
Okay, so I'm just going to grab that domain
name here. Okay, I'm just gonna say topic
here. And I don't need an optional display
name, I guess it depends, because sometimes
it's used in the actual email here that's
actually displayed. So I'm just going to copy
this here and just put F, and here, Frankie
Alliance, okay, I think we can have uppercase
there. And we have a few options here, we
can encrypt it, I'm not going to bother with
that, we can set our access policy, we're
gonna leave that, by default, we have this
ability to do retries, we're not doing HTTP,
we're going to be using this for email. So
this doesn't matter. And, you know, the rest
are not important. So I'm going to hit Create
topic here. Okay, and what that's going to
do is that's going to create an Arn for us.
And so we're going to have to come back to
this later to utilize that there. Okay. But
what we're going to need to do is if we want
to receive emails from here, we're going to
have to subscribe to this topic. So down below,
we'll hit the Create subscription here. And
we're going to choose the protocol. And so
I want it to be email, and I'm
going to choose Andrew at exam pro.co. All
right, I'm just gonna drop down here, see
if there's anything else no, nothing important.
And
I'm just gonna hit Create subscription. So
what what's that that is going to do? It's
going to send me a confirmation email to say,
hey, do you really want to subscribe to this?
So you're going to get emails, I'm going to
say yes, so I'm just going to flip over to
my email here, and go ahead and do that. Alright,
and so here came the email was nearly instantaneous.
And so I'm just going to hit the confirmation
here, okay. And now that's going to confirm
my subscription. Okay, so that means I'm going
to now receive emails if something gets pushed
to that topic. All right. So yeah, if we go
back to SNS here, you can see it was in a
pending state, if we just do a refresh here.
Okay, now we have a confirmation. So there
you go. Um, now we can move on to creating
our Dynamo DB table. Alright, so now that
we have SNS, let's proceed to create our Dynamo
DB table. So I want to go to services at the
top here, type in Dynamo dB. And we will open
this up in a new tab because we will have
to come back to all these other things here.
And we're just gonna wait for this to load
and we're going to create ourselves a dynamodb
table. So we'll hit Create. And I'm going
to name this based off my domain name. So
I'm gonna say Frankie Alliance. And we need
to set a partition key. So a good partition
key is something that is extremely unique,
like a user ID, or in this case, an email.
So we'll use that as email. And then for the
sort key, we are going to use a created date.
Okay, so there is no date time, data structure
here in dynamodb. So we'll just have to go
with a string, and that's totally fine. And
there are some defaults here. So it says no
secondary indexes, provision, capacity five,
and five, etc, etc. So we're just going to
turn that off, and we're gonna override this
ourselves. So there is the provisioned, and
we can leave it at provision, I'd rather just
go Yeah, we'll leave it at provision for the
time being. But I'm going to override these
values. So I'm just gonna say one and one,
okay. And the reason why is just because I
don't imagine we're gonna have a lot of traffic
here. So being able to do one Read, read and
writes per second should be extremely capable
for us here, right? So this should be no issue.
And then we'll just go down below, this is
all fine. We could also encrypt this at rest,
I'm just gonna leave that alone. Okay, and
that all looks good to me. So I'm going to
hit Create there. Okay, and so this table
is just going to create here and so what we're
looking for is that Arn. So once we have the
Arn for the table, then we will be able to
go ahead and hook that up into our lambda
code. Okay. So yeah, this all looks great.
Um, so I guess maybe the next thing is now
to actually get the lambda function they're
working. So maybe we'll do that or I guess
we could go ahead and actually put this behind
CloudFront and hook up the domain. I think
we'll do that first. Okay, so we're gonna
go and do some CloudFront here, sem rush.
So I guess the next thing here is to actually
get our, our proper domain here, so we're
not using the AWS one. So I've actually already
registered a domain here and I might actually
include it from another tutorial here are
those steps here. So if you feel that there
is a jargon section, it's just because I am
bringing that in over here. But we already
have the domain name. And so once you have
your domain name, that means that you can
go ahead and start setting up CloudFront and
ACM. So we're gonna want to do ACM first.
So we're going to type in ACM here. Okay,
that's Amazon certificate manager. And that's
how we're going to get our SSL domain, make
sure you click on the one on the left hand
side provision certificates, because this
one is like $500. Starting, so it's very expensive.
So just click this over here to provision
just make sure again, that is the public certificate
and not the private private, again, is very
expensive, we're going to hit request,
we're going to put the domain name in. So
we have the domain name there, I'm always
really bad at spelling it. So I'm just gonna
grab it here. Let's really hold it, we don't
need spelling mistakes.
And we're going to have the naked domain.
And we're also going to do wildcard. And so
just by doing this, we're going to cover all
our bases of the naked and all all subdomains.
So I strongly recommend that you go ahead
and do this, when you are creating your certificates,
we're going to hit Next we're going to use
DNS validation email is just a very old way,
nobody really does it that way anymore. We're
going to hit review, we're gonna hit confirm
request, okay. And so what's happening here
is that it's going it's now in pending validation.
And so we need to confirm that we own this
domain. And so we need to add a record to
our domain name, since our domain name is
hosted on Route 53, that's going to make it
very easy to add these records, it's going
to be one click of a button. So I'm just gonna
go ahead here and hit create, and then go
here and hit Create. Okay, and so um, yeah,
this shouldn't take too long, we'll hit continue,
okay. And we're just going to wait for this
to go pending to issued, okay, this is not
going to take very long, it takes usually
a few minutes here. So we're just going to
wait, I'm going to go grab a coconut water,
and I'll be back here shortly. Alright, so
I'm back here, and it only took us a few minutes
here. And the status has now issued, so meaning
our SSL certificate is ready for use. So that
means we can now create our CloudFront distribution.
So what I want you to do is go up to here
and type in CloudFront. Okay. And we're going
to make our way over to CloudFront. So, here
we are in CloudFront. And we're just going
to create ourselves a new distribution, we
have web and rtmp, we're not going to be using
rtmp. This is for Adobe Flash media server.
And very rarely does anyone ever use Adobe
anymore, so it's going to have to be the web
distribution. And we're gonna have to go through
the steps here. So the first thing is, we
need to select our actual bucket here. So
we are going to be doing this for the www,
okay. And we're going to restrict bucket access,
because we don't want people directly accessing
the website via this URL here, we want to
always be through the domain name. So that's
what this option is going to allow us to do.
It's going to create a new origin identity,
we can just let it do as it pleases, we need
to grant permission. So I'm gonna say yes,
update my bucket policy. So that should save
us a little bit of time there. Now on to the
behavior settings, we're going to want to
redirect HTTP to HTTPS, because really, no
one should be using HTTP, we are going to
probably need to allow we'll probably have
this forget. And head I was just thinking
whether we need post and patch. But that's
only four if we were uploading files to s3
through education. So I think we can just
leave it as get get in head. So we're fine
there. We're just going to keep on scrolling
down here, we're not gonna restrict access
to this is a public website, we're just going
to drop down and choose US, Canada and Europe,
you can choose best performance, I just feel
this is going to save me some time because
it does take a long time for this thing to
distribution to create. So the fewer edge
locations, I think the less time it takes
to create that distribution, we're going to
need to put our alternate domain name in here.
So that is just our domain names, we're going
to put www dot and again, I don't want to
spell it wrong. So I'm just going to copy
it here manually. Okay. Back to CloudFront
here and we'll just do Frankie lines calm.
Now we need to choose our custom SSL, we will
drop down here and choose Frankie Alliance
Comm. Okay, and we need to set our default
route object that's going to be index dot
HTML. That's how it knows to look at your
index HTML page right off the bat. Okay, and
that's everything. So we're gonna hit Create
distribution. And luckily, there are no errors.
There are no errors. So we are in good shape
here. I'm not sure why it took me here. So
I'm just going to click here to see if it
actually created that distribution. It's very
strange, it usually takes you to the distribution
page there. Okay, but it is creating that
distribution. Okay, so we're gonna wait in
progress. This does take a considerable amount
of time. So go take a shower, go take a walk,
go watch an episode of Star Trek, and we will
be back here shortly. So our distribution
is created. It took about 20 minutes for this
to create. I did kind of forget to tell you
that we have to create two distributions.
So sorry about that, but we're going to have
to go ahead and make another one. So we have
one here for the www, but we're going to need
one for the naked domain. So I want you to
go to create distribution and go to web. And
for the domain name, it's going to be slightly
different. Okay, so instead of selecting the
bucket, what I want you to do is I want to
go back to s3. And I want you to go to the
bucket with the naked domain. And we're going
to go to properties here, okay. And at a static
website hosting, I don't want you to copy
everything. For the end point here with the
exception of the HTTP, colon, forward slash
forward slash, okay. And we're just going
to copy that. And we're going to paste that
in as the domain name. All right, so we're
not going to autocomplete anything that I
want you to hit tab, so that it autocompletes
this origin ID here. And then we can proceed.
So we will redirect HTTP to HTTPS.
We'll just scroll down here. So this is all
good. The only thing is, we want to change
our price class to you the first one here,
okay, we're going to need to put that domain
name in there. So we'll just copy it here
from s3, and paste that in, we're going to
need to choose our custom SSL drop down to
our SSL from ACM. And we'll leave everything
else blank. And we'll create that distribution.
So now it's going to be another long wait.
And I will talk to you in a bit here. So after
waiting 20 minutes, our second distribution
is complete, I want you to make note that
for the naked domain, we were pointing to
that endpoint for the static s3, website hosting,
and for the WW, we are pointing to the actual
s3 bucket, this doesn't matter. Otherwise,
this redirect won't work. Okay, so just make
sure this one is not set to the bucket. Alright.
So now that we have our two distributions
deployed, we can now start hooking them up
to our custom domain name. Alright, so I want
you to make your way over to route 53, we're
going to go to hosted zones on the left hand
side, we're going to click into that domain
name. And we're going to add two record sets,
we're gonna add one record set for the naked
domain, and then the www Alright, so we're
gonna leave that blank there, choose alias.
And we're going to drop down here, and we're
going to choose that CloudFront distribution.
Now, there are two distributions, there's
no chance of you selecting the incorrect one,
because it's only going to show the one that
matches for the domain. Alright, so we'll
hit create for the naked domain, and then
we'll add another one. And we'll go to www,
and we're gonna go to alias, and we're going
to choose the www CloudFront distribution.
All right, and now that those are both created,
we can go ahead and just grab this domain
name here and give it a test. Okay, and so
it's working, we're on our custom domain name.
Now, definitely, you want to check all four
cases. So with, with and without the WW. And
with and without the s for SSL. And then in
combination of so that one case works will
try without the WW. Okay, it redirects as
expected, okay, and we will try now without
the SSL and make a domain. And it works as
expected. And we will just try it without
the S here. And so all four cases work, we
are in great shape. If anyone ever reports
to the your website's not working, even though
it's working for you just check all those
four cases, maybe there is a issue there.
Alright. So now that we have route 53, pointing
to our distributions and our custom domain
hooked up, we need to do a little bit of work
here with our www. Box bucket there because
when we first created this policy, we added
this statement here, which allowed access
to this bucket. And then when we created our
CloudFront distribution, we told it to only
allow access from that bucket. So it added
this, this statement here, all right. And
so this one was out of convenience, because
we weren't using a custom domain. And so we
only want this website to be accessible through
CloudFront. And this is still allowing it
from the original endpoint domain. So if we
were to go to management, I'm just going to
show you what I mean, I'm sorry, properties.
And we were to go to this endpoint here. All
right, we're going to see that it's still
accessible by this URL. So it's not going
through CloudFront. And we don't want people
directly accessing the bucket. We want everything
to go through CloudFront. So we get statistics
and other fine tuned control over access to
our website here. So what I want you to do
is I want you to go and back to your permissions
here and go to bucket policy and remove that
first statement. Okay. And we're going to
hit save. All right, and we're going to go
back to this endpoint, and we're going to
get a refresh. And we should get a 403. If
you don't get it immediately, immediately.
Sometimes chrome caches the browser's just
try another browser or just hit refresh until
it works. Because if you definitely have removed
that bucket policy, it should return a 403.
So now, the only way to access it and we'll
go back to the original one here is through
the domain name. So there you go. It's all
hooked up here and we can now proceed to actually
working with the landlord. Alright, so now
it's time to work with AWS lambda. And so
I prepared a function for you here in the
For a folder called function, and the idea
is we have this form here. And when we submit
it, it's going to go to API gateway and then
trigger this lambda function. Alright. And
those, that data will be inputted into this
function here. So it gets passed in through
event. And then it parses event body, which
will give us the return Jason of these fields
here, that we're going to use validate, which
is a, it's a third party library that we use
to do validations. Okay, so if I just open
up the constraints, file here, this uses,
this actually validates all these fields.
And so whether the input is valid or not,
it's going to either return an error to this
forum saying, hey, you have some mistakes.
If it is successful, then what it's going
to do. Alright, it's going to call this success
function, and then it will call insert, record
and send email. So these two things are in
two separate files here. So one is for Dynamo
dB, and one is for SNS. So when we say insert
record, we're saying we're going to insert
a record into the dynamodb table that we created.
And then for SNS, we're going to send that
email off. Alright, so this is a slightly
complex lambda function. But the reason I
didn't just make this one single file, which
could have been very easy is because I want
you to learn at the bare minimum of of a more
complex lambda functions, such as having to
upload via zip, and dealing with dependencies.
All right, so now that our, our we have a
little walkthrough there, let's actually get
this lambda function into the actual AWS platform.
All right. So before we can actually upload
this to AWS, we have to make sure that we
compile our dependencies. Now, I could easily
do this locally. But just in case, you don't
have the exact same environment as myself,
I'm gonna actually show you how to do this
via cloud nine. All right, so what I want
you to do is, we're just going to close that
tab here. And I want you to close these other
ones here and just leave one open. And we're
going to make our way over to cloud nine.
Okay, and so just before we create this environment,
can you double check to make sure that you
are in the correct region. So I seem to sit
on the border of US East, North Virginia,
and Ohio, and sometimes it likes to flip me
to the wrong region. So I'm gonna switch it
to North Virginia, this is super important,
because when we create our lambda functions,
if they're not in the same region, we're going
to have a bunch of problems. All right, so
just make sure that's North Virginia, and
go ahead and create your environment. Okay.
And I'm going to name this based off our domain
name. So I
should probably have that tab open there.
So I'm just gonna open up route 53. There,
okay. And I'm just going to copy the domain
name here. Okay, and I'm going to name it
for Randy Alliance.
Alright. And we're going to go to a next step.
And we are going to choose to micro because
it's the smallest instance, we're gonna use
Amazon Lex, because it's packed with a bunch
of languages pre installed for us. Cloud Nine
environments do shut off after 30 minutes,
so you won't be wasting your free credits.
Since it is a T two micro it is free tier
eligible. And the cost of using cloud nine
is just the cost of running the cloud, the
actual EC two instance underneath to run the
environment. So we're going to hit next step
here, we're going to create the environment
here. And now it will only take a few minutes,
and I will see you back shortly here. Oh,
so now we are in cloud nine. And I'm just
going to change the theme to a darker because
it's easier on my eyes, I'm also going to
change the mode to vim, you can leave it as
default vim is a complex keyboard setup. So
you may not want to do that. And now what
we can do is we can upload our code into Cloud
Nine. So that we can install the dependencies
for the specific Node JS version we are going
to need, so I want you to go to File and we're
going to go to upload local files. And then
on my desktop, here, I have the contact form,
it's probably a good idea, we grab both the
web and function, the web contains the actual
static website, and we will have to make adjustments
to that code. So we are just prepping ourselves
for a future step there. And so now that code
is uploaded, okay, so what we're looking to
do is we want to install the dependencies,
okay, because there, we need to also bundle
in whatever dependencies within this function,
so for it to work, and in order to know what
to install with, we need to know what version
of Node JS we're going to be using. And the
only way we're going to know is by creating
our own lambda function. Alright, so what
I want you to do is just use this other tab
here that I have open, and I'm going to go
to the lambda, the lambda interface here,
and we are going to go ahead and create our
first. All right, so let's proceed to create
our lambda function. And again, just make
sure you're in the same region so North Virginia
because it needs to be the Same one is the
cloud nine environment here. So we're going
to go ahead and create this function and we're
going to need to name it, I'm going to name
it the offeror engi. Alliance, okay? And I'm
gonna say contact form. Alright. And I believe
I spelt that correctly there, I'm just using
that as a reference up here. And we need to
choose a runtime. So we have a bunch of different
languages. So we have Ruby, Python, Java,
etc, etc, we were using no Gs. And so now
we, you can use 10, or eight point 10, it's
generally recommended to use 10. But there
are use cases where you might need to use
eight, and six is no longer supported. So
that used to be an option here, but it is
off of the table now, so to speak. So we need
to also set up permissions, we're not going
to have a role. So we're going to need to
create one here. So let's go ahead and let
this lambda create one for us. And we will
hit Create function, okay. And we're just
gonna have to wait a few minutes here for
it to create our lambda function. Okay, not
too long. And here's our function. Great.
So it's been created here. And the left hand
side, we have our triggers. So for our case,
it's going to be API gateway. And on the right
hand side, we have our permissions. And so
you can see, by default, it's giving us access
to cloud watch logs. And we are going to need
dynamodb and SNS in here. So we're going to
have to update those permissions, just giving
a quick scroll down here, we actually do have
a little cloud nine environment embedded in
here. And we could have actually done all
the code within here. But I'm trying to set
you up to be able to edit this web page. And
also, if the if your lambda function is too
large, then you actually can't use this environment
here. And so you'd have to do this anyway.
So I figured, we might as well learn how to
do it with the cloud nine way, alright, but
you could edit it in line, upload a zip file,
so as long as it's under 10 megabytes, you
can upload it and you should, more or less
be able to edit all those files. But if it
gets too big, then you have to supply it via
s3. Alright, so, um, yeah, we need to get
those additional permissions. And so we're
going to need to edit our, our roll, which
was created for us by default. All right,
let's make our way over to I am so just gonna
type in I am here. And once this loads here,
we're going to go to the left hand side, we're
going to go to a roles, and we're going to
start typing Frankie. So if he are, okay,
there's that role. And we're going to add,
attach a couple policies here. So we're gonna
give it we said SNS, right, we'll give it
full access. And we're
gonna give it dynamodb. And we'll give it
full access. Now, for the associate level,
it's totally appropriate to use full access.
But when you become a database professional,
you'll learn that you'll want to pair these
down to only give access to exactly the actions
that you need. But I don't want to burden
you with that much. Iam knowledge at this
time, all right, but you'll see in a moment,
because when we go back to, sorry, lambda
function, and we refresh here, okay, I'm just
hitting the manual refresh there, we're gonna
see what we have access to. So this is now
what we have access to, and we have a bunch
of stuff. So we don't just have access to
dynamodb. We have access to Dynamo DB accelerator,
we're not going to use that we have access
to easy to we don't need that we, we have
access to auto scaling, we probably don't
need that data pipeline. So that's the only
problem with using those full access things
as you get a bit more than what you want.
But anyway, for our purposes, it's totally,
totally fine. Okay, and so now that we have
our role, we want to get our code uploaded
here. So what I want you to do is I want you
to go back to cloud nine. All right, and we're
going to bundle this here. So down below,
we are in the correct directory environment.
But just to make sure we are in the same place,
I want you to type cd Tilda, which is for
home, and then type forward slash environment.
Okay, and then we're gonna type forward slash
function. All right, I want to show you a
little a little thing that I discovered is
that this top directory that says Frankie
Alliance is actually the environment directory,
for some reason, they name it differently
for your purpose. But just so you know, environment
is this folder here. Okay. And so now we know
our node version is going to be 10. I want
you to type in nvm, which stands for node
version manager type NBN list, and we're going
to see what versions of node we have installed
and which one is being used. And by default,
it's using 10. So we're already in great shape
to be installing our dependencies in the right
version. So I want you to do npm install,
or just I, which is the short form there.
Okay. And it's going to install all the dependencies
we need. We can see they were installed under
the node modules directory there. So we have
everything we want. And so now we just need
to download this here and bring it into our
lambda function. So we are going to need to
zip this here and then upload it to the lamda
interface here. So what I want you to do is
I want you to right click the function folder
here and click download and it's going to
download this to our download. folder here,
okay. And then I want you to unzip it, okay,
because we actually just want the contents
of it, we don't want this folder here. Alright.
And the idea is that we are just including
this node modules, which we didn't have earlier
here. And I'm just going to go ahead and compress
that. And then we're going to have an archive.
And I want you to make your way back to the
lamda interface here. And we're going to drop
down and upload a zip. Alright, and we are
going to upload that archive. Alright, and
then we will hit save so that it actually
uploads the archive, it doesn't take too long,
because you can see that it's less than a
megabyte. And so we can access our files in
here. All right. And again, if this was too
large, then it would actually not allow us
to even edit in here, and we'd still have
to do cloud nine. Alright. So now that our
code is uploaded, now we can go and try and
run it, or better yet, we will need to learn
how to sync it back to here, so that we can
further edit it. Okay. So what I want to just
show you quickly here in cloud nine is if
you go to the right hand side to AWS resources,
we have this lambda thing here. And again,
if we were in the wrong region, if we were
in US East two, in our cloud nine environment,
we wouldn't be able to see our function here.
But here's the remote function. And what we
can do is if we want to continuously edit
this, we can pull it to cloud nine, and edit
it here and then push it back and upload it.
So this is going to save us the trouble of
continuously zipping the folder. Now, you
could automate this process with cloudformation,
or other other serverless frameworks. But,
you know, I find this is very easy. It's also
a good opportunity to learn the functionalities
of cloud nine. So now that we have the remote
function here, I just want you to press this
button here to import the lambda function
to our local environment. And it's saying,
Would you like to import it? Yes, absolutely.
Okay. And so now, this is the function here,
and this is the one we're going to be working
with. So we can just ignore this one here.
All right. And so whenever we make a change,
we can then push this back, alright. And we
might end up having to do that here or not.
But I just wanted to show you that you have
this ability. All right. So actually, let's
actually try sinking it back, we're just going
to make some kind of superficial change something
that doesn't matter, I just want to show you
that you can do it. So we're going to just
type in anything here. So I'm just going to
type in for reggy. Just a comment, okay. And
I'm going to save this file here and see how
that was a period. Now it's green. So that
says it's been changed. And what I'm going
to do is I'm going to go up here and click
this, and I'm going to re import this function.
Alright, so I'm just going to hit this deploy.
Alright, and that's going to go ahead and
send the changes back, alright, to the remote
function here. Okay. And I'm just going to
hit our refresh here. All right. And then
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go back
to the land environment here, I'm just going
to give it a refresh here. And let's see if
our comment shows up. Okay, and so there you
are. So that's how we can sync changes between
cloud nine in here. And again, if this file
was too large, we wouldn't even be able to
see this. So Cloud Nine would be our only
convenience for doing this. So now that we
know how to do that, let's actually learn
how to test our function. So let's proceed
to doing that. So now let's go ahead and test
our function out. And so we can do here is
create a new test event. Alright, and so I've
prepared one here for us. Okay, so we have
a JSON with body. And then we have a string
of five JSON, because that's how it would
actually come in from API gateway. All right,
and so I'm just going to do a contact form,
test contact form, okay? And hit Create there.
And so now we have this thing that we can
test out. All right, and so I'm just going
to go ahead and hit test, and we're going
to get a failure and that's totally, totally
fine because if we scroll down, it actually
tells us that we have an undefined a table
name. Alright. And the reason why we have
an undefined table name is because we actually
haven't configured our SNS topic, like it's
our an ID or the dynamodb table. So what we're
going to need to do is we're gonna need to
supply this function with that information
and I believe we have them as environment
variables, that's how they're specified. So
if I was to go back to cloud nine here, and
we were to look maybe in Dynamo dB, I'm just
looking at where we actually configure the
actual table name here. Okay, um, there it
is. So see where it says process envy table
name, so that means is expecting a down here
in the environment. We are expecting under
our environment variables where our environment
variables, here they are, so we're expecting
a table name. And we're also for SNS, we are
expecting the topic Arn. Okay, so we need
to Go grab those two things there. And we
will have better luck this time around. So
I'm going to go and look for dynamodb here.
Okay, and I'm going to also get SNS. And we
will go ahead and swap those in. So for our
table, it's just called Frankie Alliance.
So that's not too complicated. Okay. And we
will just apply it there. And then for SNS,
we might actually have an additional topic
here since the last time we were here, and
we need the Arn. So we're going to go in here
and grab this. Okay, we need the Arn. All
right. And so I'll paste that in there. And
we will hit save. Okay, and we will give this
a another trial. So let's go ahead and hit
that test button and see what we get this
time around. Fingers crossed. And look, we
got a success here. All right. So if we were
to wanting to take a look at the results of
this, if we go down to monitoring here, okay,
and we go to View cloud watch logs, we can
actually see our errors and our success rates.
Okay. So here, we have a couple logs, I'm
just gonna open up this one here. Alright.
And so we can see here that the body was passed
along. And it inserted into the dynamodb.
table there. And it also did the SNS response.
And so these are all just the console logs
that I have within the actual code. So if
you're wondering where these are coming from,
it's just these console logs here. Okay, so
I set those up so that I'd have an idea for
that. So let's actually go take a look at
dynamodb and see if our record exists. And
there it is. So it's added to the database.
So now the real question is, have we gotten
an email, notification. And so I'm just going
to hop over to my email, and we're going to
take a quick look now.
Alright, so here I am in my email, and we
literally got this email in less than a minute.
And here is the information that has been
provided to us. So there you go, our lambda
function is working as expected. And so now
that we have that working, the next big thing
is actually to hook up our actual actual form
to this lambda function. And so in order to
do that, we are going to need to set up API
gateway. So that that form has somewhere to
send its data to. So let's proceed over to
API gateway. And we are going to create our
own API gateway, Kool
Aid. Okay, hello, let's go. So here we are
at the API gateway. And if you need to figure
out how to get here, just type API up here
in the services. And we will be at this console.
And we will get started. And we'll just hit
X here, I don't care what they're saying here.
And we're going to hit new API, make sure
it's rest. And we're going to name it as we
have a naming everything here. So I'm going
to call this for Engie. Alliance, okay. And
the endpoint is original, that's totally fine
here. And we will go ahead and create that
API. So now our API has been created. And
we have this our default route here, okay.
And so we can add multiple resources or methods,
we can totally just work with this route here.
But I'm going to add a resource here, and
I'm going to call it a transmit, okay. Okay.
And I'm just going to name it the same up
here. And we're also going to want to enable
API gateway course, we do not want to be dealing
with course issues. So we will just checkbox
that there. And we'll go ahead and create
that resource. Okay, and so now we have a
resource. And by default, we'll have options.
We don't care about options, we want to have
a new method in here, and we are going to
make it a post. Okay. And we are going to
do that there. And it's actually going to
be a lambda function. That's what we want
it to have. All right. And do we want to use
the lambda integration proxy requests will
be proxy to lambda with request details available
in your event? Yes, we do. That sounds good
to me. And then we can specify the lamda region
is US East one, and then the lambda function.
So here, we need to supply the lambda function
there. So we're going to make our way back
to that lambda function there. So we have
this SNS topic, I'm just going to go over
here and go back to lambda. And we're going
to grab the name of that lambda function and
go back to API gateway and supply it there.
Okay, and then we're going to go ahead and
save that. Yes, we are cool with that. Okay.
And we'll hit Save there. And so now our lambda
function is kind of hooked up here. We might
have to fiddle with this a little bit more.
But if we go back to our our lamda console
here and hit refresh. Now on the left hand
side, we should see API gateway. So API gateway
is now a trigger. Okay? So yeah, we will go
back to API gateway here. Alright, so now
to just test out this function to see if it's
working, I'm going to go to test here and
we have some things we can fill in like query
strings, headers, and the request body. So
flipping back to here, you're going to probably
wonder why I had this up here. Well, it was
to test for this box here. And so I'm just
gonna just slightly change it here. So we'll
just change it to Riker. Okay, and we're gonna
say bye. Okay. All right. And so, you know,
now that I have this slight variation here,
I'm just going to paste that in there. And
hit test. Okay. And it looks like it has worked.
So we can just double check that by going
to a dynamodb here and doing a refresh here.
And so the second record is there. Obviously
in cloud watch, if we were to go back here
and refresh, okay, we are going to have updated
logs within here. Alright, so not sure if
the logs are showing up here. There is Riker.
So he is in there. So our API gateway endpoint
is now working as expected. Okay. So now what
we need to do is we need to publish this API
gateway
endpoint. Okay, so let's go ahead and do that.
All right. Okay. Hello, let's go. So in order
to publish our API, what we're going to need
to do is deploy it. Okay. So anytime you make
changes, you always have to deploy your API.
So I'm going to go ahead here and hit deploy
API. And we're going to need to choose a stage,
we haven't created any stages yet. So I'm
going to go here, I'm going to type prod,
which is short for production, okay, very
common for people to do that. You could also
make it pro if you like, but prod is generally
what is used. And I'm gonna go ahead and deploy
that. Okay. And so now it is deployed. And
now I have this nice URL. And so this URL
is what we're going to use to invoke the lambda.
So all we have to do is copy this here, and
then send a put request to our sorry, post
request to transit here. So what we're going
to do is copy this URL here, okay. And we're
going to go back to our cloud nine environment,
and we are going to go to our web in here.
Okay. And in this, we have our HTML code,
and we have a function called form Submit.
And so if we were to go into the JavaScript
here, okay, there is a place to supply that
in here. And it's probably going to be Oh,
where did I put it? Um, it is a right here.
So on the form submit, it takes a second parameter,
which is URL. All right. And so actually,
it's just all right over here, I made it really
easy for myself here, and I'm just going to
supply it there. Okay, and we're going to
need strings around that. Otherwise, it's
going to give us trouble, it's going to have
to be a double quotations. Okay. And so now
this form submit is going to submit it to
that endpoint, it has to be transmit, of course.
Okay. So, yeah, there we go. I'm just going
to double check that transmit that looks good
to me, I'm just gonna double check that it's
using a post it is. So yeah, that's all we
need to do here. So now that we've changed
our index HTML, we're going to need to update
update that in CloudFront, and invalidate
that. So let's make our way over to s3 and
upload this new file. Okay. All right. So
the first thing we're going to need to do
is download this file here. So we're just
gonna go ahead and download that new index
HTML. And we're going to need to use one of
our other tabs here, we'll take up the cloud
watch one here, we don't need to keep all
these things open. And we're going to make
our way to s3, okay. And once we make it into
s3, we're going to go into the www dot francke.
Alliance a.com. And we're going to upload
that new file, I believe it's in my downloads.
So I'm just gonna go down here and show in
Finder, and here it is. So I'm just going
to drag it on over Okay, upload that file.
Okay, and so now that file has been changed,
but that doesn't mean that CloudFront has
been updated. So we have to go to our friendly
service called CloudFront. Okay, and we're
going to need to invalidate that individual
file there. So we're gonna go to www, and
we're gonna go into validations create. Now,
we could put an asterisk, but we know exactly
what we're changing. So we're gonna do index
dot HTML, and we're going to invalidate it.
And we're gonna just wait for that validation
to finish Okay, and then we will go test out
our form. So after waiting a few minutes here,
our invalidation is complete. And so let's
go see if our new form is hooked up. So we're
going to need to go to the domain name. And
I was have a hard time typing it so I'm just
going to call it Copy, Paste it directly here,
okay, just gonna go route 53 and grab it for
myself. And there it is. Come on, there we
are. Okay. And so I'm just going to then paste
it in there. Okay, so here's our form. And
I just want to be 100%. Sure, because you're
using when you're working with Chrome and
stuff, things can aggressively cache there.
So see, it's still using the old one. But
we've definitely definitely updated it. So
I'm just going to give it a hard refresh here.
Okay, and so now it is there. So just make
sure you check that before you go ahead and
do this so that you save yourself some frustration.
All right. So now it's the moment of truth
here, and we are going to go ahead and fill
up this form and see if it works. So I'm gonna
put in my name Andrew Brown. Okay, and we're
gonna just put in exam Pro. Andrew exam pro.co,
we're gonna leave the phone number blank there.
I'm going to say, Federation, I want to buy
something. Can I buy a spaceship? Okay. Whoa,
boy. And we're going to now hit transmit,
okay, and it's transmitting there, and it
says success.
Okay, so we're gonna go to dynamodb, and do
a refresh there, and we can see that it's
inserted. So there you go, we're all done
all the way there. If we wanted to test the
validation, we could totally do so as well.
So I'm just gonna hit Submit here. And here,
it's throwing an error. So we're, we're done.
So we went through everything we created dynamodb,
an SNS topic, a lambda function, we used cloud
nine, we hooked up API gateway, we created
a static website hosting. And we backed it
all by CloudFront using route 53. So we did
a considerable amount to get this form. So
you know, that was quite impressive there.
So I guess, now that we're done, let's go
ahead and tear all this stuff down. So now
it's time to tear down and do some cleanup
here. All the resources we're using here pretty
much don't cost any money or shut themselves
down. So there's, we're not going to be in
trouble if we don't do this. But, you know,
we should just learn how to delete things
here. So first, I'm going to go to dynamodb,
I'm going to go ahead and delete that table.
Okay, and I don't want to create a backup.
So we'll go ahead and do that. Then we'll
make our way over to SNS, okay. And we are
going to go ahead and delete that topic. So
there it is, and we will just delete it, okay,
and we will put in a delete me. And then we
will make our way over to lamda. All right.
And we are going to go ahead and delete that
lambda function. And then we are going to
make our way over to Iam. And I am roles aren't
that big of a deal, but you might not want
to keep them around. So we will just go in
here and type in Frankie here. Okay, and we
will delete that role. And then we were running
an ECG, or any situ instance via cloud nine.
So I'm just going to close that there. Let's
tap here. And I'm gonna just type in, in here,
cloud nine, okay. And we are going to terminate
that instance, there, you can see I have a
few others that did not terminate, but we'll
go ahead and delete that there. And we will
just type delete. Okay, and that's going to
delete on its own. You will want to double
check that there. But I want to get through
this all with you here. So we're not going
to watch that. And then we want to delete
our API gateway here. Why don't we delete
this, um, we'll go up to the top here. I rarely
ever delete API. So we'll go here and enter
the name of the API before commit couldn't
just be delete, right? Sometimes it's delete
me, sometimes it's etc, etc, they give you
all these different ways of deleting, we'll
hit Delete API. So now that is deleted there.
Um, we need to delete our CloudFront. Okay,
so we'll go here. And we have two distributions
here. So in order to delete them, you have
to first disable them. And this takes forever
to do Okay, so once they're disabled, there'll
be off and then you can just delete them,
I'm not going to stick around to show you
how to delete them. As long as they're disabled,
that is going to be good enough, but you should
take the extra time and delete them 2030 minutes
when these decide to finish, okay, and we
want to delete our ACL if we can. Okay, so
we'll make our way over there. So I'm gonna
hit delete, and it won't let me until those
are deleted. So we'll wait till those are
fully deleted, then you just go ahead to here
and delete that. I'm not going to come back
and show you that it's just not not worth
the time here. Some of these things just take
too too long for me. Okay, and then we'll
go into fringe Alliance. We will go ahead
and remove these Records here, okay, you don't
want to keep records around that are pointing
to nothing. So if those CloudFront distributions
are there, there is a way of people can compromise
and have those resources point to somewhere
else. So you don't want to keep those around,
then we're going to go to s3, okay. And we're
going to go ahead and delete our buckets.
Generally, you have to empty them before you
can delete them. So I'm going to go here.
I don't know if databases made this a little
bit easier now, but generally, you'd always
have to empty them before you can delete.
So I'll hit Delete there. And we will try
this one as well. Okay. Oops, www dot. Okay,
look at that. Yeah, that's nice. You don't
have to hit empty anymore. So yeah, I think
we have everything with the exception of CloudFront
there and the ACM again, once they're disabled,
you delete them, and then you delete your
ACM. So yeah, we have fully cleaned up here.
And hopefully, you really enjoyed this. Alright,
so now it's time to book our exam. And it's
always a bit of a trick to actually find where
this page is. So if you were to search eight,
have a certification and go here.
Alright, and then maybe go to the training
overview, and then click get started, it's
going to take you to at bis dot training,
and this is where you're going to register
to take the exam. So in the top right corner,
we are going to have to go ahead and go sign
in. And I already have an account. So I'm
just going to go and login with my account
there. So I'm just gonna hit sign in there.
Okay, and we're just going to have to provide
our credentials here. So I'm just going to
go ahead and fill mine in, and I will see
you on the other side and just show you the
rest of it. Alright, so now we are in the
training and certification portal. So at the
top, we have a one stop training. And to get
to booking our exam, we got to go to certification
here. And then we're going to have to go to
our account. And we're going to be using the
certain metrics, third party service that
actually manages the certifications. So we're
going to go to our certain metrics account
here. And now we can go ahead and schedule
our exam. So we're going to schedule a new
exam. And down below, we're going to get a
full list of exams here. So it used to just
be psi. And so now they all have psi Pearson
VUE, these are just a network of training
centers where you can actually go take and
sit the exam, for the CCP, you can actually
take it from home. Now it's the only certification
you can take from home, it is a monitored
exam. But for the rest, they have to be done
at a data center. And so I'm just going to
show you how to book it either with psi or
a Pearson VUE here. And again, they have different
data centers. So if you do not find a data
center in your area, I'll just go give Pearson
VUE a look so that you can actually go book
that exam. So let's go take a look at an exam.
So maybe we will book the professional here.
So I'm just going to open this in a tab and
open that in a tab and we're going to review
how we can book it here through these two
portals. So let's take a look at psi, this
is the one I'm most familiar with. Okay, because
Pearson VUE wasn't here the last time I checked.
But so here you can see the duration and the
confirmation number, you want to definitely
make sure you're taking the right exam. Sometimes
there are similar exams like the old ones,
that will be in here. So just be 100%. Sure,
before you go ahead and do that, and go and
schedule your exam. And so it's even telling
you that there is more than one available
here, and that's fine. So we'll just hit Continue.
Okay. And then from here, we're going to wait
here and we're going to select our language,
okay. And then we get to choose our data centers.
So the idea is you want to try to find a data
center near you. So if I typed in Toronto
here, so we'll enter a city in here like Toronto,
I don't know why thinks I'm over here. And
I'm just going to hit Toronto here. And we're
going to search for exam centers. Okay, and
then we are going to have a bunch of over
here. So the closest one in Toronto is up
here. So I'm gonna click one. Alright, and
it's going to show me the available times
that I can book. So there's not a lot of times
this week, generally you have to it has to
be like two, three days ahead. Every time
I booked exam, it's never been the next day.
But here we actually have one it's going to
vary based on the test center that you have
here. We're going to go ahead here and this
one only lets you do Wednesdays and Thursdays.
So if we had the Thursday here at 5pm. Okay,
and then we would choose that and we would
continue. Okay, and then we would hit Continue
again. Alright, and so the booking has been
created and in order to finalize it, we just
have to pay that it is in USD dollars, okay.
So you'd have to just go and fill that out.
And once that's filled out and you pay it,
then you are ready to go sit that exam. So
that's how we do with psi and then we're gonna
go take a look over at Pearson VUE. So I'm
just gonna go ahead and clear this. Because
I'm not serious about booking an exam right
now. Okay. And we'll go take a look how we
do it with Pearson VUE. So here we are in
the Pearson VUE section to book. And you first
need to choose your preferred language. I'll
choose English because that's what I'm most
comfortable with. And we're going to just
hit next here. And the next thing it's going
to show us is the price and we will say schedule
this exam. All right. And now we can proceed
to scheduling. Okay, so we'll just proceed
to scheduling, it's given me a lot of superfluous
option. and here we can see locations in Toronto.
Okay, so here are test centres. And we do
actually have a bit of variation here. So
you can see there are some different offerings,
you might also see the same data center, so
I can choose this one here. Okay, and it lets
you select up to three to compare the availability.
So sure, we will select three, and we will
hit next. Okay, we'll just wait a little bit
here. And now we are just going to choose
when we want to take that exam there. So we
do have the three options to compare. And
so you know, just choose that 11 time, okay.
And so then we would see that information
and we could proceed to checkout.